You see, I've managed to wire into all of the people around Pisco,
okay? People thought that Erin was the person who could like
control minds, but it's actually been me the whole time. You're
just you're making a joke. You know what I'm talking about, yeah?
>> No, I'm not making Someone after you [__]
someone. NO, THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I NO, NO, BUT THAT'S NOT SO
You're Am I not supposed to respond to this? He's like using
me as the reason to criticize Pisco, should I not respond to
it? They're like, why are you acting like you're the main It's
like, why does he keep referencing me? If I'm not the
Just going to hop right into it. I thought the the whole conversation
was very interesting to me. Um You could see how Destiny
Essentially, the the idea here is, hey, if you're at fault, if
you're in trouble here, right? Sorry, if Casey Tron Denims, if
these people are like in trouble for CPS and
Like you understand I can't defend your conduct, right? You're
saying them participating in this community like How do I defend
your conduct if you're going to call them out for their conduct?
Let me pull some of these clips. Okay, let me pull some of these
clips. Okay, this is the first one of Destiny's reaction to Pisco
last night. >> only if you're joking about it. It's only
if you're joking about it after the fact and only after the fact.
How do we know there's a causal connection at all between what
occurred and the community I okay.
Okay, okay, okay. So Pisco's saying you're you're saying Denims
is responsible for CPS, she wanted that to happen using her jokes
after the fact as a reason to prove that she wanted the CPS call
to happen or she was gleeful or happy it happened.
certainly Destiny couldn't criticize Pisco on this front, right?
Where he has joked multiple times about multiple tragedies, said
he didn't feel bad about it. Surely, he won't say that's participating
in community that furthers violence, right? Surely, that couldn't
be He couldn't criticize This is literally a position on which
Pisco has defended Destiny in the past. There's no way. How [__]
up is that that you've defended this guy and now he's going to
try to cut your legs out when you like came to this position
by trying to be good faith with him and defend him in the past.
That's crazy, right? But I haven't watched the clip yet. Maybe
he doesn't just totally [__] on Pisco's position.
>> I normally I'm like good faith or not good faith. No,
I am good faith. I'm good faith towards everybody, but I don't
think anything personally. I actually really hate the fact personally
on a very personal level that Pisco is making this gaslight contributing
argument. I don't know if he's getting rotted by the people in
his chat or if he just lost too many friends and he's like desperate
for either income or audience capture or what, but this weird
Uh that's insane projection.
THAT MIGHT BE THE MOST direct projection I've ever seen in my
entire life. Are you serious right now? Who Who feels like Pisco
lost friends? Where did Pisco lose friends? >> Dude, that's
so transparent. >> thing that occurs where a community
of people can stand around and and tacitly implicitly support
a thing, but if you can't draw this direct causal connection
between A and B and this whole weird stance is going to have
Well, if you're not affirmatively attacking the thing, that doesn't
necessarily mean that you approve it. Is This is like This is
A+ gaslighting weird [__] Okay, what about when they
affirmatively attack the thing though? So I'm going to continually
inject my community into this, unfortunately. Okay, you guys
are all going to be subject to this.
I literally affirmatively condemn doxxing and like what would
you call it? Like um
collateral, right? Collateral damage. I don't advocate going
after anyone around Destiny trying to harass them, dox them,
anything. I'll do content on some of the people around Destiny
who have explicitly and publicly violated previously stated principles
to continue to like farm money from his audience. I'll criticize
those people, right?
But I've actually positively condemned is that I have said, no,
you cannot dox people, you cannot go after people around him,
do not harass the people around him.
Do not go after his son, do not talk about his son. So like I
obviously clear this hurdle by
So I'm wondering where if this is where if this is the best they
can do is say, well, they're kind of like wink wink nod nod at
wink wink nudge nudging this. Why don't do that? So I'm curious
how they justify going after my community. >> [__]
behavior. I can't believe that he's moved over, but he Well,
he has to, I guess, for whatever tankie [__] um adhering
to now. This is like reprehensible and disgusting behavior that
now he's So Pisco is a tankie [__] because
he's gaslighting Hutch by saying
that I think you need some proof that they wanted this to happen
and just because you don't say you feel bad about it doesn't
mean you wanted it to happen. This is the guy who said he didn't
feel bad right? About Corinna Contor getting merked. So I I just
don't So he's basically saying that he has contributed and just
because you can't draw a line just because he says he didn't
that you can't say he he didn't, that it's obviously true he
did. That he laughs about violence against other Republicans
all the time. He obviously wants violence against Republicans.
Right? Which is the exact argument Pisco is trying to make in
the opposite
So it's just very interesting that Destiny would be blowing him
up for the way that he that Pisco defends Destiny. supports this.
One of the biggest frustrating things for me when it comes to
like doxxing people and [__] is that like I can't
get my community to do it cuz I don't have a community that generally
supports such a I do it myself because I haven't fostered that
type of community. We don't generally do the relentless harassment
um
You absolutely do.
Wait, but you absolutely do. Especially under this standard.
I believe you do it under any standard, including the one where
you explicitly do dox people, right? Where you explicitly do
dox people and then what's the broad reaction of your community?
Is it, oh no, don't do that? Because if they had a real moral
issue with you doxxing people obviously, they would leave. But
the majority reaction we see is them justifying it upon the same
I sorry. They justify it in the same way you do, right? With
no evidence. So he says his community won't dox people. Yeah,
maybe like Dude, the argument is basically like, oh, Denims is
sort of letting crazy people in her community do [__]
and so she's responsible. And Destiny's like, I am the crazy
people in my community. I am the craziest person in my community
and I'm trying to lead us in that direction where we are crazier.
They're They're really not crazy enough.
What? What?
The anytime anybody would have done in the past, I would have
just banned them for it because I had I had the most moderation
for my community of anyone.
We don't generally do it. We don't generally dox people.
Again, I'll probably just keep bringing it back to, why did you
threaten to dox Wicked Supreme? What did Wicked Supreme say that
you threatened to dox him? That you basically gave by that threat
to dox, you basically greenlit doxing this guy, right? Anybody
in your community who could do it or would do it, you've said
you want it done.
Why? Why did you do that? And we'll see uh it actually gets to
the point in the conversation with Pisco, right?
Uh he's doxxed multiple people very recently. Yes, but it will
get to the point in this conversation with Pisco
he'll actually
basically get totally proven wrong based on Pisco bringing up
one of his doxxing attempts, right?
And he'll go, I don't want to talk about that anymore. He'll
get totally stymied. He will be without response.
And he'll go, I don't want to talk about that. Why does he get
special rules? Why does he get to do that? That's [__]
crazy, right?
It's insane. How many days until he will dox Pisco? Oh, well,
Funny you ask >> large content creator on the internet.
I probably Probably won't talk >> doing in the political
space. And so when it comes time to play these games, I just
generally don't have the community for it. Um I I I can't. Whereas
these communities, all of them play this game. All of them do
this stuff constantly. All of them wink wink nudge nudge laugh
at all of it happening. Like I'm so sorry, but if I were to step
into like some
I don't find it funny. I don't like that people get doxxed in
Destiny's community. In fact, the most perpetual thing you can
find in my DMs with people around Destiny literally the reason
I said I didn't want to go on anything else. Erudite messaged
me, she said, do you want to come on anything else?
I said, no, I'm good. I'm not going to face reveal with like
with the heat that's coming down. By the way, I was on Destiny's
side at this point. I can't be blamed for this. I'm like, hey,
with the heat that's coming down on people, I don't want to be
face revealed in this community. I don't want to have my any
of my information out there. No, thank you. No, thank you. No,
thank you. Like he's he's pulling up Kiwi Farms on stream. He's
like doing all this [__] It's like, no, thanks. Yeah,
I don't want to do that. No, thanks. So obviously, I condemned
it back then. I wasn't behind it back then. And I would just
ask them like in the what? The two months where I basically did
coverage on didn't dox anybody, didn't didn't do anything beyond
calling out people's public takes, okay? I stuck I stuck entirely
to publicly condemning certain conversations, certain comments,
whatever public content that was made. All right? All right?
In those two months that it took him to try to dox me to threaten
to dox, to say he wanted me dead, all of these things. Can I
ask you guys, what happened? What happened that made him go and
say, oh, I'm responsible for it?
I'm curious.
He pulls up KF on stream. He's pulled up KF on stream multiple
times. In fact, I
Okay, it really comes down to like how how am I supposed to talk
about this? He's done something like egregious that explicitly
applies here.
But bringing it up hurts somebody else.
I don't know what to do in this case. I don't know how to talk
about this without causing harm to the other person. Right?
It's very sad. But I Okay, hypothetically,
what would you guys think if somebody who was Destiny's friend,
ostensibly,
was doxxed
on Kiwi Farms and then within 12 15 hours Destiny pulled up Kiwi
Farms and read multiple posts in his thread.
Would you think that's like kind of Would you Would you think
he's trying to do something there? Would you think hypothetically,
if that happened, would you you that that's like, oh, that seems
obviously stupid to do. I'll just leave you with that hypothetical.
You guys should think about it, okay? And then >> community
and be like, "Holy [__] did you hear that Casey Tron
actually got yesterday by a guy?" And everybody's like, "Limp
fao, good for her. Her I hope she got to death." And you would
be "Ooh, that's kind of weird." And Pisco would have come and
go like, "Well, actually you can't actually demonstrate to me
any causal connection between the response that people are having
in that chat room with anybody who actually and I actually don't
think that it matters whatsoever with the
So, he's doing the straw man voice, but Pisco's basically saying
that you shouldn't be blamed for Casey Tron's based on your chat
saying that, and Destiny is arguing the opposite. Destiny is
arguing the opposite of, "Hey, you probably shouldn't blame the
people in that chat."
Or sorry, you shouldn't blame the streamer for the chat saying
that because obviously that's like you would need more information
there.
Yeah, he's using the straw man voice to go over an argument that
makes total sense. Well, actually you can't actually demonstrate
to me any causal connection between the response that people
are having in that chat room with anybody who actually and I
actually don't think that it matters whatsoever with the Did
the creator himself actually say that it was good that Casey
Tron got actually Excuse me, that's
So, he is basically arguing this is unironically the Keffals
position, the exact one he argued against in 2022
when Keffals was trying to paint his reputation a certain way,
right? And he went, "Hey, like if you could tie some of this
conduct back, we'll ban anybody we can, right? But realistically
these people are anonymous. We can't like we can't blame we we
can't do anything unless you can show us proof of it happening,
right? We have no evidence that this is happening."
You'd have to show us some evidence, which is the obviously true
position. And now he's arguing against it somehow, which is like
asking Destiny to to take his current positions and try to make
them jive with the Keffals manifesto, he basically would have
to come out and say Keffals was totally correct in every tactic
she used against him.
That's weird. And at some point you need to have like something
needs to be turning on your brain is like, "Why am I attracting
all these people that are celebrating this type of behavior or
engaging in this type of behavior or at least looking upon this
kind of stuff favorably and encouraging it to kind of be advertised
in their community." It's really weird. But
Now, I I just feel like probably what I would do here, and I'm
not going to do it, but Destiny posted Destiny's been Now he
started like trying to post people's docs to Docspin, okay? A
website that when he wrote the Keffals manifesto, he didn't want
to even name because of how malicious the site how maliciously
the site was used,
So, Destiny has himself posted multiple people's docs to Docspin
now. And And what do you think the reaction was from his chat
when he did that? You think it was Do you think it was just entirely
like, "Oh, Destiny, you're terrible. You're horrible. Destiny,
you're horrible." Or do you think it was, "Oh, this is funny."
And then some people going, "Whoa, we're just We're just doing
this now? Is that a condemnation? Whoa, we're just doing this
now? Is that a condemnation?"
It's just It's like a totally insane standard that he himself
fails in every possible way, but he's going to try to hold Pisco
to
Queenman and I agree with Pisco, I
Cuz we think that Ethan's gone too far, I guess. Like that is
what Vaush meant. When Vaush said every opinion this guy has
is spite-based, that's precisely what he meant. Is that he has
taken a position he has categorically argued against multiple
times in his career
and he is now adopting it entirely based on the fact that
me and Queenman have like kind of been, you know, against H3
for the past couple months.
And now he's like, "Oh, you guys are agreeing with Pisco. Well,
actually that makes all of this wrong. Everything I believed
before is incorrect because Queenman and Pisco or sorry, Queenman
and Jschlatt and their communities agree with Pisco." Video's
quite a bit louder than your sound level, might just be me.
Let's see, where am I at for my sound
I'm I'm probably failing to talk directly into my microphone
is what it is. I'm looking at a monitor. Hold on, I'll move my
chair. I've got a directional mic. I'm probably looking away
from my mic as I go to talk. So, that's um that's what's causing
it to be low like low.
Anyway, we we finished. We're at the end >> behavior or
engaging in this type of behavior or at least looking upon this
kind of stuff favorably and encouraging it to kind of be advertised
in their community. It's really weird.
Sorry, I I need to move my balls so that I need to move my balls
so that I'm better angled into the microphone, okay? My bad.
My bad. I don't want to break the immersion. But hey, that's
just my opinion, I guess. [__] me.
Is that your opinion?
That's like obviously It's obviously
Like the the total change, the complete departure from previously
stated opinions with no solid like reason why, nothing there?
Man. Okay, here's another comment on how It's all about
Somebody accused me of having main character syndrome, which
I think just goes back to that um that Nicholas Ybarra thing.
I'm I'm honestly sitting here and I'm just like,
"Why am I If Am I not supposed to respond to this?" He's like
using me as the reason to criticize Pisco. Should I not respond
to it? They're like, "Why are you acting like you're the main
It's like, "Why does he keep referencing me?" If I'm not the
main character, then I'm the main villain. Can I Can I have some
lines of dialogue as the main villain in the story? Casey Tron
is being insincere in her apology, and Ethan Klein knows her
to be insincere. You would say that
it's okay for Ethan to lie about that. What I'm curious about
I just really want to know cuz I don't spend enough time in these
Discords. I just want to know where um Pisco got this argument
from cuz it didn't come from him. This is either I don't know
if Joanna would make this kind of an argument. Aaron might. Justical
and his Discord server might. I don't know if Pisco hangs out
out with all the tankings or sorry, all the tankies, okay? Like
Jschlatt.
Meanwhile, on the Jschlatt stream, it's our 9,999th
time watching this clip. songs
The tankie clip, the tankie memes we throw out here. Right. Amazing.
Link?
Hold on. I'll find the link. I don't want to play it again. It's
going to play for a second, but I'm not playing it again. There's
the link, okay? You feel Oh, no, I heard this. I heard this.
Wait, no, he didn't ask for me to to remove my perms. He said
you should ban these guys, which was pretty funny. Okay.
There's no There's no world where this argument originated in
Pisco's brain though. He's He's not this stupid. They They got
He might be dumb enough to carry water for this argument, but
there's no world where he's so stupid that he would make this
argument. Um uh it's just not possible. Like it can't That can't
just can't be the case. Hold on. Which Which argument was this?
I actually need to go back and >> is being insincere in
her apology. Oh, hold on. Wait, this is case This is the lie
about the Ethan thing. I actually sided with Hutch on this part.
I actually sided with Hutch that like I think it's a little unreasonable
to say that he couldn't lie about There's like a There's maybe
an argument here as in if Pisco's going to say the whole thing
is sarcastic or sorry, if somebody's going to say the whole thing
is sarcastic, none of it's sincere, then it's a little weird
when he if he's mixing in with the sarcasm saying you shouldn't
harass her. No, I don't think so, gummy verse. I think we're
okay. I think we're okay. Um But if if then it would be incumbent
on Ethan to just lie there and say don't harass her. Like seriously.
But I think it's weird if it's mixed in entirely with sarcasm.
I don't think it was mixed entirely with
But again, criticizing the lie there when the lie is don't harass
Casey Tron, I think that would be too far. So, it's like maybe
one of two points or three points in that entire 4-hour argument
where I agreed with Hutch.
So, like the fact that I'm getting blamed for it is hilarious
cuz like the exact argument he's making right now actually totally
agree with
with Hutch on this one.
Did Ethan direct harassment at Casey Tron? I don't think so,
but Hutch seemed to think so based on the arguments he made in
that combo, which is very silly.
Okay. Very very silly. Regardless of your opinion about the Ethan
Klein lawsuit or the Hasan debate, you know, I can see why there's
a lot of different reasons why people might disagree with things
I say, and I totally understand that. And if someone wants to
love you um I didn't see that, Windy. Not relevant right now,
but thank you for letting me know. Maybe we can check it out
after. >> an accusation that like he, you know, he has
an ego in it. Um he uh can't admit when he's wrong. You know,
I don't I I will buy that I have a bit of an ego and that I can
be hard-headed and and um I can be stubborn. I don't think that
I'm beyond admitting fault or admitting when I get something
wrong. I don't agree with that, but I I will like accept the
criticism as intended in good nature. What I find um distasteful
and what I don't like what I don't think is justified is saying
something like this. With regard to my position on Ethan Klein
and the lawsuit, Pisco might be taking a really really bad position
because Justical's entire community has been celebrating the
unrestricted harassment of the Rose girl. Okay.
Um one, that like we get all identified, that's literally just
a whataboutism. That's not even an argument against anything
he's saying, right? So, you could You could totally understand
that that's clearly not an argument about anything he's saying,
even if it were
So, again, he's quoting other people, so I'm not going to say
that's him, you know, supporting this or saying it happened,
which I I think his position would be the same as the Bad Empanada
thing where it's like I'm aware the the reputation is bad, but
for me to say that myself, I'd have to look further into it.
But he's actually being kinder to Bad Empanada in the previous
conversation. He really doesn't want that association with me.
That's [__] man. That hurts. I mean, what the [__]
right? I mean, that's Why say that? Do you think it's possible
that that the reason I'm taking a position on the Ethan Klein
lawsuit, whether it's on standards of decency in the community,
whether it's on anything, is because I want to protect Justilk's
community, a community that I'm not a part of, a community that
when I used to talk to Justilk, it would only be to disagree
uh by and large the time that I I did have some on the screen,
uh you
That's not even true, actually. Pisco and I perfectly agreed
on the Twitch anti-Semitism stuff that it was like trumped up.
It was way too far. It was obviously going to have like downstream
effects that nobody would like. I remember I had to argue for
Dan in one of those conversations when Pisco came in cuz Dan
like dropped out of the Dan had taken like sleeping meds and
refused to argue and I'm like, "Well, I guess I'm like trying
to I'll try to make his arguments for him." And then Pisco's
like, "But you have to agree that that's crazy." And I'm like,
"Yeah, I do actually. That's literally not my position. I'm just
trying to argue for Dan cuz he's basically passed out right now."
Months and months and months ago at this point, or maybe even
a year ago, a year plus ago. Um and it was a disagree. There's,
you know, I don't communicate with Jstlk. Uh I don't have any,
you know, presence on the stream. Haven't done that. And so the
only thing that I understand about why he would openly speculate
that I might be taking an like a really really really bad position
because of the entire community is celebrating the alleged harassment
of quote the rose girl is because he's lying. Oh, that's totally
true. Yeah, he's obviously
Yeah, he's he's obviously lying.
Wait, why why would anybody fight against that? It's obviously
a lie. I want to Oh, dude, I want to hear how Kafka's going to
say this. How do you even argue this? I missed the first part
of the Kafka conversation. I watched a decent amount like after
Destiny had joined. I think I joined I think I started watching
about an hour and a half after Destiny joined. So, weirdly, you're
going to get my like unfiltered blind reaction to the first part
of this. And then after that, you're going to get I'll have like
more measure I'll like know what was happening. I mean like you
think Destiny's lying? I mean what would justify him saying that?
First of all, do you agree with that? And that's why I'm I'm
taking any position is because I want to protect Jstlk from accusations
of harassment.
I I have not seen any evidence that you and the Jstlk are having
any kind of relations or Don't these people feel bad for having
to say that? It's like a it's like an in-group signal.
It's like having to say It's like having to say orange man every
time instead of saying Donald Trump or the president or
It's like It's just a really like spineless in-group signal
that doesn't mean anything. Is it really tethered to reality?
Although orange man is a little bit, but it's just an in-group
signal cuz you don't have an argument. Very sad. familiarity
in a way that you would protect him or anything like that. I
will say this that he um
you know, Jstlk and, you know, his debaters definitely have an
interest in you. I mean they were in your I mean I was just recently
going back and forth with them in your Discord uh with a few
others and uh Yeah, I don't Subhuman degenerate just tipped $5.
Oh, hold on. Wait. She sells C Sam on the e-store. The C Sam
she sells is C Sam, I'm sure. So, if she sells C Sam on the e-store,
then I'm sure she sells C Sam. Thank you very much for the five.
I think we're technically five, you know, one donation one sub
away from another hour, so thank you very much for the donation.
Appreciate it.
A lot of DGGers think Fisco's a conservative grifter and everyone
that doesn't like Destiny is conspiring with Jstlk. Yeah, that's
that's true. Yeah. And you know, I think there's an interest
from them there and that definitely It's kind of the thing where
it's like I think of that rate So, I never celebrated this ever.
Never once celebrated Oh, also, the whole thing with the name
was you could say it however you want, right? Like you're supposed
to try to like sound out the
You know what I'm saying? Like
Yeah, Pi- Fisco basically pronounced it the same way he did back
then. >> into some suspicions, right? Where I think on
for for Destiny, I think he is very much sensitive to that community
uh for a lot of I think very justifiable reasons. And he doesn't
see you
like disavowing or openly distancing yourself from them whenever
he's been significantly harmed by them. So, I think that's like
where it's at.
I just noticed a bunch of people have to like specifically try
to disavow me in like the chat, in the community. They're like
It It just shows that the most popular argument against Fisco's
positions is Jstlk for some reason. It's not like, "Hey, you
have a stupid position." It's, "Oh, you're just like in Jstlk.
You're like a Jstlk community
It's so lazy. It's just so It's so lazy. Why would somebody have
to say this? It's cuz somebody accused them of being a part of
my community as if that means
Yeah, it's
it's very goofy. >> some of the suspicion comes from. And
then also, I think part of the suspicion is that like you um
I I believe you're so close to Streaderade and I think that he
felt very hurt from her and her actions. And you have continued
to And I'm not saying I'm not making a judgment or anything.
This is where he he's seeing you do those things. And then I
think that that
So, basically, what these guys are doing is like they're This
is, by the way, just guilt by association, but with like six
degrees of Kevin Bacon added in. Like literally, if we can connect
you in any way, even through like multiple links, then you have
to disavow you have to like anything they they support you on,
you have to immediately flip position, actually.
Is the outcome of the criticisms they're making. Right? Oh, you
should just think about like if you take a position, you should
think about why they're supporting you. Like they support you,
that makes you wrong. And while I do agree you can look around
and say, "Why are people supporting me? What is going on here?"
You can do that and have that analysis. But if that's going to
change what you think, then ultimately you don't really belong
in the online debate online politics sphere, right? If you're
going to look at the people who would agree with you, a position
derived from purely your own positions,
and then you're going to say, "Well, why do these people agree
with me? Oh, maybe I need to change what I think." Unless you're
actually re-evaluating your your personal principles and how
those principles Right, you have to do from first principles
a total teardown.
But that's not what anybody's asking for. They're basically going,
"Hey, if you could like not do this cuz like
you're kind of supporting these bad people. If you could just
not do that, that would be cool." They're basically saying the
same thing they said to Erudite and Soypill at that debate event,
right? Which was, "Well, maybe you could say this stuff, but
why do you have to say it publicly? You know that hurts Destiny,
right? Like when you say these things, you know that like hurts
Destiny, right?"
Is essentially
ostensibly what they're arguing. Very sad. kind of lends itself
to him thinking like, "Okay, well like this guy's not against
those people." And Windy Biden just tipped $5. Oh, hold on. >> are
like Sauron,
a villain with many names. Jstlk
just tickled. Reminds me of reading Tolkien at release, says
Windy Biden. At release. Thank you, Windy Biden. about your interaction
with them. >> Windy Biden. I see where like where he's
coming from on that. I think that the
the hard part on this for me is that like I don't know if I don't
know if I'd call him lying. I think he's just kind of like doing
those things. And you guys like, you know, the there's an elephant
in the room. You guys don't talk. And this is something that
is kind of a uh Oh, come on. It's a Sorry, somebody knows something.
I think it's I think it's you guys don't talk about this. He's
seeing this, he's making a uh a conclusion about it. And it's
more kind of a fact issue that could be cleared up by a discussion
between the two of you. I mean no doubt I think it could be cleared
up by a discussion uh between us, but wouldn't it be the correct
thing to do, if this is his mind like in his mind, rather than,
you know, speculate like that, um wait to see any evidence of
it um because you know, he has a very influential community.
Wait, wait. Is Fisco arguing that maybe Destiny should wait for
evidence to make totally like wild speculative
I Oh my god. I agree with you again, Fisco. Actually, you need
to reverse that position and say Destiny could say whatever he
wants cuz I agree with that. Okay? So, if Fisco could take that
back and just agree that Destiny could say whatever he wants,
then he wouldn't be agreeing with Jstlk and he would be a good
person again, okay? Perfect. >> Right? I mean like you
would agree that if if someone like who we didn't um who wasn't
a fan uh that we weren't a fan of, for example, like Hasan was
doing saying this, you know, I speculate that the reason why
Ethan Klein is taking this position, for whatever reason, is
because he just he hates Palestinians, he has an anti-Muslim
bias, or some other accusation. That basically the accusation
of me is that I want this woman to be harassed. This girl to
be harassed. Right?
I want this person to be harassed. This person I've never met.
This person who's not harmed me, who's not wronged me. I want
to protect her the people who are attacking her on his view.
I Yeah, I I as I said in our we we discussed earlier in the Discord
the Discord that I I have not seen all of the uh I haven't seen
all the discussions around this. I haven't seen Destiny's statements
about it. So, I'm not here So, from the Southside donates $20.
Destiny encouraged Kiwi Farms to find the minor who sent him
Destiny doxxed her. Yeah. So, he posted multiple pieces of PII
explicitly like goading Kiwi Farms to try to find her. That is
doxxing, right? Posting like personally collated private information
that's not publicly available on the internet that is very difficult
to find. Um in fact, he's the only person who had it because
he obtained it via the uh exchange of materials, right? That
relationship he had with her through the proxy, through Solo
as the proxy. Maybe, probably. I don't even know. But probably,
I guess we have to assume that based on her testimony, okay?
So, he had those unique and he posted all that information explicitly
taunting Kiwi Farms to try to find her. here to like defend or
um you know, And if you think that's an unhinged crazy
allegation,
it's not.
He literally
He literally said it. Oh, wait, where did I post this? I posted
it somewhere. Give me a second.
Might have posted it in the Discord. Give me a second.
Did I do that? I did, indeed.
Here it is, right here. So, when this person is saying, "If you
go to the police, you could have redemption, right? Take all
the information you have." And Destiny responds to them. This
is on August 21st, 2025. This is shortly after Rose Oh, sorry.
This is shortly Yeah, it was shortly after Rose was found. And
his response to this entire line of questioning is, "I have nothing
to give them, the police. Remember, the only reason they, being
Kiwi Farms, even found the rose person was because I posted the
pics in chat to bait them into looking." Seems pretty stupid
to do if I thought she was 17, huh? Wonder if any of them will
spend even half the effort looking for the trafficker. So, again,
just in case anybody's here for the first time, you've not seen
this before. This is Destiny saying, "Yes, I did in fact go to
try and post, you know, the
the pictures." And he posted pictures of her, unique pictures
of her, which were used to find her via reverse image search,
okay?
There were no pictures that where they could find her before.
And then he posted the pictures, and some of them worked for
reverse image search because of her unobstructed face and the
high level of detail that was available because Destiny posted,
I guess, like camera quality pictures. Okay?
Um lots of other things going on with those pictures, by the
way, which are very funny, sort of cut against
I'll I'll I'll add this now cuz I don't know if it'll come up
later. But Destiny So, the testimony from Rose is she had no
direct contact with him, that basically it went all through this
proxy, which was Solo, the person who's the trafficker. Now,
there's two reasons you might say that. One would be that it's
true. The other would be because you could be held liable for
these transmitted by that account if you were the person sending
the images, okay?
I think she's probably still admitting to some level of culpability
there, so maybe you believe it. But one thing that definitely
cuts against his whole story that she basically didn't know or
there's something like where she was totally disconnected
is she knew him. She took a picture from her university, right?
Of a guy that she was saying looked like him and sent it to him,
right? Destiny posted that picture so that I think believe they
could see her university and try to tie it, right? So,
she was aware of who he was and that her material was being sent
and that her messages could have been getting sent, too. Now,
does that mean that she wasn't on that that Does that mean she
was 100% on that account? No, but realistically the idea that
this is like when he says, "Oh, well, I sent material or I received
material, but realistically it's no different than me sending
it to someone and then them violating my trust entirely and sending
it to a whole bunch of people." No, no, no, there's a tight relationship
between Rose and Solo that means it's like it is a direct exchange,
right? Like a sorry, an indirect exchange.
Like it is very, very similar to them talking directly. Like
there is a relationship that is not anything like the totally
disconnected one where this guy would have like multiple women
he was trafficking at the same time. There's no indication of
that going on, right? Like there's clearly a very close relationship
where she's super aware of everything that Destiny's saying.
And the fact that she messages him. Or that that her she's being
represented as is the person talking to him, being represented
that way.
Anyway, I figured I should say that now cuz I don't want to go
back through all this stuff. I kind of want to focus on the arguments
in this conversation, but I'll get it out now that it could be
analyzed, somebody could disagree with that if they so wanted
to.
Okay? Perfect. Perfect, perfect, perfect. Okay. All right. We
continue. Like comment on that. I'm just saying like to me it
does I I I can't say that like it's it makes no sense at all
that he's like having questions about your association with those
people. Okay, so I I just brought I brought in Destiny. Destiny,
why did you say that? Destiny, you hired me to Oh, Destiny gets
in right away. Okay. I didn't even I thought Kafka was there
for a while. That's why you hired me for this situation, all
right? That's why you paid that retainer. Come on, let me do
my job. Jesus Christ, okay. My comment was a compliment because
there's no world where any of the dog arguments that you were
wheeling out against other people came from your mind. They had
to have come from other community. I cannot believe you've cognitively
degraded degraded this much people. >> which which argument?
So, again, I guess when Destiny comes in, he says, "Oh, it's
actually a compliment that I said this because you were making
really bad arguments." Basically the same arguments Pisco's always
been making in terms of culpability, right? Same ones he's defended
Destiny on in the past.
Is Destiny talking that fast or is it sped up? Well, it's sped
up cuz Kafka was slow, but we'll slow it down. He was talking
really fast in this >> binary obsession you have with culpability
when you know that ethics don't work that way and the law doesn't
work that way. Why would you pretend
So, I can't believe I didn't work on my graph now to show this.
basically people get really mad because as you could more predictably
predict like something is a result of your actions as in indirectly,
like if I set up this domino and I could 100% predict that two
dominoes down the line somebody gets that person's guilty, right?
That person And but Pisco would agree with that that as you approach
100% like awareness, 100% foreseeability, you've basically just
done the action. I think Pisco would agree with that, right?
What he's trying to say is you're only responsible for is foreseeable
is the thing is. And he just totally dis disagrees on
Um I think Destiny does bring this up later. I don't know why
they can't hash it out there. I honestly forgetting.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I figured this is something from law school.
It's just a more intellectualized and academic way of looking
at culpability that helps in terms of the law and what you should
actually be prosecuting people for,
But it's surprising to me because this exact framework is how
Pisco would defend Destiny in terms of his comments, you know,
laughing at people getting saying he doesn't care about getting
people getting
And then in terms of Destiny's culpability even in his own legal
case and I'm talking about the the retaining and all this. I
do believe Pisco could defend him on those grounds, but Destiny's
like attacking those arguments, the very grounds upon which Destiny
would be saved or be defended by
Destiny's attacking him on those grounds. And I think Pisco's
always had these exact ways of looking at it. >> culpability
is literally a binary yes or no. So, I I don't think you understood
what I was saying there. And I think that you've misconstrued
it and so it's possible you just don't understand what I'm saying.
Sure, so I understand what you're saying. The problem is what
you're saying is not a thing that anybody believes. He spent
half the conversation trying to distinguish between responsibilities
and obligations and separating those things from the harms that
they cause. That was one of the reasons why Hutch had so much
problem like understanding what you were saying cuz literally
nobody talks about obligations or responsibilities separate
I did think Pisco could benefit a lot from like that part of
the conversation I thought they just missed, but I'm surprised
that Destiny's acting like Pisco was, you know, the wrong party
in that conversation.
Because the amount of astroturfing TJ used in Pisco's live chat
was mental.
No, I think I think there was a lot of communities arguing back
and forth in his live chat. I'm not going to go ahead and say
that I saw a lot of people I recognize in that live chat saying
Destiny was wrong on things. There's a lot of There were communities
he was acting as like a proxy essentially in the exact way he's
discussing. The thing I would say is I don't I'm not there like
arguing with Pisco. I'm not there like telling people to go.
I just I watch Pisco's stream, right? And I cover some of his
stuff. And when it aligns with what I'm covering, which I've
obviously been calling Ethan like a spineless for months now,
I think like then I cover Pisco arguing that Ethan's being kind
of spineless. That that just makes perfect sense, right? Like
that's just logical that I I have this opinion. Pisco agrees
with that opinion. I cover where people are like trying to gaslight
him out of his opinion. I I don't understand what the problem
is, but >> they cause. This is why the more responsibility,
more obligation you have is usually because as a result of not
fulfilling those obligations or responsibilities more harm will
come from not fulfilling those rules of things. And you're trying
to pretend that like having a responsibility and failing to adhere
to that responsibility, you're not culpable for any of the harms
that follow. That's just an That's an untenable absurd position.
There's no way that you believe that. I can't I can't believe
that you believe that. I I think the better in I think the way
you basically look at Pisco's thing is
when he when the thing that he's getting that he's bristling
at is people saying you're culpable for this thing happening.
As in it would make sense for me to say you did CPS, right? And
And
Hutch believed when he went into that conversation that Denims
did way more. Hutch had to back off so many different times.
As evidence was produced, he couldn't produce evidence, right?
He had to back off so many times. It happens in this conversation,
too, where they are way out ahead of what evidence they can give
and they're just operating on dislike for the person. Right?
So, Pisco bristles at the idea of them saying she's culpable
for this when realistically what you should be saying is, "Well,
there's some small level of culpability here, right? Like a partial
level of culpability that really doesn't rise to us saying" because
ultimately if you're going to say somebody's responsible or culpable
for something, I think it makes sense to describe them as the
like
as the noun
that describes the person who does that action. So, if you're
saying somebody's culpable for murder, they are you calling them
a murderer would make sense. Now, does it make sense to say Denims
called CPS in this case? No. Ergo, saying she's culpable for
CPS as a statement in a vacuum feels wrong to Pisco.
if Hutch had been significantly I guess like couched, I think
you could get Pisco there as in like is there some world where
like there is some minimal level of culpability. That's why I
think they they start talking about significant culpability later
in the conversation because Pisco's saying she's not significantly
culpable, right? And Hutch wants to argue yes and Hutch is like,
"Well, maybe 5% culpable, 5% responsible, right? There's a shared
responsibility of like 5% or something." And it's like, "Okay,
but you understand that's not enough to say she's culpable for
the thing, right? That doesn't meet the standard. That doesn't
You'd have to have some You wouldn't just say she called CPS,
right?" There is no
And And basically the idea that Pisco's pushing against the entire
time is the overconfidence
with which they're describing the scenario. As in I don't think
you're being honest about what level of culpability Denims has.
I don't think you're being honest about what level of culpability
Hasey Tron has. And I want to go through this stuff because I
do not think that you're being honest right now. I think you're
using this kind of language to get away with making accusations
you can't back up. Is basically what Pisco's doing, okay? >> difference
is that you just don't understand what I'm saying and I can clarify
it. So, you think So, what what I'm understanding you to say
is that you think that my position is that when I say something
like the word responsibility
that I'm somehow distinguishing it from like ethical responsibility
and that therefore we cannot like put someone morally at fault
for things where I'm referring to it as responsibility.
But the truth is you just don't understand what I'm saying. I
do think that people can be held responsible for reckless and
negligent action. What kind of person do you think I would be
to think that they couldn't
Then how could you possibly argue that you couldn't be held somewhat
ethically culpable for the behavior that your community engages
in if you are But he's Again, it's just a different way of delineating
culpability responsibility, right? Pisco feels like it's way
more Like culpability is saying a thing that you are like very
significantly responsible for. You're culpable for something
because you did the thing or you did something that is essentially
the thing. And this is the legal standard, too, where it's like
you need a ridiculous level of culpability before you get to
what is it? Depraved heart murder, right? As in like every single
reasonable person would believe that as a result of you I think
the example Pisco uses of firing a machine gun in a parking lot,
everybody would believe that you're going to kill somebody if
you just spin in a circle firing a machine gun in a parking lot,
right?
And so, that's like the level, but we're not at that level with
Denims. And so, saying Denims is culpable to that extent, saying
she's culpable for it, for the call, that's wrong. She's culpable
for the actions, and based on those actions, it is not really
it's not significantly foreseeable that this would happen. And
it's basically like the good test for this is if Denims had done
that and CPS was never called, how much conversation would happen
here? Because if it was obviously foreseeable
that this happens, right? That this that this was going to happen,
then you would see everybody as soon as you somebody's chat says
anything out of line, if the if the streamer didn't hop on it
and freak the [__] out instantly every single time,
if it wasn't moderated extremely
right? Then you would know that it's really not that foreseeable.
That sometimes somebody says something racist, somebody says
something somebody makes like a threat and you don't notice it.
But realistically, 99.9% of the time nothing happens.
And I think we all agree on that, right? That's pretty obvious.
And so, yeah, it's it's just a different way of delineating responsibility.
And I don't understand like Destiny does understand this. I know
Destiny understands it like word exactly how Pisco's describing
it. He's just sewing out because Pisco's saying something that
I can agree with, I think.
And I don't understand why. Directly contributing to the things
that are causing them to engage that way. >> Right. Because
you just didn't understand what I meant to say. Yes. Yes. So,
I'll tell you.
He understood perfectly and he's lying,
Nobody you spoken to Pisco you realize nobody you spoke I heard
Joanna talk to you on stream that nobody understands what you're
saying. So, don't don't pretend that everybody's getting it except
for me. Nobody understands what you're saying, Pisco.
Destiny sure loves bringing up people's, you know, significant
others a lot about stuff. He brought He brought her up earlier
when he was criticizing Pisco as well. He's looking to like diffuse
responsibility. I wonder why he would be directing his community
to like somebody who might be responsible for brainwashing Pisco.
I I kind of wonder why would that be happening? It's a little
little odd, no? You're having seven-hour conversation with friends
on podcast who don't understand what you're saying. So, please
stop pretending that, okay? >> Okay. So, so let's like
hash it out and make sure that you agree, right? What with what
I'm saying and whether or not after I've explained what I've
said, whether or not you agree with it. So, I understand ethical
culpability to be equal to moral faults. Another word for that
is responsibility, okay?
And and and I Okay. And I think that you are only ethically culpable
for the ethical wrongs you do, you in fact do, okay? So, you
are not ethically culpable for ethical transgressions that you
do not in fact commit. You agree with that, right? So far?
No. There is a There's a transitive thing that happens that you're
completely missing. Let's say that somebody creates a trap in
the middle of a room and I tell somebody, knowing there's a trap
there, walk Oh, hang on. Can you just hold on one second? So,
is my Twitch stream up right now?
Uh just cuz you're banned, right? I just want to make sure it's
offline. I'm pretty sure they rewrote the rules for Hasan like
12 times, so you're probably safe. I just undid the Twitch stream.
>> Nobody you send somebody to walk down a hallway knowing
there's a trap in the middle of the room and they fall into the
trap. You're trying to do this weird game of saying, well, you
didn't actually place the trap and make them fall into it. So,
what you would be morally culpable of is giving them
So, again, I think Destiny's definitely intelligent enough to
understand this, okay? What Pisco would say here, I'll I'll predict
it because I I think it's pretty obvious in terms of how the
mechanics work here. And I think Destiny's by far like obviously
intelligent enough to understand this. Pisco would say that obviously
if you set up a trap, you know it's there and then you tell somebody
walk down that
you are responsible for setting up the trap and then sending
them down the hallway, you've done something that rises to 100%
foreseeability. You are guilty for the thing, right? Like
Like well, there's direct intention there. There's direct intention,
there's direct foreseeability. It's like way different. But there's
nothing like is Destiny arguing that Denims knew this would happen
if she just went, "Hmm, well, huh." Like that's crazy, chat.
Is Is that what he's arguing? Like they have to use an example
that's so clearly insane it doesn't apply,
right? When realistically, I believe Hutch and Pisco kept arguing
along the same lines. It's basically like how likely is it to
happen, how much could you foresee it happening? And Destiny
understands it, so I So, they're guilty of doing all the things
to set it up so it would happen. And the level of like moral
condemnation you'd have would be equivalent to just, you know,
cutting their leg off. Like that that's how this works, >> bad
advice knowing that they might fall into the trap, but you wouldn't
be responsible for them actually falling into the trap itself.
So, so no That's your position, yes? So, so no. I mean it's it's
not my position in the way that you've described it right there.
So, my position is that one's ethics
the ethical fault, the level of like moral condemnation you would
have for somebody who set this whole thing up to get somebody
to fall into a trap and then just like hurt somebody in the exact
same way directly that had fallen into that trap. Like this they
would have the same level of moral condemnation. There's no condemnation
It's just that Pisco's saying you don't say this word because
it implies something. And I'm guessing for courts, saying somebody's
culpable for a murder when they've done something that's fairly
downstream for murder, that's probably something that prejudices
a jury. So, I'm guessing that's why lawyers speak this way, right?
>> ethical fault that their state of mind is integral to
the kind of ethical
um you know, transgression that we're talking about. So, for
example, you have an ethical obligation to refrain from intentionally
and maliciously causing the death of your child. You'd agree
with that, right? Sure. There's There's no ethical obligation
to be free from, you know, ending your child's life in every
respect, right? I mean, there could be some situations in which
your child is an initial aggressor against you, right? And where
you would be justified to end your child's life.
Got to put this little kid down.
This toddler's got to go down. It's coming straight for me. >> words,
one's moral fault is directly related in our heads and the transgression
to a state of mind, right? And when I say you you know, you don't
have ethical fault for intentionally calling CPS, it means only
that that you don't have ethical culpability. >> But you
would have an ethical fault for luring other people or encouraging
other people or baiting other people into doing it. Yes. So,
you would be ethically culpable as I was trying to lay out to
Hutch for recklessly >> To be clear, tell me if I misstate
you. You very very cleverly and bizarrely danced around that
by saying that the only obligation you had was to make sure that
you were behaving in such a way that made it so that you weren't
getting banned by Twitch or otherwise coming into harm of the
Twitch terms of service basically. Any ethical obligation, you
spent like three hours arguing this with people. You pretend
that I didn't understand or Hutch didn't understand or nobody
understood this. But yeah, I I I understand. You're maybe a really
bad
I literally just slowly walked through it and explained exactly
what Pisco's arguing. I do think there were cases where Pisco
was arguing things in a sort of like intellectualized way that
might not strike people as exactly correct in the moment. I was
willing to grant that. Like, hey, I I get it. He's he's he's
being wordy. But he's being very
And for as long as I've known, he's always been like this. He's
always been annoying in this exact way. So, to take his behavior,
by the way, his actual criticizable behavior here according to
Destiny is that he's saying something so stupid that you'd have
to attribute it to eight different people he wants to paint as
evil. Joanna, Straight Raid, me, Kleiman, right? You have to
attribute it to these people.
But this has always been the way Pisco's argued, literally forever.
We can just do it one by one. We can just do it Well, cuz I don't
know if you're going to I don't I don't know if you're going
to rewrite the whole thing. So, let's just stick on the examples
that you >> Wait. No, because you just made a claim that
I was I was being shifty and clever. But wait. Wait. Wait. Yes.
I just want to take cuz you you just said something that like
I was limiting the amount of exposure in the case of, you By
the way, this will happen multiple times. I want you to watch
for this, too. Where Pisco will slow down, he'll hear an accusation
Destiny makes, right? Destiny will speak very quickly. He'll
get a lot of accusations out. And Pisco will hear something,
he'll go, "Wait. Wait. Wait. Let's talk about this thing you
just said." And Destiny will double time speak to try to get
out of it because he realizes he's letting his emotions dictate
what he's arguing and not what he actually sees, right? But Pisco
does this multiple times and Destiny the only tactic he has for
dealing with it is just upping how fast he speaks and speaking
a lot.
So, we'll we'll see this play out a lot. It's It's very funny
cuz Pisco now says, "Oh, you just said I was being shifty here.
What precisely did you think was being shifty?" >> increasing
risk to only you know, consequences related to Twitch, but that
didn't happen. >> in. That was the first thing I mentioned.
And then after that, I said, "And also >> we can find Well,
here. If you want we can find the exact clip. Okay. Hutch said
Hutch said something along the lines of
are you saying it was something like is there no reason not to
or why shouldn't you moderate your community or something like
that or what is the purpose of you moderating your community?
And your response was something along the lines of like, well,
as long as the action isn't too burdensome, you should do whatever
you need to in order to basically make it so you don't come under
TOS action from the platform. And then you very cleverly snuck
in, now the bad actions down the road
I do believe he said you have a self-standing obligation to moderate
your chat. I do believe that would extend like obviously, he
might have said Twitch TOS. I don't recall that.
like I think the Twitch TOS blocks most like negative behaviors.
Again, if they're doing something that falls within the TOS,
it's usually something that you could argue is like a contributory
factor to something down the road, but the entire broader argument,
you zoom out, is saying that contributory factor, whatever they
contributed, is not enough to warrant the lawsuits, is not enough
to warrant how people describe the situation after the might
tie into this, but it would but you were do do you were doing
a huge work there to separate any bad actions that resulted from
your lack of moderation to the um we can find the clips if you
want. It's not the case I think it's because you read into for
example and we're going to use this one, the BadEmpanada situation
when they ask me, "Do you agree?" So this is what Hutch says,
right? Hutch says, "You agree BadEmpanada is a malicious actor?"
I said, "I know he has a reputation for uh being a malicious
actor and I've seen him acting in conformity with it, so my answer
is yes." And when you heard that, me say that in real time just
reacting honestly, you took that negatively. You took a negative
inference against the way I phrased that. Hold on. Wait, wait,
wait. Repeat what you just So wait, let me just understand. You
think that BadEmpanada is somebody that engages in bad behavior?
Yes.
Okay. I could be wrong and maybe I missed it. I don't know if
I heard you say that yesterday. I feel like I heard you say 15
times, "I know that BadEmpanada has a reputation for engaging
in bad behavior." I feel like I heard you say that 10 or 15 times.
I don't know if I ever heard you actually directly state, "Yes,
BadEmpanada engages in
I think he said he's aware of some bad behavior, but he's aware
of far more in terms of the reputation and so he was just for
the sake of argument, without knowing, without having the exact
comments or the exact examples, he was just going to say, "Okay,
I know he has a bad reputation, too." So whatever you're going
to say cuz Hutch was like, "Wait, you don't understand just how
bad BadEmpanada is. BadEmpanada is like really bad. He's like
really, really bad, right?"
And then he goes like, "Well, I don't know how really, really
bad he is like cuz I haven't looked into it, so I'll just agree
for the set of for the sake of argument, the reputation is such
that Denim should probably be careful about doing the reaction.
>> behavior like doxing and other things that's made him
not welcome on Hasan's stream or whatever else when he's not
being a weapon for him. If if if it's the case that I did do
that, if I said in sum and substance, "I've heard he had I I
I know that he has a reputation for malicious action. I've seen
him do stuff which I would consider to be malicious and therefore
my answer is yes." If my answer was that, would you owe me an
apology? No. No? Dude, he's like so Destiny's arguing that Pisco
didn't do that but that Pisco is just defending this guy and
he's like, "Well, if I did say that like I'm aware of some bad
things he's done, I'm aware his reputation is even worse than
that, so yeah, I agree with you.
Would you owe me an apology if I said exactly like what I'm representing
now?" Cuz Destiny's basically accusing him of saying, "No, you're
lying now." He's like, "Well, if I did say what I'm saying here,
you owe me an apology, right?" And
Wait, what?
Obviously you would. Wait, what are you talking about? No, but
you said that the reason that this happened is because I've been
talking to Erin and she's been telling me that there's an equivalence
between BadEmpanada and you and that's why I said that. Like
what under what circumstances would you like ever take accountability
for the kind of reckless and false statements you're making about
Including this BadEmpanada bit. It doesn't seem like you you
apologize.
So basically you said something that's untrue. If I if we can
agree that I'm I'm representing this correctly, you obviously
have said something untrue, you're just lying about me, right?
Cuz when Pisco said, "If I said so Pisco first described what
he said." Destiny says, "I don't think you said that. I think
you said this." And Pisco goes, "Okay, well that's your disagreement.
So if so they've taken two sides. Destiny says you didn't say
it that way. Pisco says he does. He says, "Well, if if I did
say it my way, then you owe me an apology, right?" Cuz you lied
about me. And Destiny says, "No." Wait, what? Dude, what?
Yik a mobile so trash. I'm sorry about that, man. That sucks.
You understand why that's crazy, right? Pisco is essentially
saying, "If you lied about me, if you misunderstood and then
you said a bunch of things that I think are defamatory, that
are maybe not defamatory, but they're obviously attacking my
reputation because you misheard me. That's like malicious, that's
like very very bad. You should apologize for that, right?" No.
Okay. Wait, what? Bro, how do you even have an argument with
somebody who's who's like this? Under any circumstances. So you
have zero that's the you're the funniest person in the world
to ever utter that comment. Um number one. Number two, I mean
you yourself have said that apparently we have no moral obligations
or moral or ethical obligations for anything that comes from
our community engaging in harm or whatever, so
How is that relevant to you made accusations about Pisco?
Right? You made accusations about Pisco, personal attacks on
Pisco based on a different interpretation. You said, "No, no,
no, you didn't say that. I think you said this." Pisco says,
"Okay, if you misheard and you made personal attacks on me, you
should apologize for those, right?" No. And then he goes to,
"Well, you basically said there should be no moral culpability
for communities." How is that even related to what the conversation
is about? You understand this is just like totally unrelated
now, right? You're just like I believe this is what they call
Gish galloping, right? This is not like an actual Gish gallop.
You're just going to shotgun out things to try to change the
topic as quickly as you can because you've been caught out in
like a totally indefensible position. Whatever I say about you,
as long as I'm not getting moderated against, it should be fine.
And Pisco's world, okay? Number two, number three, for you Wait,
who's going to moderate against Destiny in his stream? >> to
be so careful when Hutch was talking
Wait, that that was totally unrelated. What Dude, there's literally
it's just open and shut right here. You made up personal attacks
on me based on something you say I said. I say I didn't. If I'm
right, you have to apologize, right? No, I don't. Well, actually
uh you said moderation isn't a moral like responsibility, which
isn't true. He said moderating your community is a self-standing
moral obligation, but like he's just it's lie on lie. Stacking
lies on lies. talking to you. And for any human, okay, when you
say is it possible or or Ethan could have two motivations for
this behavior, right? And Hutch goes, "Well, yeah, it's possible
that he's motivated by two things." And you're like, "Well, hold
on, sir." When you say that it's logically possible, meaning
that no contradiction is entailed by him inhabiting two positions.
That doesn't necessarily mean that you personally believe that
he has two positions. You have to be so careful to to like hardcore
come down
Pisco's point is you're basically saying something that is a
possibility,
but it's not a probability. As in Pisco is is is arguing something
that there is a like 20, 30, 40, 70% chance of, somewhere in
there. And Hutch is arguing for something that given what we
know, there's like a 0.1, 0.01% chance of. And so Pisco is saying,
"You're arguing something that is very silly. It doesn't demand
the same level of scrutiny that my argument does. So unless you
want to say that you think it's very likely to have happened,
I'm going to dismiss it because you're arguing something that
is well technically possible, very unlikely given the facts we
have."
That's not him trying to be weaselly, it's him saying, "Hey,
your argument is probably silly given that it's not very likely
that this happened at all and what I'm arguing is far more likely
and we both agree on that." >> every single word that Hutch
chooses. And then for you to slime around with, "Well, I understand
that BadEmpanada has a reputation for doing these things, hee
hee hee hee hee." While later on like not being familiar with
any of the underlying clips or videos or anything from this issue
you've talked about for like a year is incredulous to me. Let's
let's let's just deal one thing at a So the notion that uh first
off, I'm it's something wrong with me clarifying what Hutch means
by can someone have multiple motives. The reason I do that is
because I've had >> Stop. That's not my complaint. No,
no. What is my complaint? You're saying that
Uh he's saying that you're being weaselly in saying that it's
not it's like possible but not probable. I don't even actually
know what Destiny's argument is here. I don't know what what
are you weaseling out of by saying you're making a positive claim
about his position that it's not very likely and inviting him
to argue that it is more likely. But Hutch wouldn't do that.
Hutch wouldn't argue that he has like a lot of evidence for any
of these things. That I'm applying a a level of sophistication
and granularity when it comes to Hutch's language that I don't
apply to my own. That's your complaint, isn't it? >> Correct.
Okay. Yes. to I'm trying to undermine that, right? And the way
I would undermine that is by because this is like what you're
doing is an attack on my character, isn't it? You're saying I'm
being slimy. Correct? Yeah, because the arguments are on our
I can't deal with them. Yeah, they're insane. Yeah. The reason
why it's relevant that I bring up um my good purpose and why
I would bring up and have particular language with one thing
and not the other is specifically to defend your character attack.
And so you would agree it's relevant for me to bring up the justification
for me being particular in my language in the example you brought
up, right? It's relevant. You keep you keep your I don't know
if you're aware of you're doing it right now. Mm no. You're I'm
not
Basically by Pisco trying to be specific, by Pisco setting up
what Pisco is doing in a lot of ways is he's basically setting
up he knows he's correct, right? So he's settings he's setting
up all of the preconditions so that Destiny doesn't get to like
get any room to wiggle out of his concession.
And Destiny sees that and he says, "You're doing it now." No,
Pisco is just being very precise about how you're attacking his
character and you're you're making this exact allegation. Once
you say yes to that, right? Then he's going to say, "Well, you
have to retract that given that your reason for doing it was
wrong." So he's going to say, "So just to sum up, Destiny's argument
is you're doing something weaselly here. You're applying a level
of scrutiny to his stuff that you're not applying to your own."
Pisco is saying, "The actual heart of the argument is my
I'm not saying it's possible, I'm saying it's likely." Very different
things. And so obviously it's not true that I'm not applying
the same standard to myself. I'm not trying to go, "Oh well,
there's a small possibility this has happened." He's saying,
"I think it's likely that it happened." And Hutch is not engaging
in the same level of likelihood.
And so
he's going to argue that that's wrong as well and that's another
character attack you've done and so you would have to apologize
for that as well. And Destiny's already struggling cuz he sees
he he sees that he is incorrect, otherwise he could just go into
it, but he doesn't want to go into >> Right. It's relevant.
You keep you keep your I don't know if you're aware of you're
doing it right now. Mm no. You're I'm not attacking you for being
particular with your language. I'm attacking you for being selective
right Yes. So so so one way in which I could attack your criticism
namely that I'm being hypocritical is to justify both my language
initially and to justify my language with respect to Adam and
Eve and all that, right? That would be a way to address the hypocrisy.
How else would I address it,
The difference was between the sure. The difference would be
you your framing of every single thing you say and every single
thing he says in the beginning of the conversation where you're
setting up the the whole meta conversation for you to be so careful
with your language there and then in the last entire half of
the conversation to be mixing up words and throwing random things
around and and doing whatever else and not So we've just gone
to an entirely different argument that is clearly by design not
actually specific allegation, right? So Destiny's gone from his
specific allegations and basically said, well, actually the energy
you had in the first half wasn't like the second half. He's gone
to something totally like basically not something you could tangibly
push against. He's gone to like a very feelings-based argument.
This is probably the first shades of the lab stuff we're going
to see. Well, actually I just feel this way cuz I don't want
to defend the things I say.
But Pisco's sitting here like, no, make a claim and then I'll
push back against it and then when you're wrong, you'll apologize.
No, he doesn't want that. Destiny doesn't want that.
I'll also say and I'm going to start trying to minimize the commentary
a little bit, but Pisco's asked for two concessions based on
the actual allegations Destiny's made. Destiny has Gish galloped
out of them. He is not conceded. He's not said, yeah, you're
right. I was wrong in that. Yeah, obviously the thing I said
was incorrect even though it's factually true. We could check
on the transcript, right? That Pisco's right in in the in exactly
what his criticism is. Hey, you misunderstood me this way. Given
that I believe it's this way. If I were correct,
you would have to apologize, right? And they've just moved past
it because Destiny's just going to keep Gish galloping away
I did see I I know I'm aware of that Honey Ari. I'm not doing
the whole like Ethan bad thing right now. I'm analyzing this
conversation. Just had a conversation. I I don't I don't think
that the same I don't think that the same skeptical lens was
applied in both halves of the How would I go about starting to
prove that you're wrong? What would it take? Yeah, you just made
a you just made a totally like
non-falsifiable claim. Yeah, obviously a non-falsifiable falsifiable
claim, okay? It's not as bad as not as bad as not as bad as not
as bad. I'm not doing that right now. in the context of that
conversation or is this an unfalsifiable assertion that you're
making that Yeah. Oh, oh, Pisco's right on point immediately.
Hey, you just made two falsifiable assertions that I falsified.
You won't apologize. Now you've made an unfalsifiable assertion
that's just based on vibes cuz you know you're already owned
in this combo. No amount of We would have to rewatch the we would
have to rewatch the conversation and go and go through some of
the examples. Can I just address the things you're saying? You're
incorrectly stating that Hutch had a positive claim that he needed
to justify to you in an argument or whatever. That wasn't true.
You came in with a positive claim and you didn't have any of
the justifications for your claim and you were saying that he
was lacking evidence to to to prove his. So so so can we is it
okay for me to examine what you just brought up, right? It's
not. So I've already noticed this has happened three times now.
Pisco goes, is it okay for me to examine the the claim you just
made about what I've done? And Destiny goes, yeah. And then Pisco
exactly points out why Destiny's wrong and why he should apologize
and then Destiny goes, yeah, but here's another thing. People
watch this conversation and they think Destiny's doing well.
It's it's so sad.
We've watched it multiple times now. Every time Pisco breaks
this down into something falsifiable which Destiny just made
another claim.
Hey, if if Pisco's correct in in his like estimation of this
contention, if he's correct and he is he's the one who is right,
then you have maliciously attacked his character for no reason.
Is the claim about burdens okay? So you just said you claimed
that Hutch had
a specific burden in the nature of the of the conversation, but
how can that be given the fact that you're the one walking in
with a positive claim, right? That's what you just said? Correct.
Yes. But just because I walk in with a positive claim and I have
a burden with respect to what I'm proving doesn't mean that Hutch
if to the extent that he makes a positive claim doesn't have
a burden for what he's saying, right? You agree Kind of.
Destiny, hold on. Hold on. Destiny be
actually you had the positive claim coming into the debate. So
ever asking Hutch to substantiate one of his claims is wrong
to do. >> What is questionable about that if you don't
mind me asking? The questionable thing is if you were to walk
into the middle of an argument between two other people where
you weren't caught up on any of the discussion and then you were
to try to interject and have a conversation with the other person.
Also, I'm going to go back to the beginning of what Destiny started
saying here, okay? I'm going to end the Twitch chat like early
tonight. I'm going to go over to Kick very early. So guys, we're
over on kick.com/jsto okay. We're just going to be streaming
there. Head over to kick.com/jsto okay. Hop in. All right. And
let's go. All right. We're here we're here for a long haul. It's
a very long combo. At some point I'll stop analyzing the same
arguments, okay?
We have I've analyzing different arguments here and it is important
to point out, but at some point we'll settle into the conversation.
We'll see them argue back and forth. The commentary will be a
little more sparse.
The questionable thing is if you were to walk into the middle
of an argument between two other people where you weren't caught
up on any of the discussion and then you were to try to interject
and have a conversation with the other person and then we if
you were to act indignant or if you were to say that the other
person is burdened by the necessity to show proof for his claims
when he's apparently wasn't even ready to have He didn't realize
like how unfamiliar you were with all the underlying material
that I just want to God. How unfamiliar you were you were with
the underlying material. Maybe Pisco is unfamiliar.
Okay? Maybe.
But here's the problem. When he goes, hey, could you substantiate
what you just said every single time? Hutch has overstated what
he can prove fairly significantly, okay? Every single time. You've
apparently been talking about for a year. I just find that to
be incredibly bad faith. That's an insane burden to place on
Hutch that he needs to be able to produce every single clip at
that point of the conversation.
Yeah, Pisco didn't say that. Pisco literally didn't say that.
He was just like, hey, could you show me some evidence for this?
And by the way, it was obviously going to be the case where Pisco
would say, hey, could you show me some evidence for in some of
these things. And by the way, your certainty of something should
be as it should be commensurate with how easy it is to prove
something, right? Like you should be able to take 5 minutes and
find a clip which was there was no problem. The issue wasn't
that Hutch wasn't able to find the clips by the way. The issue
was that Hutch had the clips and the clips did not say what he
thought they said. Right? Hutch went, here's my proof and then
it didn't remotely prove the thing he was saying. By the way,
if we want to try to prove out Hutch's first claim that I heard
from him was Denims advocated for them calling CPS. I'm down
for as long as he needs. He needs a week, 2 week, 8 2 weeks,
8 weeks. He can go and and try to prove that out to me. He also
made that claim about Frogan and Casey Tron had to admit on Livin'
Learn that he was wrong on both of those things, too. So he's
wrong on Denims and Casey Tron and Frogan. But we have heat for
Pisco for saying, hey, could you like substantiate this? I'm
sure he thought that you'd seen at that point cuz some of these
clips had been central to this debate that had been happening
for almost a year. I view that as a kind of explosion of the
claim just then. So I understand that broadly you think I'm I'm
being unfair and I'm demanding a kind of level of evidence that
I myself am not providing, but I'm just focusing specifically
on this this one point. I mean there's nothing inconsistent with
both of us having evidentiary burdens that we have to satisfy,
isn't I mean just because I come in with a claim doesn't mean
and I have the burden to to show it doesn't mean that he also
doesn't, right? I mean you agree with that. So I don't understand
why this kind of Unnecessarily. I mean if you come in with a
positive claim and he's playing the negation, the burden would
be on you initially like you were saying because you thought
that he was the one with the positive claim. The burden would
be on you initially to present proof of your claim. So so it
is my claim, right? It's my claim for various things. One that
Ethan is lying about a couple of different things. It's my burden
that he's not actually or you know, motivated by a particular
rationale. And in that part of the conversation, I know exactly
why we were talking about what we were talking about which is
essentially what this will ground down into is is doing this
kind of lawsuit against these kinds of people justified. And
what most people say is it's a you know, it's justified because
of their culpable conduct because they've done something that
for which they deserve this. And so we were at the point That
is exactly, yes. So the topic had changed, right? And it was
basically saying, well, [__] around and find out.
Hutch doesn't say that explicitly, but the [__] around
and find out thing it's now, okay, well, how badly did they [__]
around? That was the conversation that was taking place. And
Hutch is the person with the the burden because he's making the
positive claim that they [__] around a lot and they
found out.
I was >> why do they deserve it? And Hutch was saying,
well, they deserve it because of a reason. And given that it
was his claim, right? He is trying to justify in that moment
the why it is morally correct to do this lawsuit against them.
In that context, I think it makes perfect sense to say that it's
his burden to show that claim. And I don't think there's anything
wrong and I want you I want to ask you
Hold on. 1 second. 1 second. 1 second. That much is true even
if his reason sucked. Okay, even less. Do you find it concerning
that literally nobody
can really substantiate why they deserve it outside of being
like, I just hate these vile I just hate these totally disgusting,
depraved, useless
Do you think do you think it's weird that the like when you're
asked when people ask for proof, essentially all of the claims
of their conduct far outstrip any provable conduct? Do you not
think that's concerning?
Does that not concern you that you have like a level of how much
they around
in your brain that doesn't seem like coherent with reality? I
feel like that would be very concerning to me. If I found out
that I believe something wholeheartedly and then I found out
that I couldn't prove that at all.
I think that would be very I would feel bad about that. I would
feel like oh something's wrong with me. Why is J Star community
harassing a
Why as a John of that victim would you add that person on Facebook
and message them directly like Destiny did? Knowing that they
know who you are. Wouldn't that minor have like trauma related
likely trauma related to being s- to you? Why would you as the
John message this person directly from your own Facebook?
That's kind of weird, no?
Something wrong. And I want you I want to ask you that on neutral
Wait, what? Destiny did that. Yeah. Yeah. Destiny Destiny did
that. He messaged her directly on Facebook.
He He said as much on his stream. Yeah, he directly messaged
the minor trafficking victim that he purchased material or requested
custom material of. Yeah.
Actual real facts. >> guys had met on neutral ground to
arrange a conversation or whatever, then sure. But for him having
had discussed this for so long and then for you to come in presenting
the claim that you don't believe any of this was justified. And
then with with basically from what I saw no proof of your own,
you start demanding him to provide the negation of your completely
unsubstantiated view. I don't know. I just think it was a it
was a really aggressive
He didn't say the negation. He said hey, I think this is the
most likely thing, right? This is most likely. This is most probable.
It is not like noble. It's not factually correct, but it seems
to like defy expectation, defy reality to believe that Ethan
thought he was sincerely going after copyright here. Like that
was a sincere motive of his. It's pretty obvious it's just him
going after the people. And eventually everybody just agrees
yeah, he's probably just being petty and going after the people.
And then it comes down to the well, they [__] around
and found out. And then it's what how much did they [__]
around? How much did they deserve that? That's where the
>> to to frame that to a person who didn't seem like they
were trying to play gotchas at all. On the contrary, you were
doing it to him the entire conversation. It's my claim that I
don't have a reason to believe that these that these lawsuits
are justified. And I've been very open about the lawsuits being
justified. It was I think it was just basically on like what
had said or what had Casey Tront said or whatever.
Yeah, to build up the culpability argument. So so one is I am
familiar with a lot of their statements and the ones that people
bring up to me. And anyone it's so trivial to to show this is
because so many people in my open calls in which again this is
more evidence suggests I'm not bad faith and just taking a position
because Just Nickels entire community has been celebrating the
unrestricted harassment of the Rose Girl. One evidence that's
not the case is the fact that I'm open to having people of all
By the way, that's totally so again he's stating somebody else's
opinion. I do think I'm allowed to point out that this is like
not something that happened, right? At all. types come and produce
evidence to me. And I've had conversations about these particular
statements and often times I'll let the statements play out and
I'm familiar with them. I have seen that clip of Denims before.
I
It's very funny me while crossing cuz I don't use chemical weapons
in the in the exact Lonerbox thing. I like denounce chemical
weapons. I don't use chemical weapons, but I still get treated
this way. So I feel like a lot of these arguments are just built
on co- >> seen the clip of the GRD before. Now I'm not
going to claim to know all of their streams, which is what Hutch
was asking for, which I think was not justified. >> for
you to be familiar with all of their
All of their content?
I think he means like Uh dude, I
Pisco's just going to explain By all I mean by by all I mean
a substantial
significant portion. What just happened is suddenly asking for
you to be familiar with all of their streams?
Yeah, so yeah, he does this a lot. Yeah, he does it a lot. So
Isn't it crazy
that you said all of the straight No, nobody said that. And Pisco's
trying to go no, I think like this is what I mean. Like this
is what I He does this all the time. It's very funny. He tries
to basically like the one of the biggest sacrileges he paints
up in DGG is if you're ever hyperbolic on a point. Now this doesn't
get applied evenly or else obviously everybody would have been
laughing Hutch out of the room, right? It would be obvious within
the first 30 minutes that debate that Hutch had totally wrong
opinions. He was hyperbolic on literally everything he said,
every single claim he made. But
this is what Destiny does is he will try to bait you into saying
something that's a little hyperbolic, a little over the line
and then he will make that the center of the conversation. Well,
your your mental state is totally because you got hyperbolic.
A closer video of Pisco examining Destiny's case on stream. Well,
I think if he's going to take I think I should get a chance to
at least say this is what I think happened in terms of like the
harassment stuff cuz Well, we'll get into it later. This gets
so much better by the way. It's like very dry right now, okay?
It's very dry right now even though it's still fun to analyze.
I have fun doing this. I understand this is content isn't for
everybody. It's not exactly the same as the regular content on
the stream, but I love doing it. I love like just discussing
exactly how these arguments break down cuz it's fun every single
time. Okay? It's telling for me that Pisco can do to Destiny
what Destiny did to DeSouza. Wouldn't ever know that cuz I don't
know why
I don't know why you would watch
Destiny argue with Dinesh D'Souza, but yeah, I I'm sure that's
very similar. Pisco again he's just going to slow it down. He's
going to ask for Destiny to substantiate stuff, but
and that'll be that'll be good as we go. I think we're at three
so far that Destiny's not substantiated the things he said. Now
now they're arguing over this hyperbolic thing. I've noticed
Destiny do this to me multiple times in arguments, right? I'll
say something and I'll be like a little hyperbolic and he'll
make that the center of the conversation. It's a slight of hand
he does consistently. Okay, generally in in like a By the way,
you saying that right now you said that multiple times
By by all I mean a substantial
significant portion of their streams. That's what I mean in this
context. Okay, even that's not true, right? Hutch doesn't expect
you to be familiar with a significant portion of their streams,
right? These people stream for thousands
I think a significant portion of the content around H3 like the
relevant content. So he he was claiming that They stream for
thousands of hours. I I
Do you think that Okay, you acknowledge that Hutch wasn't asking
you for you to be familiar with the majority of their stream
51% plus or even 10% of all the hours they've streamed, right?
That I be generally familiar with how their streams are run.
I think is what he's point out. Do you disagree with that
That can be an okay characterization. Generally familiar with
can be generalized from a small subset of content though, not
having seen most of their videos. Again, I'm only I'm only harping
on this because you were so careful to Where would Destiny ever
say
somebody makes the argument oh well, aren't you familiar with
like all of the other stuff they've done? And you go no and they
go well, that proves you don't know anything. And it's like well,
if that stuff's cons- Destiny would easily be able to say cuz
we all know exactly where that argument goes. Okay, produce or
describe in some way, right? You don't have to have produced
the clips, but describe in some way what relevant clips happened
so we can get what you think happened on the record and then
we'll go look for them and we can find them, right?
That's that's how that always goes. It's like oh well, there's
lots of very cuz what Hutch is saying is there's lots of very
compelling evidence in the rest of the things they do. And it's
like okay, well let's go find some of that. Or you could try
to make arguments from generalities if you wanted to, right?
Like the generality that Casey Tront steals content is something
nobody denies, right? We're all good with that. If you want to
say if your argument is well, I think this is justified cuz Casey
Tront steals content and I think Ethan Klein should sue her for
that. Okay. Like nobody has a problem with that rationale for
being okay with the lawsuits. Or no,
Yeah, no I would say nobody has a problem with that in a vacuum,
okay?
But I don't think you think that she deserves like quite the
extent of punishment she's getting unless you just hate her as
a person. But broadly people don't really care if you say well,
you know, she steals content all the time so that's why this
should happen. But that's not the argument Hutch was making,
right? Hutch was making the argument that she was crazy about
Ethan Klein.
That's the argument. So what what evidence is there that she's
insane about Ethan Klein? Qualifying his language earlier when
it played to your favor that for you to throw on oh, I have to
know most of their content is an absurd statement compared to
I need to be generally familiar with how they engage with their
content. You're you're alleging that it is possible to gain a
representative sample of how one
runs their content based on a
[__] I have to point out one more
Even if this were true and Pisco did say like is Pisco can you
be held to one statement you make in that way now? Really? I
don't know if he did or didn't in this one. I can't remember
back to this one specifically how he specified this, right? Even
if he did say that,
wouldn't you just say well, that's not what he meant and he's
telling you what he meant right now and he could have easily
elaborated for Hutch what he
Or we going to hold him to that one time
Sorry, can he be held to that statement one time? Because if
that's true even less despite like going back on it later, I'm
going to say that Destiny absolutely advocated for violence against
conservatives, right?
If you remember, he said the thing that Hutch criticized originally
and then he went on Piers Morgan and he like quadrupled down
with Andrew Wilson and then somehow instead of quintupling down
the like after doubling down repeatedly on Piers Morgan, right?
Then at the end he's like well, I guess I should disavow a little
bit a little bit. But up until that point till he got totally
raked over the coals by Andrew Wilson, he literally was totally
advocating for violence. He was totally like good with it, right?
But Pisco's literally saying he's saying like I don't I didn't
mean that if I said it. My bad.
But I don't even think he believes he said it. >> A small
segment of their That's right. He's going back on it now. It
can be, yeah. Okay. And so uh when Hutch asked that question,
I think what he was implying is I did not have sufficient familiarity
with their content for the scope of my claims, which I think
is preposterous. I think that the scope of my claims is Okay,
well it it seemed like you had almost no like understanding of
their content whatsoever when he was asking questions of like
In virtue In what? Is that Is that clear?
So when you saying things like well, I don't know if they ever
read their chat, No, I no, It seems like you've never seen any
of their content ever to make any statement like that. You didn't
seem to offer up any positive claims about like this is what
I think the content is. Like you're asking for This guy is spamming
Pisko rape me a lot and Pisko I just want to say every single
statement he made. Hang on. Hang on. Just slow down, all right?
I think
merely showing that something appeared
um in a stream or in the chat isn't sufficient for us to conclude
that there's been a failure to moderate. And you would agree
with that. I'm sure that there are times in people's streams
in
Hold on. Hold on. I'm being sent a a Reddit post, a real quick
Reddit post. Hold on.
Apparently this is going to be funny. Pisko will look into your
soul and unironically say that Destiny is insane and bad faith
to even suggest that his H3 analysis is being tainted by anti-fan
communities. Meanwhile, his super chats.
That's just Doobie, bro. That's just Doobie. Trust me. If Doobie
donated like that that would be my fault, okay? That that'd be
a fault of mine, all right? If
if somebody like Doobie wants to come in here and start throwing
down $400 a stream, I'll say whatever Doobie wants,
Doobie Whatever Doobie wants me to say, I'll say it. But I don't
think Pisko's like that, okay? I think Doobie supports him because
of what Pisko says, not the other way around. I still want to
know We're just looking at this comment. I still want to know
who he ever doxxed. As far as I know, Dan doxxing a cat on Twitter
and de-doxxing the guy who harasses Rose plus some soft doxxes
on Jstock. Is there much more? Isn't there literally any Isn't
there literally anybody else doxxed who is kind of public in
this space already?
Um yes, there are There are a bunch of people who are doxxed
by Destiny
And he HAS ADMITTED TO.
DUDE, WHO DO WE EVEN DOXX? UM YEAH, lots of people. I obviously
can't go through the the line, right? I can't.
But at some point At some point I'll probably try to write an
article on this and like the people who were doxxed by Destiny,
the the stuff that went on in his in his thread just to show
how disingenuous all of his commentary is on this. You know what
I'm saying? I I would say probably my bar for most of these people,
okay? Most of the people who were in Destiny's community, who
were friends of Destiny is to I would just say go message Wicked
Supreme and ask him what he did to deserve Destiny threatening
to doxx him and lying about him multiple times to the point that
Erudite, Sam Seder, a bunch of people from Progressive Victory
had to come out and say, "Actually, Destiny's just totally lying
about this guy."
Right? What did What did Wicked Supreme do that made it so Destiny
wanted to doxx him, threaten to doxx him, and then doxx other
people around him, right? Despite Wicked Supreme's just going
to keep saying what his opinion is on stuff. I just I would wonder
what that is, okay? If you were someone who is like related to
this for some reason, just reach out to Wicked Supreme and ask
him what that And reach out to Destiny and say, "Hey, what did
Wicked Supreme do to deserve this?"
I'd be interested to hear. That wasn't the That wasn't the subject
matter. That wasn't the That wasn't the subject of the conversation.
The subject is if you do a stream that is centered on a topic
and messages are showing up that seem to run in parallel with
what the video is saying, with what you're implying, with what
the rest of your community is saying, that for you to retreat
to this thing of like, "Well, isn't it possible that maybe they
missed that one message?" It's like saying maybe it's possible
somebody missed the swastika when they were walking to to bedroom.
Like it's just such an absurd statement given the context of
what was being talked about. It's not like there was a single
chat message that went by that Denims didn't catch. She was watching
a hit piece video on Ethan, reading comments literally about
calling CPS and everything else, and giggling and laughing along
with it and talking about the deadly
Wait, did she Wait, was there a message about calling CPS that
she was reading
Or did that Was that another allegation there that is totally
In my mind, what I remember was Den like reading a message about
how they might be in trouble or how it's bad for babies to get
an illness, but I don't remember I think that's actually explicitly
not true. So again, we're just speaking really fast, making all
of these allegations, and I I hope this is what we're >> of
the disease. It if some I I don't think it's absurd at all as
you tried to characterize just then. And I want to be able to
finish this >> Okay, wait. Wait. So wait. I just want to
be I just want to hold on. I just So you see, he literally disagrees
again, and now Destiny's going to yap a whole bunch again. Like
they probably needed a moderator for this who is going to actually
Like Pisko's just about to slow down again and say, "Hey, there's
like um there's like absolutely
no way that you you just made a statement that I think is incorrect."
But Destiny won't let him argue about this again. Like I I I
just don't understand. How is this This is like a
a totally broken conversation
like dynamic, right? Pisko goes, "Hey, I think you're incorrect
on that. I want to address it." Here's the real problem here,
okay? Here's the real problem. Pisko believes that Destiny is
operating in good faith here and not just either trying to humiliate
him or punish him for being somebody who's acceptable to like
my community or Kman's community or whatever the right? That's
what the goal of Destiny is. Pisko thinks Destiny's here for
a good faith conversation. If Destiny were here for a good faith
conversation, he wouldn't be lying about you in the precise ways
that you've already like raised issues with. He's not here for
a good faith conversation, which is why he refuses to engage
on any of the things he says that you want to kind of try to
pin him down on and say, "Do you actually mean that? Do you actually
think that?"
And this is probably the most common meme that Destiny does in
debates is he will basically say some stuff, people ask him to
slow down and address something, and he will keep spamming out
words as quickly as he can so he doesn't actually have to address
them. And when you do slow him down and get him to engage on
something, like if you have a moderator who says, "Hey, you have
to answer that," then he'll do some like crazy appeal to hyperbole
thing where, "Oh, you're saying I can't ever say this no matter
what? Oh, you're saying like there's absolutely no way I could
ever in a million years say Denims like contributed to CPS."
Like, "No, nobody said that." Pisko's criticisms are pretty obvious.
Let me put a pin in this then. Do you think that Denims was aware
that people in her chat, more likely than not, were were calling
for CPS calls and were I'm not
So So Destiny just said she absolutely read out a chat message
that was talking about CPS, and now his question is, when Pisko
said, "Hey, can we slow down and talk about this?" He's already
moderated his position, and he says, "So you're saying there's
like no way at all" Dude, it actually just happened exactly how
I said it would happen.
Same stuff. I can't do this. Okay, then you Then why even have
the conversation? What have you been talking about for a year
if you're you're not even sure of this? So So You had a 7-hour
conversation If you can't come to a concrete determination on
whether or not she saw the CPS chat messages, why are you even
talking about this? Wait, so your argument is she absolutely
saw them or is that she might have seen
He's saying he doesn't know, and so treating it like she definitely
knew is probably wrong.
I I I I I I I just want to be I just want to be clear. You're
certain. What is your level of certainty that she saw the messages
that you claim that she
95 plus percent. There could be some brain disease, there could
be some other thing going on or whatever, but Okay, and that's
because the the chats in fact showed up, right? That's why you
believe
No, there's a ton of stuff we can We can look at her her reaction
afterwards to to all of the calls and everything else and the
giggling and the celebrating and the joking about it and everything
else. But But But you would agree that's not what is being talked
about. What we're talking about here is a failure to moderate,
right? And that's not contingent on her reaction to the Bad and
Banano video, is it? That would but her reaction to the Bad and
Banano video can definitely give us insight into whether or not
we feel like she might have seen the message. For instance, if
that CPS call comes out and her reaction I don't know why you're
asking me. You know the answer to this. If the reaction to that
message comes out and she's like, "Jesus, guys, what the What
like This isn't cool in my community. We don't do [__]
like this." I'm like, "Oh, maybe she didn't see the message."
So I just want to say assuming she saw it, right? Assuming she
actually saw it.
But her reaction to the Bad and Banano video I just want you
to make sure you answer it. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Man, if you actually slowly walk through this, this is
like it's just an insane burden when the conversation's going
so long. This is still like going to go on for another 3 and
1/2 hours like at minimum basically, okay? But like if you just
walk through this, it's like
it's so frustrating to see people like take Destiny's side over
Pisko's because of how obvious it is all the tactics he's deploying
here, right? Like that he is just spamming out new issues, that
he can't stop and answer any question Pisko
And it happens Oh, I think we're on time number four now,
right? Where he's just spammed new issues instead of actually
answering Pisko's question. Pisko has barely spoken in the past
20 minutes.
Um even if this were true, Alibaba, right? Even if this were
true,
I think the way this conversation's been conducted so far, it's
like very obvious to me that one of the people is willing to
engage with facts, and the other person is just trying to paint
them in as bad a way as bad a way as possible to inflict maximal
reputational damage in a totally spite-based manner, right? Hey,
I think some people I dislike agree with you, and so I'm going
to try to paint you as as as like as unreasonable
paint you as as unreasonable figure as possible, as bad faith
as possible,
as unreasonable as possible, right? Kind of said the same thing.
And I'm just going to keep bringing up things that are going
to get people's emotions involved instead of actually dealing
with anything you say. And then when you point out that I'm like
lying, I'm just going to bring up more things that will get people
emotional about this. Wow.
You You asked that question, and what did I answer? Do you remember
what I answered? What did I say? You You were asking this question
before
asked this question. No, you asked the question, "Do you think
that she saw those messages?" You asked it. Do you remember what
I answered? That we don't that you said you don't know. I don't
know. But you say you do know, right? So you do know. And And
the reason And And in virtue of what can you make that probabilistic
So Pisko's going to point out that this is the exact kind of
probabilistic insight Destiny said Pisko is bad faith for even
making in the first place. About And then a ton of his community
will say he's bad faith for making in the first place, right?
Well, you can't know Ethan's mind state so mental state. So you
don't get to say that. >> Streamers generally watch their
chat because chat will generally respond to messages in stream
because streamers usually have other moderators in their chat.
So So the only thing that I'm bringing up here, and the reason
why I'm bringing that up is because yes, streamers watch their
chat. I watch my chat. Hutch watches my chat. I know from experience
and I'm sure you know from experience that if there are if a
small amount of people as compared to a big amount of people
as a compared to a moderate amount of people,
you know, making a certain comment that will bear or whether
we're looking at chat, that will bear on whether or not we ought
to have culpability for failure to moderate. You'd agree with
that, right? Some Not necessarily. No, it depends on the comment.
Of course not. So so there's a situation in which let's say one
person in DGG says something crazy crazy crazy crazy the the
worst thing someone could possibly write in DGG and no one catches
it that changing the level of intensity of the message is going
to bear on whether or not there's a failure to moderate?
Correct, because I think that depending on the community you've
cultivated and depending on the moderators you have, I think
people in chat would be responsive in a predictable manner to
that message. Yes. If somebody in chat typed out a lengthy thing
of this I'm going to drive down and kill,
you know, Kafka Kafka Esquire. I've got I'm going to drive down
and I'm going to murder him in chat. They type it all down in
chat and nobody says or responds to anything. I don't believe
that that would happen. It's it's beyond beyond credulity to
me. So so so Kafka, I mean I'll appeal I'll appeal to you. Is
that convincing to you? So because some you know, individuals
say some bad things in the chat absent a showing that this person
is talking about >> individual saying a bad thing in chat.
It's about Okay, just really quick really quick. Okay, can anybody
here
tell me what Destiny's actually going to disagree on?
It's literally it's literally just going to be an emotional argument,
right? When when Pisco's trying to generalize it so it's not
like directly he's saying basically would you apply the standard
to anybody else? So he's going to try to generalize it and Destiny
goes, "No, don't generalize it. Don't do that." What is his criticism
here?
What did Pisco say that's incorrect? Oh, you're He's talking
about some individuals in chat. No, it's not some individuals
in chat. Wait, who is it
What do we What What is the criticism that could possibly come
out right now about cultivating a community to be receptive to
these messages, watching a video that is parallel to these messages,
reading chat comments that seem to align with these messages
and then having the messages show up in chat. You're making
Okay, so Destiny has
is totally guilty of all of these things times like a thousand
over Denims, right? Obviously, crazy standard for him >> seem
like it was a mysterious case of this message was a one-time
thing that popped up out of nowhere. Obviously, I Like Destiny
goes and joins the stream of the person who argues that it's
totally justified to dox people. He doxes people himself. He
uh he totally tries to get that entire part of his community
engaged, the part that is going to dox people that could, right?
He's basically advocating for this. They'll repeat all of his
talking points on how doxing is justified, right?
And then he'll go and criticize Denims here who's done none of
that work to get her chat to like Bad Empanada. Like not even
close. be sympathetic to that because because the intent aspect
from the both the community and the streamer are completely absent
there. Something you've completely never And he accepts responsibility
for that. You think he accepts responsibility for him having
a doxing community? Even
He does not. He says, "No, no, no, I can't even get people to
dox people in my community because my community hates
Do you think that's Do you think that's taking responsibility?
Do you think that's taking responsibility? That's totally insane
to me that you would think that, but not shocking actually. Probably
pretty much in line with the other things you say in the chat,
but >> We're spoken about it all almost to Hutch in that
conversation. Um but when the intent seems to be there at least
heavily implied from the creator and when the receptiveness is
there from the community and then the messages start to pop up,
you can't act like that's a happy accident. Who knew? LOL oops,
especially given the response to those messages afterwards. Which
was to condemn it, right?
One second. Wait, Denims condemned the CPS calls? Did Denims
say that she didn't agree with the CPS calls?
I feel like this was after a lot of pushing. But It's not. She
said she she said you should never do it. Now, I think she undercuts
that when she says the thing about oh, they're probably young
enough to like not really think it's that bad, right? But not
going to respond to that. You can see it both ways. Isn't it
like saying if if they do so dox I support it? No, it's a doxing
community. No, you're you're totally trying to equivocate. It's
fine. I'm not going to respond very much to you anymore to be
honest. Yeah, and like you could hop in the Discord. If you want
to hop in the Discord and actually have this argument, we can
totally do that. Don't you know where the Dooby Donos I won't.
I won't. You can hop in the Discord if you want to actually talk
about it. If Hutch is familiar with the content clips, how did
he fall for Ethan's blatantly misleading edit of the Denims chat?
One that clearly inflated how many people were talking about
CPS in real time. That's a great question cuz absolutely Hutch
fell for it. Hook, line, and sinker, right? He believed that
the chat presented
was actually her chat and that Denims couldn't miss it based
on that, right?
Do you know?
Do I I don't I didn't follow this or talk about this obsessively
for a year. So no, I probably saw this clip like 7 months ago.
Okay, do you want to go and find the clip to see what her initial
response was? We can. I I just think that when there's a failure
to moderate and someone is making claims that she absolutely
saw it and had a bad response to it, I think the burden is on
them. And just saying well, streamers generally look at their
chats, um that's I don't think that's going to do it. I mean
there I'm sure >> is that streamers generally look at their
chats. Why do you keep saying >> Well well well plus the
the messages were really I've got all the donations in a thing.
Yeah, I've got all the donations.
In order to say that there's like some uh responsibility here,
you're going to have to look at the number of messages, any evidence
that she actually saw the messages, any message any evidence
that someone uh you know, DM'd it to her. That's the kind of
stuff to show that claim. Not just that it existed. No, >> You
don't even believe this. This is why I'm saying your arguments
are coming You're not I know you're not this stupid. What don't
I believe? Let's let's back that you would need every single
one of these like discrete percentage figures. I'm like what
was the messages per hour and how what was the eye tracking on
the screen per hour and what was the blah blah blah. If I was
watching a video on stream that talked about I just I had just
walked away. I just walked away. I wasn't muted. I just walked
away and I just noticed that Destiny once again did the complete
hyperbole play, right? That Pisco never said this that Destiny
has tried to tried to totally hyperbolically restate what his
position is, but he didn't say anything like this. Like I can't
make a claim here unless I know literally everything. No, he
didn't say that, right? He's like, "Oh, you would probably want
more information here." But Destiny's gone to the hyperbole play
again instead of engaging with anything Pisco said. He's just
gone to the hyperbole play because he has no real argument. He
has no leg to stand on here and he's purely bad faith in this
conversation. There is like not a single I think at some point
later once they start talking about culpability, it goes to an
intelligent place a little bit, but he is being entirely like
entirely bad faith in this conversation.
>> I know you're not this stupid, man. >> back that
you Someday let's listen to Pisco's claim again. The claim is
that streamers generally look at their chats. Why do you keep
saying that? >> Well well well plus the messages were really
depraved. I think you in order to say that there's like some
uh responsibility here, you're going to have to look at the number
of messages, any evidence that she actually saw the messages,
any message any evidence that someone uh you know, DM'd it to
her. That's the kind of stuff to show that claim. Not just that
it existed. No, No. No. No. You don't even even believe this.
This is why I'm saying your arguments are coming You're not I
know you're not this stupid. >> What don't I believe? Let's
let's back that you would need every single one of these like
discrete percentage figures. I'm like what was the messages
Let's call Pisco's strawman as well. Okay, sure. Factorio NFT?
Give me Pisco's strawman here, okay?
He just mischaracterized what Destiny said. Okay, hold on. I
I might have missed it. I was looking at something in chat here.
uh responsibility here, you're going to have to look at the number
of messages, any evidence that she actually saw the messages,
any message any evidence that someone uh you know, DM'd it to
her. That's Sorry, what is the what Where did he mischaracterize
what Destiny said?
I might I might have just missed it. Hold on. Let's go back even
further cuz Factorio NFT says I just missed something where Pisco
misstated
>> saw this clip like 7 months ago. Okay, do you want to
go and find the clip to see what her initial response was? We
can. I I just think that when there's a failure to moderate and
someone is making claims that she absolutely saw it and had a
bad response to it, I think the burden is on them. And just saying
well, streamers generally look at their chats, um that's I don't
think that's going to do it. I mean there I'm sure >> is
that streamers generally look at their chats. chats. Why do you
keep Okay, so it's not the claim that streamers generally look
at their chats. I Factorio NFT, how much money you got? You want
to bet like 10 subs on this or something that Destiny has said
streamers are always looking at their chats, which is fund like
fundamentally equivalent to streamers generally look at their
chats.
In fact, it's probably a stronger claim. Do you think Pisco's
really misstating what Destiny said here?
Or do you think Destiny is just lying about what he did say?
I'm curious. We're we're waiting on Factorio NFT to see if he'll
respond here.
I actually I do want to know because
it's pretty it's pretty critical, right? I don't want to just
be missing Pisco misstating what Destiny said. But from my recollection,
Destiny has said in this conversation, streamers do get definitely
like look at their chats. They're always looking at their chats.
Yeah, they generally look at their chats. I'm just waiting. Is
this guy
Is this guy
Destiny listed
Wait, hold on. Destiny listed like four to five things now. Wait,
Denims condemned the CPS calls? Did Denims say that she didn't
agree with the CPS
I feel like this was after a lot of pushing. But Do you know?
I I I didn't follow this or talk about this obsessively for a
year. So no, I I probably saw this clip like 7 months ago. Okay,
do you want to go and find the clip to see what her initial response
was? We can. I I just think that when there's a failure to moderate
and someone is making claims that she absolutely saw it and a
wedding at a bad part of her master. I think the burden is on
them. And just saying well, streamers generally look at their
chats, um that's I don't think that's going to do it. I mean
there I'm sure
>> So he said
the other factors are not whether or not she said it, right?
What are the other factors he said? Cuz what I remember is how
she acted after, um how she joked about it after. So the thing
I saw was streamers are focused on their chats. That's what I
heard first, right? Such as culture, watching a video about CPS.
But it's about whether or not she saw the chat messages.
Do you think whether or not she saw the chat messages is affected
by watching a video about CPS? Is that streamers generally look
at their chats? Why do you keep saying that? >> But well
well plus that the messages were really depraved. I think you
in order to say that there's like some uh irresponsibility here,
you're going to have to look at the number of messages, any evidence
that she actually saw the messages, any message any evidence
that someone uh you know DM'd it to her. That's the kind of stuff
to show that claim. Not just that it existed. No. >> You
don't even believe this. This is why I'm saying your arguments
are coming You're not I know you're not this >> I believe?
So he's like, "Hey, I probably need to know like how likely it
was that at any point in time some instance she like looks at
her chat that a CPS message was there, right?" So that's what
Pisco's saying I would probably need more information. Here's
some examples of information that could make me like make a more
you know deterministic huh that could make let me determine something.
That could let me make like a real call there. And how does how
does Destiny receive that? Does anybody disagree with what was
just said? That hey, if you could show me like how persistent
these messages were, how likely it was that she saw it like if
you give me some stats on her chat, that could probably let me
make like a Like if it's 50% of the messages say call CPS now,
then I would never make that argument, right? But there's some
like obviously
obviously we just want like there's some facts I want to know
to know like what percentage of the chat is having this level
of messaging. Let's let's back You would need every single one
of these like discrete percentage figures. I'm like what was
the messages per hour and how what was the eye tracking on the
screen per hour and what was So eye tracking on the screen per
hour. Did Pisco say eye tracking on the screen per hour?
Or did
did he say that? Or was Pisco just going like, "Hey, I think
um probably I just want like to see like what percentage of the
messages involve CPS or something like
And Destiny goes, "Oh, you need all these crazy things like eye
tracking on the screen per hour What the [__] are
you talking about? Who are you Who are you talking to?" Uh he's
being hyperbolic here obviously. Uh we pointed out the same pattern
of hyperbole multiple times Factorio NFT, right? When Pisco's
clearly saying something totally sane, totally obvious, a totally
like a claim nobody would disagree with, and Destiny tries to
hyperbolize it to make it absurd. We've pointed this out at least
twice now, yes?
He does this to derail. I know he does it to derail. We still
haven't addressed the multiple times that Pisco's laid out that
like, "Hey, you lied about me. You made something up about me.
You should apologize for that, right?" And Destiny goes, "Well,
even if I did lie about you, I shouldn't have to apologize."
Which is what is entailed when he says no, I shouldn't have to
apologize when Pisco lays it out. So I'm just trying to lay out
who is the good faith actor in this conversation. So far it's
like 99%
Pisco, 1% Destiny. Destiny's obviously being bad faith in this
conversation. >> This is the blah blah blah. If I was watching
a video on stream that talked about how to kill black people,
and while I was watching this video I was laughing along and
like, "Oh man, you good kill black people by the way." And then
some people in chat started typing up like, "Oh man, I'm going
to go kill black person, right? There's this black person near
me that I should I I didn't even >> video on stream that
talked about how to kill black people, and while I was watching
this video I was laughing along and like, "Oh man, you good kill
black people by the way." And then some people in chat started
Okay, but that wouldn't That's already disanalogous in the in
in the one way it's disanalogous in terms of the video wasn't
directly unless I missed it. Did the Bad Empanada video directly
say somebody needs to call CPS right now? It might have, but
I don't recall it saying somebody needs to call CPS right now.
Right? So it's already just listing out bad things. It'd basically
be like a video on It'd be like a Lauren Southern video, right?
typing up like, "Oh man, I'm going to go kill black person, right?
There's this black person near me that I should kill." And then
5 days later a black person near me ends up getting killed. There's
no way that a year later you're like, "Well, do we really know
that Destiny saw that particular message in chat? Like what were
the messages per hour?" Like we know that sometimes he doesn't
catch every single message in chat. You would say, "Well, no.
You're So this is the the slide, this is the disintegration of
the barrier between saying, "Hey, here's some clips about Ethan
Klein talking about his kids, which are bad." And the direct
calling of like, "Hey, everybody should call CPS right now."
I I don't know about the Bad Empanada video. Can we see that
part? Can anybody find that? I I actually don't know.
Yeah, Factorio NFT I just pointed out exactly how I'm being fair,
exactly like why I'm being fair. If once the transcript comes
up, just remember it. And once the transcript comes up, we can
go back and see that. I do not believe Pisco was misstating his
position at >> You're clearly cultivating a community of
people that are receptive to the message, or watching a video
that is echoing the message, and you're laughing along and giggling
at the message. Well but well let's just break it down. I mean,
so if if there is an unhinged individual in your chat and um
they say something totally unhinged, and the community just kind
of like disregards him. They don't No one brings it to your attention.
And it And you know, it it turns out later on um let's not introduce
for the moment and we can add it later that you're um you know,
that you're cultivating a community specifically to go after
these people whatever you want to say. But just that just that
by itself. You don't think that we would say, "Well, hang on,
you can't blame Destiny for this. You can't blame Destiny for
this. They didn't see the chat." So and when it was and when
it was brought >> I would agree with you. Wait, Steven,
can I can I please hold on? Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Wait,
wait, wait. Wait, let's let's go piece by piece, right? I agree
that if it was one crazy message, you wouldn't hold a person
accountable for that. For sure. So so so that's what we're talking
about here. And what I would say is hang on a second, Right to
Bear Arms didn't see that. And as soon as it was brought to uh
Steven's attention, they Probably like I think if you were like
doxxing people explicitly and stuff like this was getting posted,
I wonder like is this stuff getting actioned on? My streamer
posts doxxes of his haters. He has no idea what to do with this
info. Am I supposed to mail in pipe bombs?
That's like That's like pretty bad, right? Is that person that
person get moderated out of the chat or
What That seems like it'd be a little concerning, right? Like
that's obviously like way way way way way worse than anything
that was said in Denims' chat. Pretty obviously, right?
What What we're holding people accountable for the chat, right?
Definitely? We're going to hold people accountable for the chat?
Probably if you're going to doxx people as a matter of policy,
you probably want to make it very clear that nobody should ever
do anything. I don't know if that's ever been done that like
you have a zero tolerance policy for anybody ever doing something
like this, maybe.
Bro, I'd argue Destiny's responsible. Oh, well, there's a lot
more messages like this Factorio NFT.
Very interesting. Ban the person. Right? Th- These are the arguments
that you had all the time with people who would come into the
and DJ would be like "Oh my god, look at this this comment that
was right there. It was so mean. It was so horrible." And and
you didn't do anything about it. And you just let it happen.
And you And you This is the exact same arguments that where you
were like, "Well, listen, I hold my community to a high standard.
And when it's brought to my attention, we take action." That's
what you would always say. And I would say, "Okay, that's reasonable,
right? If someone is doing something and they like There's a
lot of [__] that happens >> thing over and
over again. Yeah, this isn't this situation though. >> So
so how So so the disanalogy I'm guessing is because
the fact that they're cultivating like snarkers or people who
do a certain thing, right? Who are have a certain malicious attitude.
Is that
Um I would say that probably the larger aspect here is the fact
that they that Denims was watching a video that was basically
calling for or getting as close to calling for this thing as
possible. Chat was vibing with the video. Denims was vibing with
the video. And then people in chat started to do the next logical
thing of talking about CPS or CBS calls. So that these things
are Are you saying that there's a that there's a lack of connection
there from A to B to C to D? No, I mean I don't think there's
a lack of connection in the same way I don't think there's a
lack of connection between the Republicans when they argue about
what I what you are
Hold on. Didn't Destiny post a picture of Rose in a DGG shirt
to mock her for filling a doxxer? Isn't that what led to her
being found? What was his justification for that? Um I don't
know, but we do know for a fact that he did say that that happened
and that he was the person who helped them find her. So when
he later virtue signals about how bad this was, that's There's
probably a lot of reasons not to really believe him at all.
You already know what I'm going to say. That there's there is
a clear connection between the people in terms of the same kind
of connection, you know, calling people fascist, saying that
they're going to destroy the country, saying And we make this
argument for Trump all the time. All the time when we're talking
about Yeah, calling people Oh, hold on. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait. So So can we say objectively that Destiny has done
more to call for a another CPS call than Denims has?
You need help. I'm clapping and crying. You learned more from
Hasan than he ever could have hoped. And now we've come full
circle on the start train. I hope CPS can save your children
before the worms turn them into RFK clones gas bag.
So like obviously we're just only making the best faith here,
yeah. We're just making the best faith arguments we can. This
is not spite based. This guy does not form his opinions based
on spite. He's just really like consistent. He's really cool
and consistent and not a total piece of [__] not
a totally
obviously disingenuous piece of [__] Yeah, okay.
All right. That Wow. Sounds like Yeah, I I don't know, man.
Is there
Maybe he's the one who actually needs a caretaker, okay? He needs
somebody give Right to Bear Arms the the keys to all of his devices
so that Right to Bear Arms can actually lock them all so he can't
post on social media. We We delete all of his posts like this.
We I don't know, man. I don't know, man. I don't know, man.
A fascist? Wait, how How does that How does that relate to anything
we're talking about here? >> let me give you an example,
right? So you just said it's not hard to see a >> No. No.
The Okay, Factorio NFT. Here's Here's the argument. We're saying
that Denims, due to her celebration and and enjoying of the CPS
call, deserves to have life-ruining financial burdens placed
on her through a copyright lawsuit through through a different
mechanism that doesn't address that CPS call, okay? So I'm saying
Destiny has done more to celebrate that CPS call. He's more directly
celebrated that CPS call and endorsed it. And so any life ruination
through any mechanism, like let's say for example like the Pixie
lawsuit, everybody would be cool with that, right? He totally
deserves that life ruination around to find out even if through
if it's through a totally different mechanism. So you would have
no criticisms of the plaintiff in his case, right? Because [__]
around and find out he's a piece of [__] He called
for CPS. He celebrated CPS.
Right? Yeah, I'm probably I'm actually We'll wait for this response
and then we're done arguing with this guy.
Cuz he's slowing down the whole stream
You can hop in the Discord if you wants.
100%? Okay. So Factorio NFT, do you have criticisms of Pixie?
Do you have a criticism of Pixie and her case? Yeah, we pulled
this up Rhinox. Yeah, we we pulled this up already. Do you think
it's unfair that Destiny's being sued?
You have to say no, right? Or else you're just obviously
this whole time.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes,
yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes,
yes, yes, yes, yes.
I think she's warranted. Okay, is that why you've come in the
chat multiple times trying to say like, oh Pixie's getting totally
owned right now?
Because you think she's warranted? Is that is that why you did
that? Factorio NFT, you obviously Like I'm sorry, man. I'm just
going to block you from the chat. You can type to whoever you
want. Just obviously disingenuous, obviously lying. But okay.
Okay. So what So when I
I'm building out what you kind of said, I'm trying to say this
is the basics of >> You can type all you like. I just I'm
not going to bother addressing any more of your arguments. You're
obviously arguing about this. >> Steven said and how does
it apply to the thing I'm about to bring up. And so when you
say, "No, no, no, no, no, no, it's kind of seems like you think
I'm dodging it, but I'm just directly answering it." And so I
think it'll be a lot easier if you just let me go through it.
So you said basically um they don't have to explicitly say it.
That's different than you said you had a 5-hour talk with Rob
Noer. You had a 6-hour talk with Hutch. I I don't think you're
in any position to say any conversation led by you is made easy,
but go ahead. Well, I mean I don't know what that shows. You
have long conversations with people all the time. How does that
show that like a particular thing it might be like You had like
a 5-hour talk with Hutch and you covered basically no ground.
I'm just saying it's funny for you to imply that I'm the one
that is slowing down the conversation. You yap a ton and it takes
you forever to get to the point. I'm not saying that I'm always
I'm always like the most This guy is a bit of a yapper, sure,
but it's clear what he means, right? You just have to take the
time to actually listen to what he's saying and understand it.
And Hutch I think Hutch had to ask for some >> let me [__]
get to it. So you went and said something Yeah, but Kregar, what
I'm arguing is Factorio NFT basically didn't engage in the chat
for months and would just come in when Destiny would say, "Oh,
Pixie's like losing the case." He would come in the chat just
to be like, "Ha, this stupid [__] getting owned."
That that's his engagement with the chat for like the past couple
months. So I'm saying he's being disingenuous when he says that
he believes that the lawsuit is justified.
I I think that's very clear in like the things he said. But if
you disagree >> say that you're always I'm sure you just
mischaracterized what I said, but that's okay. Go ahead. Okay.
So you said when you lay it out A to B to C to D, you don't have
to explicitly say it for someone to get the picture, right? That's
kind of what you were saying just then? That the mere fact that
you know, Denims is laughing along to it, seemingly very receptive
to the argument being made by Bad Empanada, that you know, you
we don't have to be able to show that she like explicitly said
go do this to have that kind of argument. A to B to C to D, right?
That was your framework kind of? Yeah, yeah, I understand your
play. You're going to play games around the explicit word, but
yeah, go ahead. Wait, Cuffer, do you think I'm trying to appeal
to If you're going to keep accusing me of bad faith, Cuffer,
do you think anything I'm doing right now is improper? Do you
think I'm being playing weasel games? I'm trying to address what
Steven is saying. But but no, but like it's it's tiresome when
you're accusing me of bad faith in the middle of these You're
not at the bad faith part yet. Keep going. Maybe you won't be.
Maybe I was wrong.
You accused him of bad faith multiple times in this conversation.
In fact, he brought those up right at the beginning. I want to
be wrong. Go ahead. All right. So when the Republic I haven't
even gotten to the bad faith part. Well, what were you talking
about the whole probability weasely's thing at the beginning,
Steven? What was that? comes come up and say to you, Steven,
"You live in plausible deniability.
You call all of our people fascists. You say that they are scum
of the earth. You say that they are essentially scum. And that
you refuse in front of us to condemn violence. And so even you
might make some self-serving statements here and there, but you
do A to B to C to D. And so why shouldn't we hold you to the
bad things that happen afterwards? Talk to me about the disanalogy
there."
Because one, I don't watch videos of people talking about how
to kill conservatives. Number one. Number two, I have no reason
to believe that any killer or murderous person has ever come
from my community. Number three, call He's been referenced in
manifestos of murderers already, of like mass shooters. Calling
somebody a fascist or I don't believe personally that that that
person came from his community. I think that person was trying
to write like a shotgun manifesto. But literally he has been
named in mass manifestos for mass shooters. >> Or scum
of the earth or whatever. One of the things that I say all the
time everybody listen cuz you know, you have the right to think
that about other people and you don't Wait, what? It was a guy
who just named a ton of people. Like Turkey Tom was in there
as well. >> to kill them for it. Okay, freedom of speech.
You can have absolutely abhorrent views in this country. Okay,
and number four, you can say that I refuse to condemn violence
in particular situations. There are hundreds or thousands of
clips out there of me saying literally right after the Charlie
Kirk thing, there is a 30-second clip of me saying the guy that
shot him should hang for it. You should never kill people in
this country. I have an unambiguous position
Wait, why is he just lying right now?
Why Wait, why is he just lying? He refused to condemn violence
when Andrew Wilson asked him directly. But Andrew Wilson was
basically like, "Hey, Destiny, did I misunderstand you or were
you just like totally down with this? You refuse to condemn the
violence." He's like, "Yeah, I do." Until Trump and So Andrew
Wilson just made him repeat it multiple times. Why Why are we
pretending that that didn't happen? Just totally rewriting history.
Why do people participate in that rewriting of history would
be my question. You look totally disingenuous when you participate
in that rewriting of history. He did eventually get to the right
position after everybody around him, right? Every single person
around him came and said, "Hey, you should disavow violence."
on political violence, you might think differently because of
a clip or Why Why am I pretending that like I don't know that
he had arguments with Soy Pill and Erodit and every single person
around him the whole time? He absolutely did. Why are we pretending
that didn't happen? >> that you've seen, but it didn't
happen in any of the times I spent any time in any part of my
community.
But I'm just saying that it but the funny thing is that if you
change any one of these things around and imply that one, people
wouldn't be far more critical of me or two, that I wouldn't change
my own behavior. If I had a chat and we were joking constantly
about like, man, I if I was going to kill like a conservative,
I wonder what weapon we would use. I bet you could do it with
a single-shot rifle. I bet you could do it from the roof. If
I were to talk [__] like that in my chat and then
Charlie Kirk is assassinated, what do you think my response would
be? To giggle and laugh about it? Or do you think that person
everybody They'll laugh. They'll make jokes about the people
being
Yeah. Uh would that be your response? I don't know. Would it
be? No, if I if if I had a chat room and we were talking about
the optimal way to I mean, okay. I see what he's I I see what
he's trying to do here, but that Is that was Hold on. Was Was
Denims participating in that to that extent? It's again become
like disanalogous, right? He has to We consistently invoke things
that are disanalogous in the primary way, right? As in he's saying,
"Oh, if I said we should kill Charlie Kirk or we joked about
killing Charlie Kirk and then he got shot, would I say I wasn't
responsible?" Well, again, so just show me the clip of Denims
doing That's all you have to do, right?
for murder a conservative and they get killed in that exact manner?
It Well, hang on. If you're joking specifically about it and
then afterwards you make another joke about Yeah, it's just like
disanalogous in the >> But not joking like not not necessarily
joking, but like saying like, "Yeah, I think if you wanted to
kill a conservative, this would be the best rifle to use. These
would be the best conditions, the best place." And then a week
later a conservative gets murdered using that like more or less.
Again, did Denims talk about how best to call CPS, instructions
for calling CPS, how to fill out the form, how to lie and not
get your identity? Did she do this
Like we just have to we have to get totally disanalogous in the
primary attribution way, right? As in how we attribute the the
Oh, whether or not somebody's culpable for this. That's exactly
how you have to be disanalogous here to make sure that piece.
That is a piece right there. Yep, that's an ASCII piece in Pisco's
chat right there. But it has to be disingenuous in this precise
way. Again, just totally leading into the emotionality of it,
right? Oh, if I did all of these things making it disanalogous
in the way that there's a primary contention. Pisco's argument
is she didn't do these things. So when Destiny says, "Well, but
hypothetically if she did do these things, she'd be really bad,
right?" Well, Pisco could just say, "Yeah."
Uh no, I know about the Joe Mac messages. I literally messaged
his mods and was like, "Hey, you guys should probably take care
of this."
That's it. By the way, that's exactly why Joe Mac Joe Mac is
banned from my chat. It's why you should just ban him if you
stream on multiple platforms, like obviously. Like auto just
auto ban that guy. So when the plans are jokes or not jokes,
the first set of plans that you're talking about, the first set
of >> I don't know if it would matter if everybody in chat
was kind of like, you know, yeah, you could. I think you could.
It was like looking up [__] like, oh, you know, from
a distance, you know, this range right here. Uh I I just don't
think it's like super funny to spam the hard R in chats
But maybe that Maybe that's crazy, man. That's wild. I I I feel
like um we there are a lot of like edgy jokes that are being
made that are made about and even conservatives that I'm that
DJG engages in. And I think that they're all taken in in in that
sense and I don't think that people think that they're serious.
But basically what I'm suggesting You know what? There's two
things. Well, you didn't even answer my question, but you know,
cuz you said it. There's a lot of things What question do you
think I didn't finish?
I just want to address what what did I not answer? Do you not
think that I would like severely change my behavior or make a
statement or would there be >> you would condemn it. Right,
right. You would No, I I I told No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO,
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO,
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
>> NO.
SORRY. WHAT WOULD you do? What would you do? Sorry. I'm trying
to understand.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. We got a Doobie Dono down here. Destiny
agreed it's reasonable to call CPS over these things, child having
this parasite. Didn't he say that's what CPS is for? How is he
any better than his worst characterization of Denims? Wait, did
he Well, I mean he said this tweet. Was there another thing where
it's like over that parasite? You think it's re Oh, not that
tweet. But is there another one?
>> understand. You're being stupid, bro. What would you
stop doing? >> tell you Did I just tell you Imagine if
we were calling Charlie Kirk a fascist and then he got killed.
Was that the example that I gave you? If you're saying that he
should be or you if you're saying that the conservative should
be killed, you would stop doing that, right? Is that what you're
saying? >> If I in chat were talking about the optimal
ways to murder conservatives and then some conservative were
to get a week later using more or less what we talked about,
I wouldn't just come Hold on. an illness. >> Uh is this
real or is this going to be a totally disingenuously clipped
thing that's not real at all? Hold on. Let me >> an illness,
negligence event, that is not justification for a CPS call.
Just so you know, your child contracting illnesses due to severe
negligence is absolutely grounds for a CPS call, and it should
be. We don't want kids who are getting sick because their parents
are being like insanely neglectful of them. They're what
Okay, hold on. What did he say here >> child contracts
a disease, an illness, even through a potential like a negligence
event, that is not just He said potential negligence event. As
in like you need to Probably, I would say Pisco's argument would
be you track down you need to turn that from potential into actual
negligence, right? As in how likely can you get How likely is
it that you get this disease not through negligence? >> fication
for a CPS call.
As in I think to me the reason you do the call here is precisely
Sorry, the reason you don't do the call is because you don't
have a good idea of what that child's home life is like. You
have like Ethan being hyperbolic on stream and then correcting
himself. So, you should look for more information. You should
look for more clips. You shouldn't just say, "Oh, I hear this.
I'm going to call now." Right? It should be an impetus to gather
more information. It shouldn't be an impetus to make to take
an action immediately. Just so you know, your child contracting
illnesses due to severe negligence is absolutely grounds for
a [__] If you did find out that it was due to severe
negligence through that extra investigation, then yes, you would
make that call back. Make that call would be >> [__] CPS
call, and it should be. We don't want kids who are getting sick
because their parents are being like insanely neglectful of them.
They're Would that Would that be an unbelievably crazy statement
to make? What the What do you Why do you think CPS is ever called?
So, again, we're just sewing out. I I do believe when Pisco says
potential there, I believe it be something like what I said cuz
that is my position. But maybe he Maybe he's like, "Oh, you should
never call CPS from the internet." I don't know. Seems like that
he's arguing that if you believe this if you saw the clip and
believed it, right, that you should make that call. For anybody
who believed the bad up in order thing, they should make that
call because it's totally justified to do so. Okay. A little
little bit weird, to be honest with you, but
Okay. come out and say, "I condemn I'm guessing, but I'm guessing
when it all comes down to it, all three of us, me, Pisco, Destiny,
would all be the same position there. That it's actually when
you hear that story, it's an impetus to gather more information.
It is not Sorry, it's a reason to gather more information. It's
not a reason to make that call immediately. >> the shooting.
Cuz if I were to come out and say that you should People should
roast the who condemn the shooting. You guys would really [__]
plotting it in chat. No, it would be a severe course correction
in my community. You You You would stop doing this. Pisco shouldn't
have engaged on this. He should have said actually come up with
like a more analogous to the primary thing we're disagreeing
on, come up with something that's more analogous cuz I don't
think this works, right? Like it is an analogy, but it's disanalogous
in the primary thing we're comparing. So, that's Analogies are
fine. Comparisons are fine. But the specific reason this would
be disanalogous is because you are explicitly like participating
in this in a way that Denims did not explicitly participate,
which is the heart of the issue we're >> [__]
like there's somebody who just got You would stop You You would
stop doing what? >> We definitely not make any more of
those jokes. That's crazy. I don't know if that killer came from
my community or if I contributed to it. It's like, "Okay, don't
say things like that." It would matter whether or not they came
to your came from your community that you would Isn't the risk
Isn't the whole argument >> matter at all. It wouldn't
matter if people are not feeding into it. I'm not feeding into
it. I would like to finish. So, regardless of whether they came
from your community Look, Hutch's whole thing is it doesn't matter
if we know whose community it comes from. That's Hutch's >> Hutch
was incor No, Hutch First, Hutch doesn't even believe that. If
he said it, he was misspeaking because you were him. So, so it
does matter. So, so I want to be I want to be clear. Does it
So, so it wouldn't matter in your case either. So, are you going
to call on your people to stop making jokes about assassination?
Hello?
Like that's To me, how How is the guy who jokes about all these
super bad things happening making these arguments that actually
if you joke about it after the fact, you are totally creating
a culture that causes that thing to happen. Right? Like it's
just nuts. Did he just run? No. Quick Doobie super chat again.
Just so we don't lose sight of it, can Desi please lay out his
justification for doxxing E-Sports Batman? Wow, that'd be cool
if we could get that. Is Maybe he will. Hello?
>> Is I'm going to ask, I think for the third time, was
the example that I gave was making jokes about a thing.
Oh, the example you Hold on. The example you gave was talking
about it, I guess beforehand. Um
Sure. Again, it's disanalogous. I actually don't know how Pisco
ended up there. I He should say that this is disanalogous,
to be honest with you. I think on this one, unless I'm missing
>> So, I want to be I want to be clear. Does it So, so
it wouldn't matter in your case either. Hutch's whole thing is
it doesn't matter if we know whose community it comes from. That's
Hutch's >> Hutch was incor No, Hutch First, he said it,
he was misspeaking because you were
Destiny, I I'm glad that Destiny and I could totally agree, okay,
that Hutch does not have agency, that Hutch is really incapable
of engaging in the conversation. Hutch is like a complete
who probably shouldn't have a stream. I'm glad that Desi and
I could agree on that. That's really weird. I don't know if his
community Is his community going to turn on him now? He's like
supporting a J Soc Queen and talking point that Hutch is like
actually brain damaged, totally without agency, completely incapable
of actually having these
I don't think Pisco believes that, but Destiny sure does. >> Number
one, and number two, it doesn't really matter if people are not
feeding into it. It doesn't matter. So, so it wouldn't matter
in your case either. So, are you going to call on your people
to stop making jokes about assassination?
Okay, so whether or not it's your
um that did it, joking about it doesn't matter. Like joking about
it is bad. So, Pisco's making like an adjacent point here. It's
not totally on on point with what Desi's saying, but again, the
hypothetical is disingenuous, so whatever. Hello?
Is I'm going to ask, I think for the third time, was the example
that I gave was making jokes about a thing. Yeah, so I That's
what I'm understanding. Maybe I'm not hearing well. Maybe I have
a a block in my head.
So, he's So, that So, Pisco, understandable mistake, but a mistake
nonetheless.
He's probably thinking Desi's trying to come up with an analogy
that could apply to the situation, not saying if we explicitly
came up with plans to kill Charlie Kirk in a time, place, and
whatever, right? Like Desi's saying we explicitly talked about
the conditions under which you could kill a conservative commentator,
right? So, and then it happened in that exact way. It's like,
"Well, yeah, you could probably point to more culpability there."
Um and absolutely what that would probably be a major indicator
of is that's where the investigation should go, right? Yeah?
Okay. Let's say in chat we're discussing between three different
rifles that we think could kill somebody in a single shot, the
appropriate distance by which to shoot at them, and how much
training would be required before we could take the shot and
kill them, and then how we would escape. Yeah. Desi, real quick.
I'm sorry. Wait Wait a second. Wait a second. Let me just ask
a quick question. I'm going to I'm really sorry if I interrupted.
Desi, are you saying it like just to use a term that might be
helpful, there's a like an element or a feeling of conspiracy
that exists in the chat >> Right. We're discussing about
a crime as if it's real. I want to use his Pisco doesn't believe
in conspiracy crimes or any of that. So, there are no crimes
like that in Pisco's world. So, no, I don't want to talk about
We're clearly I definitely believe more in
Wait, I definitely believe in
You don't think I believe in conspiracy? I'm saying that if somebody
in chat If If all of us were collectively engaged in this discussion
on the So, again, another character attack on Pisco. Has Pisco
done a character attack back on Destiny?
And by that I mean one that Desi wouldn't just lean into. Like
Desi would lean into all the things about doxxing, but has Pisco
made a single character attack? So, I I think we're at like eight
character attacks from Destiny so far. Ones that either Desi's
made directly or that Pisco has brought up that he made in his
stream the previous
I don't think I've heard a single character attack from Pisco
onto Destiny. optimal way to somebody. And everybody seems to
be talking along. You can call If you want to call it a joke,
that's fine. But everybody's talking about it, and then somebody
ends up dying a week later because of the same type of So, so
it's a situation in which they're talking in an ambiguously serious
sense. It's not so serious that anyone can say that it's like
genuine plans, right? And but cuz you didn't want to accept what
Kafka was saying there about conspiracy. But it's not so obviously
joking that it couldn't be fairly characterizable as a joke.
Is that right? It's ambiguous. >> Sure. Okay. And so, what
you're suggesting is um those kinds of comments, not fully jokes,
but not fully
explicit planning, serious planning, wouldn't you change your
behavior in the community going forward? Is that your question?
Yeah, I think that you would change your behavior going forward.
I I think the problem there is the disanalogy is with what you're
talking about with with the the kind of disanalogy. Yeah, so
so Oh, uh you know, I should like I kind of operated like a higher
level, so it's it's just I understand how it took Pisco a little
while to get there to like the obvious criticism you'd have.
I wasn't watching it, by the way. But I I get it. Listen, I'm
operating at like a higher level. The disanalogy is in the in
the context in which um Denims are watching that clip, it was
it's not talking about government action. It's not her agreeing
to do anything in in kind of like the preparatory Wait Wait Wait
Wait Wait Wait. Can I finish what I'm saying before you like
spaz out? >> Yeah. Sorry, go ahead. Like you agree she's
not like agreeing to contemplated government action, right? She's
not agreeing about the best way to to do the We not understand
on purpose or This is like literally everybody's just coming
in and going, "It's so funny." Literally everybody comes in and
goes, "Wait. Hold on. It's like common sense that Denims did
all these things." And like everybody knows that Denims did these
things. Even less in the waiting room. I'm covering this. We
can talk tomorrow even less. I'm good, to be honest with you.
We can talk tomorrow. I'm I'm just going to get through this
content cuz you guys will sit here arguing the dumbest [__]
for so long. I am totally down 100% to talk tomorrow night. Okay?
100% will not you will not be able to stop me. Okay? So, okay,
yeah, we're good. We're good. I just I it's like you have to
have you understand at some point if I do want to talk to you
about something if I do want to get down to whether or not something
happened and I think maybe people are overstating it and I have
multiple examples of people overstating it that I might ask you
for evidence and you going, well, you understand why she was
doing like the thing it's like, bro, you don't hold Wait, how
is Wick here? How is Wick here trying to hold Denims responsible
for this in a way that he would never hold Destiny responsible
for this [__] he does. Like isn't that embarrassing
for Wick? Shouldn't Wick like scurry off into a corner like the
rat he is? Like Wick, you will not hold Destiny responsible for
the explicit doxxing he does. How are you going to hold Denims
responsible for a Quick
Quick question.
I exactly what I stated previously. I just don't get it. The
infringement on Ethan, right? She's not talking about the best
way to plan a bad or malicious act against Ethan. You agree with
everything I just laid out so far? Not not really, no. >> Which
which part of what I just said did you not agree with about characterizing
Denims? It's the thing it is the thing that is logically entailed
by or would follow I'm sorry it would careful not logically follow.
It is the thing that would consequently follow from the behavior
they're describing. If I were to make a plan to get a bullet
right in front of somebody's head as Yeah, so the the disanalogy
here, the the disanalogous thing is that what Denims chat did
was not come up with a
Right? They didn't come up with a plan. They weren't talking
about how they would do it. They were saying, oh, somebody should
call CPS because they were saying, but as Destiny said, oh, if
you if you thought somebody was doing this through negligence,
which is the argument Badonkadonk's making,
then you would advocate for calling CPS. That's what they're
all doing. Destiny already won this argument for Pisco. Pisco
just doesn't realize it yet, right? That the argument Badonkadonk's
making is via negligence with clips of Ethan speaking. He's not
making these Like the only thing that fixes this and probably
the way you say Badonkadonk's bad faith here is Ethan comes out
and corrects this and I don't believe that's in Badonkadonk's
video, I think. I've never seen it clipped in the Denims stream.
Okay? Like that's But what Ethan says there, I personally think
you look for more information, but with what Destiny said, oh,
like a negligence event has been talked about, he hasn't been
cleaning up the poop, they put everything in their mouths, there's
dog [__] on the floor,
Like he's kind of laying it out for >> as quickly as possible
from 100 yards away. That would be a plan to kill somebody. Even
if that's not the actual last thing that I'm planning, right?
To say that Hot Shot's question, I'm curious, do you still stand
by this? If you genuinely believe that somebody's kids are being
sick are are sick because of severe neglect from the parents
such as they're crawling around in dog [__] do you
not think that that is an adequate grounds by which to notify
CPS?
I don't think you understood what I was saying there. I think
that
I will.
I think it would be adequate grounds for a person who believes
that negligence is is materially harming a child and that they're
that's happening that they would be that they I think I'm justifying
that that that would be justified. What I was saying there which
I think that you did not understand is that is not itself a justification
by which I mean, you know, someone could get from that reasonably
or unreasonably a particular justification and they could argue
that it's justified, but it's not itself a justification. So,
the analogy that I want to do to demonstrate the difference So,
I I Okay. So, justify a justification, I understand that to be
a me maybe this is my failure to communicate is saying something
like this, you should do this because XYZ. This In other words,
it's someone making an argument to a particular conclusion or
prescription. It's someone adopting a certain reasons, right?
In virtue of what is this okay? In virtue of this
I think that they are being neglected and that's why they're
sick. What I mean to say what you didn't understand there is
I was making a distinction between reasons that someone might
have that apprehension versus they themselves doing it, right?
And so the example I provide is you would agree, wouldn't you,
that a lot of people, maybe even millions of people, right? Upon
hearing the fact, and I believe that you think these are all
facts, that Trump is a fascist, that's trying to destroy this
country, that he is materially hurting and the cause of misery
and death across the entire world and that he could absolutely
be the cause for the the destruction of our society as we know
that. Do you think that that is a justification to enact violence
against Trump? God damn, Doobie is going the off, dude. Destiny
agrees Ethan's story is adequate grounds to call CPS. Is he also
building a committee of people who call CPS on Ethan? Wow.
No. No, right? Even though you those are all true things and
even though there are millions of people We've showed this, by
the way. Like it literally just is there. who could come to that
conclusion. The difference is Right. The difference is the You
don't know what I'm going to say. Well, we just agreed that it
wouldn't that you're dodging the difference between reasons Yeah,
yeah. Because the difference what the difference is is because
when I before I said this is the thing that's consequently entailed
by The reason is is because there are a plethora of ways to address
uh a difference even a severe difference in political opinion.
There are very very very few ways to address severe child neglect.
Yeah, so if you want to make this analogous then you have to
say you need to give me what are the other things that people
could have done with that information?
Yeah, so I'm not saying that an individual themselves um is would
not be justified in my under my view not to call CPS there. I
just want to be very clear about that. Uh in in the in the scenario
as presented where there is but it's not just them getting sick
and rolling around in [__] you right? It's it's the
neglect part of that that it's important. Because you're a father,
right? You understand that things happen that are like that's
what's so horrible about the the notion that CPS is justified
in this context which I've always said it's not justified is
because can I finish? >> is so I'm just trying to figure
this out
With like your kid overdosing while staying with you, would that
be like an act of neglect?
Just curious we're talking about things. I wonder if that would
be like an act of Talking about I was explicitly No, because
you're trying to make it something it's not. It was explicitly
about neglect. So, I I agree that Wait, do you agree Hold on,
let's do let's do very basic. Do you agree that the video was
about neglect? That was just watching a video about neglect.
>> Among other things but which neglect is a central part
of it, yes. It's not only about neglect, you'd agree with that.
Do you have a problem with me qualifying
Uh I don't know what qualification >> Wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait I just want I just want to
be clear and I just want to make sure that um we have total agreement
by Do you think Hold on, do you think this is like the balance
or something? No, please don't dox Doobie. He has done nothing
to deserve that. Is Doobie Doobie literally would come on this
this stream right here and argue with Destiny about these things
and ask these questions directly.
Why is it bad? Like literally they've invented a precedent where
being mean to Destiny means you should get doxxed, right? Like
that is the precedent they've set. You've been mean to me on
the internet. You've criticized my behavior, my publicly accessible
behavior on the internet. Therefore, you deserve to be doxxed.
That's like ultimately where they're going. That's basically
saying you should dox anybody who makes content on the internet.
I think that's a pretty silly line to have, especially when you're
using it explicitly as a weapon to inspire fear from people so
they don't engage. I just want I just want to be clear and I
just want to make sure that um we have total agreement by Kafka
as well. What I just qualified there, there's nothing wrong with
me saying that there's other purposes to the video, right? There's
nothing wrong with that? No, there's not. Okay. It's not weaselly
for me to say that. Okay, cool. So, the so the so it's about
neglect, right? So, if you are telling your audience and you're
watching something especially well, maybe even well, not even
especially actually this would be an element of the wrong. It
is a necessary part of it. If you if it was built on a lie, okay?
So, you have a thing built on according to Ethan at least a lie
that somebody is neglecting their child and it's at such a severe
point that the children are now becoming sick multiple >> Yeah.
And Denims is applying she she has this epistemic justification
to make all of these things even worse. Oh, diseases that adults
and children get are really bad for children. Oh, this must be
why they're sick all the time whatever,
How are you not What what is to a reasonable person listening
You read more on Destiny. Not surprised coming from a J-stock
fan. Watch more Queenman instead. Wow.
Wait, what was even said I don't know what was said to this guy.
Watch Queenman instead. >> do we have before us that would
be moral to pursue? Yeah, so I'm not saying that
What options do they have to pursue? Yeah, so the the general
audience?
By the way, I I believe if somebody is accusing him of being
a Destiny fan, I'm far less likely to do that. I'm I'm the one
who says Hutch isn't a DGG orbiter, by the way. I believe Queenman's
the guy who does say that. Sure, what options are there? They
could do nothing or They could do nothing, which is the case
for a lot of You agree that there's a a great deal of moral wrongs
that people are that are shown in videos and the vast vast vast
vast vast majority um you know, they're not directly saying that
a call for audience action, right? There's a for example
Okay, so that's not my question. My question is is what could
a person do? They could do nothing or Yeah, they they could do
nothing, that would be the vast majority of cases. They could,
you know, bring it to Ethan's
who are closer to the family. Uh if you actually um if you I
think are deluded enough to think that this is deserving of a
CPS call, which I do think it is >> Why would that be delusional?
It I think it's delusional on Ethan's own video. Do you not think
it's delusional on on what they were doing on on what you heard
from Ethan? What Ethan said essentially What you heard from We're
not talking really about what we heard from or Badonkadonk. We're
really talking about what we heard from Yeah, so you don't think
that somebody could listen to Badonkadonk's video and think,
man, I think CPS should probably get involved here. I think that
people could possibly think that, yeah, they could definitely
think that. Okay, you you understand that. Do you think Denims
understood that? Uh so, I think that Denims could understand
that other people could think that, yes. >> Okay. And was
Denims doing anything to counteract that thought or was she furthering
that thought? Yeah, so I think that she was in some ways adopting
a lot of what by laughing and by being coy about it. Do you disagree
with that
She didn't explicitly endorse it, right? >> strongly Well,
the fact that she started to talk about that when diseases happen
that are the same between adults and children that it's really
bad for the children doesn't seem like she was being coy or joking.
It seems like she was like She No, she was adopting it, right?
She was adopting it. Yes, yes, I agree. Okay, yeah. So, but she
but she didn't go out and say but she was adopting the characterization
of the harm, right? Not adopting the the response that you're
proposing here, right?
Correct. My argument is that the response So, I'm going to So,
I'm going to do an analogy here, which is the vaccine analogy.
Why can't we just talk about the thing So, because I want to
remove our into Dude, they just spent so long talking about Destiny's
analogy that was totally disanalogous.
And now Pisco's going to try to go to an analogy to illustrate
his point. Oh, why can't we just focus on this? >> malfeasance
about Denims and her malfeasance here. And I want to take a a
different case to see if our our reasoning holds up. Do you have
a problem with that?
You have a problem with that? Yeah, no. So, suppose that you
have a crazy anti-vax family and they go on YouTube and they
say, you know, I love my baby daughter, I love my son. We didn't
give them any vaccine, we didn't give them this, this, and that.
And I know that there's a raging case of measles going on here
in Arkansas whatever, but I know that with the grace of God they're
going to be okay and I'm actually sending them to school and
I don't care about anything but be but I know they're going to
be safe, I I it. And uh streamer, let's say yourself, uh watches
that and you directly say, "This is so irresponsible.
They are placing the life of their children at risk. These kids
could quite easily die, and there is no reason to do it based
on a delusion. These parents are completely neglectful. They're
so irresponsible. What are they
And then later on, some people call CPS. And uh commentators
come up to you and they say, "What the [__] Steven?
You did this. Are you culpable for that CPS call? In the moral
sense?" Not only would Not only would I be culpable, I would
probably brag about it. If that was a person's actual position,
that they felt like not vaccinating their kids was child abuse,
and they were saying things like that to the audience, and then
CPS was called, do you think the person would be like, "Oh my
god, I can't believe you guys called CPS." No, the person would
probably say, "Good, they deserve to [__] lose their
kids." >> you've been talking You don't You don't
Okay. You don't take the view that CPS is justified to call on
everyone who is part of an anti-vax family. >> No, because
you don't have a legal obligation to vaccinate your children,
and a lack of vaccinating your children doesn't imply negligence
in this case.
Wait, I thought he just said
that Wait, does he not believe that not vaccinating your kids
cause significant
He just said he would call because not vaccinating your kids
cause significant harm, and then he switched to actually you
don't have a legal obligation.
What What just happened?
How did that happen? Saying things like that to the audience,
and then CPS was
You don't You don't take You don't take the view that CPS is
justified to call on everyone who is part of an anti-vax >> you
don't have a legal obligation to vaccinate your children, and
a lack of Oh, I didn't go back to >> vaccinating your children
doesn't imply negligence in this case in the United States of
America.
We're not talking about legal We're We're not talking about the
legal standard here, are we? You You don't think To some extent,
Oh, we are talking about baked into it, but the legal standard
has baked into it a whole lot of ethical assumptions and implications.
Yes. If, for instance, we There are some laws that that if somebody
is following the law to some
Hey, Pisco, do you think you're going to get to talk there? Shut
the [__] up. I'm still talking cuz I talk really
fast, and you don't talk fast at all. So, I'm just going to keep
talking and keep going and keep going and keep going and keep
going forever.
Hey, Pisco.
Oh, what? >> We would probably assume, like, okay, well,
this person is probably trying to to except We're not talking
about CPS, which is a government body. They're not there to enforce
ethics, so they're to enforce the law, right? If you were to
send a kid to school every single day in in in filthy clothes,
or naked, or whatever else, right? And well, I don't know if
it's not ethical or not, but like maybe it's like a little You
say, "Well, there's probably something wrong here. There's probably
something not good here." The disease that Dennis is talking
about specifically was a disease of negligence, right? And not
vaccinating your children doesn't
Wait, no, it's But it's not a disease of negligence. I think
the part of the reason it's not okay to call CPS on Ethan is
because that disease can be transmitted through means that aren't
negligence. Like, you could get that from just playing with the
dog that hadn't like that hadn't pinched off effectively. Like,
easily a kid could get that. That it is not a disease that conclusively
proves negligence in some way. Now, I think there is some mandatory
reporting, probably due to outbreaks. You don't want multiple
people You don't want that outbreak spreading. But But the primary
argument people have for calling CPS being bad is that just because
you had giardia doesn't mean it's immediately a negligence situation.
If you believe that, that you just don't have an argument here,
then you then Destiny would just believe that calling CPS on
Ethan is justified automatic. It does not necessarily mean you're
being negligent. You don't think so in the sense that we're talking
about in the sense that we're talking about >> Actually,
I do. Actually, I do. Okay. But I don't But CPS isn't here to
address that type of I don't know if I call it a moral failing
or a disagreement on epidemiology or whatever. That's not what
the CPS tool is not used for that. is passed off as a disease.
So, that's like BadEmpanada's claim, right? But Destiny is saying
it's a disease of negligence. That's Destiny's argument right
now. He just said it's a disease of negligence.
And I would say probably it's not a disease of negligence, at
least not anywhere like maybe negligence could play into it like
any disease, I guess. Negligence could lead to it becoming more
likely.
But it's
If it's a disease of disease of negligence, and Ethan comes on
stream and says they got it and also makes claims that makes
it look or makes it sound to people like those kids are eating
dog [__] well, I think that is a negligence situation
that would rise to oh, you should just call
for that. But if I were telling my audience this is neglect,
this is basically child neglect, I think they should lose their
kids. I don't think Like, if I was driving that narrative that
[__] hard, and and somebody did call CPS, like, what
do you think my response would He just said
Wait, Pisco.
How does he say this?
And he obviously is the position that not vaccinating your kids
is neglect, and he said he would say as much, and then he would
like celebrate if the kids got taken away by CPS, and then he
said, "Well, actually it's not illegal." I'm totally lost on
what he's actually trying to claim here now. >> "Oh yeah,
yeah, I can't believe you guys did that. Oh." Well, I'm I'm I'm
I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm not here to say what I'm not here to
say what your your response would be, but I just think that like
even though I think I didn't like the analogy. You didn't like
the fact that my response would follow that and make you uncomfortable.
Ho- Hold on. Let's give me Dono.
Pisco is a bigot for making that vaccine denier vaguely southern,
but I support the behavior.
No, no, no. With With respect to if you were um you know, shown
back uh what what happened to that that child in or you know,
what happened in that situation. But what I'm what I'm trying
to talk about is specifically the situation in which there's
a you know, a vax this anti-vax family. You're saying that you
would You would feel culpable for the call that took place that
you don't know about, that you didn't adopt, that you didn't
want to happen. And someone did it, right? Someone did do the
CPS call. Now, you would recognize If I If I I would feel some
level of culpability, of course. If my audience is doing things
powered by things that I'm saying, even if I'm not aware Yeah,
I would Even if And even if you don't want it. And And even if
you don't want it. Even if you explicitly don't want it. You
didn't say it.
You didn't say it. Nobody operates IN THE REAL REAL WORLD that
way. You don't have to say a thing directly. >> I I I understand.
No, but I I know I understand. But in the moment, you it is your
belief and intent that you don't want someone to call CPS in
the hypothetical I'm giving, which I assume is mapped onto what
you just said. And you didn't say it at the time. So, there's
no there's no expression of any kind of government action. You
You just talked about the health risks there. And then someone
does it. It's something that you didn't want to happen. And then
afterwards, you say, "Hey, this is not
Do you feel that in that moment, in in the situation in which
you didn't want CPS to be called in this vax case, but someone
took your genuine, correct, true statements, different than this
situation where I think it's it's not true, but your genuine,
correct, true statements about the vax case, and called CPS,
that you would be culpable for it? Cuz you just pointed out the
health risks. That much. No. Right. Right.
So, this all comes down to whether or not you could prove she
saw the messages, whether or not she really wanted CPS called,
and then we just go back to the same argument again. Wait. No,
no, no, no, no. It's not right because the thing I told you earlier
that you're missing the the the reason why this is disanalogous
is because a lack of You Someone from your audience Uh I know
we fully imply neglect. The analogy is because a lack of vaccination
doesn't necessarily imply neglect. No, no, no. We might have
that epidemiological difference I know we disagree Wait. I know
we disagree on that. I know we disagree on that. But someone
hears you say that. They don't have the kind of view that you
do. Someone from your audience hears you say that. They don't
put two and two together that the the vaccine position doesn't
raise a cognizable claim and for the CPS stuff or whatever. >> to
be There's going to be There's Hold on. There's going to be some
level of of knowing or some level of intentionality or some level
where we're going to say, "Well, could a person have known that?"
If I'm talking to my child like, "I saw this dude outside yesterday
who looked just like Agent Smith, I swear to god." And then somebody
walks out and starts murdering people who are like, "I think
I do live in the Matrix." Am I culpable for that? Probably not.
Right. So, I don't think that there are many people that think
that anti-vaxing is a legitimate reason to call child protective
services. If we were to poll the entire US, my guess is that
number would come up at less than 10%. But for the amount of
people if you were to poll them, if children are getting sick
because they're crawling around in dog [__] all day,
do you think that CPS should be notified? That number would probably
be over 50, 60, 70%. Do you acknowledge the difference between
those two things? I I acknowledge that you probably find a big
a bigger percentage of people who would say that uh CPS should
be called in one scenario versus another. I totally acknowledge
that. >> Wait, say bigger. We're talking like one or two
orders of magnitude bigger. I I I don't know what what the basis
is for you to say that. I mean, I don't know. I'm I'm talking
about I'm I'm >> You have no nothing in your Wait. I know
it's more You think that like it might be like 5 to 7% difference,
or it might be like 5 to 9
>> I thought I thought this was like really unhinged to
ask people. Wasn't this Destiny's entire point about Pisco asking
for stats at point in this conversation, point in the Cutch conversation?
He got mad at both times,
Why is Pisco even fighting on this? Well, I think he's correct,
isn't he? He's basically saying that this all comes down to how
culpable somebody is, and he created a situation where it's like
basically if you couldn't tell or if you knew that she wasn't
doing it, right? As in we have some level of you know, we can't
definitely know her mind state. But if you knew she was innocent,
then shouldn't you not punish her as if she's guilty?
That's like what Pisco is trying to lean towards here. I just
told you I don't know. You said two orders of magnitude. I understand
order of magnitude to be like 100 times, 1,000 times.
An order of magnitude is 10 times. One order of magnitude, 10
times. Two orders of magnitude, 100 times.
10 to an exponent. >> times more. That's what I understand
it not to be like 25 more.
.5 like half a percent of people would be like, "Okay, well,
they're not vaccinated." You think if you You think if you And
I just want to make sure, Kafka, you understand this. So, you
think that if you polled America um when we're talking here about
an order of magnitude, that there would be uh you know, something
approaching, you know, 10 times, 100 times more people in America
who would say that, you know, um the the poop situation that
we're talking about, that's child neglect, and it would be an
order of magnitude less who would say not vaccinating your kids
is Okay. >> 8 to 80%, or 7 to 70%, or 6 to 60%. Yes, I
think it would be about that significant. I don't I don't I don't
I Like, in my mind,
He definitely doesn't know what an order of magnitude is, or
he's like beating around the bush. I don't know. But But But
But But But
if Destiny's arguing this, then what is even his claim against
Denims? I don't What is his What is his problem with what Denims
did? I I don't know where his Like, hasn't he just made the argument
that it was actually justified for Denims to call for the CPS
call, and like she should have been bragging about I I literally
don't understand what his argument would be. >> have that
intuition. I I think that if you ask like every Democrat or I
don't know, like I guess maybe maybe it could be that oh, well,
since it's a BadEmpanada video, you should assume everything
in it is a lie, which actually isn't all that far 80% of Democrats
would probably say that it's neglect to not give your your kids
vaccinations. I do agree, like I said before, that I think it'd
be more for the Are we talking about neglect? I thought that's
what you were just talking about, neglect, right? >> about
neglect rising to the level of having to notify CPS. Not neglect
as in like you've been neglectful. You're using this in a very
casual sense now. >> Okay, well, you're accusing me of
deceit this whole time. I'm totally I'm There's no war
There's no war game. >> IF SOME IF SOME If somebody sees
that children are crawling around in [__] versus
somebody else says that Kenley doesn't get their COVID shots.
Do you think that there would be a significant We'll just say
significant.
Oh, by the way, there are people in here who talk about like
the thing Destiny accused me of with
Uh I've never had anything in terms of material of that Rose
person on my computer in any of my Discord messages. I sent a
picture of this girl's face
to the Solo person and was like, "Hey, you didn't hide this person's
stuff well enough. Her Twitter account is pretty easily findable
if you look through your leaks. Um you should tell them A, tell
them to start scrubbing the internet of her PII cuz I think she'll
probably get doxxed by KF if they figure out who she is. That
was what I said. But I didn't have any ever and then because
I guess Solo's like a a provocative guy, he told me after he's
like, "You know that girl is like underage, right?" Like after
I showed him the picture. I'm like, "Oh, well. I'll delete that.
I'll delete that. Get it the [__] out of here." But
I never had material of her like Destiny has said multiple times.
So, never had never retained. Solo did say that, but then he
admitted that it was cropped.
And obviously it was just cropped to her face. I was just like,
"Yeah, people found her like face or her Twitter account. You
should probably get rid of or tell her to to start scrubbing
her PII." So, I was like, "I was trying not to let that girl
get doxxed." Um that was before I found out she was a minor and
probably like some people would feel there's a mandatory duty
to report. Like in response to me saying she should scrub her
PII, Solo I believe told me she was a minor. So,
I don't know. I If people have an issue with that, I would love
to know what the issue would be.
I don't think anybody would ever substantiate along those grounds,
but
Uh there are also aren't DMs of you admitting to it to another
content creator either. Yeah, there wouldn't be. Yeah, no, there's
nothing even remotely
I just wanted to point out how it's like obviously bad faith
trying to like weaponize the same accusations trying to muddy
waters, but I'd be totally fine with talking about it and discussing
what I've done, what Destiny's done, with anyone who wants to
make those
Okay. And it would be a fair assumption that most people would
probably know that, right? That like if I tell somebody that
these kids are crawling around in [__] all day. I
think that would be most people's intuitions.
Yeah, okay. So, if Denims is watching that, we know that that's
going to be most people's intuitions. That
I feel when you take a pic with with Wick TV of all people and
he's got to mog you by having far better dental
That's rough, right? Not rough. So, let me ask So, so, so, so,
so, so, let me ask you a question. If people's impressions are
that um a baby is eating poop um from you know, a dog animal
or something and they contracted a disease, on those facts alone,
like if you were to ask Americans, "Hey, um you're given the
situation in which someone reports
or tells you that um that they know that the baby contracted
a disease at a household for eating poop um and that in giardia
or whatever, they got giardia." How many Americans do you think
are going to say that CPS is justified on those facts? It's probably
going to be some amount even though we all agree it's not justified
on those facts. You
Yeah, but we're not talking about like a one-time this happened
one time and somebody got sick now. Yeah. No, no, I talking about
somebody saying if you want, we could even we could we could
we could flip it. Let's say that a kid shows up one time at school
and his clothes are a little bit dirty. And then somebody calls
CPS and the police show up and you know, they find out this kid
is being severely neglected or whatever else. You know, people
would probably look at the person who called CPS and be like,
"Whatever, I guess you got lucky." I mean, yeah, I mean, I guess
you know, good catch or whatever, you know. That would be it.
Let's say that a kid shows up and he's been sick, you know, all
year long and you find out, you know, the kid is like, "Oh, well,
the dogs poop everywhere in the house and we get sick all the
time." Let's say that you call CPS for this. I don't think this
is a good argument either.
Yeah, you should have. Good job. Nice. They give you credit.
They say, "Good job. You should have called CPS. YOU DID THE
RIGHT THING. CONGRATULATIONS. YES." I understand, right? So,
I understand that that the people would see a difference between
those two scenarios. What I'm trying to tell you is the mere
the fact that someone would think that what Ethan was doing is
neglectful doesn't per se make them unreasonable. And I want
you to acknowledge that. Even though they're wrong. You both
You and I both agree they're dead wrong. But the fact that someone
thinks that it's neglectful, that that opinion doesn't mean that
they're in bad faith, right? They're just They're just not thinking
clearly, right? Doesn't mean that they're bad faith. You agree
or not? I I don't know if I would call it neg-
He would have to agree. >> would be at like the level of
gross negligence or recklessness if you're a content creator
putting videos out on the internet for people to consume. No,
no, no, no, no, no. Did Destiny just think that Pisco is saying
it was neglectful to post the video?
Is that Is that what he just heard and
I'm saying this. If someone takes the view that what Ethan did
was neglect, that that isn't per se a bad faith opinion, right?
Someone could interpret the statement I don't know if I disagree
with that. I don't I would almost fight you on the points when
you guys were talking to when you were talking to Hutch, you
guys were saying the CPS caller was the one who had more culpability.
I don't even know if that's true necessarily. If you listen to
the things that these crazy people say constantly and you're
like, "Jesus fuck." And you're a mom or dad or whatever, you're
like, "Fuck man, I'm going to make a call to CPS." So, that person
wouldn't necessarily be in the wrong compared to like Denims
or
Oh, okay. So, somehow the CPS caller may be actually less culpable
than anyone in this situation. Actually, this Denims and BadEmpanada
may have more culpability in this situation than the CPS caller.
I want to explain what I was saying, right? I basically was saying
that I It's plausible
I Like, okay. If BadEmpanada
had disingenuously edited stuff and like made it sound
maybe even worse than it did. But like the problem is he lets
the Ethan clip
I would say Like I'm trying to think of how I could get there
that I want to blame BadEmpanada more than the person who actually
called CPS. Maybe you could get there if it's like totally invented.
If he like totally If he like used AI to make the clip of Ethan
saying that stuff, then maybe you could do that. Maybe. to me
that Denims violated her ethical obligation to refrain from um
you know, failure to moderate and to refrain from >> say
plausible, you mean that it is logically possible that she >> no,
no, no, no. Did Did Des- So, again, um Did he just say plausible?
>> to refrain from um you know, failure to moderate and
to refrain from When you say plausible,
If you listen to the thing talking to Hutch, crazy people say
constantly and you're like, "Jesus fuck." And you're a mom or
dad or whatever, you're like, "Fuck man, I'm going to make a
call to CPS." So, that person wouldn't necessarily be in the
wrong compared to like Denims or I want to explain what I was
saying, right? I basically was saying that I It's plausible to
me that
So, So, Pisco's entire problem with Hutch was that Hutch was
saying it's
Plausible does mean, yes, like based on evidence it's it's like
plausible. It's likely that it could happen. That this would
be the case. So, Destiny just wasn't paying attention and just
tried to mock him because once again, Destiny is just being bad
faith in this conversation. He just wants to try to humiliate
Pisco even though this is really humiliating for him. He just
tried to dunk on something that he misheard. And actually, he
misstates, so I don't even know if he misheard it. He like He
like says he said plausible. Well, by plausible, do you mean
No, no, no, it's obvious what he means by plausible. It was when
Hutch was going, "Well, there's like a one in a million shot
that this could happen. It's possible." Well, do you mean it's
like technically possible? Yeah, sure, okay, but that's you worthless
to talk about if you don't believe it. Denims violated her ethical
obligation to refrain from
you know, failure to moderate and to refrain from >> When you
say plausible, you mean that it is logically possible that she
that No, no, no, no, no, no, the prerequisites and such. No,
but there's a good that there's a good So, the the tragic the
real tragedy here is that Pisco
took this and thought Destiny was doing something other than
trying to humiliate
Right? Pisco took this as Destiny trying to make like a real
point.
And it is just Destiny trying to like throw Pisco's words back
at him in a way that doesn't make any sense and Destiny totally
it up and looks like a complete to anybody who's actually paying
attention. But he's like just trying to mock Pisco instead of
engaging in the conversation at all. Which realistically is just
on par with the entire beginning of this conversation so far.
And I don't know I feel bad for Pisco that like clearly this
guy was his
Clearly this guy was somebody he like looked up to in some way.
And And Pisco is still responding back in good faith here and
it won't matter that he's responding back in good faith. People
will still paint him as like the unreasonable person in this
conversation. Good chance. There's a By plausible here, I mean
I mean to say it's a it's a case that I think merits looking
at and on balance I think is reasonable that she didn't push
back enough on what BadEmpanada was doing. I conceded that during
the discussion. Um that Wait, why why are we phrasing it as if
she didn't push back enough?
Why Why What's the problem with phrasing it that way? Wait, wait,
wait, wait, what's the problem with phrasing it that She's saying
it sounds like because if a person murders somebody and the other
person was holding them down the entire time, you wouldn't say,
"Well, the guy holding them down wasn't pushing back enough on
his friend murdering the guy." She was assisting here with the
claims of negligence. She wasn't just like All I'm trying to
All I'm All I'm trying to say is you are s-
Like Pisco literally can't say anything without Destiny trying
to interrupt and gish gallop in a different direction.
Like the entire By the way, the heart of this conversation is
exactly what Destiny just tried to paint as obvious. Like, "Well,
no, no, no, no. I think she's directly responsible for this."
That is the heart of the conversation you're having. So, you're
basically interrupting him to go, "I'm going to restate the title.
I'm going to restate the title of the debate, the main question
of the debate. I'm just going to restate that." You understand
how that's completely worthless to the conversation, right? Everybody
here would understand that it's complete It doesn't add anything.
He just interrupted Pisco to restate the main contention of the
debate as if Pisco's unaware of what that contention is. So paranoid
The only distinction I'm trying to make here Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, let me let me state it. The reason is when you start
with the thing that she didn't push back enough, it sounds like
we're starting at zero and we're arguing to how much did she
push back. But I'm not starting at she should she did nothing.
I'm starting at she was culpable They're even watching right?
They're even watching it right? That's what you're trying to
say or for
Mr. Pisco or Mr. Duby donation real
Just a quick reminder that by Destiny's own admission he received
in goon to vote videos of a traffic minor and kept it for about
a year after he was told she was a minor. This is all true. I'm
so glad Destiny went after Duby. I don't think Duby really had
dug into this at all. And then after Destiny threatened to dox
Duby, Duby probably went and availed himself of all the facts
and was like, oh, this guy's a really bad person. Oh, this guy's
like somebody I should mock all the time. Duby Duby, okay, that's
awesome. >> push back enough, it sounds like we're starting
at zero and we're arguing to how much did she push back. But
I'm not starting at she should we she just did nothing. I'm starting
at she was culpable They're even watching right? They're even
watching it right? That's what you're trying to say or for what?
That's not what I'm trying to say for YOU. SHE WASN'T JUST WATCHING
IT. She was watching it and agreeing with it and supporting it
and laughing along with it. Her whole chat was going along with
it. So first of all, I'm I I I think that we should calm down
for a second, all right? And just let's chill, all right? So
what I'm saying there is trying to distinguish
Does Pisco not see through this? So I don't know I don't want
to give him too much credit but there is there's like a former
person who is like a next level intellect, not super socially
strong all the time.
I I just don't know like I've never done if I went to University
of Pisco or I worked in some job with him, I'd have a better
idea of just how intelligent he is. I do think he's very intelligent,
but I don't know if it's like there are people I've known who
basically
operate at a level where they sort of have to slow down for everybody
all the time.
Right? There's a few people who are like software people I know
who are probably like they're like discrete math like pure math
grads who are very very very intelligent and happen to slide
into software cuz it was the where they could make the most money.
And they like have to slow down all the time for everybody. And
so I can see how maybe Pisco sort of when somebody is misrepresenting
him, he might actually think that that's them just not following.
And that it happens enough that he's very used to just going
like, okay, I understand people don't always follow My god, that's
totally me. It's definitely not me. I just know other people
who are like that who I can see that they have to interact like
that with people. And so so you're saying he's on he might be
on. Yeah.
I'm just there are people like that and I I don't know if he's
at that level quite where he's just usually operating on like
he understands precisely what's going on. I can say if he doesn't
respect the person, he will just attack them for being a re cuz
he has definitely done that to Rage Pope like a hundred different
times. >> distinguish. Maybe I should include also the
kind of adoption or the implicit adoption that we're talking
about here where she's nodding along and being like, oh, that's
crazy chat. Yeah, it's very dangerous, okay? So all I was trying
to distinguish when I said failure to push back is a situation
in which one is merely watching it and then critiquing it, right?
That's all I'm trying to do. And when I say you're paranoid,
what I'm saying is you think that what I'm doing here is some
kind of converted attempt to help Denims. That's that's really
what you thought I just did there, right?
You thought that, right? Okay. So all I'm trying to do, I'm telling
you in real time. I'm trying to distinguish a situation in which
somebody is just watching what they're like a bad of not video
for the purpose of breaking it down and for the purpose of criticizing
it and someone who is not doing that. Someone who is not pushing
back. >> Notice now in order to make that work you're using
someone. You're using someone. You're using general nouns or
pronouns whatever, right?
Again, Pisco uses the this the he's trying to make it a generalizable
differentiation so he can apply it apply it to other situations
and show that people don't seriously have this criticism, right?
That's I think that's pretty transparently what he's trying to
do. The implication of Destiny's criticism here is that Pisco
doesn't want to defend Denims, but that's not true. He's trying
to say, well, this is the standard I'm trying to create so that
I can apply this so and show that you're disingenuous in other
ways because nobody really lives up to this. We're going to apply
a standard to Denims that we will not apply to anyone else.
Yeah, no, it's it's just crazy that Pisco treats this guy like
they're friends like he's, oh, you're my friend who I would rather
hang out with and like I feel like I feel like it's unethical
for me to do that right now given that you're in a legal case
and that's with another one of my friends. But like I get the
sense that Pisco and I don't say this is in like it's bad. I
get the sense that he was he looked up to Destiny, he was friends
with him and he would like to hang out with Destiny more and
he feels like it's unethical for him to do so. And I get the
feeling from Destiny that he's like just trying to humiliate
Pisco almost exclusively in this conversation.
And you could see that by the way that is based on the repeated
over and over and over again character attacks from Destiny on
Pisco and zero character attacks going back against Destiny.
We're at like eight, nine to zero so
Eight or nine to zero in terms of the character attacks. So we'll
see we'll see if that keeps going.
So there's another character attack. Hey, you're being like a
a debate you're saying things that don't matter. Debate pervert
here has to mean you're becoming pedantic in areas where you
shouldn't be or you're you're hyper analyzing areas where you
shouldn't be and there's no purpose. So Destiny should have an
example where Pisco got too granular
and criticized something that was like
And so I hope he's got an example.
What's Destiny's goal here? It is to invoke emotion in a way
that Hutch did but even more strongly thereby like
getting anybody in his audience to move away from Pisco until
Pisco stops supporting arguments that work against like his community
in some way that he feels like don't support him. So basically
if Pisco makes an argument and Queenman and I agree with him,
I think it's very likely that Destiny would come in to say to
basically paint Pisco as bad to get as many DGG fans to move
away from Pisco as possible. I think that's his explicit goal.
That is in my mind what's happening. It's exactly what happened
over the communism stuff. And Destiny will not be good faith
in this conversation because he knows on the merits he gets dog
walked so he has to keep doing character attacks. He has to keep
appealing to emotion. He can't just stick to the facts of what's
happening. And then when Pisco points out, hey, that was a character
attack and you that was wrong, right? Destiny immediately brings
up another issue. Explicit? I think it's very explicit in what
he's doing. Yeah, but if you want to say that I like it's an
explicit statement of intent, no. I think it's explicit in terms
of like I can't think of another reason. I think it's the most
plausible explanation for what he's doing right now. So if you
if you're asking like do I think he explicitly said so? No. I
think given the set of factors here, given that he continues
to attack Pisco's character instead of his arguments, given that
he continues to attack the people around Pisco, I do believe
that it's just about humiliation, about making his community
move away from these people. And he's trying to use things that
they can't question, right? You can't question whether my community
is evil so he's going to try to web Pisco into my community somehow.
Which is completely unreasonable. Basically I'm watching like
the beginning of what he did to me or Queenman happen to Pisco
in real time. So
I'm just I'm just pointing it out cuz I've already experienced
it, right? I got webbed onto like Kiwi Farms in their mind and
now Destiny's going to try to do an adjacent thing, web like
me and Queenman or whatever onto Pisco. Kind of weird, kind of
gross. I say Queenman, I'm the only person who gets brought up
here like repeatedly over and over again.
I don't know why. >> isn't necessarily a ruling on
Spicy chat. Spicy chat is evil, guys.
again arguing that Hutch is not intelligent enough to have this
conversation, which is my argument so I thank Destiny for agreeing
with me. Pisco clearly thought Hutch was capable to have that
conversation. I disagree and Destiny absolutely high five Destiny.
Let's go. We both agree Hutch is too much of a participate. Let's
go. Thank you. >> You go to bad example. You're demonstrating
exactly WHAT I'M SAYING. >> NO, I everyone knows that I
have a When when Destiny said that Hutch probably is being abused
by his wife due to profound mental I personally thought that
was a bit far. Like I get that we shark on Hutches sometimes.
But when Destiny said that Hutch probably should never be allowed
to have children because of profound mental re I just thought
it was a bit much. I blushed. I was like, dude, we we shark on
Hutches from time to time, but like that was that was too far.
That's too much for me. I would rather not go that far, okay?
I personally think Hutch should be allowed to have kids and shouldn't
and his wife shouldn't be considered for abuse of, you know,
somebody with profound mental personally. But when Destiny said
those things, that was crazy, okay? character for being particular
about my words, trying to clarify in like the most specific way
possible, and that sometimes, you know, I'll I'll be you know,
clear about the men's rights and knowing versus That's what I
do. Why did it take you like 3 hours to get to understand that
what Hutch was talking about was degrees of culpability? When
he said it like four times, you keep trying to make it a binary
thing of like you're either culpable or you're not culpable.
So, I I I don't think that you're understanding. I obviously
agree Oh, if you guys are on That was a joke. I don't Destiny
did not verbatim say those things, right?
That that was a joke. Uh it was a joke. It's playing on couple
different elements there. If you didn't get it, it was like a
joke.
being things such as Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, I don't think you're understanding. No, I I really don't.
We know I'm about to I'm about to specify. I'm about to specify.
DO YOU THINK THAT YOU UNDERSTAND
DO YOU DO YOU DO YOU THINK THAT I TRULY don't understand a notion
of partial responsibility, that I don't understand joint and
several liability, that these concepts are foreign to me? Is
that what you think? No, that I don't I don't, which is why at
the beginning of this conversation I said you must have bitten
this argument from somebody else. Because when you I wanted to
turn out when you started talking about proximate cause or or
or butt four things, and you're like, well, you know, you could
see that you know, at the end of the chain once the chain of
causality is
By the way, I'll just point it again since people want to say
that Pisco is agreeing with me. If you watch my conversation
or my coverage of the Hutch conversation, I actually was saying
Pisco's being too wordy here. Hutch doesn't understand. I did
say Hutch needs to actually stop him and say, I don't know what
you mean. Can you explain that to me?
Which I think
I can't tell with Hutch if he just doesn't if he's feeling like
intimidated or if he feels self-conscious about his intelligence,
but it doesn't make you stupid to not understand something or
not know something. You just stop and say, hey, could you tell
me what you mean? Right? So, he wouldn't do that and I think
it led to him really not understanding.
But it was I had to Google some things Pisco Pisco was talking
about. I don't think that makes you dumb. It just makes you not
know a thing he's talking about. But it once you understand it,
you can understand the arguments. Hutch was getting emotional
about the arguments without understanding. It's kind of rough.
You don't say that. Wait a second. So, I mean, you can I'm just
going to take an
But we'd still put it on Pisco a little bit. He should actually
be able to see that and and be able to under like communicate
that to Hutch in my opinion. Uh someone who hmm I'm not going
to use that example.
Wait, wait, wait, I I just want to be I just want to be clear.
I understand partial responsibility. I totally do. In fact, I
was the one who introduced the notion uh when I said, do believe
that Denims has significant responsibility for the call for the
uh for the malicious call. And um I introduced the you know,
what about 5%? So, it's clear even in just taking that conversation
without this pretend story about me stealing a um some kind of
information or whatever, it's clear that I understand the notion
of partial responsibility. No one can watch that video in which
we're talking about percentages, in which I'm trying to hold
Hutch to, you know, some level of significance. He says, what
do you mean by significance? Here I mean 5%. And um that that
someone could come away reasonably thinking I don't understand.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, I think I think anybody that would
watch that would go, why is it taking this Pisco guy so long
to just talk about gradients of culpability here? Cuz that's
what I was like, how how is he talking about this for SO LONG?
IT DID NOT GO INTO SCALES of culpability here. It's insane to
me. But you But you agree I in that conversation demonstrate
that I recognize that concept. I'm using it,
Once you've been pushed into having to address me directly, which
makes it feel bad faith. Yes. >> So, so, so, this is what
I'm trying Maybe I can clarify this. Um that's an explicit lie,
by the way. That is an explicit lie. Before they get into the
conversation about culpability, Pisco asks Hutch for the percentages.
Well, before anything happens, he goes, what would you say? 5%?
That's before they get into the long conversation about culpability.
It's like right off the bat. Because they're basically it's where
they argue about um like significant culpability, significant
Yeah, it's Pisco. Um
So, that actually That's just a lie. It's not after criticisms
at all.
Um Dan claims there's no proof he doxxed besides one time.
Um Well, I mean, sorry. I guess
should we say he doxxed?
If you I think it's doxxing if you only use it for your own purposes,
right? Like if you if you if you go after the person, you like
get somebody's information, you go after the person, that's doxxing,
right?
Anyway, there are different levels of doxxing Dan's been responsible
for and he's totally defended it. So, it's weird that he says
only one time that you can prove, but Okay, maybe this will be
helpful. So, because I see culpability as inextricably tied to
a given mental state, I don't really um conceptualize moral fault
with relates with relating to particular results without a mental
state. You understand? Why is it okay Hold on. I agree with you
100%. But then why is it earlier that you were talking about
the percentage chance of somebody doing something bad in the
chat as being the the the defining characteristic on whether
or not you did a bad rather than what you just announced and
I totally agree with. It does depend on the mental
Jesus Christ.
Is Destiny culpable for Rose being doxxed by KF given he posted
her university in a photo of her in DG G shirt to mock KF for
failing to dox her?
Uh yeah. Well, I mean, that is literally doxxing in and of itself,
right? It's information you've collected
through various means and you've published it for the purpose
of harassing that person. I would say when you publish that stuff,
right? And you explicitly call KF out to look at it, I would
say that's for the purpose of harassment. But that itself is
what's important because it helps you get gives you insight into
the mental state of the person that was spreading the [__]
in the first place. He admits to doxxing her, doesn't he? No,
he's stopped doing that even though he's explicitly said so.
So, he's reversed course on this explicit admission that he is
the person who helped him find helped Kiwi Farms find her. And
now he's started saying that like, my community doxxed her, I
guess.
With no evidence at all.
Um he just shotguns out stuff and then let's other people argue
it so that they can figure out where the edges are,
Wait, I will explain, Steven. I will explain. So, because the
reason I kept asking and and maybe you thought this was bad faith,
too. I asked Hutch, well, it's possible it came from your community,
right? And he was like, yes. And everyone gets exasperated like,
oh, come on, Pisco. You're trying to say it's the exact same
thing when Hutch watches a video and and just totally misinterprets
Maybe listen, guys. That could absolutely be my own communication
deficiencies. I am totally willing to accept that. But the difference
is we ascribe culpability
It's pretty obvious Pisco's looking for Hutch's standard on what
you could apply like globally that is free from bias. He's trying
to create standards that are free from bias. So, when it comes
to non-intentional states, uh I'm here using the model penal
code. And I understand it's a legal concept, but I believe it
will also apply to our ethical concepts. I don't think you'll
fight me on it. This notion of recklessness and negligence, right?
Um you don't call someone negligent just because they introduce
in a trivial risk, right? You don't introduce You don't call
someone culpable for being negligent or reckless because they
are like, uh you know, sending um their kid over to do grocery
shopping, right? Because we consider that a low amount of I think
the perfect way he's about to address something, but it's like
the act versus rule utilitarianism thing, right? Like as a rule,
what Denims did is not something you could be banned for. It's
not something that's illegal. It's not something that most people
would even be mad about, but it's because that act was was um
followed up by another act of somebody actually calling CPS that
we act like it's like the worst thing in the world. But that
in and of itself shows us that clearly we don't think what Denims
did was that bad. We think it had a bad result or possibly had
a bad result here, but we're trying to do this whole thing where
we're pretending that these people, you know, only look at the
utility of the act and they don't care about like by rule, how
bad is this? That's what Pisco's trying to point out the entire
time. That if this hadn't happened,
nobody would be criticizing Denims. risk. And so, you just asked
me what Wait, wait, wait, can I finish my idea? You don't agree
with Hold on. No, because you don't agree with what you just
said. Okay, yeah, I do. Okay, it's nothing to do with the percentage
chance of risk. It has to do with the intentionality but and
the responsibility that you have in terms of sending somebody
into a into a certain
Those are the same thing, right? Like like how likely is it that
you're unaware that your actions could have negative outcomes?
Negative consequences. Yes, yeah, it is. It is. I'll I'll tell
you what. I believe this and and I I hope that we can agree on
that. Give me an example. Sure. So, someone is reckless when
they consciously disregard not any risk, right? A substantial
and unjustifiable risk, right? You don't call someone reckless
So, the state of mind is intrinsically linked to a certain quantum
of degree of risk, okay? So, no one would say, for example, No,
no, no, hold on. No, it's absolutely not. It's not What did you
say? The keyword there is is is known or justifiable. You have
to have a mind state about the If if a father tells a a child,
can you go to the store and pick up some thing? And there are
murderers in the store. They're killing everybody. The dad doesn't
know. And there's a 100% chance of the child dying when they
walk in there. That's not neg That's not Well, maybe neg That's
not the news flash. Yeah, Pisco's not saying that, dude. What
is the That would almost be intentional. That would be like intentional,
right? No, not if they didn't know, though. Not if they didn't
know. Oh, no, yeah, but they didn't know it's a 100% plan of
death. They didn't If they didn't know, it's the known part is
what talks about negligence or disresponsibility or negligence
here. The knowledge pertains to Okay, uh he didn't add that part.
Like like as in it's a 100% guarantee if they go in there, they
die. That's Sorry, when you just say that, it sounds like you're
saying they do know. But then he says they don't know. >> level
of risk, right? The knowledge itself, the mental state of apprehension
is based on a certain significance of the risk. I'll give you
an example, right? So, so that we can just agree on this. Um
if someone sends them to the supermarket not knowing that there
are murderers all over there like the one you just gave, they
are not consciously disregarding a substantial and unjustifiable
risk. You agree with that, right? So, you're not However, um
if they know that there's Just on this Just on this just on what
we just said there. This is why the chat groaned because funnily
enough I actually think Hutch is for whatever Hutch's intuitions
I think were spot on in all of this and I think a lot of the
groaning you were getting was was intuiting a lot of good I thought
I thought Hutch's appeals to emotions were great. All of his
appeals to emotion, they were all fantastic. >> What you
just said is the knowledge of the risk. When you say, "Well,
when Denims is engaged in some behavior watching a video and
then somebody calls CPS and it feels like the intent of her,
the entire community of the video she's watching, is to push
that type of behavior." And then you say to Hutch, "Well, isn't
there a chance that >> from your community could engage
in that behavior?" Do you really think that when Hutch is reviewing
it in critically, do you think that if you would have put a gun
to his head and say, "Hutch, I want you to answer this right
the [__] now." Do you think that you're helping or
hurting this situation? My guess is that Hutch would probably
say, "I think I'm helping. I'm trying to spotlight a thing that
I think is important and you know there might be a crazy person
out there doing it the wrong way but for the most part I'm doing
things to reduce the amount of harm here. I just want to be clear
that would definitely be true of the reckless mindset but there's
also this other level and again this is a legal concept but I
think it also fits in our intuitions is negligence. And negligence
isn't just when you consciously disregard a substantial unjustified
risk.
Destiny's on Coke again talking super fast. He is I think I have
it at a 1.25 to be fair. I do have it at a 1.25,
But he was speaking incredibly fast cuz he's got to get eight
times as much volume out there as Pisko again. Pisko says No.
Wait.
Where you Yeah, I agree. Hutch is not negligent, okay? I don't
think that >> You're not close to it. I I know wait a Wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait.
No, because you guys don't understand. I don't raise that point
to suggest that Hutch is negligent. The point I'm raising when
I say Hutch is mere increase of risk is not enough to imply a
culpable mindset. The risk you need to show is signi- of some
degree of significance and we're going to treat you differently
based on whether you consciously disregard that risk. >> that
you're smarter you know that nobody knows that nobody believes
this. I would never This would be a thing that I you would just
illustrate a quick example. But with the one that I just said,
let's say you sent your kid to the store there's murders and
you didn't know about it.
No, you didn't. You danced around this and I I brought Wait.
I brought I brought that example up. Wait a second. I brought
that example up. You were pushed to it. You got pushed to it.
Listen. So so I'm just I'm just telling you guys can disbelieve
me if you want. You can take
That before they really got into it, hot Pisko is like what percentage
and Hutch is like, "I've never even thought about what percentage
culpability Denims has." Which by the way, if Destiny was being
good faith, when Hutch says, "I've never even thought about what
percentage culpable Den- Denims is." That's an insane thing to
say, right? Like an obviously insane thing to say. Like you are
saying she deserves something and then when people ask, "Well,
what percentage did she do to contribute to the thing?" You say
she did that deserves it. "What percentage was her contribution?"
He goes, "I've never even thought about that." I said
What? Like Steven's view.
Cap show the I'm doing this because I'm trying to appeal to the
justilt community to improve the harassment on bro. That's Steven's
opinion. Or you can take my view of it which is I was trying
to find new ways to explain the same concept. The same concept
which is that our intuitions about culpability don't relate to
the result nakedly. Our intuitions about responsibility relate
to result plus mental states. And so when I said and and everyone
goofed on People are like, "Oh, Duby's This guy's like do- Duby
donated $200 of K Keffals log posting." Wait, what did Duby say
that was false?
No, dude that's the actually the argument. It's just again it's
just the Keffals argument, right? Uh that's that information
is from a bad place.
Um that information is from a really bad place actually.
Wait, but is it wrong? No, but it's from a really bad place.
>> we I have a bunch of replies saying like, "What? You
don't think the de- father that's being sent over there would
be responsible for the death of their child when they did that,
right?" They're just not understanding the point. The point isn't
that the father is not responsible or culpable. Here, I'm using
by the way, when I say responsible it's not weasel. I just use
those words interchangeably. Responsibility, morally at fault,
justified or
Wait. LMAO yeah Pisko is is FS trying food chops trying to get
the 300 views from J stock. So I just use those words >> I
see what they're saying. Like as in he's like, "Yeah, I don't
have a bigger platform than Pisko >> interchangeably. Responsibility.
What? Like just think about it logically. What would Pisko be
getting out of like supporting me?
Like what reason would he have actually have to look at this
and in terms of being just totally disingenuous, a total grifter?
What would he get out of supporting me? Can anyone tell me what
that would be? I actually have no idea. It feels like it's just
obviously nothing, right?
Like there is literally nothing there. That he could possibly
get out of. >> Morally at fault, justified or or sorry
culpable. Those are all words that I use interchangeably. It's
not evidence of me doing a lower standard for people. >> is
I'm just trying to re-explain the same concept. Sure, that's
fine. Most people intuitively at that point though would feel
like the father is somewhat at fault because they would view
that as being at least negligent of not protecting your child
from going to a bad part of town where they're going to My my
my point is and you don't even dis- Quick reminder that Destiny
encouraged his audience to report Pixie's wife to ICE. Is he
trying to appeal to Trumpers?
Another banger from Duby. Let's go.
Uh that's like Keffals logging. Well, actually it's like just
searching his Russell logs probably but >> Truth is they're
culpable >> that most people would view the father as being
somewhat culpable in some sense. Culpable in some sense. And
so yes, no but that I was saying that and that's what's so frustrating
is because people didn't >> Yeah, but the but should the
peo- you might say that peo- well, you could argue you're saying
that. You were but you're what you're saying is well, he's guilty
of this thing of negligence but that's completely divorced from
the resulting bad action. He
I mean he did play around with the meme of Pisko replacing Destiny.
If that were real, supporting you would be a great attack vector
to suppress Destiny without outright alienating his
Okay, how? Like I I just don't get so platform size, I just don't
get how that would make sense cuz he's not supporting me at all,
right? He's explicitly saying he disavows.
He's like, "Oh, given taking this as given like I I disavow that."
So I just don't see how right cuz that's the thing is Destiny's
coming in and pressing him. So we played around with this idea
as like a joke.
Although like I kind of believe it. At least I'm like, "Okay,
Pisko's not somebody who's operating like ultra bad faith who's
only spite based, who's just doing this to aggrandize himself.
I think he has principles."
But that was mostly a joke.
But I guess yeah, that could be a a reason maybe. He didn't murder
his daughter. He didn't the daughter. You was Yes, you did say
that, okay? But the second thing too is imagine the father not
only sent his daughter to a bad part of town. Imagine he got
into a group chat and started telling a bunch of his shady friends
>> Yeah, now it starts to seem more intentional, right?
Now it starts to seem more intentional. Yes. Yeah, I agree. Now
imagine if his daughter gets and he laughs about it in his group
chat with all of his friends. >> starts to seem more intentional,
doesn't it? So what is this analogous here between what Denims
did and what the dad would do in that circumstance? >> What
I was trying to So
Like I I literally was friends with people who were in Destiny's
inner circle who would send me massive imagers
like 4,000 by 15,000 imagers sorry images cuz I was going to
say imager albums but then they stopped doing albums they started
like pasting them all together into one image of just Hassan's
logs of him like complaining about his trip to Australia and
[__] Which by the way I covered and enjoyed covering
cuz he does soy out about his chat a lot in a very funny way.
Okay? Hassan is very funny to cover in terms of how he is like
the biggest diva on planet Earth. I'm sorry if you guys are big
Hassan fans and you don't like that. He is like the biggest diva
on planet Earth. Like it's crazy, okay? But just the level of
like yeah, there are people who just recorded everything from
his Discord all the time. Like in Destiny's inner circle. He's
like fully aware of that.
He has like no ground to stand on whatsoever here. First of all,
let's make sure that we agree No. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. I I
I I want to I am going to appeal so I know exactly what you asked.
You asked, "What is this analogous between the added circumstances
to the hypothetical that make them different than the Denims
one?" Everyone locked it in. We know that, right? We know that.
What I want to do though is make sure that we agree so far in
the framework. You might not believe I had this framework and
I want to get clarity on that but I just want to make sure we
agree on the framework.
you agree, right? That one is not culpable in the sense of moral
Oh, no.
I was just I was just arguing about some stuff in the Discord
because
they're going to take as given Pisko's like entire premise for
this was oh, they're blah blah blah blah blah something about
the J stock community. I was like, "Oh, if you're going to keep
saying that over and over again, I feel like I should get to
argue about whether cuz it was like he's like, "Why did you say
that I support like harassing Rose because the J stock community
supports me or something because they they they support harassing
Rose." I'm like, "Oh, if you're going to take that as given,
I think I should be able to say that's not true and also say
why it's not true and why it's disingenuous for anybody to make
that criticism.
I think that's fair to be honest with you. Anyway, this is Destiny,
Duby, J stock and esports were coordinating. J stock and esports
posting [__] in Discord. Duby donating in YouTube
chat. You would ban people that did that to a guest. Wait. Okay,
but the I was just I was just arguing
Here's why this is like a disingenuous argument. If you're going
to say if people are going to if Pisko's going to entertain on
stream this whole criticism that like webs him to me, then I'm
going to point out that that webbing is also disingenuous. That
like the the fact that they're trying to web him too is not a
fact. It's actually contentious.
I think that's fair.
Although listen. I don't know if anybody
Can Destiny really even make that argument if he never banned
Evil Fossil? Destiny, you would ban somebody who's like donating
thousands of dollars to you but just cuz they're like unhinged,
Well. Now he did give I think he gave Evil Fossil a lot of his
money back to be fair, okay?
But it's like he did let him donate the
bility to a result nakedly, right? They're not nakedly just because
you caused the death of your child. You're not culpable in the
sense, right? >> It depends on the mental state of the
And the foreseeability and and foreseeability plays into into
the role of like what a couple of mental states would look like.
If something is very foreseeable and you don't cognize it, but
you should, right? That would be a negligent mindset. All that
other stuff. And so, um one is not culpable for the intentional
version of culpability that I'm trying to say and uh versus the
negligent one. So, that's all I'm laying out here and I don't
hear you to disagree with that. And that is what I intended to
say, whether it came across the right way. What I wasn't trying
to do was that communities don't have responsibility for their
community. What I wasn't trying to say is that there's no duty
to moderate. What I What I wasn't trying to do was protect Just
Stilk for Rose harassment. >> talking about the Just Stilk
thing, right? We're not talking about the Just Stilk thing.
So, I just If Pisco is going to keep saying like this part, which
again says it, in my opinion, like it's fact, then I think I
get the reason I I can reasonably like argue against that, right?
That I don't think there was like harassment that went on like
significant harassment. And I think the harassment is probably
less than than death It's almost certainly less than Destiny
put on her. And so, the people virtue signaling about it, if
they're going to pretend that I should be banned, then they should
obviously want Destiny banned even more.
Oh, he does this quite a bit, by the Cuz I would say with regards
to the Rose harassment thing,
I just wanted to ask Destiny exactly why he doxed me. Yeah, I
I get that, yeah.
Like I I would love to know with with you East Coast Batman,
um you didn't meet these people in real life as much. I think
Supreme met basically all of them in real life. So, I like bringing
up Supreme cuz he's somebody who's like tangible to most of them.
Like I would wonder why, given that Wick's done multiple events
with Supreme, why would Wick support Destiny despite Destiny
threatening to dox Supreme for no reason? And I personally feel
like shouldn't Wick be shouldn't Wick be asking Destiny for that
reason?
Are you banned? No, I'm not banned. But that's your That's your
speculation. That's your open speculation.
YOU BELIEVE SO, SO YOU BELIEVE I want to increase harassment
on this person I don't know who has never harmed me. On basis
of what?
What? Why the In virtue of what? Oh, because Just Stilk's in
MY CHAT. I TALKED TO COUNTERPOINTS. He's in your community.
But you don't give me that grace on that, do you? You don't give
me the grace that Oh,
Is that what this is about? Wait, what? Wait, what?
What is that?
Wait. I'll Is there somebody I've like cut out of my community?
Wait, who have I cut out of my
Is this like about Yoge or something or Carrier? I think these
are two specific people we talk about as in we we've defined
exactly why they're not allowed. Give me that grace on that,
do you? You don't give me the GRACE THAT OH, OH, I SEE THAT Destiny
was cut out of his
Yeah, but the Kelly thing is like on a totally different basis,
so I'm like I don't like her personally.
Yeah. Yeah, I just I specifically don't like Kelly on a personal
level. That's like totally different.
Is that what this is about?
No, that's not what this is about. This is about the I'm still
waiting for you to give the example on Denims. I don't know why
you're going into this. >> no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, the point is the reason I'm addressing this at
all is because you openly speculated that the reason why this,
which is, you know, it's maybe a little bit of words to to put
out, it that the reason was because of a nefarious intent to
increase harassment or protect a community who is known to be
harassing a young woman who's never harmed me. And that is That
is up, man. You can't You can't What's wrong with me? When you
say it's up, if somebody were to reach out and harass you as
a result of that, would I be in some sense culpable for that
harassment? >> Well, well, in the sense of recklessness,
but I wouldn't But But But if I tried Wait, HANG ON. HANG ON.
HANG ON. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. NO,
NO, NO. I DIDN'T KNOW WAIT. I did not No, I Oh, I just missed
I just missed what he's saying about. Hold on. I had to time
out a whole bunch of people. >> that the reason was because
of a nefarious intent >> policy. to increase harassment
or protect a community who is known to be harassing a young woman
who's never harmed me. And that is That is up, man. You can't
You What's wrong with me? When you say it's up, if somebody were
to reach out and harass you as a Was the policy? If you just
come in here and you're like, "Oh, I miss Kelly." Like I'll just
time you out. It's fine. Probably now that I've said it though
Now that I've restated it, it's probably going to be a week time
out for people. >> result of that, would I be in some sense
culpable for that harassment?
in the sense of >> If you If you just like to go, you could
jump out right now. I listen to this, but I wouldn't But But
But if I tried Wait, HANG ON. HANG ON. HANG ON. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT.
WAIT. WAIT. I JUST MISSED IT AGAIN. YOU >> NEFARIOUS intent
to increase harassment or protect a community who is known to
be harassing a young woman who's never harmed me. And that is
That is up, man. You can't You can't What's wrong with me? When
you say it's up, if somebody were to reach out and harass you
as a result of that, would I be in some sense culpable for that
harassment?
in the sense of recklessness, but I wouldn't But But But if I
tried Wait, hang on. Hang on. Did he just Here, you're directly
culpable for like the action you took? Yeah, that's exactly what
he's been arguing the whole time.
Did he just Did he just like agree with Pisco and then he's going
to do a dance of victory on his agreeing with Pisco? Is that
what we just witnessed? HANG ON. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT.
WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. NO, NO, NO. I didn't know Wait. I did
not NO, I DID NOT WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. DESTINY. WAIT.
WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. He just
is sewing out and Pisco literally just said the same thing he's
been saying the whole time. You're culpable for your recklessness.
That I'm I'm actually so people find this kind of content compelling.
He's just screaming. He's just screaming like a child.
Instead of He He doesn't even say this is why I think I'm correct.
He's just screeching like a child.
That's very bizarre behavior. >> Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Destiny. Destiny. So, as a result of
that, I might say that you're like negligent or reckless or whatever
if you say that, but hang on a second. There have been people
from your community that have messaged me with uh you know, suggestions
that are not true in the in a similar vein. Do you accept culpability
for that? No, you don't,
But you didn't No, lying about you, lying about him, repeating
lies that you would make about Don't get it Don't get it twisted.
>> no, no, but not the unhinged stuff, right? You take
You take credit for what you actually say, not what you could
increase the risk of saying.
I don't think I've said that either. Just stuff like um you know,
attacking my credibility in the sense of like my credentials,
saying that essentially I'm I'm defrauding people, not you know,
holding myself to be on to have never been admitted to practice.
Those are things that come from people who are parts of your
community. Now, I've seen you defend me on that score and I would
never hold you culpable for it. And I'm applying a consistent
lens.
Oh, by the way, for anybody timed out, $5 donation gets you untimed
out. No, you're so inconsistent. What did you just say? Because
I But But But why do I Oh, also, pretend I shilled right now
cuz we probably need more time on the stream. What do we got?
We got 2 hours? Probably need some more time on the stream, guys.
So, pretend I'm shilling. I don't know. I don't know. I do see
people make those kinds of attacks. And when I see it, because
I don't want people to make those types of attacks. I think there's
other stupid arguments they make that they can attack you on.
I counteract it. Because And that that shows the intent of me
when I
Destiny said, "Wait, where did Destiny say Pisco wasn't a real
lawyer?" Hold on. Where did he say that? Ebola. That's like the
exact kind of Oh, MattNLT, thanks for the 10 gifties. Let's go.
Let's go. It's another hour.
You'll love to see it.
Thank you very much, Matt. Appreciate it, buddy.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. >> criticism of you. I'm
not here to criticize you for saying you're a fake lawyer or
whatever else. And you can see what you just pointed to was an
action you said, "Oh, well, look. I guess he doesn't want these
things But But But But But here's Here's the thing, right? So,
so Denims did did clarify afterwards, right? Now, that was after
after Extra time for Candace Owens Black Heart. Thank you very
much, Marmaduke,
the 500 kicks. Appreciate it, buddy. >> She said what she
said and and or she watched that video and people brought it
to her attention and criticized her for it. She said that she
never called CPS and that it wasn't justified. That's what I
understood that she said. That's from what I recall that she
said. And so, I'm asking on what terms are those different? Was
this after she she know she saw that CPS was called or was this
after a significant public backlash? I I mean, I'm not sure what
I think it's in the reaction stream where she's reacting to Ethan
and Ela having CPS called on them, right?
If I'm not mistaken, I think I put that link. I didn't watch
the context around it's from Denims thing, but I think I put
that in Pisco's Discord around this time where they were talking
about it. Give me a second. So, that we we can just watch it
right now. We'll watch what she said, okay? So, the question
will be is this a disavowal
of the CPS call? Going through all your things, accusing you
of crimes you didn't do? No one should be subjected to such treatment.
Sure, but we're talking about
not cops showing up at your house. We're talking about CPS, which
anyways, to begin with, one, I don't condone. I've never Two,
I've never condoned it and you will not be able to find a clip
of me saying, "Yes, we should do this." Because it doesn't exist.
I think CPS should be exclusively used for family vloggers who
are total pieces of [__] that use their kids Oh,
so no, he doesn't really think Okay. All right. Date? Well, I
mean, it's during her reaction to Ela complaining about CPS.
So, I actually don't know the date on this one. I've literally
given Ethan Klein credit on multiple times Give me Timed out.
I'm upset that Pisco is giving very orthodox and well-understood
ideas of culpability and he's being painted as doing special
pleading. Uh yeah, that's happening. multiple instances and I
will do it again right for not showing photos of his kids. I
think it is actually very cool of him to try his best to not
have his kids in photos, in videos. I respect that a lot. I I
think he's he's a piece of sh-
I think this is like going above and beyond actually. Above and
beyond what I'd expect somebody who feels like they've been harassed
by Ethan to the degree that she thinks that. Right? I think this
is actually above and beyond. So this is after the call? Yeah,
it's definitely after the call.
>> Destiny's argument is is it after the call or is it
after the backlash? It is after the call. >> respect a
lot that he doesn't bring his kids on camera and use them for
content. is on her platform right now advocating for our children
to be forcibly removed from us by child protective services.
Maybe she should think about issuing an apology and retraction.
Or at least saying calling CPS is crazy, don't do that.
No, but she she does kind of she goes after being like Ethan's
the worst person in the world and like yeah, his kid and watching
Bad Empanada be like yeah, his kids crawl around and eat [__]
and her whole entire chat being like call CPS, but she be like
Wasn't her whole entire chat still virtue signaling over an edited
clip? Obviously don't call CPS. It's like yeah, right. The thing
is these people So she said obviously don't call CPS. Oh, okay.
All right. Okay.
Like dude, I swear to God this is like the biggest this is the
biggest like online documented mass hysteria event that's ever
happened. Like so many people have lost the plot entirely on
this one. Was that edited clip assaultment
I don't know. Might have been. Could have been. Could have been.
That's basically like the point a lot of people are standing
on now is this is actually the biggest like mass hysteria event
that's ever happened and this is going to be like Kephals campaign
against Destiny
times
the Twitch poll campaign against Prime Kai. It's going to be
like all of these witch hunts that ended up being false. It's
going to be like all of them multiplied together into the same
thing.
Like it's crazy how
how much this has been distorted in people's minds. People are
knowingly a lot. Whoops. Okay. We'll go back We'll go back to
this. >> I mean those are coinciding, right? Like maybe
the backlash is when she sees it. Maybe the backlash is when
she sees No no no no I'm saying I'm not sure about this. I'm
not sure.
Well, how Hang on a second, but then what else are you saying
that she's doomed to be insincere because if it happens to be
that she sees it when it coincides when it's a public thing,
therefore she can never be sincere about the apology or you will
never take that as a sincere statement about about about about
statements made after mediation or settlements. Didn't you say
Casey Trons whole statement must be insincere because it came
at the end of the settlement or mediation?
Wait, is Destiny going to argue that Casey Tron's statement was
sincere?
There's no way Destiny's going to sit here and argue that Casey
Tron's statement was sincere, is he? >> No, the reason
why Casey Tron's statement is insincere is because it's obviously
insincere. It's obviously insincere given everything we know
about Casey Tron's character, given what she was apologizing
for.
Hold on hold on hold on. Destiny literally said he's going to
chase talking Kweiman and dox like five people and is still threatening
to do so to other people right now. Yeah, this is actually true.
Actively still threatening to dox people. Actively has been doxing
people this month. >> It's obviously insincere given everything
we know about Casey Tron's character, given what she was apologizing
for. Do you actually dispute that? Do you think that she was
being genuine there that she apologizes to you know Ethan's employees?
She apologizes to Asmongold. >> can't if we if we're going
to say that necessarily every statement made at the end of mediation
is insincere, then there's no possibility you can say that well
Denims statement at the end of massive public backlash, that's
sincere. No, that's ridiculous. What I mean to say is like it's
in the nature of what
Funny enough, I actually think the Ethan thing it's like table
stakes. It's like the Ethan thing where he's saying like don't
harass Casey Tron. I think he's really saying regardless of his
feelings, don't harass Casey Tron.
Right? I think Denims is saying regardless of my feelings, don't
call CPS on Ethan that's crazy. Right? It's like you can not
like the person. You can not want to say you were wrong. You
can not want to say that something done to them was bad, but
you can also say don't do that. It's like crazy to do >> Casey
Tron is saying
that it it strains credulity given our priors about the what
what Uh he's just jealous he doesn't have a snark community.
Destiny you mean? I mean I don't think that's true, but if you
mean that his community snark His community does snark. His community
totally does [__] like this. He's like actively trying
to build that up right
Like absolutely. Casey Tron stands for given our priors about
what someone could reasonably expect an an apology for that she
actually meant um aspects of her apology there. That's what I
think is I think you agree with that. And what is in the nature
of Denims and the snarker communities and all the people fighting
her, right? >> Where is the evidence of her advocating
that similar type situations? What do you mean? Evidence of her
advocating for similar type situations? >> Where's the
course of conduct of Denims that would you know justify us taking
this kind of negative inference on on her apology that that we
would think or it's not apology, her stating that that was never
intended she doesn't think it's justified. What Where is the
evidence? Show me the order. Show me the piece of paper where
he wrote that we need to keep all the No, I didn't say that.
You're you're making it sound ridiculous when you're like I'm
I'm asking for an explicit thing. What are the kinds
I would just ask the very simple question here is why when you're
arguing that she did do it, do you guys all argue for things
that are lies? They'll argue she didn't say she didn't disavow
it after the fact. They'll say she never did or they'll say she
explicitly called for it or they'll say she's like sitting there
nodding along and saying like yeah, someone's got to do something
Somebody's got to do something. She like encouraged it. Why do
you have to lie about the things she did in order to make the
arguments you make? That's really the only question, right?
If you were if you were telling the truth and what she actually
did was enough, then wouldn't you just be able to say what she
actually did? Which is she went and then she said yeah,
kids getting adult illnesses is actually worse cuz kids don't
have a very strong immune system.
Right? Which is in reference to Ethan's kids being in some kind
of danger like Ethan's kids not being cared for, right? So I
do think it's like agreeing with that they're not being cared
cared for in some way, but she advocates no specific thing.
uh couldn't you just be honest about it? I think you could just
be honest about >> the things that shows that she has a
history of this stuff where she actually wants uh these kinds
of reports to be filed. She actually wants you to go out and
uh dox people at her stream. >> videos on stream. She's
laughing along with it. She's giggling after CPS gets called
and your chatters are all having a hoot about it. >> but
that's that's merging with the thing itself. That's merging with
the conduct itself. That You're saying the conduct is so obvious
that she's Let not Casey just tip $5.
I did not know about the rule. Currently crying and throwing
up. My bad.
Okay. All right. You're fine. You're fine. Hold on. I'll unban.
Unban uh
like that.
I didn't get you, but I'll get you. >> she should know
that that's a call for CPS that you that that is itself the evidence
also that she's being insincere regarding her statement that
is not Did you see the Did you see any of the Discord chat leaks
um Let's be real. This whole drama is just about Destiny losing
his orbiters because they were given undeniable proof that he's
a piece of [__] You're giving this dude way too much
charity, Pisco. I mean, I'm sorry that's kind of just true, right?
Like that's literally just all it is. >> of the Tyler Robinson's
Discord group? I saw some of them.
From what I saw, I would be I would be
Well, that's the thing. That's what I think they all secretly
mean, Kilo. They're like giving it away, right? They're like
oh, you're providing cover for for Chase Dog and his Discord.
And it's like well, Pisco is sort of in a roundabout way arguing
that you should be able to have some reasonable set of evidence
that somebody meant to do something or somebody was complicit
in something to actually punish them for it, right? So he is
sort of making my argument for me. But realistically, that's
how most people think. So that's like the liberal way of thinking,
right? That is liberalism. How justice works in under a liberal
doctrine. So they're getting mad at Pisco for explaining to them
how justice works in liberal democracies.
Hey, we need to have some level of evidence of this or else I
think it's probably bad to punish these people.
if that group was a radical crazy group because it seemed like
when he dropped the message in there, people were like wait,
really? Holy [__] Oh my god. This is Uh hold on.
I do have to answer this. I don't mean to be pausing quite so
much here, but Pisco just accepts all his about this this community
and Rose. So correct me if I'm wrong. I think I could go talk
to Pisco about this and I could say here's how I see the situation,
but realistically I think if I asked him he would say it's very
similar to the Bad Empanada thing where he's sort of granting
some stuff. He's getting criticisms and he's granting some stuff
based on like I'm not going to argue this cuz it's immaterial
really to the allegation, but it's like that you would use this
and try to tie me to it. I don't think he's like granting it
as fact. I think he's granting it for the sake of argument. Is
my impression. >> crazy group because it seemed like when
he dropped the message in there, people were like wait, really?
Holy [__] Oh my god. This is terrible whatever. That
was all I saw. I don't know if there was more released, but from
that Discord group, that's all I saw. If I would have seen him
say that same message if you would have seen him drop that same
message and everybody's LIKE OH MY GOD, BRO. HEAD SHOT. GOOD
JOB. A PLUS plus dude. I'm dropping on Tomato Town next, right?
You would What would you think? Would you think that there was
a much higher chance that Yeah, we'd apply more culpability.
Where did they celebrate the CPS? He said Okay, hold on. You
asked me that. Where are they celebrating CPS?
Um I can't believe you really asked me that. Where did they Where
did they
Like you can hear him start to hyperventilate. It's just a pure
appeal to emotion. Just wait until they pull the clip, okay?
Just wait until they pull the clip. If I if we watch some clips
and I demonstrate that, is your opinion how what percentage is
your opinion going to shift on this subject? >> That that
if they celebrate CPS actively after the fact, that will definitely
that will definitely color my opinion.
you're So like give me an example of what it would be and then
I'll tell you how I think it would affect my opinion.
What about the iDubbz video? Is the iDubbz video is of the CPS
call? Is there an iDubbbz video that like celebrates the CPS
call? I watched the whole iDubbbz video.
I didn't think it was very good, but I didn't think that happened.
There was? Yes.
Oh, the iDubbbz video is Ethan, you need to protect yourself
better online.
Okay. That's me being good faith, right? Agreed? I'm giving you
an advance of my reaction will be before I see it, right?
Yeah. Okay. So, what So, so So, give me the example of thing
and I'll tell you how I think it'll affect my opinion.
>> right? I'll be back in 5 minutes.
So, Destiny steps out here to go get a clip, okay? Remember how
you just said Candace, dude, it's not even fair with Candace
because it's is actually such
with Candace, okay? It's actually such
because Erica Kirk did the dumbest thing imaginable. Erica Kirk
is the biggest Erica Kirk gave total and complete cover to everything
that Candace has been saying. Erica Kirk basically came out and
rubber-stamped all of Candace's opinions. Erica Kirk
Erica Kirk is the dumbest human being on planet Earth. Holy Erica
Kirk is the dumbest person on It's so bad that she would go and
like have a meeting with Candace and just sit down with her and
be like Like cuz that implies everything Candace is saying is
serious and needs to be taken seriously.
Right? I'm sorry, this was the dumbest decision she could have
made. It's incredibly embarrassing. Holy [__] Okay,
holy [__] All right. You go back to this. Destiny's
going to disappear for 5 minutes. Now, he's saying I I'm going
to show you proof that Denims celebrated, okay? And then we'll
go watch what actually happened. Uh spoiler alert, it's going
to break down to Oh, well, don't look at what Denim said, look
at what her chat says. Yeah. Cool.
Kafka, thoughts about this? Are you convinced that I did this
to uh promote protection of a community that um on Destiny's
view is trying to uh further harass Rose?
Is that what you think? That you that you're doing all this to
protect uh Destiny's community? >> Yeah. Do you think that's
why I'm doing this? That's what That's what he openly speculated
about. And that's what See, this is I think this just gave me
like a pretext or yeah, a pretext to discuss this in Pisco's
Discord cuz I was like, oh, I don't think this happened. It's
like tough to say exactly what it is, but realistically, if you're
looking for the community that has harassed Rose, it is Destiny
and his community far more than anyone else, right?
That's the That's the real issue for me is like I just think
it's totally disingenuous.
Obviously, Destiny's community and Destiny himself specifically
have heaped way more harassment on Rose than anyone else. Well,
except maybe Keemstar. I don't know who messaged her who might
have found more info on her. But like my community doesn't even
factor into that conversation. Destiny maliciously doxxed her
and then Destiny himself, the person who who requested custom
content of this minor who's being trafficked, right? He messaged
her on Facebook from his own
and tried talking to her.
Destiny tried reaching out to the minor who is trafficked to
him directly. Don't you think that if you didn't want to harass
Like that's pretty insane, isn't it? Like the John reaching out
to the minor who is trafficked to
Proof? Destiny claimed it himself
Destiny himself said he messaged her. Cuz he thought it he thought
he is so that he thought it he he thought it made him look good
cuz he was like, well, she blocked me and then I didn't message
her again. Unironically, he came out himself and said it. Pull
the clip. Somebody can grab the clip. What he suggested?
Yeah, we'll grab the >> seen the evidence of that, but
it's also I mean, I've seen maybe >> Why aren't you Why
aren't you convinced by that? I wonder. I just I mean Again,
I I think it's Again, this comes back to more of a fact issue.
I'm not really super familiar with all this. That's what I was
going to come in here and discuss with you about it. Yeah, but
we've been talking about it for like an hour plus and uh Sure,
but I mean like I think it's I think it's a thing where there's
a whether you intended to or not, I think that there can definitely
be cover for that community
what what do you What do you mean I'm covering? Hiram, I think
you're covering for her because you drink water and drinks water,
actually. I think that's >> And for them on with with respect
to the harassment of Rose, you think that I would I'm the kind
of person that you know that would want to do that to cover these
people who are harassing a young
Why would I have that intent?
I don't know that you I don't think I'm not saying you possess
that intent. I'm saying that there's I think that the Destiny's
community definitely has the ability to He's got to He's got
to virtue signal to everybody, guys, okay? I think they're corrupting
a lot of what you do. They're trying to find you as an ally.
They're I mean, currently fighting with people in your Pisco
right now. They very much have an interest in bringing you to
their side to some degree whether, you know, that's intentional
or not.
I think in terms of like the Destiny and him trying to stop Oh,
sorry, him trying to doxx people, I think I would like Pisco
on my side. I would like to go and lay out why I think it's like
bad, why it's disingenuous.
Right? I think that would be good.
in terms of the H3 stuff, Pisco has his own opinion. He happened
He agreed after I gave my opinion. I'd given my opinion. Oh,
what's up, Alassanabi? Thank you very much for the Yeah, [__]
this Destiny guy. Yeah, he's just totally full of [__]
man.
But I
I like stated all of these opinions in Ethan Klein. Like right,
Queenman and I were talking about this months before Pisco ever
weighed in on any of this stuff, right? I'll I'll give Queenman
his laurels. Like he was obviously pointing out how awful Ethan
Klein was even before I was. Like it was through talking to him
that I was like, oh, yeah, actually when you look at the evidence,
this guy's kind of a piece of This guy's actually kind of the
worst, in fact.
But we had that position way before Pisco. And Pisco came to
it on one thing, one specific thing.
These people are losing their minds. >> and I think that
the nature of your relationship with Destiny at this point makes
it easy for them to try to co-opt a lot of your stuff. Yeah,
but I I can just be myself and do like like I'm also I interact
with Counter Points. I'm on good terms with Not So Erudite.
uh hold on. Hold on. This is actually a great point, Litigious
Gamer. How many Destiny community members have have been in Pisco's
Discord, in his call-ins, arguing with him vehemently to change
his mind on H3? And then how many of my chatters or Queenman's
chatters have gone and done the same? What's the ratio between
those two?
Cuz I know I've watched a whole bunch of these conversations.
I've never advocated for somebody to go talk to Never said go
talk to him. I've never said, hey, go defend me over here. I
don't say that, right? You guys can do whatever you want.
But a whole bunch of DGGers have come in and tried to argue with
Pisco on this. Like pretty explicitly. Different sized communities,
though? Yeah, but
But I'm saying that if if it were the case that I was trying
to manipulate something where we're trying to get Pisco on our
side, why wouldn't I go and say, oh, somebody should go argue
with him. Why wouldn't I go argue with him on this, right?
Why would I go and argue with him on something else?
Oh, Kathy has called in, but Kathy you I don't I don't think
you can can't count I don't think you can count Kathy as a part
of a community, to be honest. >> I'm on good terms with
you. I talk to members who are frequenters of that community.
And so, in what sense is it that I I've fallen into the black
hole and of You're also on good terms with Erin and Ange. Communism!
Tankies! Tankies! They're all tankies! Meanwhile, every night
of my stream, okay? Last Friday night, that's it.
Epic. Last Friday night.
community, please say
Hit one. I don't do it.
Get back to work, Matt Walsh. Defend Start defending Israel.
Last Friday You got to close it and keep going. Is she part of
What is she doing that's snarking? I'm not saying that she's
snarking, but I'm just saying that you maintain relationships
with people that are not that that Destiny has issues with.
By the way, Destiny doesn't actually have issues with Erin. The
second the stuff happened with Erin with regards to those leaks,
he immediately defended her and then only later when it became
effective to do so, when it became convenient to do so, he flipped
and started [__] Erin. When immediately those leaks
happened, he was totally on Erin's side. He was like, oh, no,
Erin's a nice person. She's never done anything bad to me. Nothing
like that, guys. Don't go after her, right? Is Straight Raze
a coper? No, I actually argue against Fuentes' ideas like a decent
amount, but not because I not because I'm like uh polar opposite
of him. It's because I don't like some of the like I guess entailments
of the things he argues for. But he totally defended her and
then it was only once like she was kind of attached to Pisco
that he started going, oh, yeah. Also, how did Erin get away
with all of this stuff? And then he started flipping back and
forth. He'd go like from stream to stream being like, well, actually
Erin didn't really do that much wrong, but also, how does she
get off the hook? It's very goofy. So, his DGGers are very
Example of Oh, issues with I mean, like but I'm also maintaining
relationship with people that he is good friends with.
Sure, but a large part of the Destiny community's issues with
Destiny surround this lawsuit that arguably probably wouldn't
have be at where it's at without Straight Raze's involvement.
I mean, she It's not like she's totally removed from it. Holy
crap. I mean, but but but I mean, that's Is that true? Wait,
I thought Pixie was suing no matter what. What is he Is he saying
Like What could that possibly mean? That might be the most most
insane >> this lawsuit that arguably probably wouldn't
have be at where it's at without Straight Raze's involvement.
I This lawsuit wouldn't be where it's at without Straight Raze's
involvement. So, he's either claiming that Pixie would never
have like filed this if the videos don't get put out, but then
why did I I thought they said the opposite, that she was already
planning to. Isn't that their reasoning for her deleting a message
being like spoliation?
Is that she was obviously planning to file the lawsuit no matter
what? So, then I guess Kafka would have to agree that she absolutely
did not spoil She She's not guilty of spoliation. She didn't
do anything like that, right?
Very very weird.
Also, I don't know. I'm trying to think. It's possible that some
stuff never comes out if those videos don't get released. I think
those videos were getting released almost no matter what. I think
those videos were definitely getting released. That Sunday happened
to be the one who went first, but that those logs were in other
places. Yeah, I I believe 100%. I would say I would bet any amount
of money that if Erin didn't send those logs to President Sunday,
those videos still get made.
I mean she It's not like she's totally removed from it. Holy
crap. I mean but but but I mean that's true of anyone who's like
a potential
No no no no no. You don't understand Charging Jim. There are
still people who are going to make videos regardless of whether
or not Sunday was first to make a video.
That regardless of if those logs get sent to Sunday, that video
does still get made.
Now, I don't think that's a reason that you don't loop Pixie
in, which is what
Is the criticizable thing here, okay?
But I just I just wish The only real criticism I have is that
they didn't loop Pixie in. Like I I do think it's bad to go without
her consent without her wanting it to be public, but it's like
ultimately if you feel like it's going to it's a story in the
public interest and it's going to get released no matter what,
then I think you do your journalistic duty and you just inform
them that it's coming out and there's nothing that's really going
to stop it at this point and you're going to drop a video on
it and here's like 24 or 48 hours heads up so you can get anything
done that you need to get done.
Anyway, there is no argument. Trust me, if you know everything
behind the scenes, there is zero argument that that you wouldn't
argue with me if you knew everything that went down. That regardless
of whether Erin sent the DMs to Sunday, those videos would have
been getting made. They might have been a week or two delayed,
but they were getting made. >> We involved the fact pattern
there and I don't want to get into actually talking about the
merits of it but for reasons I've already stated and and that
is Sorry, we got to quick doobie don't Pisco, I think it's time
to just be honest. I'll say it. We are in fact converting you
to a tankie communist communism with $10 super chats. You have
these opinions because I pay for your coffee sometimes.
Is that out of respect for the process and out of respect frankly
for for what I was doing at the time in in the sense of what
we're doing in New York and like so there's a bunch of reasons
why I don't talk about that.
But regardless of it, you got baited on
So again,
in terms of the core criticism here that Pisco is giving cover
to the people who harassed Rose, I think Pisco is giving even
more cover to the people who harassed Rose by Sorry, I'm not
actually going to make this argument. But if you were going to
make the argument I think platforming Destiny on this topic would
actually be giving more cover to the people who have harassed
Rose. I think, okay? I think. But I I don't actually make that
argument. I don't think he's trying to do that. I think it's
I think I If I disagree with Pisco, I just say these are the
things I disagree on. I wouldn't go, "Hey, you're like helping
this community adjacently by agreeing with them on something
even though you've never talked or coordinated." into fighting
with somebody
Who's that?
Kind of crazy how much J Soc is still in Destiny's head. It is
kind of crazy, isn't it? It's kind of weird. I don't know what's
going on there, man.
No, Sunday still streams old man.
I agree. I'm not accusing you of anything, but you want to pretend
that you don't know what you're doing. So what are you accusing
me of doing? I don't I don't make any claims about what you're
doing, but you know what you're doing and you can't claim to
stand apart from what you're doing. But what am I doing? I don't
know what you're doing. I don't make any claims about what you're
doing, but stop making me TRY TO STAND ON ANYTHING. STOP. STOP.
Stop trying to actually make me stand with a spine on anything.
Stop. Stop.
Uh are this Kafka guy and Zip Zip the same person? Are they will
never make a claim of their own to stand on?
It's like so embarrassing. Just make a claim, bro. Holy sh
Say a thing. Say a thing and stand on business. It's so not difficult,
man. >> Take a You want to take a a distance from all that
stuff, that's fine. But there are parts of your community and
and your engagement online that are bleeding into it that are
trying that there are people trying to pull you to it. I'm Okay,
and just in terms of
I have never without
some precipitating action brought up the Destiny drama in Pisco's
Discord or brought Like right? I've never There's always something
precipitating here, you know? Like in this case, they're talking
about like my community harasses Rose as if that's like a foregone
conclusion
or they celebrate harassing Rose, which is just explicitly not
true, by the way.
So when they're going to say that, I'm going to go, "No no no,
my community doesn't harass this person. Here's what actually
happened and if you were actually mad about this person getting
harassed, Destiny is guilty of conduct far more egregious."
I think that's totally reasonable for me to say. I should get
to say that when they're discussing this topic on stream.
So I'll ask you, should should I ban
Should I ban just Silk from my
I think that there are a lot of very good reasons to do that.
Is that Is that yes?
Whether you
How am I Dude, I'm like I'm like straight up Bro, these guys
make me seem kind of badass. I'm not going to lie. I am actually
like so I'm almost getting to the point where I'm like, "Wait.
Wait, they make me sound so cool." They make me sound so cool.
I'm like this shadowy figure in the background manipulating everybody
to be against Destiny somehow. I'm like so
Oh my god. Should I ban Queeman? your inactivity. Yeah, I think
you should. I think your inactivity in that brings up a lot of
Hey, is it wrong to accuse people of having a cabal that controls
everything with no evidence for that? Is that like
And follow-up question, do you have any issues with the term
Zog?
Just unrelated questions. Don't worry about it. Okay.
But I shouldn't ban
I shouldn't I shouldn't I shouldn't ban Counter-Points, right?
I shouldn't ban
I don't I don't see Counter-Points acting in a way that's trying
to harm other people online. Right?
You're saying I should take a stance in
Okay, so that's really easy, okay? That's really really easy.
Uh in terms of my conduct versus Destiny's conduct, I'd like
the list of my actions that have harmed him and his actions that
have harmed me, okay?
Cuz I'm going to contend that realistically I've never said anything
about him that's false
And he consistently lies about me and then tries to intimidate
me from speaking about him. I don't try to intimidate him from
speaking about me.
I don't really have the the platform to do it.
So most of my content when I stream, at least for the past what,
month, two months? There are times when Destiny gets more active
in doxxing and [__] that I do go back to covering
his stuff. But like I realistically just cover other stuff cuz
it's more interesting and I have
You said he's funny, that's false. He was. He used to be. It's
It seems to be totally gone at this point. By the way, this whole
time while this conversation's happening, he's looking desperately
for Denims celebrating the CPS call. Okay.
Or do you think I should? I mean you think I should because because
why? I mean I think because they have very clear intent to try
to cop your language to use it to harm Destiny. I think it's
fine I think it's fine for you to go to an area
Dude. These people like I don't know. Pisco is so good faith.
He's like, "Oh, could you substantiate that in some
This guy just repeats Marco Rubio over here. Uh they're just
going to use you to to harm Destiny. Wait, how? Uh they're just
going to use you to harm Destiny. How? Uh they're just going
to use you to
Bro, you got to make it Say something.
Do some [__] dude. The other week I did a reaction
of Soy Pill and Destiny's conversations with these two conservative
lawyers in which I almost uniformly praised their performance
and said they did a wonderful job. The other like when they people
were going after Steven for
trying to charge him with
Dude, are you are you serious with that sh So so you think are
you are you
You're you're you're you're scared that I'm going to uh what?
Because I because I state my genuine views on stuff. Prove your
loyalty, Pisco. Grovel before daddy and ban his haters is basically
the content of this entire argument right here.
Because some community that's bad could take it a certain way,
I'm sure that like the all the people who are fans of Denims
and Hassans, they love that I'm I'm talking about this case in
the way that I am. But that's incidental to why I'm doing it,
right? It's not related to why I'm doing it. Why I'm doing it
is because it's my opinion, right? Why I'm doing it is because
of all the reasons that I want to talk about it, not because
I want to um please Denims, please Hassans, but people seem to
think that I do, right?
Is that your impression? I I want to
This is just for money. Like Wouldn't it I have overwhelming
Dude, him and Zip Zip are like the same guy. Uh I would never
say this, but like people are saying it. I would never say it
cuz that would be but people are saying it. Wait, so can you
find these people and get them to talk to me? Well, like
Do people are saying it though? They're like would that happen
if it weren't true? Dude. And to my credibility's detriment defended
you and the DG community and I will tell you this Pisco I I
Did this guy just say he's lost
Okay, so you're just you're arguing it's like Optics within that
community like Pisco would would it look better to these people?
Okay.
Would it look better to these people if Pisco flipped his opinion
for no reason other than
adjacent some other streamers agree with you. So you have to
flip your opinion and support Destiny.
Would that make Pisco look better in these people's eyes?
Like like that would be totally disingenuous, right? What are
they advocating for? Hey, what steps do you want me to take?
Pisco's going to keep asking that by the way. Hey, what do you
want me to do? You want me to ban these guys? You want me to
like flip my Pisco What do you want me to do? And this guy literally
can't say I guess he did agree on the banning maybe. I I understand
where you're coming from on this, but you're a person with a
legal degree. You're a person with some level of credibility
on the internet and you're a person who really was not a huge
part of this drama [__] in the past and then now
after your falling out with Destiny, we see you engaging in it.
We see you Come in engaging Wait, wait, engaging in what?
in what?
In the discussion around this drama stuff that Could you state
the harm, please? Please state the harm. Like please for the
love of God, could you state the harm? Could you do anything
useful? Holy
Engaging in what?
In the discussion around this drama stuff that really
What drama stuff? So so I'm not talking about drama stuff related
to Destiny.
You're you're talking about No, no, I didn't say related to Destiny.
Drama. I don't remember you ever prior to the January of this
year getting in the middle of online drama stuff and things like
this and having these massive
Pisco absolutely
hopped on during the twitch anti-semitism stuff was all about
arguing that that was uncalled for. So this is just false. Pisco's
been on my stream multiple times. Not always to disagree with
me by the way, like he seems to claim here. But
Dude, I I don't like
It's actually super gay that he has to buy in and just be like
he has to take his fact. He can't even give me what he gave BadEmpanada
which is a little frustrating, okay? I'll just say that. Little
frustrating. He can't even give me Well, actually that's like
he's got a bad reputation, but I'm unaware. He can't even give
me that. He's just got to go yeah, this guy's evil. I disagreed
with him every time I ever saw him which we did disagree a lot.
I I feels like weird to me that he wouldn't even give me but
I know why it's cuz
Because of how the communities overlap. I get it. I get it. It's
fine. But even in that case, okay, even in that case I support
him here.
the drama on All right, so let's just go through examples and
and then we'll we'll see if you agree. Do you remember when President
Sunday went after Aella I Oh, yeah, another perfect example of
Do you remember that? Do you remember what I did there?
I do. I remember you had a really great showing against him.
Your specific debate with him and I think that you had you came
in there and you clearly
Some people disagree on
Well, hang on a second. Do you guys remember how many posts when
I would do Sunday posts where people would keep you know trying
to debate me and trying to say that I was wrong about stuff defending
Kyla and I kept defending and kept defending and kept defending
and kept defending and went on Sunday stream and spent 7 hours.
Doesn't this sound exactly what I tend to do when I get pushback
significant pushback on an issue that I I like weighed into
that I I don't just have this like neutral approach that I never
address things related to streamers. I mean what you just characterized
was completely wrong, right? This is totally in keeping with
my personality, right? And in what way is it not in keeping with
in what way is it in what WAY IS IT NOT keeping with the personality?
You care about the people that >> on. Wait, wait, so now
you're condescending me.
Wait, now you're kind of No, you don't understand. So President
Sunday's like really bad and Kyla's like really good. So when
you engage with drama there, it doesn't count in the same way.
Right now, you're like arguing with the bad people against the
good people. But when you argue with the bad with the good people
against the bad people, that's good. Cool. I
Is this guy the
lawyer for a preschool? Like I hope he I hope he's a lawyer somewhere
where they can keep him like taped together. They can keep his
like water wings on so he doesn't drown in the coffee pot. You're
saying that I You're you're saying that I only defended Kyla
because she was my friend. I think that I think that you would
have defended her in any case to the extent that you did, no.
I think you would have you
What? Wait. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. So
he's arguing that it's actually good to defend your friends no
matter what. That like no matter what they've done, no matter
how bad it is, it's best to defend them. Like actually I think
you would have defended her NO MATTER WHAT.
DUDE, I I FEEL LIKE I have to look at Pisco's face there as he
like absorbs >> that you would have defended her in any
case to the extent that you did, no. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Dude, he's like, wait, what the [__] are you saying?
Are you arguing that I like disingenuously argue my points on
the internet? I think there's no more no more like insulting
thing to Pisco when someone says that he is dishonestly doing
something that he's like disingenuously performing.
I think there's like nothing more insulting to this guy than
that comment right there. You think you think I would have you
would have you think I would have defended Kyla even if I thought
she was wrong and she committed credential fraud. If I thought
that she committed credential fraud defended her. If I didn't
know her, I wouldn't sorry. Help me out there. So I wouldn't
have waited into it unless I didn't know her. So once I provide
you an example where again that's not true and I've talked about
something which happens to come up or like I make it I make a
tweet about it that is to someone I don't know. I'll give you
actually an example right now. So the TikTok fugitive. Remember
the TikTok fugitive?
I don't. I'm sorry. Okay, so in case you don't remember,
there was this TikTok fugitive guy and I happened to
see that I think I had him on stream or
Keeping in my character. None of this is inconsistent with what
my my modus operandi is. By the way, I don't know how long has
Destiny been gone for at this point? I do think it it seems very
likely to me. He goes for like 15 or 20 minutes. I'm pretty confident
that he gets the clip. He watches the clip. And then he goes,
oh [__] this isn't enough. And then he desperately
searches for another clip. And then after like 20 minutes, he
comes back and he's like I didn't have the clip. I I I mean I
respectfully disagree. I understand that your perspective is
different from mine. From an outside observer watching you do
these things, I remember you going through this stuff. I think
that you have very strong opinions when it comes to legal stuff.
I think you have very good takes. I really enjoy hearing you
and I think you are very good at defending those and really sticking
to those. I think though in these situations when we are looking
at them, I do not think there's a very interesting legal question
as to the H3 lawsuit. I do not think one exists. And so it's
really hard for me to understand where you are coming from. I
will tell you.
I will tell you. I will so I will absolutely tell you my initial
interest in the case, but I I I do want to say it is in keeping
with my character.
Hold on. Who was this?
Go back. I'm going to look at this Jen comment right here. Yes,
poor little J talking queen and why involve these those innocent
little
character and what I tend to do is to like comment occasionally
on things that come before me and and then again get into these
rabbit holes and get into these arguments. That's In fact, it's
not just that. It's like
The truth is Kafka only wants you to cover drama when you agree
with Destiny because Destiny is a spiteful man child and Kafka
is a noodle spine sycophant.
Wow, that's so true. My whole interactions with Steven weren't
just like prior to January of this year weren't just glaising
Steven almost all all the time. It was disagreements. It was
the rare occurrence that I went on strictly to agree with him
and the more recent stuff when we were when we were just doing
things Okay, real real real quick. Just for the sake of I said
the Facebook comment >> Rose lied under oath. Yes, funnily
enough Rose and Pixie did the same. Haha, but that's all of Just
Kidding's Discord server now. Because remember, so that Say this
guy in Just Kidding's Discord server is openly bragging about
in that server posting emails. This guy created several email
accounts and was harassing Rose, was harassing her family, threatening
them, telling them like I hope
So he literally never threatened
What happened from what I understand is he had an email account.
He messaged her and was like, hey, you're doxxed. Here's how
you would remove stuff from here. And then they talked. They
corresponded.
And she he helped her remove some stuff. And then after a while,
he'd been messaging her about stuff being removed. He thought
she got spooked and then he was also I think he'd talked to Pixie's
team. This guy's like way parasocial, way too involved. I agree
with that, okay, that's I think basically if Pixie just wanted
help or needed help with stuff, I don't think it's wrong for
someone to help her. And then I think Pixie's legal team said,
hey, if you could like give us the email for her, that would
be cool. And I think Say was like, well, I feel like I should.
And so he emailed Rose, tried to get in contact with her one
more time including messaging once
to her and a few other people related to her saying like, "Hey,
just so you know, there's a legal case going on here and if you
got spooked I because he didn't like message and say, "Did you
block me?" He was like, "If you did get spooked, here's like
how you would reach out to this person."
Which I Again, I understand how that's like weird, but people
are basically saying, "Well, he him thinking he got blocked and
then doing the extra messages, that's like obviously harassment."
And I'm like, I I think it could be unwanted. I don't think it's
obviously harassment. I don't think it's crazy in any way. And
realistically like the worst thing that happened there, in my
opinion, was including some information about how their minor
child was
to his parents, right? Like to her parents that she made up of.
But then I I think that's like a whole argument on its own, right?
Is it okay to know that a minor was trafficked and then they're
like 19 now or 20 now and then you don't
you don't feel like Yeah, I don't know. But I think that's probably
the worst thing that happened. Yeah, I just said people related
to him or to her. Which I I think it's like bad. I wouldn't have
done that, but I think he didn't want to give away the email
contact to other people. Yeah. Yeah, I I agree it's bad. I just
don't think it's like crazy harassment or threats. I think it
doesn't rise to
And basically like after that happened, I because I was out of
town, I didn't get a chance to go over it. And then I came back
and I'm like, "This is like annoying." And then Destiny had fully
doxxed the guy and I was like, "Okay, I like I feel like I think
you kind of got punished outside of my control."
I just didn't see the need to like go, "Oh, this guy's to be
banned." It's very clear if you ever If anybody does that in
the future, if you're like emailing people who are related to
the content, you're like talking them off platform coming from
my community, like I can't really [__] I'm not [__]
around with that anymore, okay?
So, anyway, that's that's what happened there. I think it's totally
conflated. And then we're going to hear what Destiny did. So,
do you think Destiny is the person who requested specific custom
videos from this woman from this girl who was a minor being trafficked
knowing now for a fact that she was a minor and she was trafficked
after he found out who she was, what did he do? >> You contact
John Peters. Oh, I see that you haven't yet. I hope that you
would have done the right thing and I see that you failed to
do that. It's very
By the way, I don't think that was uh >> were getting doxxed
and harassed by the way by all of I think I think He and he also
doxxed the guy. >> who watched the stupid Willy Mac videos
and everybody else in Just Go's Discord server, right? Um and
we could see Yeah, we didn't We totally disagree with >> of
the server where they all laugh about this [__] But
now the claim is that I >> We didn't laugh about it. that
I was collaborating with Rose secretly in order to um in order
to make a whole bunch of lies and [__] up and
Nobody makes this claim. >> By the way, the only person
who collaborated with or tried to do anything with Rose was Joan
and Pixie. I had zero access to this person. I have messaged
this person one time in my life and it was when I found their
Facebook account and then I messaged them and they blocked me
immediately. Whoever that the the actual Rose person is. But
So, the minor that was trafficked to him, he decided to go try
to message on Facebook. Now, personally,
I think an extra email from a guy you were already corresponding
with,
an extra email from that guy behind a block including emails
to like other people, I'm just going to say
you messaging the minor that was trafficked for you to see what's
up, I think that's weird personally, okay? I think that's probably
something you
But that's just me. I would probably say that's even worse than
what Cypher did.
Also, the key witness is I'm just going to say I think that's
very very very
They're both pretty bad. I agree they're both bad. I just think
this combined with his open and accepted and confessed to doxxing
of Rose as in posting a bunch of PII taunting Kiwi Farms to try
to find her and then accepting responsibility for that saying
that was So, I think given these two things, his conduct is like
an order of magnitude worse than Cypher's. And so, I really don't
think him trying to virtue signal and say that my community is
like evil when he's done worse himself, I just don't think it's
like an argument you can make. I think it's like clearly not
There isn't really much merit to put a scale on this. You're
just wrong to
There's totally a Like I would say it's just totally disingenuous
from his side to pretend that
he cares about this. Yes? Yeah.
It's fine. >> Joan and I guess however many Anyway, I just
wanted to show that he did actually message the the person who
was trafficked to him as a minor on Facebook to I don't know.
I don't know what he was going to do to be honest with you. Don't
It's Very strange. >> on, but almost everyone who knows
me in my time here is I love having these debates. I love having
these arguments and it's never been the case that I've like you
know, didn't done the kind of practice you're you're you're talking
about here or that I diverge wildly on on the A3 lawsuit. On
the A3 lawsuit specifically, I can tell you exactly why I did
Uh Desombre, um tomorrow we'll take Collins on all this stuff.
If you want to call in tomorrow, you can come and argue this.
I think I think there's just no possible way to argue this that
Cypher's conduct is worse.
I think it's like almost impossible to argue it. >> this
because I know exactly why I did this. My I was about to go home.
It was either a wedding or it was some other It might have been
like a bachelor party or whatever. Oh, I'll go even further.
I'll say anybody who just argues that they're both bad and they
like trying to compare them doesn't make sense is just sweeping
for the obviously worse action, right? >> I mean, I I have
the text. I was about to go home and the lawsuit had just dropped
and my editor messaged me and was like, "Hey, this might be interesting
to talk about." And I'm like, "Oh, a copyright case. A copyright
case from Ethan, right?" My last knowledge of Ethan's copyright
cases was the bald guy one.
Apparently, um Dan took Food Shops' perms away in the Discord.
Oh, I forgot also Dan asked me for the clip.
I maybe I shouldn't say it. Dan asked me for the clip of Food
Shops or whatever saying um that she has to cross the street
when she sees a child or whatever. So, if anyone has that clip
and wants to send it to me so I can send it along to Dan or send
it to Dan directly.
I'll let you just send it to me and I'll send it to Dan, okay?
But the clip where she talks about having to cross the street
if there's like a child on the same side of the street like she's
scared of what she'll do to the child. If anybody has that one,
that would be By the way, Destiny's partner in crime who he leaked
multiple sealed documents
Very cool, very awesome. Or maybe just one sealed document multiple
times. Very cool, very cool. one which I followed, one which
I read the briefing, one which I read the opinion. And I went
into that on because he sub Dude. Food Shops thought she was
going to get in on the Arc Raiders streams.
Food Shops thought Food Shops thought it was going to be her,
Mr. Mouton, Dan, Pikachu just chilling playing our
Unlucky.
Unlucky. >> So, let's experiment with this. It's more like
pop culture-y type legal thing. Does that sound like crazy to
you that that happened so far as I've related it?
No. Okay. So, so that So, wait, wait, wait. So, so because it
seems to be that we're we're assessing the the credibility of
the notion that I'm motivated to to do this because I'm grifting
or something or that I'm doing it for some improper purpose.
>> you were grifting. Okay. So, well, so we'll so we'll
keep going. My editor tells me, "Why don't you react to this,
all right? Why don't you Let's try different things. Let's see
what's going on." And that's what I do. I react to it in real
time and my going into it, I am sympathetic to Ethan because
I know that he has this track record uh for the for the copyright
stuff. And in the course of doing that reaction, I I'm like,
"Wait, this doesn't make sense." Immediately, I'm like, "This
rationale doesn't make sense." You can watch me react in real
time to it, all right? You can watch me in real time. The video
is up. It's one of my most hated videos like all my other videos.
very well regarded among my own community. I came on stream at
the time and discussed it with you. I remember all this. >> So,
so and what do you think is more likely why I started reacting
to to people reacting to the argument what I said there? Is it
because I I have a vendetta against Ethan Klein, you know, before
he said what he said? Or do you think it's because people kept
bringing it up and saying, "You're wrong, you're wrong, you're
wrong, you're wrong." And the fact that I'm responding to people
saying, "You're wrong, you're wrong, you're wrong, you're wrong."
Isn't that exactly
what my personality is like? Isn't that exactly what I do all
the time? And I bring people in to specifically have the conversations.
It's just not credible that the reason I'm doing this is to ingratiate
myself. If I was trying to grift, what I would do is read the
room and and pander and and and pander and pander. That's what
I would
What's No, no, no, but what's What's the divergence? What's the
divergence? What I Okay. Wait, wait, wait. Real quick.
>> Oh my god. How long Surely we've got all of the denim's
proof now, guys. We've got it all. All the denim's proof is
Two two guys. >> Let's check it out. This guy first, okay?
Oh, we got a one more one more Doobie comment here. Another Doobie
super chat. Kaf is a grown ass man going to another grown ass
man begging him to stop publicly disagreeing with his Z Daddy.
What a sad display. The roach in a suit profile pic makes so
much more sense now. Wow, Doobie really don't miss, does he?
Has Doobie ever missed
with a super chat? People are like, "Oh, this guy keeps spending
$10 a chat." It's cuz he doesn't miss. He's got like 100% hit
rate. It's crazy. >> Let's I sent you first thing. Just
send the first link to Pisco, okay? We'll just Let's just watch
this one, okay? This is 9 months ago. Okay. So, um 9 months ago.
>> Kaf, can you going to message it to me? I'm trying to
send the record. One
Give it a exhibit.
Sticker on this. Um okay. Oh, wait. This might This might make
sense why it might be difficult for
Can Pisco not get DMs from people who are he's not friends with
and then he's like not friends with me or Destiny trying to be
Switzerland? Is that what I'm getting?
Maybe that's what I'm getting.
Cuz I I like tried re-adding him on Discord and I couldn't re-add
him on Discord. So, I'm guessing that that's
I I'm guessing that might be what it is. Okay, I just sent it
to you, Pisco. Okay. Does this happen Here Here my My going to
be as I'm putting the clip up for the audience, is this clip
before or after CPS is called? Cuz the claim is that they celebrated
CPS being called,
Well, the title of this clip is Denims claims Ela is complaining
about CPS for
Destiny blocked him, if you remember. Pisco said so himself.
Oh, I didn't remember that. And thought about doing worse to
people.
Is she still friends with the other account? Maybe. >> two
minutes after the CPS call. Okay, got it. Might just not see
it. Okay, we're we're seeing it. Also, can this take two seconds
to figure out how to put videos on stream more consistently?
Ela here to be like, this is Pink it's
He's going to get it up here eventually. >> Literally,
the vast majority of people are like, vast, are not remembering
anything that happened to them at three. Okay. I think that is
pretty clearly
a CPS call. Yep. Now, what we're looking for, what Destiny said
he knew he could find really easily, was celebrating the CPS
call, which is different, right? Minimizing is like doing this
minor thing, this like little thing. Celebrating is saying it
was a good thing that it happened. She's not saying it's a good
thing that it's happened. She's saying it's they're complaining
they're making too big a deal out of it. That is very different
from celebrating it. It's just sympathy, right? It's just she's
just pulling like the IDF classic card of like, please, my life
is so difficult. Please, everyone that That's the guy who's spamming
Pisco me in in Pisco's chat over here. >> us needs [__]
awful experiences because we're the ones dealing with the real
awful experiences. Oh, so she said the same thing. Okay. Like
the exact same thing. Cool. Ela did worse to Palestinian kids
in the IDF. I mean, I'm sure she's thought about doing terrible
things to people when she was in the IDF. I can't
on what she
So, this was By the way, Destiny spent 20 minutes looking for
a clip of Denims celebrating the CPS call. And this is what he
showed up with. No, Destiny's here. This is Destiny went AFK
to get a clip of Denims celebrating the CPS call. This is Denims
celebrating the CPS call. >> I think that that is her downplaying
the significance of CPS call, okay? >> Yep. I don't think
that's her celebrating the CPS call. Wait, I Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, can
So, claim was celebrating the CPS call. Pisco said he would change
his opinion if you give him a clip of Denims celebrating the
CPS call. No, no, wait, wait, wait. Why can't we agree on that
So, so far >> this holistically, okay? No, no, wait, because
we're talking I'm still talking about the clip. Let me finish
talking about the clip, okay? Let me Let me explain to you why
Denims is bad. Denims is really, really, really bad. So, knowing
that Denims is bad,
like, this will all I will be able to turn this into something
that it's not. These are messages from her chat while that clip
was playing. Is this a fair representation of them? Wait, no,
so so
These are messages from her chat while the clip is playing, bro.
>> Is this a selection of messages over like a 10-minute
period and you're you're picking out the worst >> of messages
that I just clipped out from the chat. Cenk Uygur, you can send
him the picture if you want so he can read along. I just did
it in the 60-second clip, okay? ACAB includes CPS, but I get
the point. You're not swatting them. If you even have a family
YouTube channel, you got to have CPS come and make sure they're
safe. It's just a conversation with a social worker. It's crazy
that the Zionism supporters don't appreciate having random searches
of their homes, being falsely accused, being questioned, etc.
Okay. CPS are not cops. They are not brutalizing children. They
are literally just asking people questions. Like, there are so
many cases of people with like seven Pisco should have said after
every single one of these chat messages, do you disagree with
this? >> being falsely accused, being questioned, etc.
Even have a family YouTube channel, you got to have CPS come
and make sure they're safe. It's just a conversation with a social
worker. It's crazy that the Zionism supporters don't appreciate
So, it's just a conversation with a social worker. Agree or disagree?
Even having random searches of their homes, being falsely accused,
being questioned, etc. Okay.
Comparing it to Zionists, you know, comparing it to Palestinians
who have to have their houses randomly searched. Okay, do we
disagree that that's like a >> CPS are not cops. They are
not brutalizing children. They are literally just asking people
questions. Like, there are so many
Okay, that's minimizing as well. We're looking for even the chat
messages. Could any of these chat messages be seen as celebrating?
So, like, I think it's like one of four could maybe conceivably
be considered celebrating so far. >> seven adopted children
just kept in the worst conditions and CPS doesn't give a I just
don't get why people are making a judgment call on this. I don't
know why they were there. I have no proof who called. All I know
is CPS checked on kids. So, I'm not going to
So, still no celebration. >> the worst thing that's ever
happened to a family ever. Their kids were on the show. I personally
think that any house that has a child that gets giardia should
get a quick visit. If not from CPS, then from some health inspector.
That's Destiny's opinion one-to-one. He totally agrees with that
with that. We've seen him say that explicitly. >> were
a concern, it's up to the doctor, not people online. I work at
a school and when you have to call CPS, doesn't always mean that
those children are being taken away or taken out. I just want
to remind you guys that yes, even if Destiny had messages from
Denims' chat of people
that wouldn't prove anything, but these are messages that are
totally like neutral, that totally neutral to like maybe slightly
smug with the Palestinian
and they're not even they're not celebrating. They're Some of
them are straight up like denouncing, essentially. That one right
there, right? Oh, it shouldn't be up to people online, it should
be up to the doctor.
And he Okay, so I think we can all agree that these chat messages
are like an embarrassment to try to pull up as proof that Denims
celebrated the CPS call, >> the home. CPS can also offer
other services and other help to assist the parents. It has to
be a case of abuse, like severe abuse, to have the child removed
from the home. I think the real point is that CPS got called
because of what they said on their show. Uh Again, can we get
any disagreement on this? >> So, if they have nothing to
Yeah, that one I would say is not That one's like smug. >> it
wouldn't be a problem, right? You're making some assumptions.
Sometimes the abuse might be a step parent and the child might
be safer with other bio parents. It's very situational, but maybe
CPS where you are is worse than here. CPS also doesn't just take
kids away. They can order that they clean their house, order
parenting class, People are supporting People are actually supporting
Destiny reading these logs as if anything's been pro This is
like the most embarrassing argument I've ever seen in my entire
life from Destiny. And we've seen some doozies recently, but
he has chat messages that aren't even like celebrating, and he's
trying to make those chat messages support his claim about Denims
celebrating because Denims didn't celebrate. So, he's trying
to use the chat messages to increase his claim against Denims.
But the chat messages aren't even celebrating. So, now he's just
like, I guess hoping that everybody will tell him he's a big
boy and he did really good. says And if the situation is really
bad, they'll put the kids with they blah blah blah. There's like
10 Yeah. When you are watching the chat, when you're listening
to her response
So, those chat messages don't support anything he said, and now
he's using them as if they're support for his >> this.
I think it's downplaying the significance of CPS call. Agreed?
And yeah, I'm kind of sort I actually don't even think that was
mostly downplaying even. Well, maybe it was downplaying. He's
basically saying like, yeah, CPS is a service that exists. Like,
they're really not that bad. So, sure, downplaying. I think some
of them were straight up saying, this isn't the purview of people
on the internet. Nobody from the internet should ever make this
call. That's a totally reasonable opinion. I would say there
is as many that were like negative about a CPS call happening
as there were celebrating or even being >> Sort of. Yeah,
giving cover for it.
Do you think it's fairly characterizable as celebration? Sure.
I don't Maybe I'm crazy, right? So, I When we When we say When
we say celebrate, we don't mean birthday party. He should have
He should have been forced to walk through those chat messages
one by one and classify them. Is this celebrating? Is it downplaying?
Is it denouncing?
It's so embarrassing. Uh-huh, yeah.
He has to understand that like no matter Yeah, the Oh, hold on.
We have one
degenerate in the chat. Yeah, this is
Yeah, this is gross. Bro, have you ever seen Destiny cover something
where like his community doesn't like somebody? Are we serious?
Like, it's it's actually cultish. It's like the most cultish
[__] I've ever seen in my entire life.
Nothing is proven by these messages. Even if you had messages
of people outright celebrating, I don't think that would prove
something about Denims' conduct, right? But he doesn't have that.
He doesn't have anything.
party. We mean like basically endorse.
Well, I I I don't Do you Do you view this as endorsement?
Or do you think that it's not as a big of a deal? So, for example,
I could I could imagine
There's a So, the obvious thing they're doing here is they're
mimicking Denims, and Denims is saying, I think Ela is overplaying
her hand here. I don't think it's that big a deal. She's not
saying call CPS is a good idea. In fact, in the same stream,
she will denounce calling CPS. She'll say, do not do that. Do
not tap the glass. Do not touch the poo. Do not be involved personally.
she'll say
that Ela is overplaying this. Now, she doesn't like the clients.
She feels like she's been harassed by the clients.
I think this is totally fine to say I think they're overplaying
it, but never ever call them. And then she gives Ethan She even
goes above and beyond and gives Ethan laurels, says like, I think
he takes good care of his kids. I I think like he's he's never
shown pictures of his kids on the internet. I think that's really
good and I've given him that credit. I think he's a total piece
of [__] but you know, I give him credit for this.
I think that those two things are one in the same, and you know
that. I do not
so now, could we go find on the day Charlie Kirk was murdered,
the first time Destiny talks about it? Could we find the DGG
tone on this on Charlie Kirk being murdered? And see if we could
apply that in the same way and say they celebrated him getting
killed. Is that a problem? Is that like a big deal?
Is celebrating like bad things happening to your enemies, no
matter how bad they are, is that a big deal now? Are we morally
Are we wagging our finger at that, guys?
Cuz oh my god,
I feel like that would be maybe the most hypocritical [__]
that's ever happened in these communities.
My goodness. Not think that downplaying and saying it's not as
big of a deal as the same as saying that it's a good that it
happened. Do you think that those are the same thing?
Okay, let me clarify that it was an acceptable outcome of events.
Okay. >> Hold on. I saw a really I saw a really comment
that it Hold on. It's a really It's justifying
it.
It's justifying
Oh, boy.
Oh, boy. Oh, boy. >> an acceptable outcome of events.
I get I'll also say that's really bad faith to Wick. I am just
doing a soy voice giving you guys tone indicators about Wick,
but I also am not even attempting to say I'm addressing his >> And
I think that that's again reintroducing the same problem. I agree
that this is downplaying. I disagree with a lot of the stuff
that you just pointed out. I just My wife goes to a friend with
two black guys and says that her husband beats the [__]
out of her and the friend says, "Well, you are kind of annoying
sometimes." That's a celebration. Is that a celebration?
Again, is that a celebration?
That's Apparently, that's a celebration according to Destiny.
I don't know why we introduced two black guys here. I don't know
why black guys are on Destiny's mind. Are they operative in the
conversation?
Why did he just bring up two black guys? >> with a lot
of the stuff that you just pointed out. I just My wife goes to
a friend with two black guys and says that her husband beats
the [__] out of her and the friend says, "Well, you
are kind of annoying sometimes." Why Why did he add two black
guys? Oh, two black eyes.
Well, okay. Two black eyes.
Oh, well, I Listen, it sounded like black eyes to me. Yeah, I
mean it's not really he didn't kill you. Do you Would you say
that I was like, "Dude, what the fuck?" He's kind of like That
is That is >> too or That is downplaying
I thought he was like trying to imply something about like that's
why the person didn't believe them. saying that is that is give
that is potentially saying that it's not a big deal that it happened.
It's saying that Yeah, true. It was a bit of a Freudian slip
there. Yeah, you know, it's it's more
you know, acceptable. I I will definitely grant that.
Destiny said this was like if Tyler Robinson posting in his Discord
after the assassination was filled with people going boom headshot
awesome.
But that's not what it's like cuz that's not what they did. That'd
be like Tyler That'd be people going to his Discord and saying
things "Well, hold on. What was it?" Trying to think. Charlie
did advocate for like Kill Mar Brego Garcia to get sent to the
the prison or whatever. Like that would be where it would go,
right? >> But I'm not What I understand the claim to be
is that they celebrated for you. That is to say they said that
this was a good thing that happened. It's possible that this
is I mean, I agree a lot of this stuff is really bad. >> Hold on.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Hold on. I have to I have to take a step back
and I got to morph my mind cuz you're so you're so out of um
Wait, what about that is is
Wait. I I have to step back and just deal with how bad faith
you are that you didn't just accept that that woman getting hit
and then her friend going, "Hey, you're kind of annoying sometimes."
That was not a celebration.
I'd say
Um cuz you're you're just inhuman. You might be a sociopath,
okay? Okay. Um it was the same thing. It was him laughing about
it. It was him saying he didn't give a [__] about
that guy. He deserved it. "Fuck around find out." Right? It was
way more effusive, way more supportive than anything Destiny
has said. somebody engaged in some behavior
and Like it's it's just straight up And and that's what maybe
makes the Wick like so embarrassing here is because I do believe
Wick has gone on the other side of some of the Destiny stuff
in terms of like I know he thinks it's bad, right? It's bad He
would say, "Oh, it's bad optics." But I think Wick has gone has
not stopped or sorry, has stopped short of saying Destiny's like
morally wrong. Destiny's like morally in the
But he's going to say Destiny is justifying these attacks.
And Like it's so performative, right? And that's what Pisco starts
to hone in on here at the end that like you don't hold yourself
to even like 1/1000th this standard. Why should I take you seriously
when you pretend you're going to apply the standard to other
people?
Like you don't even come close to holding yourself to this standard.
Why are you applying it to others and pretending you're like
an authority
Like you do so much worse than this all of the time.
For objectively worse events, right? Like how is the Destiny
thing and him saying he refuses to disavow violence until Trump
disavows violence, right? How is that
He just keeps saying, "I refuse to disavow violence. I refuse
to disavow violence." And then he he laughs and jokes about Charlie
Kirk getting shot. How is that better than Destiny and the CPS
call? I don't understand how you get there. Right? It's a worse
event. As bad as the CPS call is, it's not getting shot through
the throat, right?
And then he's laughed way more than Destiny has about it.
But I I literally just don't I don't understand where you come
from on that.
Like who who could possibly take this virtue signal seriously?
It's just a pure virtue signal.
Wait. Hold on. Where is that Thinking Monk clip? People forget
how crazy his violent comments are. What is this? What is this?
I showed the crime statistics.
Not not exactly like I need You need conservatives to be afraid
of getting killed when they go to events.
Yeah, this is the This is the comment that he doubled down on
with Andrew Wilson multiple times. And then and then everybody
sweeps for him. By the way,
embarrassing if you sweep for this and say Destiny's point here
is that we all need to lower the temperature.
That's You are an embarrassment if you argue that, okay? He could
say I have to walk it back or I was wrong, but this idea that
conservatives need to be afraid when they go outside, that's
not him saying we all need to lower the temperature. >> Come
on, dude. >> to their leadership to turn down the temperature.
The issue is right now
they don't feel like there's any fear. Like I don't know I don't
know it's like memes. It's just memes to everybody, I guess.
I don't know, bro. I don't know. I don't care. I'm playing video
games, okay? I'm done today. I don't give a God, I'm going It's
going to be so
By the way, I I'll say
there might be some worlds where you could justify
like political violence in the modern paradigm. That might exist
hypothetically, like philosophically.
But Destiny doesn't stand up business here. He basically tried
to stand up business, got categorically disavowed by everybody
around him, and then went, "Actually, I wasn't even making that
point the whole time." Despite like quadrupling down on this
point. Crazy. It's just It's so
This guy is played by completely different rules. It's insane.
Somebody find this.
I think um
when Charlie Kirk got assassinated, I watched it on stream. I
was like pretty There were some messages in chat that were like
kind of like, "Wow, he got assassinated." Okay. Um
Wait, we're not Okay. Compare Compare her response to Caco. But
it's in Pisco this, okay? What is What is your takeaway from
my
Okay, so when he pulls whatever this clip is, I will want to
see Did he go on He went on Piers and like yeah, he Basically,
this was the clip that everybody talked about. This off clip
right here that we just watched. This is the clip everybody was
talking about. And he went on Piers about this and he said, "No,
no, no. I'm not going to dis I'm not going to say I was wrong.
No, no, no. I I stand on that. I stand on that." And he did that
with Andrew Wilson. And then eventually at some point near the
end, he goes, "Oh, never mind. I actually I actually do think
violence is bad." Because he I don't know. He's the most feeling
people murdering Charlie Kirk or people supporting it in my chat.
Okay, this is the statement from Destiny. I'm going to put it
up on screen. One second.
And this is my bias showing through, okay? Because what I expect
is that sometime after this
I feel like he might have come out and tried to correct. But
maybe he said, "Oh, violence is never the answer." or something
first.
But then this clip came out and he stood on business on it. So
I like for about a half day. Now, also keep in mind
He stood on business just long enough for everybody to confirm
that was really his opinion and then he totally backed out to
people telling him to shut up. I haven't gotten any blowback.
Nobody's criticized me. This wasn't weeks later, months later,
whatever. There's no lawsuit, okay? I know, but but is is like
the question whether you're a better person than Destiny?
No, the question is is why is my response what it is versus what
Destiny's response is? It might be
there are a couple conclusions. A, that you have different appreciations
of the of the harm. B is because you're a better person than
Destiny, perhaps. C could also It could be a bunch of different
reasons that you think that you're holding yourself to a higher
standard. I don't know why that informs our intuitions about
whether this constitutes celebration. And if you agree that it
doesn't constitute celebration, you can just change it to be
downplaying and then we can see what entails from that. So Pisco
is like literally, "I'll let you change the statement on what
you said you were going to show me, but you said, 'Would you
disavow this if she celebrated?'" And Pisco is like, "Yeah, that
would change my mind a lot." And then they don't even come close
to proving that at all. And he's like, "If you want to change
it to downplaying, we could see like what I think then."
It's a
I still don't understand why we have to you have buy into the
celebration if if you don't think it's justified. Um hold
Okay, this is before This is before the Wait. Caco, pass this
one along. Oh, wait. Hold on. Is this just about the person who
shot Charlie Kirk?
Do you want me to put this video up? I was about to play it.
I'll see. No, you don't have to. I am a better person than her.
That's We're fine. We all got that.
Wait, what was it though? I I kind of want to see it. Hold on.
Hold on. I'm going to try to find it. See if I can find it here.
Hold on. I'm going to try to find it. Uh Thinking Monk Charlie
Kirk ETD Oh, FYI.
FYI. Will this There we go. Also, just cuz we're having a lot
of jokes and
just so that I'm Wait, joking and meaning? >> absolutely
[__] clear. Wait, if he's been joking and meaning,
does that mean that this is not sincere?
Wasn't that the standard we were just applying to Destiny that
if you were joking and laughing, that also
you're not sincere. You can't possibly be sincere.
Are we supposed to take him seriously? Especially given shortly
after giving this opinion, he gives this opinion about wanting
conservatives to be afraid. Do we I hope they find this dude
and I hope they hang this guy. This guy's It is absolutely unacceptable
to be out and about assassinating people, okay? That's wild.
Same feelings I have about Luigi I have about this dude. Not
acceptable, not okay, not cool, not epic and not based, just
insane. Also,
So, that's for the guy he wants harm for the guy, but he also
wants conservatives to be afraid. I think he can hold these two
opinions at the same time, right?
I think you could think this about conservatives broadly and
also think that the guy should be punished who did the shooting.
Right? Yeah, okay. All right.
All right, send this one here and give me your takeaway from
this. And these will be the only two we do for now. No, I'm saying
you can hold those those beliefs, right? That the guy needs to
be punished and that conservatives should be afraid. Those aren't
mutually exclusive. I'm trying to find 100 of these but This
is 2 months after the last clip. So, this is 2 months after this
is after the CPS call has been placed, right? The last one was
after the CPS call was >> Right. Right. Yeah, this one
is also that, right?
Well, it's 2 months after the last one and time only goes in
one direction, so I would assume so, yes. It's after the CPS
call. >> why you Why are you being such like I'm just clarifying
this for audience. Do you think that I'm doing something wrong
there? I'm I'm just saying that this is after This is also >> was
9 months later and the 9 months ago and the this clip is 7 months
ago, so it's still after the CPS call.
Well, 9 months ago is like within a week or two of the CPS call,
isn't it? >> Yeah, there's a lot of [__] idiots
in chat and me just saying that this is after I'm just saying
that and you're like taking offense to me doing it. >> agree.
There are a lot of idiots in your chat right now. I do agree
with that. I want to show this to guys. Hello, is this um Child
Protective Services? Yes, yes, uh uh thank you. I would like
to report a case of endemic dog [__] Oh, she can't
You can't laugh at a joke about this after the fact cuz then
if you laugh at a joke about it after the fact it shows that
you were insincere before. So, Destiny was calling for violence
on conservatives, obviously.
Right? Cuz laughing and joking is the same as condoning and that
if she laughs after even after you disavow, if you laugh after
the fact, that means you were dishonest when you disavowed. >> infestation
in a a house. This house um as far as I know, it contains children
and it also contains um two Zionists. Then as we all know, Zionists
are baby killers, so I think this is a very dangerous situation
for the children given the dog [__] and the Zionists.
Why don't you send over a squad? This is This is not funny. When
Ethan is like totally neurotic and freaking out over anybody's
commentary, this is very very unfunny. This is not cool. This
is unacceptable.
Completely disgusting. Do not laugh. I unequivocally disavow
the homeless-looking man on the screen joking about calling CPS.
Oh man, this is the guy that he called Osama bin Laden. Yeah,
I really think this is important enough of a case that you should
send those guys over there. Keep those kids safe. Honestly,
great service, 10 out of 10, highly recommended. Thanks. Anyway,
let me know how it goes. How dare you make jokes about CPS? How
dare you make jokes about SEAL Team 6? How dare you make jokes
about Zionism? How dare you make jokes about dog [__]
Honestly, I condemn I
What is our conclusion from this? >> describe How would
you describe How would you describe BadBunny's behavior? What
is he doing? I think that he is
and reveling in and making horrible jokes and absolutely just
He absolutely justifies Can we say celebrate? Can we say celebrate
is akin to Yes, no, I think I think I think BadBunny is yeah.
I think I think
Are we sure making jokes is reveling,
Are we sure? >> BadBunny justifies it. She's laughing along
with it. So, how What do we feel like Destiny is doing? >> she's
I think she's absolutely downplaying it.
No, this is like I did a like I did a purely performative disavow
at the end. That was me not really disavowing. Okay, you want
a secret? I didn't really disavow that. I thought it was funny.
I think you are allowed to do jokes. I can find the jokes distasteful,
but I'm not going to ever say, "Oh well, actually, this is where
you should get sued. You're actually a horrible person." And
I don't think laughing at a joke about something means you endorse
it. Trust me. I I've watched Nick Fuentes a couple
I don't endorse the Holocaust, okay? But sometimes the guy makes
the right baking cookies analogy and it's just I can't help it,
okay?
Not actually That hasn't actually happened, just to be clear,
but it's the whole point, right? Somebody can make a joke about
something that's like totally like it's black humor. It's literally
dark humor, right?
>> And I think that she is 100% She's self-conscious.
Why is she downplaying it by playing a celebration? >> I understand
it. You tell me this is a totally wild read. She That's true.
That's true. If she'd been joking about Ethan's kids, that would
have been okay under Destiny's metric, okay? You want to joke
about somebody's kids, you want to talk about kids who and their
sex extremely young kids about their sex You want to talk about
any of this? Totally on the money, okay? Totally fine in Destiny's
world. >> He is interpreting this as a joke and she is
basically self-aware about the claim that people are making that
she is trying to call CPS and she thinks that that is ridiculous.
I don't hear her suggesting that I think Listen, I don't agree
with the joke here. I think this I think it's toxic. I think
that what BadBunny is doing is ridiculous. I think that Destiny
is kind of downplaying it as well is horrible. Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, what I just said, that's not unreasonable
what I just said, right? She's self-aware about this whole thing
and she's calling attention to it. It could maybe That could
be a reasonable thing. You agree that she should have like some
kind of like state-mandated caretaker, probably should lose the
right to vote, shouldn't be allowed to live or exist on her own.
If she's this in At the very least should never be in any public
speaking position if she is this unaware of her impact. Like
cuz this is somebody who could encourage murder, whatever, if
she's this Can you agree with that? You're going to tell me she's
watching somebody who's clearly celebrating. You say You said
it yourself, very obviously reveling in the misery that's been
caused.
Destiny would use the exact same out
that BadBunny would use. BadBunny's argument is, "Well, while
the CPS Well, sorry, I don't even think he'd do the the caveat.
But his argument is Ethan is being a victim. He's playing a victim
with the CPS call and I'm going to start making fun of him now."
That's BadBunny's position.
Destiny laughs at Charlie Kirk
under the exact same reasoning, right? The exact same
Conservatives Now, conservatives aren't the same as the victim
in this case, right? But conservatives literally are milking
this for all they can and I'm going to just start laughing at
them cuz [__] those people, right?
That's BadBunny's position. I said joking about the CPS call
and everything else and she's sitting here watching and giggling
along in conjunction with I showed you all those messages in
her chat just from a 60-second clip and you very cleverly I know
because you heard people make the claim that Ethan did this said
that this came from a 10-minute compilation somewhere else, but
that just came from the same thing. >> hang on a second.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, I just want to pause.
Whenever you do one of those comments, I think that we should
address it. So, you just said
Finally, it only took like an hour and a half, but Pisco has
finally said, "Hey, when you do one of your like bad homs for
no reason, when you imply like I'm making disingenuous arguments
or something, we should actually address it cuz you just keep
going past it and throwing off like little digs and then we never
come back and address it. So, I'd like to actually I'd like to
actually address it." >> the fact that I bring up the 10-minute
thing in the in the in the different window there, that that
was somehow wrong to do. Why is that wrong to do for me to bring
that up? I just know I know where you got the criticism from
cuz I saw the same criticism come from the snarkier communities.
>> Yeah, like in my Discord, is that is that something
that's wrong? A lot of people in Discord now, yeah. Okay, but
if that's the case, why would it be wrong that factual information
to become that's brought to my attention in my Discord that I
click on it and review it? What's wrong with that? When did I
say there was anything wrong? No, I'm asking because the the
implication you agree I'm not implying that I said there was
anything wrong with that. I just told you where it came from.
Where's the implication coming from? Because you said I didn't
know where you got that from. 10 minutes and you're going to
claim that you didn't What's wrong with me factually providing
a statement that I knew where you got it No, no, because you
understand what You see how implication is so important to you
now? Yeah, I do understand, Pisco. Yeah, but you see how implication
is so important to you now? It's not what other people are doing
it. You see You're acting like I'm blind, dude. Dude, he's He's
just going to talk really fast and then you're owned. You're
totally owned. And yeah, we have I have the album the Dewey Don'ts.
I've not been playing it You're acting like everybody else is
blinded. You're acting like nobody has any idea what's going
on and only you can see all that, but you are very intuitive.
You very much understand pretend they don't exist anywhere else.
It's very frustrating to deal with.
So, chill. So, you take what Destiny just said there Jesus Christ.
Is Destiny really pretending he thinks dark jokes should be off
the table when the dude has like five recent dramas over making
jokes about people being shot, children being drowned, child
Yep, it's like totally disingenuous. It's like totally [__]
Holy [__] Is that an endorsement for further CPS
calls? I would say Given the Given the behavior of her chat,
the communities around her and the person she's watching and
supports, yes. That right what we just saw there where she's
like making light of CPS. So, you you would take that as So,
not only was she previously doing it, she is currently or to
whatever extent this, you know, today to this thing actively
encouraging and intentionally maliciously more CPS
I don't know if I would pile on so many adjectives there to try
to give you an easier argument, but I would say that you're encouraging
to be a >> It's intentional. I don't think somebody's tickling
her if that's what you're asking. No, it's intentionally. I don't
know what level of intent you need. Like she can see the future?
No, because I don't know if you want The reason I bring this
up There's a chance that somebody in the The reason I bring this
UP IF SOMEBODY DOES a bad Let me make a basic statement. If somebody
does a bad and you laugh and giggle at it and say, "Ha, yeah,
you got him." Are you encouraging future behavior like that?
Yes or no? Wait, encouraging by which you mean intentionally?
Let me restate it and say the exact same thing again. If somebody
does a bad and you giggle it You giggle along, you laugh at it.
Are you encouraging that type of behavior >> Uh guys guys,
every single time
every single time you laugh at something that is sad, like a
bad event where somebody got hurt, you're actually trying to
get that person hurt again, okay? Absolutely with intention.
Absolutely with malice aforethought, okay? You find that thing
funny, that is >> Yeah, yes or no? You don't know what
it means This is a standard we all live by in the real world,
right? This is a This is a standard we all live by. To encourage
behavior. Bro, I feel like Counter-Points is just sitting there
like, "Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Like I just
came I just had to defend you all these times. I just had to
I tried criticizing
I I tried criticizing you for this and you said that I was wrong
and now you're arguing with Pisco and you're saying I was right."
Right? Counter-Points had one time he was correct. One time he
was I Destiny, I criticized you and said you making jokes about
this meant you were like kind of encouraging more behavior like
this and Destiny was like, "No, that's insane counter points.
You're totally right." And that Now he's sitting here with Pisco.
Pisco, you don't understand when you joke about something, when
you laugh about it, you're actually making sure it will happen
again with intention. You want it to happen again, obviously.
It's just transparent, right? Anybody Any reasonable person agrees
with this,
Uh-huh. I want to say I want to say I don't know what you mean
when you No, no, I don't know what you mean. I don't know what
They're justifying it which can enable and even encourage further
CPS calls. The question is, should she be culpable for it?
I think minimizing it isn't encouraging more. I think minimizing
it is basically trying to take away from Ethan's ability to play
the victim over it.
And that when she makes it very clear, when she makes it explicit,
do not go do
When he makes it When she makes it explicit, I think she takes
that away, the part where she could be encouraging it again and
she gives out rationale totally disjoint from liking these people.
She's like, "No, no, no." >> Just don't do it ever. What
do you mean? What do you mean by I don't I don't know what you
mean. Okay, then answer it to the best of your abilities. No,
if what you mean If what you mean if you if If what you mean
by encourage If what you mean by encourage You don't understand
English language. I'm asking you to answer how you would answer
if somebody were to ask you, are you in Like the the just consistently
spurging at high speed, completely
without any care for what the other person says, like it's just
pathetic, right? Like Pisco has been trying and I don't know
why. I have no idea how he's been this patient the whole time,
but he is still trying to have a real conversation with Destiny
and Destiny just keeps spurging. Every time Pisco has like a
point he wants to make, Destiny just starts spurging and spurging
and spurging.
It's totally disingenuous. For a completely different reason,
I don't think you should talk to this guy without a moderator,
either, right? Cuz like Jesus Christ, he's not even attempting
to have a fair conversation. Spurging a bad >> So, I understand
I I understand
I understand
I understand encouragement. When When someone asks me if something
is encouraging I don't know. This is not responsive to what I'm
saying. I'm I'm
So, he's just again more just of the trying to humiliate instead
of letting Pisco answer. So, Pisco is saying, "This is what my
understanding of that word would mean, right?" As in he's trying
to reach understanding so he knows for sure what Destiny is saying.
Pisco has always done this. Pisco has always gone, "Just so I'm
clear, this is what we mean with this word so I can agree with
you cuz I see reasons where it could mean something else." And
he's always been this way. He's always been super precise, super
And Destiny's just spamming, right? He's just spamming as many
words as he can trying to humiliate Pisco for literally just
trying to be precise. Why? What kind of person Like what kind
of anti-intellectual exercise are we witnessing where Destiny's
core strategy is not letting the other person say their ideas?
That's Destiny's core strategy here. It's just to not let Pisco
say what he thinks at any given time, right? Basically, if Pisco
won't say what Destiny wants him to say, he's not going to let
him speak. This strategy is employed this entire debate so far,
right? I just I don't understand
how people find it compelling. It just seems pretty obviously
not compelling to >> I think that you don't answer the
question. If what you mean by encourage is intentionally encourage,
I think the answer is no, but it's not necessitated that one
who giggles along to some reprehensible statements is intentionally
encouraging the underlying acts. No, I don't think that that's
entailed. No. If that's your question. If somebody does a bad
and you laugh and giggle along, are you encouraging that behavior?
If what you mean by encourage is intentional encouragement. If
that's what you mean. >> it in the plain understanding
of the sense of the word. Yeah, but so someone could understand
encourage to just mean be causally linked to some other harm
and they could just be No, no, nobody
I challenge you. Submit to me who understands encouragement means
that you have to conspire with them to do the future bad act.
Show me one person and one example of somebody who believes that.
So, I didn't say con I think she means like with intent. Like
as in you're saying you should go You guys should go do this.
So, if some people might understand encouragement to mean or
it like anything that might make it so Basically
the guy who shot Is it Paul McCartney? Thought he was being encouraged
by like a record or something, right? Isn't that right? Like
he thought he was being encouraged. Is it like that somebody
could feel encouraged by somebody something or is it that the
person with intent is trying to encourage people to do it? Cuz
I think he would Pisco would disagree on the second one, right?
As in he doesn't think somebody is trying to convince Denims
is trying to convince people to go call CPS.
Conspire, right? So, conspire is something that No, but that's
You said you said have to be causally linked. You mean causally
linked. By By causally linked, I mean Do you understand what
I'm saying? So, I I can No, no, no, no, no, no, no, you're missing
gentlemen. Yeah, yeah, so so what I mean is You guys know what
causal is? So, so I'm When somebody does a bad and you laugh
and giggle along, are you not
So, instead of instead of actually letting Pisco speak, he's
just going to spam words, words, words. Not really saying anything
conclusive. I think I might have it at 1.25.
It's difficult to even hear what he's saying to this thing. When
somebody does a bad and you laugh and giggle along, are you not
encouraging the same behavior? So, if by encourage you mean intentionally
encourage, by which you that's your conscious object to get them
to do it, the answer is no, right? But if what you mean is there's
a high risk and there's a potential risk, significant risk, that
it happen, I think the answer is yes. Do you understand that?
Is there anything wrong with what I what I just said? If there
is a high risk of it happening, would it be fair I think Pisco
I think Pisco just gave away high risk for no reason. And that
again, you just pointed out Destiny does not Destiny does not
at all
apply the standard to his own actions. >> that a third-party
observer could observe and say, "Person A is encouraging the
behavior of person B." Is it fair for someone watching to come
to that conclusion?
Yes. Uh just on the fact that they're giggling along now. Even
though you just said that you might even Like it must Pisco to
not just say, "You understand that like this do as a influencer,
That you're like straight-up responsible for. Like you could
absolutely make the argument that you laughing about Corey Compatore
and that assassination led directly to the Charlie Kirk thing
and that you should be held responsible for it. I just I like
that that seems like paint by numbers to me. And unintentionally
be furthering that behavior. It wouldn't be fair for a third
party to observe the situation and go they would have to differentiate
between the intentional and unintentional encouragement. >> You're just
asking the same thing which is to say, is it enough to know that
someone giggles along with someone do saying something that they're
intentionally trying to further that thing? And I'm What I'm
telling you is no, it's not enough to know that just based on
that. I didn't say intention. I You're the one that really wants
to add this word in here. I don't think intentional matters what
But wait, wait, why why can't Why is it Why is it wrong Why is
it Wait, wait, I just want to be clear. Why is it wrong for me
to suss out what you mean? I'm just trying to make sure that
we understand each other and you're somehow suggesting that's
a wrong thing for me to be like
Hold on, another Doobie Doobie Doo. Wasn't Destiny just arguing
that he was not encouraging people to kill Republicans when he
joked about Charlie Kirk's assassination? Has he changed his
mind or is he lying now because it's convenient? Fantastic question,
Doobie. Doobie's perception is at, you know, the 99th percentile.
Doobie perce- Doobie perceives all, okay? Wow.
It's just so disingenuous the whole >> Well, I can answer
your question depending on the mental state that you're trying
to imply. You want to keep things ambiguous and vague and I just
I'm I'm trying to adjectives that are that are totally beyond
the point.
Destiny is less qualified
and reliable
as a moral arbiter than he is as a
physical trainer, okay? As in he I would more I would much rather
take my advice on going to the gym from Destiny that I would
on any moral consideration. He is completely disingenuous. He
lies constantly. He is He is not a single like moral bone in
his body. It's actually embarrassing how he will flip in this
conversation to a totally different position to try to win in
one micro like one micro debate, one micro battle of this conversation.
But wait, >> Like it's like oh my god, like my husband
punched me yesterday. Somebody's like, "Did he punch you violently?
Aggressively? Like what do you What the [__] It could
be true for one and not the other. It could be true for one and
not the other. It could be true for one and not the other. Sure.
Common parenting thing. Child, 4 years old, uh
Oh, Wick is Wick is fully on board.
Oh, hold on. Where was that? Oh, come on, Pisco.
Oh, did I miss it? Did I miss it? Did I miss it? one and not
the I got to go back. Oh, right there. Oh, come on, Pisco. Come
on. It's like really obvious that
It's really obvious that Destiny is just being incredibly bad
faith here. The other It could be true for one and not the other.
Sure. Common parenting thing. Child, 4 years old, uh punches
another kid and the parent laughs along. They're like, "Oh, he
hit his mom, but you shouldn't do that. Haha." Look, even though
the parent in that case, they don't want them to hit it and they
say, "You know, don't hit the other kid." They're encouraging
the behavior by laughing and giggling along with it. That's how
kids work. When you laugh and giggle along, they do the behavior.
>> And and what you mean there is And also that's the same
way how Yeah. What you mean there is that their actions, regardless
of their specific intent, might cause it to happen again, right?
That's what you mean. Correct. Yeah. Yeah. So, there's nothing
wrong with me hashing out what we're talking about, right? Like
there's nothing wrong and or like sweet me for me to just say,
"Let's just be clear about what we're talking
By the way, Pisco most of the time here is not even making claims.
Destiny starts spurging when Pisco is like, "Hey, could you clarify
this thing to me?" Like Pisco hasn't even started making a claim
and Destiny will start spurging about Pisco just trying to clarify
some [__] It's crazy. >> Not being clear. You
just played another game. You just said regardless
of the intent. If you want to put the intent analysis aside,
we can do that, but you're not doing that. You're trying to Your
initial claim was that she didn't intend to do it. Yeah, okay,
that's fine, but you're saying that Well, maybe she didn't intend
it. No, you said she did intend it and maybe it was encouragement
regardless.
Is this Is this like a joke about Charlie Kirk dying on like
the day he
Is this encouraging future in like basically by joking about
this by laughing about it, are we encouraging future assassinations?
Are we are we encouraging future
Oh, wow. And then he's going to say, well, actually, but I disavowed
it that day, too. In the same way Denims did. Like basically
in the exact same way that Denims did in the middle of like and
dismissing.
Does that Does that totally like make her disavowal moot as well?
I don't I don't get it. You don't understand that even though
he joked after his assassination, he said bad. Yeah, if only
Denims did that. Dude, the way he like now I understand where
his position came from like so oh, well, did she disavow like
then or like months later? It's like oh, I understand why you
have that position cuz you're trying to differentiate yourself
from Denims in some way over the Charlie Kirk thing. Okay, I
mean We can separate it. She is encouraging us even if she's
not being intentional about it. So like I just want to be incredibly
calm. When I say if by encourage you mean intentionally encourage,
I'm just making it clear to what extent I agree with your claim
and to what extent I don't. I agree that this could have the
effect of encouraging this kind of behavior. I don't agree that
this necessitates that she wants this to occur more. You understand
that difference? That's why and the only reason I'm bringing
up this
I want I want you to acknowledge that it's good faith. NO, BUT
I WANT YOU
YOU'RE SAYING NO, NO, I won't even I'm sorry. I I'll pretend
you're good faith. I'll pretend for just a second that you're
good faith. Move move that cuz I just did a bad, right? I said
I'll pretend you're good faith. Okay, no, no, I will take what
you're saying at face value,
So then my question will be That's Oh, you took back one of the
12 ad homs so far. Cool. So let's say that we have her encouraging
it and it might be intentional, it might be unintentional. Maybe
she's misreading the situation. Maybe okay, she is in an awkward
state and she's laughing about a thing to try to play it off,
right? Maybe okay. And I'll grant you that that is possible and
I don't mean possible as in sociologically possible and no
Yeah, it's a decent chance. It's plausible. There's Okay, yeah,
I'll say that, okay? What could we look to to try to ascertain
her state of mind prior to and after the CPS call. What would
we look to because in my opinion, I think I've provided maybe
not compelling evidence in your world, but at least some evidence
that seems like she's kind of supportive of it happening. What
would be the evidence to the contrary to say that actually she
really didn't want that CPS call to be made. She really don't
I think the evidence to the contrary in the standard is just
Destiny continuing to joke about Charlie Kirk getting continuing
to joke about the firefighter, right?
And so obviously
If Destiny's willing to bite the bullet that he has been encouraging
assassinations leading up to and then after Charlie Kirk getting
doesn't he encourage the Charlie Kirk assassination? He's willing
to bite the bullet on that. Then yeah, we're I I guess we can
move on. Cuz that's if we apply his own standard to himself once
again, he comes away wanting. He's applying standards to people
that he fails far worse than anybody he attempts to apply them
to. He doesn't support that type of behavior. You know, I think
that you could if she were a better person perhaps or if she
were um, you know, trying to give off that impression, I think
that she would be condemning it in a more serious tone. She wouldn't
be this flippant. I basically think that what you've put here
shows that she thinks it's kind of no big deal. It's not really
a big deal that to the extent that it's a big deal, it's okay
to joke about it. It's okay to continue to put the the bad and
banana stuff even though he justifies it. And so she basically
is I think with with what she's doing here and not being clear
about where she stands on the
The Kathy message got me. I'm so glad Pisco dumped test. And
so she basically is I think with with what she's doing here and
not being clear about where she stands on the CPS call and it
being bad, I think she she is being reckless. I do think that.
That's culpable. That's that's a level of culpability. The thing
is you
But hang on a sec. But hang on a second. I always
You understand? You understand I always granted this, right?
You
you can watch
All this work to get to where Pisco already was.
For the behavior. He said there was almost no level of culpability
Steven Steven Steven, there's only there's a video Steven Steven,
there's a video of me going through this and declaring in what
sense I think that they're culpable and what sense they think
that they're not. So when you say this is the first time that
you've ever come to the determination that these people have
acted in some culpable sense, it's just wrong. And in fact, I
said so on the very video that you reviewed. And so when you're
saying that we just came to this realization, it just is not
true. There are not only one example of me saying this. So then
I'm so curious then then what was your then I missed it then.
I didn't understand anything. What is your huge disagreement
then with Hutch? If Hutch was saying that she has some culpability
for this call, the CPS call and you're saying I agree there is
some culpability there. What was the big disagree?
I came here after the J Soc Destiny split. Why does DG hate this
community extra hard? Cuz I conspired with Qman to
totally disingenuously paint Destiny as somebody who sent nudes
and or videos like videos of his friends, family members, etc.
without their consent to people he'd known for very little amount
for a very small amount of time, right? I conspired with Qman
to invent that entirely whole
So Destiny really hates us. He definitely didn't do those things.
He definitely isn't like guilty of all those things. You definitely
can't just see that transparently if you look at any of the evidence.
Um, it's just all made up, guys. It's just all made up by some
crazy Qman is Native American friend from Canada. Oh, the two
of us the two of us we're just like
We're just crazy. >> Qman. Yes, so the big disagreement
is people are trying to conflate one's responsibility with respect
to their intentional and malicious mindsets with those who are
merely reckless. And you would agree that we put so much more
implication on someone who's intentional malicious. You know
this, Steven. You know this, right? An actor who is intentional
and malicious >> I'm hearing I'm appealing to Kafka here.
Kafka, is the reckless standard close No, I'm not maltreating.
to maliciousness My grandmother was um
But I'm not. >> or to totally neutral.
I don't I could have a bad maybe a bad little read. My understanding
is you have nothing no intent at all. You know you're not even
manslaughter, there's nothing. Then you have things like like
negligence.
I don't know if gross negligence is the next category, but once
you start to hit reckless,
I think you're a lot closer
Poetry the poetry here would be fantastic if he loses this debate
in the exact same way he lost the bet on Apple River. You'd love
to see it. >> to like intentional like this is reckless
is a standard of like you should have known better. Yeah, she
should know better. Yeah. So wait for you to say that people
are making this grave error of conflating recklessness
with she with she was doing the Also, Matt, we're going to be
doing outreach, okay? We're doing all kinds of outreach. Don't
worry about it. We're going to grow this
Ho, we're going to grow this community big time. All right, it's
not going to stay small. It's going to be a whole group of people,
all right? Don't worry, it's coming. Lots of people doing work.
Lots of people doing work. Lots of people building it up. >> This
intentionally maliciously. You understand that
You know what? These two things are very close to each other.
So so so I'll I'll just give you an example, right? So I just
mean like other people to go and talk and have conversations,
argue with people, that kind of Someone is driving down a street
incredibly recklessly driving, all right? And they hit an unfortunately
a pedestrian.
Someone else is taking a car and intentionally as part of a terrorist
act. Although let's remove that out of it. We'll we'll just keep
it so that no one can add anything. All right, someone is driving
and they try to hit that very same pedestrian with their car
on purpose. As between those two, don't you put so much more
culpability on the person who is trying to kill the person as
compared to the person who should have known better?
Absolutely. Yeah, so that's my point. That was my point, all
right? And you what you took from that was Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, what what
So Destiny just agrees with Pisco. And by the way, Pisco literally
didn't even make a claim on that front when Destiny started spurging.
He only was trying to clarify what Destiny meant. He was trying
to delineate.
And Destiny just started spurging the [__] out as
if that was indi- like some indictment of Pisco. >> Wait,
let me finish. What you took from that was the reason I'm setting
forth this standard is to protect J Soc.
Okay. Um, I still agree with that. What I said
Hold on. Hold on. HOLD ON.
THAT'S ANOTHER NAME DROP. Oh my god. And Destiny still believes
that. Destiny believes Pisco's engaging in all of this just to
protect little old me. You see, I've managed to wire into all
of the people around Pisco, okay? People thought that Aaron was
the person who could like control minds, but it's actually been
me the whole time, okay?
I'm controlling everybody, all right? I am the big bad. I am
I'm yeah. I'm literally Voldemort. I dude, they make me sound
so cool. I like I get kind of annoyed cuz they're making things
up about me, but also they just make me sound awesome.
Like I'm awesome.
Pisco's got like an alt my community cuz he secretly knows that
like I'm right about everything. In virtue of In virtue of what?
I like the car because I like the car example, okay? Yeah. Let's
say that we we saw this happen, okay? Let's say that after the
person, okay, there are there are two worlds right now where
there's a reckless driver and he hits a person. In one world,
he gets out of the car, he sees the person, Mhm. and he's like
calls 911, you know, runs to a neighbor whatever else. In the
other world, he backs up over the guy, runs him over again, and
drives home. Would we move the needle at all from reckless in
the latter to >> Let me give you what you want. Yeah. So
so let me give you what you want. There are some facts that you
could offer to a person that what they did was so depraved and
so likely to in the context of let's say homicide to cause uh
you know, the harm that it did that it reaches a a degree we're
going to we're going to just call that like uh some kind of constructive
intent, a constructive malice in other words. And this is called
depraved heart murder in the context of homicide. You know, you're
spraying the Okay. assault rifle in the parking lot. Now, no
one can prove that you intended to kill the four people that
got shot in the head. And actually when we go to look at it,
right? It turns out, you know, we know we have a mind reader,
and we know that you actually didn't want to kill anybody. Okay.
But your conduct was so depraved was so reckless was so likely
to cause the result it did. And we're going to have to have that
kind of constructive malice, constructive intent. I'm not about
Sorry, I did I did agree with Destiny on this one thing. Okay,
this one thing where Pisco I I said this during the debate by
the way.
You got to just go take some time and like think about it. Think
of how you can take some of the things you say the
and how you condense them and still convey the same information.
So you feel like you're still being specific, but like a lot
of the time it's Love that. But that's why we're arguing on the
quantum of evidence that this is like all else equal that those
kinds of comments No, because then you have to actually make
the empirical case that these kinds of comments have the tendency
like all else equal if you had seen this clip and uh you know,
at the time you see saw it, would you be able to predict would
you be able to predict >> now? You would wait So like let's
let's say that uh I I know this might be >> When you When
you say would you be able to predict, you're you're talking degrees
of probability that people will follow what happens. If I know
right now that things related to the phone are a a big a big
bad in terms of people like swatting people for instance, right?
Now if I start trying to, you know, talk on stream about I think
this guy might be his girlfriend and you guys know >> people,
right?
What base? True. Um or you guys know there's some things okay,
right? Hold on. Wait. Wait. Why did he say that? Wait, why did
he say that though? Wait, hold Wait. Why did he Hold on.
start trying to, you know, talk on stream about I think this
guy might be his girlfriend and you guys know >> people,
right?
What base? True. Um or you guys know there's some things okay,
right? Could you say that like, well, this is almost like a depraved
heart version of this type of thing? It's If you're a streamer,
you know these Boo, this is Jidion. Boo, this is things are happening.
You're watching a CPS video on stream. You're watching all this.
And then when we review the the response to that, and it's one
of giggly, laughing, playing memes and jokes about it. What are
you supposed to think? So are you trying >> How could it
not be? >> So so yeah, so I'll ask you. Are you Are you
trying to hurt eSports Batman? Uh emotionally and psychologically,
yes.
Are you Are you trying to hurt eSports Batman? Oh, so it was
over his doxing of eSports Batman.
doxing of eSports Batman with no reasoning by the way. With no
reasoning. Somebody Pisco's talked to multiple times. Somebody
Pisco Well well, I don't think they liked each other a lot. They
usually disagreed. They were like friends to some extent, right?
Also, I have to just pause. Boo, this is Jidion. I haunt Destiny's
days and dreams. Uh emotionally and psychologically, yes.
So he's going to totally make a joke, okay? Oh, I'm just going
to Yeah, emotionally and psychologically Okay. Kind of like in
the way Destiny was emotionally and psychologically devastated
such that he couldn't inform the FBI he had solicited from an
international child trafficker. You know, he was just really
emotionally compromised. Who just suggested? I'd have to think
back to how much gear he actually lost in Rust to actually know
the answer.
Another meme.
So let's listen to this without me >> giggly, laughing,
playing memes and jokes about it. What are you supposed to think?
So are you trying >> it not be? >> So so yeah, so
I'll ask you. Are you trying to hurt eSports Batman? Uh emotionally
and psychologically, yes.
I'd have to think back to how much gear he actually lost in Rust
to actually
So just zero engagement.
He knows that he has no way to actually explain this on a stream.
The only explanation any of these losers ever have is the only
thing they'll ever say is, "Uh why are you talking about it?
Must not be a big deal if you're talking about it." They'll like
dox you and then be like, "Whoa, if you talk about it, you actually
don't think it's a big deal."
Actually know the answer. >> No, come on. I mean, let's
be serious. Tell me the No, no. This is stupid pivot. No, I'm
not here for you to defend Jidion's community. I know why you're
trying to defend Jidion's
He's defending somebody he knew from before I was even in any
of these communities. Pisco and eSports Batman have known each
other since I was ever in any of these communities.
Destiny and eSports Batman have known each other for like 15
years.
I'm not joking. It's like been so long that they've known each
other. They didn't even have the DGG site. I think it was a TeamSpeak
or something like 15 years ago.
That's how long eSports Batman and Destiny have known each other.
community. Right after telling me that you're NOT TRYING TO COVER
JIDION'S COMMUNITY. SO LET'S BE FUNNY. IT'S VERY
SO HE has to invoke Jidion's community instead of defending his
actions, right? He thinks that this magic code phrase, Jidion's
community, you're defending Jidion's community. That's his magical
code phrase to not have to make an argument. I I And unfortunately,
Pisco like starts to hone in on what the argument is, which is,
"Hey, you're advocating a standard you don't you don't actually
believe in out of spite. You don't believe in this standard.
You can't possibly advocate for the standard or you are responsible
for significantly worse things, far more egregious conduct, and
far more like a far larger volume of egregious conduct than Denims
is." >> Yeah, no, I'm I'm asking the standard. I'm asking
the standard. I'm asking the standard. Which is horrible optics
for Pisco only in the sense that saying Destiny's wrong on anything
is horrible optics for everybody who's not Destiny.
Right? It's not horrible optics for him in a vacuum. It's horrible
optics for him in the way that arguing with Destiny ever is horrible
optics for anybody who's not in Destiny's community or sorry,
for anybody.
Yeah. It's like But that's unironically what their arguments
break down to is, "Hey, could you like not disagree with Destiny?
Hey, could you like just let Destiny do whatever he wants? Hey,
could you let anything go that Destiny does?"
That's what the argument breaks down to every single time. We
can go We can go down this road next if you want. But I'm asking
you, okay? Would this not be a depraved heart type of thing that
Denims is doing by watching a video No. Because because Yeah,
I'll tell you why. It's not fair to know that Denims is probably
thinking someone could call CPS on some [__] like
this, right? I'm going to play this. My audience is primed for
it. You don't think so? I'll I'll I'll tell you why. Because
if you were to ask and take a poll of people at the time that
this uh you know, statement was made of her just like laughing
along and whatever, and you were to say like, "What are the odds,
right? What are the odds that um someone actually calls
>> Because that's rel- that's absolutely relevant to the
question of whether we're going to say there's some kind of constructive
malice or constructive intent given the relative odds. So I would
imagine you would say in
There's like intensely, insanely good content after this that
I almost dude, it you have no idea. I don't want No
Can I just finish a thought? I would imagine that you would say
with respect to uh doxing Okay, because it takes you for someone.
You're going to say that I'm going to say that if the odds are
incredibly low and she's going to say the odds are incredibly
low, then her saying the thing can't possibly be constructive
malice because she never thought that there were high odds for
this to begin with. So it's foolish to say that her saying a
particular thing meant that she intended for it to >> Yeah,
I don't I don't I don't think it's But that's not the comparison.
The comparison we need to use is a relative one. So for instance,
she might think that the odds of it are low, but the question
isn't do you think the odds are low? It's not an absolute risk
comparison. It's a relative risk ratio. You would say, "Are the
odds going to be higher or lower after you do this video?" Oh,
no. I don't agree with that.
Again, again this standard would be totally insane if you try
to apply it to Destiny in any way.
Like all of the every time you call somebody a fascist, that's
adding a relative risk that somebody will take some action that
they're going to compare them to another They're going to say,
"Oh well, this person's evil. I can do anything to them, right?"
He's basically arguing anytime he calls someone like these are
all bad actions. And we're we're just totally wrong. No, I don't
agree with that. I I I think that when when we're we're trying
to intuit like a a state of intention intentionality that it's
your conscious object to do something. I don't think that you
merely look at relative risk. I think you absolutely do look
at absolute risk. I I think that that is the case. And and I
think that you would you would >> look at relative risk.
Of course you look at relative risk. You're talking about the
risk of them having a thing happening.
You're not trying to make it over 50%. >> So I So I understand,
right? Like that you would probably proffer this in defense of
your conduct. You think, right? Like it wouldn't be justified
to cause physical harm to some of the people who have antagonized
you, right? It wouldn't be justified to do that.
I'd have to think about who we're talking about. No, but look
let's be honest. Like there are people for whom you think it's
justified to dox them. That's not That's not a position that
you shy away from, right?
Generally speaking, yeah. And if someone came to you and said,
"Uh Hello, Pisco's chat sure has a lot of How many How many chatters
do they think I have? I'm sitting here. I'm covering this content.
I've got maybe 420
people here right now. 450. I'll hold on. I'll refresh. I don't
even know if it's 450 still. It's 450. Okay.
How many chatters do they think I have that I can like go when
there's 3,000 people watching this stream this this this stream
right now. And they think the chat's like all my people. WHY
DO NONE OF THOSE PEOPLE WATCH ME THEN? Where are all of those
people? Where are the those people at, dog?
Where are those Where are those at?
Oh, you know, it turns out that uh one of these people gets hurt
by someone bad because they've been going after you. They're
trying to uh defeat >> I know I stream late. I know. the
liberal Joe Rogan whatever. I think that you would say I couldn't
have predicted at the time I doxed these people. >> No,
why would I say something? No, that's a Pisco's world. That's
a ridiculous argument. As soon as real life information is thrown
out and doxing and all that [__] comes out
Doobie bites the most insane bullets
He's basically like, yeah, I understand that like when I say
that I want to dox people and then I dox people, then yeah, there's
a real chance those people will get hurt in real life.
And it's like, okay, but he argued I was insane for saying that
by the way. Just to be clear, he literally said I was insane
and sewing out for saying that obviously it's increasing the
chance I get hurt. Obviously there is a chance and I think his
community is dedicated of that I could get hurt from that. But
now when Pisco is asking him, he's going to bite that bullet.
>> of the thing that are possible. Yeah. Why do you think
I hate this community so much? Just because they've engaged in
this behavior towards me, towards my girlfriend, towards anybody
in my life for over a
>> Yeah. Why the [__] would you say that to
me? And and and Example? Example? Example? Example?
It's Isn't that YouTube TOS? It is. Oh, it is. So, when you So,
when you say that in response, you know, doxing is justified,
you're not saying therefore that hurting them is justified.
Yeah. So
Not necessarily, no. Not necessarily, no. But you know, in the
case of the specific people I'm talking about
Unfortunately for him, in case of the specific people I'm talking
about >> this for these DMs about you saying like, hey,
I wish this person Has this person been doxed yet?
Yeah, I um for Anna, that's For Just a Kol and Kleiman, I kill
them if I could. I choke the [__] house into it.
Um but not for Anna, no. We'll get back to the death threat in
a minute. I just want to address Oh, hold on. Is that the only
one? Cuz I could have sworn there's I think there's another one
where he says like somebody should kill Just a Kol and Kleiman
and Lav and Mr. Girl. So, there's another one where he actually
does advocate just killing us and says someone should kill
Yep. And then I do not believe he took it back. I think he doubled
down when asked about this.
I Anyway, just So, when when Pisco says like, well, what if they
got hurt? Would that mean you're advocating for it? And he's
like, well, not necessarily. Unless I did advocate for it directly.
>> So, if someone said like like in response to you doxing
them what you take to be a self-defense dox, that what you're
doing
grossly reck Would you say Wick is culpable in doxing? I wouldn't,
okay? I wouldn't. I think it's totally wrong to dox people. I
think it's totally wrong to go after adjacent people. But I will
say when all these people hear that Destiny's Destiny's logic
is you operate adjacent to a community that doxes people around
me, so I get to dox you and harass you as much as I want, right?
And then you hear that rationale, see him dox people that used
to hang out with, used to talk
and then you go back and hang out with them, you better be prepared
for that standard to be applied to you, right? You're accepting
that standard by going back with him.
And like trying to support him, trying to come in like talk in
Pisco's chat about Pisco, I think you're accepting that standard.
I think that standard is insane. I think everybody should reject
that standard. And even though I think Wick has accepted that
standard himself, I would still say I would ban you from all
my communities. You cannot do that you if you do that. It's wrong,
okay? Yeah, I am like a principled on this. I get it. I understand.
But that's how it's always going to be. And I'm going to keep
maintaining that. Cuz here's the thing, eventually Hutch will
actually look into this and he'll see that I totally disavowed
every every instance where somebody said anything about doxing.
I'm totally on the disavowal train,
and then he'll go, oh, it's just like me. He That guy is just
like me. And then Hutch will start defending me. And all I need
is Hutch on my side and we can do anything, okay?
We can do anything. And he'll find out Hutch never cared. No,
surely surely when I prove exactly like precisely that I've been
in the right this entire time, surely surely that'll matter.
Surely the facts will matter. No, the facts the facts will
It'll totally matter to a whole bunch of people. You guys are
crazy. You guys are saying that I see Clueless getting hit in
the chat. No, no, the facts will matter. The facts will matter.
>> plus and that you're causing potential
harm to befall these people, harm that wouldn't be justified
under the circumstances.
You would say >> be justified. I don't know if I would
agree with that. I thought you I thought we just cleared that.
Like Kafka, I don't know if you heard like I thought we cleared
>> You said wouldn't be justified. I feel like these people
have been attacking me relentlessly FOR ALMOST
WHERE'S LAV AT? We Have you noticed how he's gone from saying
these people have been I feel like I feel like
What does I feel mean? The [__] is the purpose of
that?
You don't You don't say I feel like this happened, so I'm going
to go hurt these people. That's not what you do. You say this
happened, so I'm going to take vengeance. If that's what how
you're going to operate, right? Don't do the I feel. Remember
how badly he sewed the [__] out about Lav saying
I feel all the
Uh I feel like these people have been attacking me. I feel like
these people have been attacking me.
Uh When you are a narcissist, the truth does feel like an attack.
Say what I lied, bro. It's the year engaged in and up to potential
physical altercations in real life that they're instigating or
encouraging. I I thought we just agreed that it wouldn't be just
Oh, apparently we're instigating or encouraging confrontations
in real life. To fight to like physically hurt them.
I said I have to think about it, didn't
Oh, I mean maybe you'll bite the bullet that what you're doing
there is
Well, uh so Pisco doesn't realize, but obviously Destiny has
explicitly argued for us to be hurt already.
And he did so back in February, I >> a kind of constructive
intent to physically hurt them. I don't think you would bite
that bullet. You that you have the constructive intent to physically
Oh. OH. OH, HOLD >> HURT THEM. WAIT. WAIT. WAIT. Jstarkcourt
is harassing Mr. Mouton, too. So, this guy said this, and then
I went and looked and saw that there was an account of somebody
impersonating Mr. Mouton and posting pictures of Mr. Mouton,
and I banned them. But like I would never have known if this
Destiny fan hadn't come in and said this was happening.
But like that's just obviously an op. Brand new account comes
in and is like, oh, I'm Mr. Mouton's biggest fan. He's like posting
pictures of Mr. Mouton. I'm like, you're a weirdo. Get the [__]
out of here. Like it's just clearly like an op. So bizarre.
Like you would bite that bullet. You that you have the constructive
intent to physically hurt the people you're doxing. I think Oh,
hold on. Hold on. Is there any evidence at all of Kleiman, Jstark,
Esports, Batman, or me doxing Destiny or anyone related to Here's
the thing, Doobie.
Is there any evidence at all of somebody around Destiny being
doxed
before he tried to dox me or Kleiman?
That's the real question. Or did he just totally make that up?
Did he just entirely make it up?
Cuz what I'm going to assert is that
Destiny decided
that he was going to blame me and Kleiman for Kiwi Farms, and
then he took stuff that all happened before either Kleiman or
I were like doing content on him. And he just totally
made up that we were responsible. So, while I was still Destiny's
friend, I'm responsible for the stuff that was happening in that
period of time. When I was like advocating for Destiny, arguing
on his side of issues, right? Apparently I'm responsible for
all the doxing that happened. So, while I'm sitting there and
I tell, okay?
I tell Natsumeraide, no, uh the KF doxing [__] is
getting crazy. I tell her this in like November or something.
I don't think I'm going to go on anything else. Thanks for the
invite, though. Uh so, I said that then.
I'm culpable for uh me being afraid of KF doxing me. I'm culpable
for them doxing Destiny's friends
when I'm literally one of Destiny's friends that I'm concerned
about possibly getting doxed if I show my face somewhere? That's
crazy. That's crazy. that in a way I think that you would accept
that that is a potential outcome. Sure. >> No, no, but
would you bite the bullet that that's your constructive intent?
That when you dox people >> like I don't like biting the
bullet here cuz none of these people that you hang out with bite
the bullets on any of their behavior. So, why would I give you
Again, another little another little attack on Pisco's character
or saying he hangs out with me or Kleiman or Doobie or whatever,
right? When that's not true. It's just another little little
little knife twist there cuz he's just been doing that repeatedly.
We'll see if Pisco does that back. >> the line of rationale
so that they can replay the stupid [__] clip over
and over again. We don't We don't have to use you. We don't We
don't have to We don't have to use you. No, I'm not going to
No, I'm not going to No, no. Wait, you got Yes. Yeah, I was not
I was like, hey, doxing [__] obviously wrapping up
insanely right now. I'm not going on a show. I'm not doing that
right now. Sorry, dude. No, thank you. I might have entertained
it with like a mask or something, maybe. Like a Corantos thing,
but I don't really want to do that. But yeah, I showing my face
around that time. Cuz that stuff was wrapping up, but I'm not
responsible for that. Destiny engaging with the thread and like
directly trying to fight with people in the thread is responsible
for that. That's not me. conversation folks on dinners. I know
that you want to win brownie points with your new friends, okay?
We don't have to talk about this. [__] you. Wait.
Wait. Wait. Can I can I can I say [__] you? Uh this
guy this guy sucks. This is This is annoying. [__]
that guy. [__] this guy. Wait. [__] this
guy. [__] this guy.
Wow, [__] Kleiman. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. This is the This is the mood at the moment.
God, it took me forever to load this. It's my bad. What the What?
Yeah, it was. Literally this is exactly what it was, damn here.
Sorry, it took me a minute to find it. What the [__]
man? What did I do?
Did I do? >> Wait. Wait. Wait. No, wait. Listen, I don't
hang out with those people. I don't hang out with Just a Kol.
I don't hang out with Kleiman. I don't hang out in you know,
their servers. I don't go around talking about you. Do you hear
me doing that? Do you hear me going out and and saying all the
horrible things that Occasionally I'll disagree with the political
take you give. I'll I'll cover in my opinion fairly. >> I
understand that you don't do that. You're You're playing the
role that the epic centrist played base The question here is
what the [__] do you want me to do? Like what do
you want me to do? Cuz I swear
I knew Is Missy here right now? Is Missy still here? Cuz I said
this last night or the night before. I said all I'm going to
do is I'm going to go interact in these communities and just
be like a nice person, just be like my best self, and just claim
like my place, like I get to interact there, right? And I feel
like Destiny saw that and was like, "Oh, I can't allow that.
Oh, no, that's
You know what I'm saying? Like I I think I just I said that,
like I'm just going to go be nice in these communities and then
eventually it'll work. And Pisco I feel like Destiny heard that
and he's like, "I have to go confront Pisco over this now." It's
a clear girl back in 2017. That's what you're talking
You think I'm You think I'm trying to fence ride and you think
I'm I want brownie points from every side. Is that what you think?
Absolutely no, just from their side. But yes. That's what I did.
I just I just reviewed Hold on, hold on. But
Yeah, it's like the universal reaction right there. That's like
the universal What the I just reviewed
I just reviewed a Doobie conversation where I talked so much
[__] about Doobie's position on the on the strikes.
If if Doobie wants to donate to me Wait, wait, hang Wait, wait.
I don't agree with Trump on everything.
Dude, it's like literally not a single good faith argument from
Destiny's side. You have to give like another position he has.
Like what else would he agree with mine or Queenman community
on? What other position does he have that we don't hate Aaron?
Wait, you don't hate Aaron either. Where where? Bro, he's just
like spamming words over and over I'm admitting I'm brain broken
on it. It's not falsifiable to me. Like like sorry, words disconnected
from reality is what I should say. He just keeps spamming out
sentences that don't have any connection to reality. >> It's
now no point in arguing. It's a faith-based position that I hold.
I have a special revelation from God for you doing this, so it's
not even worth arguing. Like but Back to the denim thing. Why
would Why? YOU KNOW WHAT? ACTUALLY HERE, I'LL DROP THIS HERE.
FOR For you to be so incredulous and be like, "Oh, are you saying
it's constructive intent to hurt somebody?" Blah blah blah. Most
people would say yes when it comes to doxing. And when it comes
to doxing adjacent behavior, which is also probably one of the
reasons I don't know why. I don't think Hutch even brought this
up. Um it's funny actually, we're in a we're in an area where
you said we've been bringing it Oh, by the way, um Destiny brought
up like my girlfriend. He said my girlfriend. Destiny's girlfriend
messaged me directly to say like, "Hey, thanks. It means a lot
that like when Kelly was kind of going after me, you said something."
It meant a lot that you like try to keep your community away
from ever criticizing me. And also the whole community was against
Kelly on that, too, right? But like So when he says the J Soc
community is behind harassing his girlfriend, I'm just like in
what universe? Like it's literally
Well, I I think him and Lena aren't together anymore, Jacob,
but I just don't understand in what universe is this my fault?
I just don't get it. Destiny would think it could be bad, right?
And I feel kind of bad bringing up, but I think it's important.
One of the reasons all
Destiny's girlfriend, the girl whose doxxing he pulled up while
scrolling KF on stream? Yeah, that exact one. That exact That
precise one, yeah. So why Hutch might be annoyed by people like
Bad Empanada cuz Bad Empanada literally I'm pretty sure posted
his doxx on a video that Hasan played. Wait a second. I So I
agree that that [__] is [__] up. I agree
that not only that, that this kind of excuse that people say,
"Well, you have public
Oh, I will say
Destiny also tried to blame me and Queenman for the Hutch doxx.
The Hutch doxx had been posted months before that. And Destiny
basically just didn't let them know at that time and then brought
it up when it was convenient to Hutch. Or somebody brought it
up when it was convenient to Hutch to use as a weapon against
other people. But if they'd let him know when he was originally
doxxed, he would have known that it didn't have anything to do
with us, obviously,
So access to it and so it doesn't count. I think that's chicken
[__] I think it has to do with your No, no, no, we're
not No, no, no, we're not talking about I don't care about your
virtue signaling here. There is a guy who has engaged in Yes,
I agree. I'm agreeing with you. Yes, I know. But then when Hutch
says
Oh, he almost said >> guy for doing bad stuff like this.
And
And you say No, you say, "Well, I know he has a reputation for
No, I What I said was Hang on a second.
Denims is playing videos of him on her stream that then possibly
leads to CPS being called on Ethan. You're like, "Wow, is there
a direct causal link? Can we actually logically link all of these
activities to one another?" Come on. Like that's an absurd set
of arguments. We we just broke this apart. So and with respect
to the Bad Empanada comment, I immediately said he asked me,
"I'm just reacting." And I say, "I know he has a reputation for
being malicious. I've seen him act
Huh. Another Doobie don't know. Hold on. What does Doobie have
to say? Does Des diddy have any evidence of me doxxing him or
anyone? What about Esports Batman? If no, what's the justification
for doxxing Esports Batman and encouraging people to doxx me?
And Wicked Supreme.
Yeah, all of those people would be good to know about. in conformity
with it and so my answer is yes. That's what I said. And the
reason that you think I'm giving cover for Bad Empanada, though
you can watch previous streams where I say, "Is this person like
Bad Empanada? Do they do the kinds of things that Bad Empanada
does?" Clearly implying that I think Bad Empanada is a malicious
actor. You can try now because of the order that I did it, which
was honest, it might be in your mind that that somehow I'm trying
to give cover for Bad Empanada, that that that is just so much
[__]
No, it's totally justified. When Hutch When you asked Hutch,
um I think it was like, "Why is
Has Pisco ever brought up the Wicked Supreme doxx/attacks?" So
it's doxx threats as far as I know. I don't think Supreme's been
doxxed yet.
I also think I also think Destiny
threatened to doxx him without really being able to. I think
Destiny understands that he would get sued if he did that.
So I think Destiny just decided not Well, all There's one of
two possibilities there. It's either that um Destiny's friends
decided that was the hill they were going to die on, which is
particularly embarrassing if they basically picked out one guy
that they were going to say, "Oh, actually that's too far." That
would be crazy. But I do believe Supreme has pretty openly said
that he's in California. And California, I think for doxxing,
like intentional malicious doxxing, I think that is you can actually
be sued for that. So
Yeah. Is Ethan doing this lawsuit? And he gave a reason and then
you were like, "Well, I think it's because of this malicious
thing." And Hutch is like, "Okay, sure. Yeah, it's it's possible
that he used two reasons." You were very sharp and very keen
to clarify, "Excuse me, you bald I didn't say that. I love Hutch.
You didn't mean that it was logically possible that they could
have these two positions. Hold on, we got one more. How the actual
hell does this manchild justify moral frogging about Bad Empanada
doxxing when he doxxed like five people with shallow dishonest
dishonest justifications in the last few That's a great That's
a great question gives you the ability to weasel out of whatever.
You were like, "I need you to
they have two motivations at least." And you forced him to take
a position. But when you say when you say when somebody that
I absolutely >> you exactly what happened. People can
Okay, I was there, too. Like what Why do Why do you think that
like I'm not allowed to contest your your rendition of that conversation?
So he asked me, I just think that it's it's like that he could
have had two motives. And I'm like, "I'm just clarifying. By
that, do you mean that there's like some good reason to believe
he had a second motive?" Or do you just mean the bare like question
that I wouldn't like disagree with is that he could have it.
had a second motive. Um I am anti-doxing and Destiny is wrong
to doxx.
Okay, are you going to do anything about it or are you just going
to go, "This that's really bad. That's really bad." Like I think
you should set some conditions, but you should have set conditions
back before, like, "Hey, if you ever doxx any of these people
you're threatening, I'm actually not going to have you around."
Right? But because you set no conditions, Destiny just continues
to doxx people, you enable it.
Like I If you want to say something bad happened and I can't
prevent it, so I'm going to prevent it going forward. That's
okay. Right? You I Oh, well, Destiny, you know, you gave me some
reason reasoning and I I wasn't following it, so I'm going to
say, "Okay, you just can't do it again or I'm going to have to"
But there's no like future That's the problem. There's no like,
"Oh, if this behavior continues, if this gets worse, I'm going
to do something."
Do you just mean the bare like question that I wouldn't like
disagree with is that he could have it. And the reason why I'm
doing that is is simply
because people have asked that of me and I've said, "Yeah, of
course he could have two motives." And what they've taken from
that is, "See, Pisco admits that he could have two motives and
therefore why What the [__] is he talking I'm going
to say this is one of the only time I'm going to say this is
a not mad thing, I guess, or I'm going to try to be When you
speak like this, every single person, Hutch included, hears an
accusation carried along there that they're intentionally and
maliciously trying to conceal their true beliefs. Especially
when you started that conversation off by saying, "I want to
make sure that we both agree that this is an important conversation
to have cuz I don't want to run through
He It's It's not ambiguous.
There's no way to read it in.
He literally says "I'm pretty sure this is true and it's irrelevant
to the conversation, but I just haven't seen all of the specific
content." That's That's true for
He's just saying what he's been doing.
So so so what's informing my conduct in the conversation is what
I
Is He doesn't want to make accusations that he can't possibly
prove that he feels like are based on other Like Okay.
Every single person around Pisco
who's been arguing with him on this topic consistently overstates
the case for why Ethan is justified in doing what he's doing.
They consistently let their emotions get involved and they they
overstate every single thing they think Denims has done and they
look stupid doing it. Pisco notices that and goes, "You know
what? I don't want to be one of these who gets totally emotional
and just makes things up that didn't happen. So I'm probably
going to say, 'Here's what I know happened and I do understand
he's got this reputation, so I'll grant that and if if there's
like contention, we could go into it later, but I think it's
probably not going to come up.'" And they go, "Oh, are you like
sweeping for Bad Empanada?" No, he's trying not to look like
all of you are. Uh how to deal with what are like I think very
obnoxious
>> hold on. I don't disagree with anything you're going
to say. I'm just saying that to say all of that and then to get
to better mental health, like, you think the better mental health
is like a bad guy, right? And you're like, "Well, I understand
that he has the reputation of being a bad guy, and I have seen
him do some bad things." You understand that you've hedged yourself
in that case. You're in like you're Fort Knox. You hedged against
everything there. The the the reason I hedged and qualified in
the sense of I didn't immediately say unambiguously yes is I
was racking my brain to see if there were moments in time that
I'm specifically recalling such that a challenge in that moment,
can I actually like produce these examples of the accusations
that I'm coming up with? Not all of us are so, um, you know,
flipping and reckless as you to make these accusations off the
cuff of certain individuals without having the evidence prepared,
like the accusation that you said that I actually want to protect
a community that's harassing a young woman. LET'S GO!
NOT ABOUT the Not about the harassing the young woman part. That
actually was not great timing on my pause. But, sorry. Whoops,
whoops, whoops. Whoops, I meant let's go as in he totally
And he's saying the thing I just said. I don't Not about the
roasting. Oh my god, we didn't do that.
Dude, that was Sorry, the let's go is Pisco's finally saying,
"Hey, not everybody is is as like loose
with what they'll claim about other people as you are." Like,
I try to be precise. I don't care that you're not precise. That
doesn't matter to me. >> or at least that's not how I'm
going to >> As I I'm thinking out loud. I'm just honestly
telling you what >> beings just don't have a clip reservoir
ready to produce immediately. >> But you think I don't
act like this? But but this is
But but but but Steven, I've acted like this as long as you've
known me, right? People have always said, "Why can't he just
get it out? Why is he so wordy?" This is not something that is
But just to be clear, hold on. That was a stupid thing for Pisco
to even like agree with and move on from. Most people don't have
a clip reservoir.
Is that what anyone's asking for? Or are they just saying, "Hey,
your strongest
should not be without evidence."
Your strongest claim, which for Hutch was Denims absolutely advocated
for calling CPS in that call. That was what he said. He said
Denims advocated directly for calling CPS in that call. Like,
he he said explicitly.
Okay? You shouldn't make that claim with while being unaware
of what your evidence actually is.
Like, all you need to do is calibrate your claim to what evidence
you're aware of. That's it.
Nobody's saying that you have to have all of the evidence. You
don't You don't have to have everything to make your points.
But, you should be somewhat in the ballpark. And these people
are not close to the ballpark. They're barely in the same universe.
>> out of character or out of step for me. This is how
I engage. And now, are there ways that I can improve? For sure.
What is unjustified is to say, "Oh, he's just grifting to make
money from Ruby. He wants to protect this community." or Once
upon a time,
Destiny used to point out Vaush disingenuously doing this and
called it like a simulacrum as in I don't ever show the conduct.
I don't ever show evidence. I provide you a story of who this
person is. I build a simulacrum of them so you never take them
seriously again in the future. Once upon a time, Destiny talked
about Vaush doing that disingenuously to with him. And now he
just explicitly does that to everybody else as much as he possibly
can. together in my head how unbelievably and insanely aggressive
you are with somebody who is relentlessly golden retriever levels
of good faith and charitability to you, and you're trying That
is totally inaccurate for that
Hutch was not being good faith at all. Or I I I said the other
opportunity was that he basically has the IQ of a golden retriever,
and then I would agree with Destiny there. I guess. >> That's
condescending to Hutch. This is condescending to Hutch, man.
>> It's not condescending. I have a lot of respect for
for people like Hutch and Josiah. As in When I say this, what
I mean is like I think I think Hutch views you, he respects you,
he views you as a friend, he respects you intellectually, he
he has all these things in his Dude, this is so funny how this
applies to the Pisco and his feelings on
Cuz I think that's the only reason Pisco hasn't gone like insane
in this
Right? For all of the bad faith accusations Destiny's made, not
just accusations that are bad faith, but accusations of bad faith
from Pisco, I think he would have lost his mind on anybody else
doing this. >> in his mind for you, and he's trying his
best to get out of his feelings. Yeah, and you're trying to run
these
>> Wait, did I do this with you? Wait, wait. Did I do this
with you back in the >> We enjoy this. This is fun for
us. It's It's different. Like with you and Rob Noer, DO YOU HAVE
THE SAME conversation with your mom that you do with Rob Noer?
>> You should ask my mom, man. Sometimes. Listen. >> You're
sitting in a random with a person with a client. I don't know
if you're a >> not a client. No, no, not a No, no, but
like if you ask people in my personal life, like and we are having
a like a back and forth, I don't know what to tell you. Like,
this is just how I engage with in discussions. I've always done
it. Everyone will tell you that it's in conformity with what
I do. And the reason why I had we had those exchanges with you
and I treat you cuz I I don't treat anyone different.
Just going to say
You know the big difference is? You know why I feel good about
if this is like one I was moving away from covering Destiny again
before he started covering the side by stuff and straight up
trying to dox people in my Discord made it clear that like I
have to make these arguments in public and and have this fight
cuz if I don't have the fight, he's just going to keep trying
to kill me, right?
But, I I was trying to move away. But, like the one thing that
gives me confidence in this fight
in this quote unquote fight is that like I look at my friends,
the people who come on my stream and hang out, and then I look
at the people who go on Destiny's stream, and I'm like, "Oh,
all the old busted lame losers go on Destiny's
and the cool people come on my stream." So, I feel like that's
That's just I feel comfortable, right? Like, eventually it all
shakes out. We win. I'm sorry. That's just facts, okay?
But, he's like all of the busted losers,
and and we're just like the cool, edgy, funny people.
It's going to obviously win in the end, right? I'm sorry. Like,
that's just facts. It's obvious. Frankly, I don't want to treat
people differently. Now, sometimes, if if they're coming on,
it's a different kind of moment, and like I can tell if they're
really struggling. But, I just like don't view Hutch that way.
I'm going to treat Hutch the way I treat people in in the debate,
right? This is a debate about the [__] merits. And
so, I treat Hutch the way I would treat you when we're talking
about self-defense, right? Do you see any big difference with
how I treated Hutch versus how I
You're saying that makes me want to say slurs for how lame it
sounds.
Why? Cuz the people who I hang out with are cool?
Like, legitimately,
I would kill myself hanging out with these people. Like, if these
were the people coming on my stream, I would kill myself.
Right? If I had to start my stream, and and the people hanging
out with Destiny now were the people coming on my stream, outside
of Dan, I would kill myself,
I'm just saying.
There's a big difference. It's a big >> What are you doing
in self-defense? You're doing this weird like normative,
you're trying to, um, equate normatively these two things, but
it's not like you're saying like, "Well, you treat them differently,
uh, but you treat them >> No, you're acting like I'm treating
Hutch maliciously and cuz I like I don't like them or but it's
just totally in line with >> a whole tangent and say Pisco
has lied so much about my past. I was like, "Really?" "Yeah,
basically everything." I was like, "What do you mean?" Like,
"Here's a clip. Pisco said I was a pro StarCraft player. What
a I didn't barely play StarCraft like pro I never played StarCraft
pro. I was a StarCraft II professional, right?" You would look
at that and be like, "Well, what do you mean StarCraft II?" Well,
Jesus Christ, is that really that big of a difference there?
I wouldn't expect you to know that. It's not cuz I think you're
[__] It's not cuz I think you're an idiot and don't
know the difference. I just don't I wouldn't expect you to delineate
between StarCraft and StarCraft II. The same way that I wouldn't
expect any normal human being outside of the Ask Yourself Discord
server to talk about a logical possibility, meaning that syntactically
the deductive logic follows that there is no contradiction between
two of the statements. That's not a thing that any normal human
being thinks about. So, you you might disagree
Uh, that's true.
But, I mean, if someone's going to say it, I'll ask them what
they mean. I think I got like debate aids from, uh, Avi and Isaac
recently, and I have talked to them recently in like the last
year, right?
That That By the way, that's true that people don't talk that
way, but that's not the criticism Destiny's making. And this
criticism's essentially always applied to Pisco. So, it's kind
of like you're you're bringing up a thing that a lot of people
made fun of Pisco for in the past,
but then you're saying that that thing indicates he's like defending
my community or or trying to get in with like certain people.
That doesn't make any sense.
Right? Like, this is just always the way Pisco was.
And we've had these different conversations where in many ways,
you know, I credit a lot of what they've, uh, said to like I
understand people are going to take the different view that this
is stupid and you shouldn't have done it. But, it's really helped
me think about like where the disagreements are. I I like When
I think back to the socialism conversations that we had with
Counter-Points, with you, with, uh, EconoBoii, all these other
people, it it really makes me think that there's a lot of semantic,
uh, lack of understanding. And that really opened my eyes. And
people can see the conversations I had with Isaac. They can see
where, uh, you know, I'm being introduced to a lot of these different
ways to analyze conversations by, um, Avi, who I just had a conversation
with. And there's just like a very clear way like why this is
now coming up and why I'm more thoughtful about um, the terms
people are using. It's because of that. It's not because I hate
Hutch. I don't hate him. Why why would I do a podcast with someone
I hate? >> And maybe you don't Maybe you just don't understand
how it comes off, but what you're talking about, I agree with
you. When it comes to Isaac and Avi, even if I disagree that
they're vegan thing and even if I think the Ask Yourself server
is whatever, they are very good when it comes to their logical
statements and their deduction. And their And
Reminder, Pisco's community is too stupid to follow the conversation.
So, because they are too stupid, they have to dip into caf talking
points. It's a drama community, not a political one.
I've followed this conversation the whole time.
I think I think if you feel like Hutch was good faith in the
previous
you don't actually pay attention.
Like, the the
pretense of this conversation is that Hutch was good faith and
Pisco was bad
And if you believe that, you just didn't pay attention to the
first conversation at all. Like it's very obvious. >> And
if you And about semantics I learned things. Yeah, and I learned
things in those Discord servers in terms of how to formulate
better
I understand but I'm saying that when you take propositional
logic and you apply it to an ordinary ass conversation >> but
it's not prop logic. What I'm all I'm doing there is that they
have clued me into where where I'm like a lot more thoughtful
about it than I used to be, um, is
semantics. It's to make sure that we that I before I answer something
like like what just happened with encouragement, right? Before
I answer something, I just want to make sure that I know what
I'm committing to and I want to make sure that we're using the
same terms and that we're not God damn it. Doobie just keeps
donating 10 bucks, 10 bucks, 10 bucks. Honestly, you do you just
need to log off or focus on whatever menial job you managed to
stumble into if you think the money I'm spending here is a lot.
Uh-oh.
That's what I thought. That's
Dude, people are like, "Doobie's like going to go Doobie's spending
all his welfare money." I'm like, I don't Dude, I think Doobie's
got a lot of money. I've seen Doobie drop this much money in
a lot of different places, a lot of different times. If it's
If it's welfare money, I mean, he's got a lot of it. Welfare
in the states must go crazy. >> equivocating. Another example
of this is when it when it came to the socialism conversation,
I just want to be clear, what do we mean by socialism and then
we're going to condemn it? If what we mean by socialism is, um,
you know, 100% owning the means of production, no avenue for
private enterprise, whatever, then we might have a different
conclusion than Oh, hello. What is this? Do me, [__]
Yes. Yes, Doobie's finally here. Yes, let's go. Sorry. Uh, Doobie,
thank you for the 25 gifted. Super appreciate it. Love the support.
Massive.
Massive. Dude, that was crazy timing. What the I think that adds
more time to the stream. I'll probably just get rid of the timer
in general. We'll just get rid of the timer. We'll just go however
long we're going to go cuz there's some stuff I might want to
cover after this. We'll see how far we get. >> Socialism
means the government does stuff. And so I've just I'm a lot more
thoughtful about making sure we do a proposition Thank you so
much, Appreciate Yeah. I I Okay. Like even the example that you
just used, okay? Disagreements over what socialism is, like this
is a there's heavy semantic content in terms of like you're talking
a subs a hugely subsidy difference between these two definitions.
Okay. Also, we'll go at least 8 hours, at minimum 8 hours. >> Which
it is good.
I might control Doobie into giving me that money, by the way,
with my crazy Voldemort powers, okay? Doobie's totally mind controlled
right now. Nothing he can do. >> differentiate on. He had
to give that money. He just couldn't stop himself. >> somebody
says like, um, like is it possible that I could jump to the moon?
And you're like, I think you actually use I I used that, yeah.
No, I used that to normal
human being. You never in your life and if Hutch By the way,
all of these arguments that Destiny's making now have nothing
to do with his core argument that started this conversation,
right? Where Pisco says, "It's insane to say that I was like
trying to defend other communities or I was trying to like with
with you to like so get support from these communities or something."
Like he's he's basically totally abandoned that and is now just
going, "Hey, Pisco, have you noticed that you're like kind of
a [__] cringe?"
That's like where the conversation's gone. "Hey, Pisco, have
you noticed that you're kind of like a [__] cringe?"
Like he's not making any claim anymore. He's abandoned every
claim he's made cuz he can't substantiate any of it and now he's
just like, "Pisco, you you kind of suck, man." tried to get you
on that
Former friend, by the way. >> Later on in the conversation
where he was like, "Well, you said that it was, uh, earlier I
know that everything you're saying is bull because you said that
it was impossible that Dennis do this, but you also said it was
impossible to jump to the moon and actually you can't demonstrate
a logical contradiction involved in jumping to the moon unless
you involve the laws of physics and all that." Like nobody talks
nobody thinks like that. IT'S WHAT IN YOUR MIND WHAT ARE THE
chances that Hutch is going to pull a a [__] philosophy
trick on you like that to get you in an argument?
>> I suspect that what Hutch means is it's a decent Oh,
did I miss a Doob Doobie super chat? Whoops.
Hold on, I did miss one. Why do these convos always end up people
in analyzing Hutch by implying he's too stupid to engage with
the convo at Pisco's level?
why would so many different people with wildly unaligned interests
all come to the same conclusion that Hutch is probably too stupid
to follow a conversation? That must be because where he was like,
"Well, you said that it was, uh, earlier I know that everything
you're saying is bull because you said that it was impossible
that Dennis do this, but you also said it was im I'm sorry, Hutch
can follow Hutch needs to ask when he doesn't understand something.
Hutch needs to say, "Please explain this to me because I don't
understand." If he could learn the humility to just do that and
not feel like he's out of his depth or whatever, if he could
just go, "Hey, I don't understand this, could you explain it
to me?" then he could follow these conversations. I don't think
he's like but he is obviously
like pretty self-conscious about his intellect and when he doesn't
understand something, he will not ask a question to clear it
up. And I think we actually demonstrated this in real time when
I pointed out, "Oh, I don't know what Pisco's saying right here.
What's a self-standing obligation?"
And then I went and looked it up and Hutch brought something
up with regards to obligations and it was clear he didn't understand
what Pisco was at. And I was just I was laughing cuz it's like
you should just ask for the definition. Ask what he's talking
>> possible to jump to the moon and actually you can't
demonstrate a logical contradiction involved in jumping to the
moon unless you involve the laws of physics and all that. Like
nobody talks nobody thinks like that. It's What in YOUR MIND
WHAT ARE THE chances that Hutch is going to pull a a [__]
philosophy trick on you like that to get you in an argument?
>> I suspect that what Hutch means is it's a decent chance.
That's what I suspect, all right? I just say that. Wait, wait,
no, but We say possible mean possible, right? Yeah. And then
you move on and you're done. You don't have to spend 20
Okay, no, what I suspect Hutch is doing is he's saying there's
an outside shot, right? Like there's a one in a million chance.
Like you could say there's this other possibility that you haven't
ruled out, so I want to focus on that. And it's like, "Well,
I want you to substantiate how likely you think that is because
if you don't, then you're just bringing something up that could
be like a one in a million shot that you don't really care about
and then we're wasting time." That's Pisco wants to avoid that.
>> minutes explaining possible realities and all possible
universes and like You're saying to move on.
When I say
Life is just so much easier when you just admit you're dumb.
Well, it's not even dumb though, right? There's not You're not
dumb because you don't know some specific term that someone's
using. That's the thing. And
I feel like it's just it's an obvious demonstration of intelligence
to learn where you've missed something and be willing to slow
things down to make sure that you're not [__] it
up. Like I think that's
obviously demonstration of intelligence. So when you go and you
say like, "Hey, hey, uh, I you just lost me, can you re-explain
this?" That's actually a sign of intelligence and I don't think
saying, "Hey, I just don't know what you're saying right now.
Can you explain to me what you mean what this means, what that
means?" That's intelligence. It's trying to make sure you can
integrate the information the other person's saying so that you
aren't lost so that you're not wasting both of your time. Hey,
why I'm doing it because like it becomes a a like a hang-up in
the conversation. The reason I do it is just to show people like
Um, hypotheticals are almost always useless, says That Chisel.
That is totally wrong and I don't know how you have conversations
with people if you can't isolate like basically the variables
of things you're agreeing or disagreeing on, which is what you
use hypotheticals for. That's really bizarre.
I'm not trying to with you at all. I just want to make sure that
when the audience sees this clip, they're not going to be able
to cut out me saying, "Yeah, he could have had two different
motives." And then people say, "Look, he said that like the only
reason I'm doing it is not because I don't suspect Hutch
plausible that he doesn't mean this. It's And when I say that
like I I'm just trying to take this moment to get people to appreciate
why I'm doing it in good faith. But you turn it into I've heard
the term that you used, slimy,
that I'm getting these opinions from other people, that I'm trying
to like, basically pull the wool over Hutch's eyes because I
guess I don't know why.
Oh, hold on. >> I'm trying to like, basically pull the
wool over
Destiny has moved on to optics Pisco because he lost the argument
so bad. He's like moved into you kind of look like a nerd. You
kind of look like a loser when you do this. That's like his argument
now. He's dropped all of his actual claims. He's even dropped
the I feel statements and he's like, "You You look really crazy
when you say this." >> Hutch's eyes because I guess I don't
know why. Like I want him to suffer. I want Hutch to suffer.
How is that in line with the rest of my the rest of the stuff
I do? I I don't think that I've ever like Have I shown to be
malicious >> it's intentional. I don't know if it's intentional,
but I know that like when you argue with if you argue with me,
you argue with Rob, Noor, these are like the kinds of convos
you engage in. Yeah, and I I treat him the same way. But like
you you see on Livin' Learn when we have conversations about
Mom Doddy, about the the shutdown, it's the same [__]
And I in those moments, like, yeah, I treat with I I treat him
the way I would treat other interlocutors in that moment. And
sometimes Hutch is, you know, I love him, he's my boy. Sometimes
he I think he's sometimes unwilling to answer question and I
have to push and push and push and push a little bit. Not unlike
you and not unlike maybe sometimes me, right? I don't I think
I try to answer questions, but, um, you know, we all have our
moments. So all I'm just trying to say is I'm not treating him
any materially worse and why would I do that? What What's the
incentive that I have to just
my [__] on him? Like Why What is the possible justification
that I would to do that? Hutch wanted to have the conversation,
so did I. I thought it's
I want to So so in the future if you're on stage with some politician
or something else that says like, "Do you think it's possible
that we could fund some program with ABCDEF or whatever?" You're
just going to say yes or no? Well, I think Hold on. If that politician
was coming to Pisco and the pretense of the conversation, the
the reason the conversation's happening is cuz that politician
said Pisco was wrong about something on Twitter, you better believe
Pisco's going to be a pedant like during that conversation, okay?
If for some reason they decided to start talking because that
person was saying, "Pisco, you're
Then yeah, I think I think Pisco would be super pedantic in that
conversation. >> likely that you're going to say, "Well,
when you say possible, do you mean does it entail a logically
a contradiction or
Don't worry, chat. If I hit the $500 YouTube daily limit, I'll
get an alt and keep talking [__] Listen, I I I think
there is a more clean way you can say it. I I don't know about
possible, I do mean likely or something like that. Maybe there's
a a faster way to say it,
that isn't advice like maybe I'll accept in terms of like saying
it in a less I don't know, less annoying fashion. But the thing
is, it doesn't show I'm malicious. It doesn't show that I'm trying
to It might not show it, but it it it's it feels that way. It
feels that way when you when you say it, dude. It feels that
way when you basically say that everything I'm doing in that
context is to try to like mind [__] It seems condescending
to Hutch. How do you think I'm curious. Curious. No, stop doing
this. It feels like you're saying that Hutch is stupid. It's
not that. It's a different thing. We We We have different skill
sets. We excel in different areas. We do different things. It's
not Like I don't think that Hutch spends all of his time doing
a hardcore llama debate lord blah blah blah. Like I don't I I
don't think he just does that. I don't think Josiah does that.
I think both these people are very intelligent people. I respect
their political Hutch is like the only guy in the whole gaming
world who's not a [__] political I have a ton of
respect for him. So it's not Don't stop doing this weird thing
where it's like, "Oh, are you saying I need What? What opinion
does he
Though okay, I'm pretty sure that this entire thing
just that Hutch really hates Sargon. I'm almost positive that
it's just that Hutch hates Sargon here. I hate to I hate to just
assume that Destiny's rationale for this is entirely spite based,
but it it's got to be that, >> him like I don't treat him
I don't treat him differently. I don't I treat him like a a smart
person Okay, I I don't know. You said you you you made the claim
you made the claim that well, when you say it is it it it is
that way. How do you think Hutch felt at the end of your conversation?
I think he felt great. I think he felt fine.
Hey titty. I It seemed like at some point there he's like, "I'm
tired. I want to go. Hey Hutch, shouldn't you substantiate your
positive claims?" Man, who cares? I'm tired. I want to go to
sleep. I I didn't watch the last hour, so maybe at some point
Hutch got back on course and it finished really great. I don't
know, but that was where I stopped watching was around that part.
>> he feel bad?
Okay, then then one of us is super autistic cuz my takeaway was
I think that there's a feeling that you get sometimes where you
have a very blue until a brain blue ball unsatisfied feeling
where you're like, "I feel like I just argued for 4 hours and
I feel like we didn't actually cover anything." Which I actually
I don't even think you guys got to the central point of >> think
we did either. Wait, no. You know, I I I don't think we did.
I I agree with that. 4 hours you barely got through the meta
conversation. I would be surprised and I could be wrong. I would
be surprised if Hutch came up with that conversation like Has
Pisco been able to argue that Destiny's clearly not operating
good faith in this conversation with regards to the multiple
character attacks Destiny's made that Pisco raises? He says,
"Hey, it's really [__] up that you made this character
attack on me. Can you say that if I'm correct in what you're
making it over? If I was actually correct there, you'd apologize,
right?" And Destiny goes, "No." "No, I wouldn't apologize." And
all of those times that Pisco brought one of those up, I think
there's at least four or five times now. And he's like, "Can
we go back to that?" Destiny's like, "No, I want to keep going
over here." And he just keeps running away with the
They've been circling the whole time. Well, Destiny's just trying
never to
He He's He hasn't addressed a single
actual question Pisco's asked. Essentially this entire Like it's
actually crazy how when Pisco says, "Hey, you said this about
me. You said it for this reason. If that reason was false and
I was correct, you'd apologize, right?" And Destiny goes, "No."
It's totally wild. >> Man, that was a really good argument.
I think it was probably like, "Fuck, that was so unsatisfying.
I feel like we didn't get to talk about anything." I I'm I'm
not sure about Did you see us like do the aftercare there where
I'm like, "I love him. Nobody attack him." I would Pisco's subtly
accepting that he paddled Hutch pretty hard, okay? Had to give
him some aftercare. >> that is that you think that that's
also performative so that I Oh, Doobie, that was my exact analysis.
I don't know if you were here a couple hours ago, but I think
Pisco
remembers the good times. Destiny actually says this about Hutch.
Destiny says like, "Well, I think Hutch looks up to you and I
think Hutch really likes you and I think Hutch wants things to
work out." So he's like really good faith in the conversation.
That's not true, but that is what's happening here where I think
Pisco saw this guy as his friend and he thinks that it he's ethically
obligated not to go and like cover a bunch of his stuff right
now and cover his lawsuit, right? And so he doesn't want to be
involved
at all.
but he wants to be friends with Destiny. He thinks Destiny's
his friend still. He thinks Destiny is like good faith and just
like kind of lashing out and he he's so sure that Destiny's going
to go back to being like a good guy right
It's like I Man, I I don't know.
I don't I don't see I couldn't possibly have that faith, man.
maybe. I certainly couldn't hang out with Destiny, but maybe
maybe there's something maybe Destiny really turns it around.
But again, I think he has to start answering for some of the
behavior, right? Why did you threaten to dox Wicked Supreme?
Why did you dox Esports Batman?
Like can you show me the evidence for for whatever reason you
give? He shut down By the way, Pisco has a perfectly reasonable
trying to apply a standard of oh, if you laugh at jokes,
you're basically approving this action continuing. You basically
are What is it? Endorsing that action, right?
And you're and you're also endorsing like whatever comes from
that. And so Pisco's like, "Wait, why did you dox Esports Batman?
Would you say that that's obviously cuz you wanted him hurt?"
And Destiny basically says He basically says, "Well, I would
say something, but I Nobody else will agree or nobody else will
actually be honest about this, so I won't." And then he kind
of says yes and then he kind of says, "Oh, I don't want to talk
about this anymore. It's [__] up." It's like Okay.
What? So Pisco uh
Every time Pisco like goes and tries to apply Destiny's standard,
he's presenting this conversation to Destiny, it's cataclysmic
for Destiny.
I think he's trying not to do that cuz he thinks Destiny is I
don't know, maybe he thinks the guy's struggling and he wants
to be friends again. I don't get like uh the the notion that
I'm trying to like with Hutch. What do you think aftercare means?
What is aftercare for? Yeah, so come on. That's You're just you're
making a joke. You know what I'm talking about, yeah. >> No,
I'm not saying that. Sometimes you say something AND YOU DON'T
MEAN IT EXACTLY THAT WAY. YOU DON'T NEED AFTERCARE FOR JUST BEING
NICE TO SOMEBODY. YOU DON'T NEED AFTERCARE FOR JUST BEING NICE
TO SOMEBODY. YOU DON'T NEED AFTERCARE for just being nice to
somebody. You're
Aha, your analogy lets me run in a
You thought we're going to have a conversation, but your analogy
lets me run in this direction. Come chase me, >> fast and
loose. You're being FAST AND
NO, YOU'RE BEING ASKED MANNERS AND I WRITE WRITE them so [__]
hard. This is like such a great microcosm of the entire conversation.
Of like Pisco's trying to Pisco loses focus for a millisecond
and Destiny's going to run like a mile with whatever he just
Yeah, he's just going to totally sperg out
Like and again, I just can't stop
Who finds this like totally childlike tantrum throwing style
of argumentation entertaining or compelling?
Like he is just throwing a tantrum constantly. Perpetually like
a child banging his fists and feet on the ground laying on his
stomach banging his fists and feet on the ground, but in conversational
form. Like there was a time where he could actually and I'm going
to maintain this. There was a time where he could actually engage
in the conversation, too. But he is so out to lunch like morality
wise now and he's so Yeah, he's so out to lunch with what he
has to advocate for. He can't have like a real conversation anymore,
right? Like he's out here on this doxing thing trying to justify
that totally undercuts so much of his like bedrock moral prescriptions
from years ago, right? The entirety of the Keppels manifesto
totally undone.
And he just can't have real conversations with people anymore.
Like he can't even
He has no leg to stand on. I don't know. It's it's it's sad.
You're being fast and loose. That's not at all what I meant.
What I meant is I made sure after that, right? I'm not saying
like go All right. Another doobie don't know. Just in case people
missed it earlier. Is Destiny culpable for Rose being doxed because
he posted a photo of her in a DGG shirt and her university to
mock Kiwi Farms for failing to dox her? Oh boy. I don't like
that. I That sounds like information from Kiwi Farms. Is it true?
Yes, unequivocally true, but it's also from Kiwi Farms. So what
the [__] >> What I said was, "By the way, guys,
I love Hutch. Hutch is my boy." I'm not just saying that facetiously.
I like Hutch a lot. I do a [__] podcast with >> you're
saying it facetiously, but I'm saying that like the the conversation
was probably deeply unsatisfying.
Well, there are aspects about it that were unsatisfying to me,
too, but that I don't I don't think it >> The whole thing
was unsatisfying. Okay. Nothing of substance was spoken about.
It was like a debate with Rob Noer and Andrew Wilson where it's
like
That is almost entirely on Hutch for the first hour and a half,
2 hours that
That is like entirely on Hutch. Hutch was the person who wouldn't
engage in a hypothetical, wouldn't answer a question, suspected
a trap the whole time, would not come close to like engaging
at all with what Pisco was
So yes, it was like that, but that's not Pisco's fault. I don't
I don't know the [__] I just debated for 4 hours.
The way I can tell you my impression. I CAN >> 3 HOURS
IN, HUTCH WAS LIKE, "I think I'm tired of this combo." And you're
like, "Are you [__] >> what you did? You know
what you did? No, I I can just tell you my impression if you
want to hear it. >> You think Hutch was actually like
I I don't know. I mean like I think he was probably like frustrated
with the conversation. But I don't think that he's Yes. I'm not
frustrated with it. I I don't think that he's like sad or angry
about it. I just think he's
Oh, hold on. I saw I saw another mention of my name. Yes.
I don't think
Jace Doc has broken Destiny. It's so
Yeah, but I mean, yeah. Yeah, a little
And realistically, there are multiple times during the past year
that I tried to move on and this guy just wouldn't let it go.
Just kept like trying to dox people. I don't know why.
I'd like move on. I'd start covering other stuff and then he
would come back and be like, "Oh, you should uh Like I have to
go post I have to go cover like screenshots of this guy's
When I'm doing other [__] You brought this on yourself.
Why the [__] would you call it aftercare? You're
kidding me. Okay, Pisco, you brought this one on yourself. Yeah,
Pisco.
Pisco not always speaking the best. >> think I don't think
I don't think that he's like sad or angry about it. I just think
he's fine after. >> No, no, but there are different types
of frustrations. There can be frustrations like, "Fuck, like
I didn't have like the information here or like oh [__]
he got me on this point." And then there's the frustration of
like, "I feel like my intuitions are being twisted around and
I'm being yanked around all these different topics of discussion."
I don't even really know what Yes, but Pisco doesn't have that
problem.
The funny thing here to me is that if you actually like if you
go watch my coverage from YouTube, I think it got posted, right?
I think Riolu posted that stuff. But if you just watch my coverage,
I'll explain to you exactly why Pisco's asking the questions
he was asking. He's just transparent the whole time. Like Pisco
is is he has a clear goal when he's asking certain questions
the entire time. It's obvious. It's transparent
if you're paying any amount of attention.
And Hutch is refusing to answer those
I think because he can kind of see where they're going and he
doesn't like that he's going to have to admit to some things
where he was wrong. But he just refuses to engage. And I think
that's the first hour and a half of that conversation easily.
Pisco's just not saying anything. Sorry, Hutch is just not willing
to to engage and and give concessions on anything. Very unfortunate.
Yeah. >> So just because that's a feeling that exists doesn't
>> both of us generally speak Well, no, I have felt that
way after the [__] rage combo that we had the whatever
the time before last or whatever. But like generally speaking,
we're both collaboratively trying to build towards some end.
And you're not usually
trying to like sneak away from things like I feel like actually
you kind of have in this conversation which we'll go back to.
But I do feel that way when I debate with Andrew Wilson or when
I watch every Jordan Peterson debate. Well, no, but but hopefully
hopefully that people can understand a difference between me
and Andrew Wilson.
The difference is and and I hope that people remember my conduct
when it was reacting to the insurrection debate that you had
with Andrew Wilson when I felt that people that for example,
this is exactly where I defended you, right? Do you remember
when he said something like, "It's not my burden to show whatever
whatever whatever." Remember when he said that? And everyone
and their uncle was saying, "Oh, it's he's right, you know, he
does Is it just me or is it weird that DGG isn't donating during
this conversation and letting Doobie go wild without a reply?
No, it's not weird.
It's not weird if you think about >> the burden. That's
correct. He doesn't have the burden. But then
Oh, sir sir Destiny would never dox Destiny would never dox >> partway
through the conversation. >> Okay. Um he makes a claim
like I think that the definition you provide >> Kathy,
could you record a a voice note and send it to me via DM of that
exact thing I just said so I can it can sound better. Thank you.
>> would better fit the term riot as opposed to insurrection.
Of course, once he made that claim, he is putting into issue
some kind of reference to what words ought to mean. And so he
needs to provide Wait, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I just want
to finish the [__] Can I finish it, please?
I will say I saw Sovereign donate, okay? I saw Sovereign donate
and I saw the pesos being I saw the pesos, okay? I saw you donate.
I saw the pesos.
Get the No, I defended you on on No, no, no, no, not in terms
of the the personality stuff. I defended it from his tactic trying
to uh hide his relative burden in that context. On the same grounds
where I was saying that it actually is Hutch's burden now with
respect to whatever point he was making about Denam's intent.
I was defending you when you were correctly stated to Andrew
Wilson and he was being using a a slimy insincere debate tactic
that he didn't have a burden anymore. So that's precisely what
I'm not trying to do. I'm open I have the calls to have people
come in so they can they can chat about stuff. I'm just saying
that my guess would be is that Hutch probably felt like that
was an Andrew Wilson or Riolu ignored debate that he had with
you. Not like a debate with a friend who's collaboratively trying
to build towards some argument. It was a debate, man. I mean,
I don't know what to tell you. We are we've had conversations
before. I think that the fact that I started from
It's crazy. I've never thought Destiny would conduct himself
in a manner where JizzyK might actually have a point. He's acting
just like him. Wait, what do you mean he's acting like me? Where
do I do this to people? I'm perfectly capable of having any kind
of conversation with people. I don't know why anyone act like
this is the uh like I can't.
I can absolutely understand Hutch's side of that conversation
and explain where Pisco could be better.
But to me to me
Hutch needs to be humble and say, "I don't understand what you're
arguing, so I can't even really argue back." And Pisco needs
to be like gracious and not be an ass to the person who's not
able to keep like keep up with him. And so realistically when
it's two people doing their profession and one needs grace and
the like right one needs grace and charity
and the one of them needs to like be asking for help. It's like
I'm not going to I'm not going to tell you that that's equal.
That's one person being way worse at the job than the other person.
See you later, Kiruko. Thank you for being here tonight. Sorry
we didn't miss the stream last night. >> perspective of
like, "Well, can we just agree that this matters?" It would it's
it's trying to build some set of like understanding and and and
guiding principles where we can walk away from it having at least
some set better sense of a position. And maybe that kind of style
works better with Avi and these other types of people. I don't
have any problems with those people. Maybe it's because, you
know, they're also autistic or whatever. But I it is not an indication
>> said was fine. When you said when you said maybe that
style works better with those other people, that's what I'm saying.
I think it does. Not because Hutch is stupid and not because
somebody is able or not able, but just because of how people
different people do >> Okay, so then why don't you give
me the benefit of the doubt there instead of [__]
accusing me of trying to grift to tankies?
I mean, that's basically >> Because you're doing this because
because we because we're it's the difference between negligence
and recklessness. You should know better. If this is a private
conversation, I would have a difference of opinion about it.
This was a private >> to tankies? Wait, with respect to
tankies? And what's that? You're really autistic in public and
that helps tankies. Am I trying to to to grift from like grifting
is something you do, I think, right? Unless you think that there's
unintentional grifting. I feel like grifting is an accusation
of intent. You're doing something insincere to make money. And
you've accused me in >> individual How many individual
donations has Doob has Doobie sent in this stream?
Well, I I hold on. I like that Destiny went here, right? That
Destiny basically accused Pisco of saying things disingenuously
for money. Now, here's the thing. Okay? Destiny doesn't want
to engage in this argument
because I do think as much as we joke about the rupees
I know there are like 10 guys like 10 oilers around Destiny
that throw mad cash at anyone who will support him, okay?
I don't know why we have to pretend like if there isn't Why do
you think Wick is so ready to go all in defending Destiny,
And I can actually point out
Wick used to have a zero tolerance on doxing policy in his Discord,
okay? That changed specifically for Destiny, right? I don't think
like I haven't seen any demonstration of Pisco changing his beliefs.
I've seen all of the same liberal beliefs, all of the same like
really progressive beliefs that are so [__] annoying
to me sometimes, you I see all that stuff still there.
I don't see where he's changed on anything. I can't see one iota
of change. He just doesn't think Ethan Klein was telling the
truth. That's what I'm accusing you of. How many people in your
chat right now or in your Discord are also in JizzyK's Discord
or also in Doobie's Discord or also Those are the That's the
answer. But that's not even really the Should they be banned?
Should they be banned? Should they be banned? Should they be
At least that, yeah. Should they be >> relevant to this.
It's not about should they be banned.
YOU'RE DOING IT RIGHT NOW WITH THE WITH THE BINARY. OH, WAIT,
so should they be banned, right? Imagine I have a [__]
nothing in my Imagine I have a nothing. You can't do anything.
There's nothing you can No, no, tell me what I tell me what I
ought do. No, no, no. I'm telling you that Jesus Christ. Okay,
hold on. The JoeMac bit is a lot. Okay, it's a I don't even
No, I'm being serious. Wait, I'm I'm being What ought I do with
respect to Doobie's donations? Should I not accept them and give
it back? I'm asking what the moral Hold on. Is that a Doobie
donation? That is a Doobie donation. Hold on. This is super interesting.
But can you please get Destiny to lay out his justification for
posting Esports Fap Man's personal info on a doxing website known
for swatting?
Hey, that's a great question, Doobie. I wonder if Destiny would
talk about that. I wonder why Destiny keeps refusing to talk
about that.
Pisco's DGG mods banned me for agreeing with him over Destiny
months ago and Pisco's been looking into it ever since.
Yeah, I heard about that. I I did see him say, "Sorry, Doobie,
I still haven't really looked into it." the other day.
How would I comply? >> It's not about accepting or denying
the donation. It's the question of like why are all of these
people super supportive? That's the question. Presumably because
they >> Which I don't even care. That's not even that important.
That's not even the central part. I think I laid this criticism
out like at the beginning of the thing and I spent 5 hours listening
to this. That's not somebody's central thing. I'm not saying
like, "Oh, it's cuz he's brain broken on this." >> so I
Wait, so so so can we be So you don't think that I'm grifting
for tankies, do you? Kind of. Why? Like he asked that, Destiny
runs in circles trying not to say it and Pisco's like, "Okay,
I'll let this guy finish." And he's done spurking. So you don't
think I'm grifting for tankies, right?
On virtual what? You think I'm a tankie supporter? You're one
of the smartest people I've ever had the pleasure of talking
to online. And some of the things that you were saying to Hutch
yesterday were so unfathomably unbelievable that I cannot believe
that they originated from the same mind as the person I spoke
with in our personal space for 2 years. That's just impossible
for me to believe. That Hutch can ask you a question as plainly
as if somebody says that some children are
Dude, Pisco just needs to keep saying like, "Okay, so why am
I doing that? What's the evidence of me doing that? How would
me being with Hutch lead to tankies benefiting?"
That's what Destiny has failed to lay out this entire time. How
does Pisco being very hyper like a with Hutch, lead to Tankies
winning? He's desperate for friends. Well, he's desperate to
make up for This is what Destiny does is he talks all this [__]
He says Pisco's clearly grifting. Pisco goes, "Hey, you kind
of just made that up. You should probably apologize, right? You
were wrong." And Destiny goes, "No."
And then Destiny goes, "But you're the most intelligent person
I've ever met in my entire life." What? This doesn't make any
sense, bro. What the [__] are you saying? >> dying
in a house. Do you think that justifies the CPS call? And you're
like, "Well, does it logically mean that causally it's like then
you have to necessarily imply that every single person Oh, Pisco's
cooked. He's using the straw man voice for Pisco. Uh-oh, the
soy straw man voice. You are the soy straw man guy now, Pisco.
Okay, you >> is going to be calling CPS and it would be
a justification for them to call it. Like that's impossible to
me that a human being can't say like, "Yeah, of course. Sure,
of course. Yes, Hutch. That That would be reasonable for you
to call CPS at that point." >> I guess I'm shocked because
I feel like I've always
I mean, Pisco kind of Pisco wasn't eviscerating Hutch, though.
That's Pisco's way of talking. When somebody says, "You're wrong
and you're lying and you're bad faith right now." That's Pisco's
way of determining how somebody's bad faith or not, right? Like,
you could say that he thinks that's like not aggressive. It's
just what has to be done.
So, when he says Hutch is my boy, he really does mean it.
Trust me. I guarantee you Pisco If Pisco had like a 10-year-old
child and that 10-year-old child said he was wrong, he would
do that same thing. He would do that He would He would quote
unquote eviscerate that 10-year-old child just as hard as he
goes at Hutch.
I I fully believe that, okay? >> interacted this way. I
feel like it's consistent with my personality. And people, for
better or worse, it's been divisive. It's been divisive. There
are people who have always hated my contributions, who have always
called me a pedant, who have always said that like the contributions
I have or it's always like, "Well, technically, you know,
I made similar criticisms to this of Pisco, but I'd say it's
more and I think I'm holding I I believe this happens here. I
believe he wouldn't hold the same standard for behavior for most
people. Um there's like a class of people he dislikes and a class
of people he likes and then 99% of people in between those. But
like I think for the people he likes, like Destiny, there's like
a clear standard of behavior he allows Destiny to engage in and
still defend him and still try to be friends with him that he
doesn't allow anyone else. Which is whatever. He wants to be
friends with Destiny. I get it. It's fine. It's totally fine.
I don't And I don't say that, by the way, in terms of like he's
sweeping for Destiny on his on his law cases or anything like
that. It's the impression I get for like him after the multiple
character attacks still being good faith, still trying to talk
to the guy normally, right? That's my That's the impression I
get. It's not in a way that I'm like I'm not making a harsh criticism.
It's whatever. He used to be good friends with this guy. He followed
his content for a long time. It's whatever, man. I can't zoom
out the >> Everyone
put it in chat right now. The the glasses guy with the little
[__] finger up. That has always been my
For better or worse. I don't always agree that that is in in
you know, in fact the case. I don't agree that Um but but that's
that's my that is my I agree. I agree. I agree. But the difference
is is that when people were complaining about you there, they
were complaining about the style,
but not the substance, right? Pisco might be right here, but
God, he's so [__] annoying. He'll say, "Oh, he might
be right here, but he's so [__] right." The main
complaint right now though is on the substance. That it feels
like you're
No, Pisco got a decent amount of hate when he disagreed with
Destiny. >> cover for all of these people by employing
the most insane arguments, the most Majin Buu tatted Vegeta fighter
in the history of all of argumentation.
Just give me a second. >> go back to the the Sorry, I just
need a What the [__] does that reference even mean?
>> real quick. Hang on. Um you guys cannot um
actually fix for the chat?
One second. Chat. Okay, we got it. Okay, no more chat. YouTube
chat, sorry. You're done. This is Uh I'll be real. I was the
person where I was like, "Oh, I banned that guy for using hard
Rs in my chat." So, I let one of Pisco's mods know. I'm like,
"Hey, just in case he's live on Twitch right now." I didn't know
if he was, but like they'll auto ban you for that. So, you need
to get that chat off screen or ban that guy or whatever. And
then they got rid of it. >> Um go ahead. All right, I I
snitched. I didn't want the guy to get banned if he was But I
didn't realize he was on Twitch, so.
>> Or he is No, he is on Twitch, right? That's his Twitch
chat. >> I don't care about YouTube chat, okay? >> were
doing TOS stuff.
Um What's the point? Like like No, what like what >> Wait.
Wait. Wait. I'm so I'm curious. Going back to everything that
we said before, okay? What when Denims was watching
all of BadBunny stuff, the first video related to the CPS stuff,
um where he's talking about the guard guard gear or whatever
the [__] it is. And then the laughing about when
Ela and Ethan complained about it and she's like laughing at
the in response to them >> it's a wrong thing. I think
it's a wrong thing. No, no. And and then okay. And then And then
when she watches the BadBunny joke and the accusation Do you
think Yes. That's so so >> Do you think that But I was
just clarifying Uh no, I think it's Babidi that does it. I think
Bibidi's the dad. Cuz it's Bibidi Babidi Buu, right? So, I think
Bibidi was the dad. Babidi is the sorcerer who's there, who learned
how to do stuff from his dad. And then Buu's their like primary
creation.
Bibidi Babidi Buu. culpability. Wait. Wait. Let's say that a
second CPS call comes happens. We don't really know who it's
from. Let's say a second CPS call happens. Do you think that
she would have some culpability
in that second CPS call occurring? In it that she be partially
responsible for it >> So So, I understand culpability to
refer to a moral fault, right? So, it it's some kind of like
moral Yes. So, the
is yes with respect to recklessness. Yes with respect to negligence.
Not yes with respect to intentional malicious uh phone call.
Wait, why is there a moral fault related to recklessness? Yeah,
because you're So, that kind of conduct contains a substantial
and unjustifiable risk.
Correct. So, it's tied exactly to the harms that could result.
For instance, >> have the same moral intuitions with respect
to someone. And we went through the car example to to show that
that And that's what I mean, right? Like No, no, we absolutely
have the same moral intuitions. If somebody drives drunk and
they get home, the person doesn't say "Do you what You drove
drunk home?" And the guy's like, "Yeah, but I didn't hit anybody."
They say "You could have killed somebody." You wouldn't say "Excuse
me, I didn't kill anybody. And even if I did, that's a separate
action than just driving drunk. So, these two things are not
logically entailed by one
I think he'd say you didn't murder someone, probably. >> Okay.
So, I agree that we would just because you didn't cause the death
of another person. And um just because you didn't actually have
the results of is But like this is why we penalize drunk driving
absent accidents, right? It's why you penalize drunk driving.
It's like if the CPS call never happens, what happens to Denims?
Literally nothing, >> you could be like charged for I don't
know, drunk manslaughter or whatever the [__] that
is. I mean, there are some uh situations in which I mean the
kind of conduct that issue with drunk driving is so reckless
at this point and everyone knows it. So, we all we we we understand
that. So, I'm not trying to say that the bad act only occurs
when the like the kind of result elements. I'm very intention
pilled. What I will treat very differently someone whose conscious
object is to produce a bad result as opposed to someone who is
acting really, really recklessly or even negligently um and bad
stuff happen happens to happen or it just happens, right? Um
absolutely agree with that. No doubt about it. What all I'm trying
to say is there is a huge significant difference between those
two things. And you have to really be on Uh Denims said don't
call CPS. Well, Destiny is arguing unironically
that if you laugh, you are encouraging an action. If you joke
about something, you are encouraging the action that you were
joking about. The guy who jokes about um like child's
child children getting laid, the guy who jokes about children
dying, about Charlie Kirk dying, about Charlie Kirk getting assassinated,
rather, about the what the firefighter getting shot in the Trump
assassination attempt. He jokes about all of these things. He
is arguing that if you laugh at something, if you joke about
it, you are actually encouraging that happening in the future.
By his own arguments, okay? By laughing at the firefighter and
saying he didn't care, he actually caused Charlie Kirk to die.
He is culpable for the death of Charlie Kirk.
By his own arguments.
But he Like he's obviously just he's obviously just not thinking
and obviously being like
I hate to use the dog whistle, but turbo bad faith. Like just
insanely bad faith. Obviously insanely bad faith. >> honest
with yourself. At the time that Denims watched that video Wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Hold on. Hold on. >> it real quick real
quick cuz we might agree on everything, okay? But cuz cuz I just
want to disagree on one thing. You said it goes back to the question
I asked Kafka to moderate earlier. You say there is a huge difference
between these two things. I personally I don't see There is some,
but I don't see as much daylight between like between like depraved
heart and first degree. I don't see as No, that's not what I'm
saying. No, no, no. Depraved heart is >> Like with with
recklessness >> That's an area where reckless It's so
Depraved heart is past reckless, I believe. The risk is so great
that it's going to be some kind of constructive intent. So, we're
going to treat it actually the same.
I don't think Isn't depraved heart used as a second degree murder
justification >> No, but but like essentially you're you're
fulfilling the malice aspect of murder. The thing that makes
it the worst is you're so reckless that we're going to treat
you like you you basically tried to Yes. Yes. Yeah. That's But
that's But when somebody is watching of I just don't understand
how what Denims is doing is not This is This is why >> think
it was her response
Just to be clear, this is like the entire conversation again,
right? Like if Destiny had been engaging good faith the whole
time, I feel like he would realize this is what both the conversation
with Hutch broke down at at like the heart of the conversation
there and the heart of this conversation. It's like Pisco doesn't
feel like you could say she was intentionally trying to cause
a CPS call. And he's asking what evidence you have or why you
believe that. And basically people just keep playing different
clips and going it's obvious, right? It's obvious, right? And
Pisco goes, "No, no, no, it's like obviously not. It's not obvious
at all."
Like you make an argument for why dude Destiny reading those
chat messages and going, "Oh, it's obvious she's celebrating,
right?"
But why doesn't it seem like the response indicates that that
is basically what she was doing?
The reason why I think that I'm not going to do that kind of
constructive intent is because all else equal, I think the risk
of someone else doing the CPS call on the basis of that statement,
right? That that statement is a butt-for cause relating to some
So that's what you have to show, right? Like the risk is related
to the thing, right? What is the thing itself? The thing is her
making that comment, right? Um that her the additional risk by
her making those comments and having those reactions is essentially
small in comparison. No, you don't. No, you don't. No, you don't.
No, you don't. No, you don't. There the butt-for doesn't even
need to be demonstrated there.
Well, Destiny didn't like collective blame when like Keffals
was trying to use collective blame on him. That was really bad.
Okay? But now that like collective blame is based and you can
use it to go after your enemies, it's actually awesome. Because
we always support what position is it, Missy? What position do
we always support? Yes, the most spiteful one that goes against
anyone we have personal petty beef with at any given time. That's
how we pick our positions. That's how we win. Let's [__]
go. If you go out and you drunk drive and somebody goes out somebody
else goes out and
Um actually doxing is awesome now because these guys said bad
things about me. They were like really mean to me. So doxing's
actually totally cool now cuz I want to dox them.
Like it's actually just this, right? That That is the level of
intellectual like intellectual exercise we've undergone here.
Um I don't like these guys, so now anything I do to them is
Destiny's mission is to prove Vaush completely correct. Let us
pray that Extreme Dad never decides to do the same thing, okay?
Extreme Dad Like I I'm just saying Vaush is always correct,
way ahead of his time. I pray that Extreme Dad does whatever
he has to to change his future. Vaush saw into his future. It's
not unchangeable, but like holy [__] you got to change
it, okay?
Cuz Jesus
It just by it's we're so lucky
Yeah, probably my guess is going to be less than 1% of drunk
drivers actually get into an accident. Unfortunately, in the
US a lot of people drunk drive.
That's true, but wait. Do more than 1% of aggressive or evil
chat comments get actioned on?
Do more than 1% of a streamer like laughing at somebody saying
something bad, like basically not denouncing a bad action, do
more than 1% of those get actioned on?
What is the Why would he make that differentiation? Oh, maybe
I I might actually be lost in this one. This might be Pisco's
bad argument. Hold on. Sorry.
It's higher versus This would be like in absolute terms it probably
increases the order of magnitude of accidents significantly.
So yes. And I would argue Denims not moderating the chat messages
versus moderating them, I don't think it's anywhere near that
significant an increase in risk.
Yeah, probably my guess is going to be less than 1% of drunk
drivers actually get into an accident. Unfortunately, in the
US a lot of people drunk drive.
Yeah, but wasn't Destiny just arguing the relative change is
what the big deal
I'd say it probably like 10x or 100x's or 1,000x's the risk of
getting in an accident, right? Drunk driving?
It's got at least 10 or 100x it, right?
But can can you clarify for me cuz it feels like you just stumbled
into that argument I made before, which is it's not about absolute
risk, it's about relative risk. It's that you're taking an action
that's going to it's significantly in
Destiny was wasn't he just arguing against the chance of something
happening, not just that the absolute risk of it happening is
high. No, no, I don't I don't know if that's true. So like suppose
that for for example, that you have Wow. a tiniest little sip
which I would say is a medium sip of wine, okay? You have now
just significantly increased the risk of a crash, right? But
you're just sober, right? You are sober. And so yeah, it's it's
the it's a significant increase in risk, but by all account it's
not significant enough such that you are in any danger whatsoever
of crashing more than like I don't know, you being tired on a
particular day or you having like a bad fight with a partner
on a given day. In that context In that context Wait, wait, wait.
I just want you to grant it, right? So in that
I would, but cuz I don't know if having a single sip of wine
does anything
No, no, no, but assume, right? That you've you've taken a sip
of alcohol such that it has significantly increased the risk
similar to the uh the Just say like five times the risk or something.
Just say like five times or whatever. of distraction from This
is actually helpful. 2% blood alcohol risk increased by about
three times, 5% or 0.5 0.05
seven times and okay, whatever. You're you're saying some You're
saying some stuff, okay. Similar to the risk of you know, having
2 hours less sleep than you would have, right? But you're still
good to drive under every normal standard. In that context, right?
Notwithstanding the increase in relative risk, you are not reckless,
right? You're not negligent.
Agreed? I disagree. You think you're recklessly driving if you
have like 2 hours sleep deprivation equivalent I'm somebody who
drove tired way too much in my casino
a 2-hour
a 2-hour sleep deficit. You're a little tired. But but you're
good to drive in compared to an old fart who is even on his best
day
You know what I'm saying?
I feel like we're hitting the limit of like on the fly hypotheticals
here where it's like I don't even know if either of these two
really understands what they're like trying to argue in this.
I feel like it's there. I get I get it a little bit, but it's
like can we Probably because we'd be looking at like things related
to
We're like hitting a little bit a little bit of like diminishing
returns in the on the fly hypothetical. Pisco's arguing that
Denims didn't increase the risk substantially enough that really
any penalty should follow. And Destiny disagrees. And you should
just go to say why you think that in the first place, right?
Why do you think Denims increased the risk like really substantially?
And honestly, I don't believe that I don't believe Destiny can
argue that in good faith and say she substantially increased
the risk in a way she she that she should be held culpable, held
liable, held responsible for this.
Unless he basically takes responsibility for a ton of his own
behaviors. It wouldn't be intent. There's another word you would
look here for, but like what is like for instance, you don't
need Like we would view somebody who who drank a little bit of
alcohol differently than somebody who maybe took an anti-allergy
medication versus somebody who maybe just didn't get quite enough
sleep. But I but we could look to the purpose of not having a
lot of sleep, right? So for instance, let's say somebody only
got like 2 hours of sleep and they went driving the next day
and it was because they were up all night taking care of their
kid who was crying versus somebody who only got 2 hours of sleep
because they were grinding the end of the Arc Raider season.
Do you think that we would hold one of these people more culpable
if an accident happened the next day? I think all else
Yes, I I think as between those two cases we would hold the person
who has the kind of the trivial reason for for staying up a little
more like we would treat them a little different.
I think it's hard to say exactly how you treat them differently.
It's like you probably in the public eye could see one one of
those people not being held as responsible, but in terms of like
the application of the law, I don't think the law takes like
differentiates a lot unless it's unavoidable, right? Unless for
some reason you had to drive. I would say
No, I think it goes in like did you have to drive? Right? It's
not like what it's not how much noble the reason was that made
you lose sleep. It was what is the reason you had to drive? Are
you just driving to work? Are you driving to the hospital cuz
your child had their throat cut and you're trying to like prevent
them from bleeding out? If you had to drive, then maybe I let
it go. But if you didn't have to drive, it was just a totally
optional thing. You could have taken a taxi and cost cost yourself
some money. Yeah. Definitely all else equal.
Um as between those two cases, which one would we see as more
culpable between two people who are relatively not culpable,
right? The question is would that situation, that is where you
have a minor sleep deficit, but not nearly the you know, to the
extent to which it would impair your driving to some kind of
normal standard of driving that we would all accept.
You need to have a threshold that's a risk. Just just decreasing
the relative risk. If you're an alien being who's optimal The
threshold I think the threshold will be relevant when we're talking
about like unintentionality, but for intentionality, I think
the threshold would basically completely
I'm thinking about skipping a little bit here cuz I don't care.
What was he saying? They're trying to isolate
basically like where you would actually get mad at somebody for
increasing the relative risk. And again, the standard Destiny
just proposed, which is if you intend if you intentionally want
to do something, which you'll never be able to do, right? Unless
you try to read intent. And Destiny's example of reading intent
in Denims is saying, "Well, she laughed about the event after,
so she wanted it to happen. She wants it to happen again."
If you apply the standard to Destiny, he basically is the reason
Charlie Kirk got shot. He basically is culpable for Charlie Kirk
being shot. So, it's a really disingenuous standard to apply,
one that he clearly doesn't believe in because he would never
say, "I'm responsible for the shooting of Charlie Kirk." Right?
He laughed at the firefighter getting shot. He made fun of anybody
who cared. He said he didn't care about that happening. And then
he continued to joke about it, right? For months and months and
months. And then Charlie Kirk got shot, and he laughed about
Charlie Kirk being shot. So, where in the world is he getting
off with trying to apply this standard? >> I was just like,
but then I like put like a little bit of dirt from the floor
on it or I step on it with my shoe or whatever. And like there's
there's no We would We would treat someone who intended it differently.
And that was that was that was my whole point in the stream that
you soyed out about and said I was a grifter. THAT WAS MY WHOLE
POINT. YOU JUST RESTATED IT.
What was your whole point? >> My whole point is we treat
so differently the intentional
acts of someone than the acts that even if they you know, imposed
an unjustifiable risk and they're culpable for that.
Yeah, this is the entire argument. Did Denims want CPS called
and was she explicitly explicitly reacting to this video to try
to get CPS called? Pisco's saying, "No, you can't possibly read
that into her actions." Destiny's going, "Yeah, obviously. Like
people in her chat literally said that CPS isn't even
It's like I We treat them so so differently. That was my point.
>> course. But the question is whether or not Denims should
have known that this behavior was going to result in this which
any reasonable person would say, "Of course you would know this.
Obviously." And you can tell that by reading into how they react
to the situation.
Uh I mean, I don't know that you can Does Denims strike you as
a person who is like conscious of Does she Does she strike you
as a bright
Don't
do that, Pisco. Just say there's just no reason to believe that.
Don't go, "Oh, well, maybe she's just
Please don't. Please don't. It's like the worst It's like the
worst argument.
Although I do appreciate if if Destiny actually spurts out again.
>> to know all the entailments of the kind of risky behavior
she does? I'm not sure, but maybe she is. But No, you're right.
Denims doesn't know every single possible thing that could result
from every single possible behavior. What I mean to say
Yo, hang on. THAT'S NOT WHAT I SAID.
I just I want anyone who thought I was like mean to Rally in
that conversation. Imagine if I was doing this to Rally. What
I mean to say
raped me. Yo, hang on. THAT'S NOT WHAT I SAID.
LET ME REPHRASE THIS IN A MORE LIKE reasonable human way. No,
your statement was ridiculous. Does Denims know that if she watches
a video No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. People thought you
Some people thought I was mean to Rally.
I was just saying if I like soyed out like this, like super hard
and just kept bringing it up over and over again, I feel like
that would be a bit much. Feel like I like stated my concern
and then video saying that Ethan's children are potentially dying
from diseases of negligence.
Is she aware that someone is going to call CPS? That's That's
the question, right? >> Do you think that she's Do you
think that she knows that that's like on the table, that she
could be pushing people in that direction? >> I don't know.
Do you know what's on the table, that when you dox people they
might get
Killing is possible. I think it's very very low. Is it Is it
on the table in the same way? Is it on the table in the same
way?
The Thank god Destiny's lawyer is on the call so that Destiny's
lawyer CAN SAY, "NO, NO, NO, HE DOESN'T BELIEVE THAT. HOLD ON.
SHUT UP. NO, NO, NO, NO, NO." DESTINY, DON'T SAY YES. >> YEAH, I
would say I would say in a way, but the intent in the response
I'm doing this in response. God damn it. Um what? Look, okay,
are we talking about recklessness or negligence? Because it's
not a question of if she knows, it's a question of if she should
know. All right? Reckless Recklessness is about if you should
know that what you were doing
Oh, is that So, that's a differentiator. Destiny Should Destiny
know the outcome of doxing people before he doxes them? Should
Denims know the outcome of not moderating her chat? Okay. Like
How That literally differentiated them 0%. Thank you.
Lawyer, thank you. What a great What What a addition. Thank you
so much. >> And it happened. That's it. We don't need to
show that she knew it or that she had had knowledge of it. And
she was
Should she have known that if you do stuff like that Well, this
is this is what I was saying earlier when I said we should agree
then that she It literally just applies to both of them. And
Pisco's entire question about, "Hey, if we apply this standard
to you, how would that go?" Still 100% relevant. Changed literally
nothing. Should have a Leave alone the fact that Destiny actually
did advocate for the people he was doxing to be killed as well.
Okay? Which Denims did not explicitly advocate for the harmful
thing to >> caretaker and shouldn't be allowed to stream
anymore if she cuz if you don't have certain levels of agency,
then you don't get certain rights and responsibilities, right?
Or or or privileges. So, should Denims have known that this is
a possibility? That That it's a possibility that it's say it's
that it's likely that as a result of her watching this video,
someone will um you know, do the actual CPS call.
Yeah, that or that she's at least increasing significantly the
odds of somebody She's increasing the risk such that it doesn't
meet a threshold, is Pisco's I think that she And he stated that
opinion over and over again, so I don't understand what the confusion
is. Like they literally perfectly laid out exactly how Pisco
is looking at it. He's saying it doesn't meet the threshold where
I believe she's done something significantly wrong or rises to
negligence or or recklessness. And you would have to give me
more information. >> know that she is given the size of
her stream that she is significantly increasing the risk. The
problem is As in significantly increasing the risk, but going
from 0.0001%
to 0.001%,
right? Which is probably somewhere along the lines of what her
actual contribution is. That's not a contribution. That's not
a significant contribution. I do think it's a small risk. And
unfortunately,
um you're going to >> a small risk like just like stepping
on a steak would be before serving it to a
Wait stepping on a >> a small risk of something that it's
not going to They're probably They're not going to notice probably
not, right? Well, hang on a second. But this is a malicious It's
not No, so so so so so so let's do it. Let's Let's Let's use
that example. Step on a steak, right? I agree not good, right?
The person So, it's a prank and they're stepping on the steak
because these they're like rude to the Nice. Pisco's going to
do the This is It's funny how it comes down to that rule versus
act utilitarianism thing. Cuz when I say something from a philosophical
standpoint, I'm never really totally
that I'm actually saying it correctly,
So, in this case, I was like, "Oh, it's like basically as a rule,
how bad is Denims' behavior?" It's not really that bad. And people
are acting like it's crazy cuz they're taking like an act utilitarian
perspective on it and saying, "Oh, it resulted in something really
bad, I think." Even though they can't really prove it. But it
is like that, right? As a rule, what Denims did is not very different
from what almost every streamer does so much of the time when
they have beef with other people. the service or whatever. Step
on the steak. They get a parasite and die, okay? Holy And and
and all of the Are you culpable for murder? Are you a murderer?
When you just thought you were like with this guy, are you a
murderer >> [__] servers are looking around
themselves and they're like, "What the fuck?" And the guy who
did the stepping raises his hand weakly and he's like, "Hi."
And then the question is, in that moment, you agree low risk
of really really really bad event. It happened. All right? Mhm.
How do you assess that person? Their culpability, right? Now,
it was absolutely
the culpable for them to do that conduct. But in reality, the
risk of the result happening was in absolute terms low. That's
the comparison I'm trying to make. Yes, but the thing that you
keep missing is that the we tie our moral culpability that you
have for failing your moral responsibilities, your moral obligations,
your professional obligations. We tie the harm that results from
the worst cases of people not following these responsibilities
to the failure to follow the responsibility. That's why when
you get a DUI,
you're getting it's a big charge. But why
Wait, but the DUI is like a really really really significant
absolute risk, right? When you get hit with a DUI, that's because
you could be increasing the likelihood like 10 or 15 times that
you're getting in a fatal accident. Well, so why do you get a
DUI? You might not even break any traffic laws. I I totally agree
that we should be like There are certain reckless conduct that
are felonies, right? Manslaughter is not like a minor thing.
Manslaughter is a felony, all right? So, there are absolutely
states of mind that are reckless that we There are some things
that you could do that are reckless that are worse than other
things you could do that are intentional, right? I would say
intentionally trying to pickpocket someone is better than drunk
driving, right? Now, in the case of the intentional act of >> Wait wait
real quick real quick. Funnily enough, those things tie into
where you have the greatest level of obligation, where you have
the greatest level of responsibility. The greater the responsibility,
the greater the obligation, probably the greater moral fault
by not following said >> maybe you would maybe you would
understand why when I'm talking to Hutch, I'm bringing up things
like risk. Is this a significant risk? Is this an insignificant
risk? But instead of you saying, "Huh." and trying to think,
"Maybe Maybe Pisco is getting at something here. Maybe it's actually
relevant to talk about the amount of risk and that will play
into how we factor about the ethical obligations." You took that
as yet another slimy debate tactic. But of course, the amount
of risk bears on the ethical question. It's not about the It's
not about the amount of risk. It's about the amount of unnecessary
risk. And especially the intentionality of the violation of the
obligation. Even if you know like I right now give like orders
to my chat to go and some person, and chances are of anybody
following through is probably less than 0.000001%.
But just the fact that you could issue the order like that. >> Yeah, so
any kind of No, I Because it's because that's a huge failure
of a
has a track
Okay. But Denims explicitly, we've already had this they keep
using analogies, right? Every time they go to an an analogy,
it's always this person explicitly said they wanted the thing
done. Why is every analogy disanalogous in the primary
attribute of the argument? As in what the heart of the argument
is, every analogy you use is disanalogous at the heart of the
argument.
That's so dumb to me.
It's like hypothetically, if you were like totally wrong and
then we like put it in a different scenario, but in that scenario
you were totally wrong, Pisco, how would you explain that? It's
like, well, you already you said you smuggled in as a condition
of the hypothetical that I'm wrong. Like, why are you doing that?
That like as a condition of the hypothetical, you've explicitly
advocated for the thing, but Denims didn't explicitly advocate
for the thing. So you're just like smuggling in a totally different
situation that's disanalogous at the heart of the >> SHE
HAS OBLIGATIONS to the chat to not be engaging in behaviors that
could get people swatted or CPS called. Let me give you a perfect
example, I think. Sandwich thrower, you know the sandwich thrower?
He got let off, all right, whatever. But the sandwich thrower,
he threw something at ice or national guard or whatever. And
let's say that he's throwing that sandwich with the intent to
kill the guy, all right? And you can prove that he threw the
now he's a like a diluted fool. Uh-oh, is it the Hamas is it
the Hamas moment? So long as Hamas has genocidal intent, the
war in Gaza must continue? With no capacity to wage war themselves,
they are still evil and need to be purged from this last >> or
he is like so incompetent that he has no comprehension that his
sandwich has exactly zero chance of killing this person, he does
it anyway. I'm going to treat that person as like an attempted
murderer, okay? So and or at a bare minimum, it's going to be
some significant significant penalty. Yeah, you didn't have a
gun there, but the only reason you didn't weren't successful
in killing them is because you're a stupid person that tried
to use a sandwich because you had like some notion that they
might be allergic to something or or whatever. You So I There's
like a there's like a mix of these two things that like There's
probably a system you could come up with, but I think it's
When there's no real significant risk, I don't think you quite
look at them as a murderer. You look at them as like a Dude,
like a risk to themselves almost. Like somebody like that who
wants to kill someone so they throw a sandwich. Like that person's
not able to evaluate the world correctly. Maybe there's a better
example where someone's able to evaluate the world correctly.
It seems like they're really missing >> Absolutely take
the view that intentional conduct
I'm an intention I I've said it always that intention to me is
the most important thing. That is why that is why I was making
this point. So absolutely, if you could show that Denims conscious
object was to make the CPS call happen, I think that that's a
lot easier case than the kind of statements that have been shown.
Those statements absolutely downplaying, those statements absolutely
unjustifiable. Those In the same way by the way, I think that
some of your jokes and other people's jokes sometimes are unjustified.
I'm not saying that they're the same thing. I'm not saying they're
the exact same thing, but I will take issue with with certain
things. But like I don't think when you're calling
uh you know, making certain jokes about Corey Compatore, making
certain jokes about victims, I don't think that you want them
to die, right? I would defend you and I have defended people
like who Rob Morrow have accused you of saying that you want
Republicans to die, right? You don't want Republicans to die,
do
Hello? No, but what's the difference? >> The difference
is it's not your conscious object to make them die. Now I just
want them to be super afraid that they're going to die. Someone
might look at your comment and say okay. We're also not if if
somebody called CPS on Ethan and like Denims and CaseyTron and
all them, it's hard to separate because these communities are
so toxic, but if they just laughed at that fact, then it would
be gross, disgusting, whatever.
But let's say that again, to make the the reason why your analogies
are so mind Okay.
So admitting that he is gross or >> and the daughter one's
a good example too. It's because you're you're erasing the part
where they are watching something that is driving the behavior.
If I was watching video after video, if I was talking about like
this is one reason I don't do even though I like
Video did Denims watch multiple videos like video after video
on Ethan's kid kids eating dog [__] or was there
like one video that she watched? Is there like a ton more evidence
that we're unaware of? Cuz he just did another thing where he's
smuggling in a thing that didn't happen here. Right? She was
watching video after video after video. Well, she I think she
watched one video. >> Guys, I don't tell me guys we need
to get our we need to start training. And then he goes like don't
ask us like two weeks later should we start harming and training
like that increases the risk of a whole bunch of bad [__]
I don't I usually don't put I don't think I've ever pushed people
in this direction. But like if we were watching videos on like
best ways to conservatives, best ways to intervene so 911 can't
get to people in time. But if I was watching videos Was Denims
watching that video on how best to call CPS and use government
functions to [__] up uh Ethan Klein's life? Is this
Someone got shot and killed and then I started laughing and making
jokes about Like would you not look at me and go like, are you
like hoping that somebody you're Would you not look at me and
even if I'm not >> I I would treat you differently. I I
would treat you differently if that versus current facts, all
right? So I'm just giving you what you want. I absolutely I would
I would So Pisco's like hypothetically in that world, yeah, I
would treat you differently. And Denims needs to like cool, so
we agree I'm right. I think I think Hutch would also do differently
as well, right? So Hutch is somebody who's very critical of my
jokes and all this cuz he's a soy [__] What dude?
Oh, Pisco's Pisco had a Hutch moment. Pisco's literally trying
to get a word in, Desi just keeps sperging and sperging and sperging.
>> I think I think Hutch would also do differently as well,
right? So Hutch is somebody who's very critical of my jokes and
all this cuz he's a soy liberal, whatever. That's fine, okay?
He's
Dude, when will this guy stop sperging
Just just spastically motor mouthing out as much as he can. Pisco's
like, hey, you literally just let me talk for 2 seconds, dude.
Like come on. >> But I think I could be wrong, but I think
that Hutch would have a much more negative view of me if I was
in my chat saying like, okay guys, how are we getting the next
conservative? Like let's theory craft. Like what are some sick
what are the best guns, the best load outs? Like how do we not
go? Like it would be So again, did Denims do any of this? No.
So if you had evidence of this, it would change Pisco's mind,
but you haven't presented any evidence of this happening. You
just keep making things up over and over again, over and over
again, over and over again.
Like is this guy capable of
Like honest to god, is he at least better when he debates conservatives
Or is he like this all the time? Cuz I feel like at some point
I'm going to start taking it personally that I once thought this
guy had something compelling to say and I feel more I feel worse
and worse about that every single day anytime I hear him speak.
Literally anytime I hear him speak, I'm like, I thought this
guy was compelling at some point. And it like actually makes
me feel physical disgust.
But I but like he has to be able to make arguments at other times.
It it has to be the case. Way way way way way worse. But you
but the thing is like I I agree that to the extent that there's
no facetiousness there cuz there's there's actually jokes and
there's kind of like ambiguous things, right? And we want we
want to avoid the situation where it's just like obvious conspiracy
or obvious attempt, right? And so we're putting out that one.
So you're giving a kind of example where it's on the margin and
it's unclear whether it's a joke, right? Cuz if it's very clearly
a joke, then even the pre-joke conduct, you're not really going
to you're not going to say that there's like major culpability
there, right? And
Thinks it's gross  disgusting to joke about the CPS call
after it happened, but not about drowned children in Texas. Didn't
he say Republicans need to be more afraid that violence will
happen to them? Yeah, it's uh Yeah, it's like obviously these
would be the points. Maybe it's
Like I
Obviously these are the points and I'm just curious why Destiny
doesn't understand that he's like stepping on rakes right now
and why I do think absolutely Pisco needs to be more aggressive
about just applying the standard back on Destiny's behavior.
Like you it literally should just be mirror emoji until Destiny
escapes the mirror emoji, right?
Like Like that is the only way you should be able to you should
be arguing this right now in my opinion. Mirror emoji. Oh, you
think you think it's really bad that Denims laughed at jokes?
Mirror emoji. Mirror emoji, mirror emoji, mirror emoji until
like we're like respond to it. Respond to it. Sorry. Hold on,
where's the Z Z [__] No, no, no, not that one.
I missed It do It do be like that, Mr. Stancel. There we go.
Let's do those jokes, but I mean you'd be on no different terms
than what the Republicans are accusing you of. Now I disagree
No, wait, I would say no. I disagree. I would say there was major
moral fault, yes. And when we talk about when we talk about Yes,
but when we talk about like negligence or or rather when I'm
sorry, when we talk about recklessness, that's why there was
that clip I sent you earlier. That's why when I see my chat saying
some I don't wait I don't just stop talking about it or I don't
just like change a little bit the way I talk about it. I will
very clearly say, hey, don't [__] people even even
fascists. We don't kill people for differences of political opinion
in the United States of America. We don't do that here. I It's
not There's no [__] guesswork there unless you've
just seen a clip of me.
But we just want them to be a little scared. They should be like
a little more scared. Like maybe not the worst that they're a
little more scared. There's no guesswork. Mhm. No, I I mean like
I understand that there are distinctions between different kinds
of conduct that could be an issue. And the examples that you're
providing, again, these are distinctions that I think Yeah, so
his the the real understand thing Sorry. The thing you need to
understand here, Tequila Sunset, is that Destiny is not a vile
disgusting [__]
that can't be trusted. So that's what Denims is. She's a vile
disgusting [__] that can't be trusted. And so when
she says don't tap the glass, it makes no sense, it's like horrible
to do. Obviously we don't advocate for that here. Right? When
she says that, she's lying. And that's proven by her joking after
the fact. When Destiny says don't do it, it's because he actually
means don't do it. And when he laughs about it after the fact
and consistently does exactly what he says encourages the thing,
it's actually like
it's implied that he still disavows it after the joke, even if
he doesn't say so. Like every time he jokes about it, he still
is like actually disavowing.
And it's just like it's basically in essence like Denims was
born that way and Destiny was born as the person that it's like
always just a joke, but but like never take him seriously. And
when he jokes about it, he's not ever encouraging it. But Denims
is. >> do matter in terms of how we assess the the relative
risk of them. The only thing I'm saying is that someone pointing
to an increase in risk and awareness of risk, right? You would
grant that like you calling these people fascists, you calling
these people, you crazy people who want to take over the country,
that does increase the risk, right? It's mitigated by some of
the things that you're saying, right? No, no, it can increase
the risk. I I accept all the increase of risk as long as my analysis
is accurate and my positions are And if it's the And if And if
it's the case if it's the case that for example, you made everything
you said but you didn't have the condemnations of violence, let's
say. And someone ends up someone else, you're going to perhaps
responsibility culpability for failure to moderate. Maybe if
there's enough of a like of a showing that there's a causal connection
between you and what actually occurred and terms of they came
from your community and maybe they're directly linking what you
say to why they did it. Maybe you would imply even some like
negligent or reckless culpability with respect to the completed
act itself or that result, but I guess I I want to break Just
real quick cuz you keep getting really hung up on this causal
chain. I don't care about necessarily the causal chain. I care
about the factors and if they would be like if they would transfer
or not. So for instance, let's say somebody Somebody You said
they mentioned things you said, but let's say they didn't. But
let's say that all of them they Somebody and let's say that they
did a whole manifesto and they planted a whole bunch of stuff
that Josiah said, right? I think that we're pretty in alignment
on a lot of things, right? And I see that I say a lot of similar
things. I would start to I would Well, I mean it's hard because
I don't think me or Josiah necessarily encourage violence. Um
That's That's the Republicans' characterization. Now I Again,
I'm not adopting that characterization. Let's say that sure.
No, no, hold on. I'm not I'm not cuz that characterization is
not true. The facts are different. But like let's say that me
and Josiah were really on this like Merrick Garland needs to
Are they different? Somebody's got to find this guy and take
Are they different than the So again, what if me and Josiah were
like explicitly trying to hint at taking action, which we haven't
proven Denims has done ever, but what if we were like explicitly
saying action should be taken? So he's again once a He's once
again made it totally disanalogous in the primary
the primary
disagreement. Like it's it's literally the place the disagreement
is he's made it disanalogous. He's smuggled in that Pisco's wrong
from the beginning of the hypothetical again.
I Do you think he's unaware that he's doing this? I
kind of say it and Josiah says it and then somebody does this
manifesto and they write Well, Josiah said this thing. Even though
they did they weren't from my community and me they might have
even said like I've never I'm not subscribed to anybody but Josiah.
I would feel a level of like okay guys that we don't do this,
right? Cuz I see how it contributes to that. But that would be
like an outcome that I cuz I don't want people people for their
for just the difference of political means. I want to make that
known. But that's not going to prevent me from doing an accurate
political analysis. People might People because they're trans
or because Well, it's not going to stop him from joking about
it, too, which according to him when Denims does is
they're fascist or because they're whatever. Bro, I'm I'm going
to stop doing an accurate analysis. I'm going to try to make
the people know I can. Yes. And And if there's a person who keeps
on promoting anti-vaxism by talking about his personal situation
and keeps on you know, you know, talking about how he's
over by CPS calls, unfortunate CPS calls, you might continue
to say don't call CPS, but but you're going to continue covering
his content and saying hey, like this is dangerous. Like the
anti-vaxer is wrong and all the examples of his own kids' health,
they're not right. Not with You're going to see the risk, right?
It's already happened. The CPS call for the the vaxers in my
hypothetical, they've already happened. You put out a statement
that says, hey, I don't want you to call CPS. I would never call
CP
Just talk. Your community is a good example of this behavior.
Okay, thanks. >> Yes, don't do it. But you're not going
to stop doing the thing
or substantiate if you like, but you >> that will increase
the risk in that context, fair?
That you're going to keep calling out the anti-vaxer even though
they have the CPS call and it already happened. It's been demonstrated
and you Uh this guy is like um a DGGer. He's probably just going
to start getting really really upset in the chat.
Be gentle with him. He's having a rough couple days.
Okay? Just be gentle. >> like I Yeah. No, sorry. When I
said bye, I was just like saying okay. I assume when most of
these people get their chat messages read, they leave. So I just
kind of assumed he would leave, but we'll see. >> because
it's going to vary from example to two example, but like there
there are worlds where I will moderate the unfortunately
Really? There's no way. There's no way. No, no. Don't buy this.
>> Absolutely is. No, I absolutely do because it especially
because my community is 90/10 men and a lot of the communities
that for politicals are 90/10 men. There are a lot of criticisms
that I don't necessarily lean into as hard on when it comes to
certain dating things or women things or whatever the [__]
because I know that
the community will take it a certain way. Or back back in the
gaming days, I think there was a lot of really cringe
That's what Destiny's known for for like totally letting up on
people, right? Totally letting up on people, not not going hard
on them even when there's like a downside. For sure, I think
so. >> streamer whatever And but like if I make any of
these comments known publicly, there's 90 million incels in my
comments that are like alongside me. No matter how much I had
you, no matter how much I try to like cut that they're always
going to show up and weaponize as arguments. So at some point
I'm like [__] it. I don't I don't think I will. Unfortunately,
I I think even in that sense. But I But I would I would say that
maybe that's going too far. I just for whatever reason I don't
necessarily need to do
People in the chat are joking about feeding their pets copious
amounts of cheese and I want everyone to know that I disavow
that reference to Ethan Klein feeding his dog a lot of cheese,
okay? I disavow that reference. That's snarking.
Snarking is unacceptable. Do not snark.
Quit snarking. >> But you acknowledge we're like levels
and levels and levels away from Denims' behavior. Well, I mean
like I don't know, man. I think that this is not a big risk.
These kinds of like reactions to All else equal, they don't seem
very risky. And you can show me evidence of It's not about risk.
It's about intent. Is there a single time I'm just curious and
maybe there's a couple of times that Is there a single time where
Denims says seriously
It's It's about intent. Remember every time Hutch tried to show
intent and every time Destiny tried to show intent, they massively
overstated what happening in the what Sorry, they massively overstate
what happens in the clip.
And then they cope about it afterwards, right? They massively
overstate every bad element of the clip and then they cope and
try to like just go Oh, are you serious? You don't believe that,
Pisco? You don't believe that this is her like celebrating right
now?
And Pisco like infinitely good faith
goes Wait, do you want to change it to like Oh, she minimized
and then maybe we could like try to have this conversation again.
They're like No, she celebrated.
She's She's endorsing. She wants it to happen again. >> Guys,
the CPS stuff, we don't do this. This is not cool here. I That's
what was That's what I thought I That's what I remember seeing.
So I'm just saying I remember seeing something like that. I just
don't And this isn't me being weaselly. I don't have instant
recall of this the condemnation that was there. I thought I remember
seeing that. So >> the video earlier you were saying things
like well, you need to be able to justify your assertions blah
blah blah, but I'm No, but no, but No, but my assertion isn't
My assertion isn't that I know her conduct to you know, to be
a thing or not. I I'm just saying what I've been seeing so far
doesn't justify the lawsuits. That's a separate We haven't even
reached that. But all I'm trying to say is regardless of your
thoughts about this and you seem to take a view which I mean
I guess it's like more protective of your
Does anyone have the full song In My Dreams? I kind of wanted
to start playing it and I can't find it now. >> More responsible
for your community and in some ways I think that's in line with
stuff you said before. In some ways I think people could argue
that it's maybe inconsistent, but I'm not going to get into that
right now. Regardless of your thoughts about who's right here,
do you actually get the culpability in the way that you know,
Steven says or in the way I say? This is an honest disagreement.
It's not that I want to promote Hasan. It's not that I want to
[__] support snarkers. It's not that I want to support
Just Talk community. statements Sure. They were state I I'm happy
you brought it back there cuz it's like Okay, even if he's like
being pedantic with Hutch, how is that him supporting my community
or something? What part of that is Where is he supporting my
community there? That doesn't make That make any sense. Yeah,
Pisco's always said it that way. I know. Thank you to my god
beard level man
All right. See you later.
On September 16th
I
my dog
a dream
in a dream the dream I fed him too much
He [__] out his brains. brains And then he passed
away. passed away But only But only in my dream my dream
And then coincidentally,
my real dog died on that very same day, but that had nothing
to do with me. I only
him in my dream. So many dreams about canine,
but I don't do that stuff in real life. In real life I love puppies.
I only
them
my dreams
only Oh my god. I I so hard. That is so hard to hit, okay? >> my
dreams Oh my god.
in my dreams
Bro, that doesn't work at 1.25. I'm sorry. only
In my Tesla you will find so many skeletons of canines,
but that has nothing to do with me. My ops put them there to
frame me. My brain is like Jekyll and Hyde
By the way, by the way, just to be clear, Ethan Klein said this
was like justifying all kinds of hatred against him. This clear
joke, this clearly incredibly funny joke.
Uh my god.
Love this Ryan Beard guy. He's so awesome. I'm sorry. I got to
cut it there. I can't listen to the whole thing. But
And maybe I don't know. You should You should ask actually cuz
maybe I'm just Maybe I missed this. It truly felt to me like
you said Denims had absolutely zero culpability for the CPS call.
She might have small culpability just for not moderating her
chat for some weird reason that was never articulated that well
to me. I didn't feel like Denims like you felt that Denims >> or Casey
Tron or any of these people that they had any moral culpability
for placing the call.
What I meant by that >> happening for the call happening.
>> Okay. So, if if I said that that isn't what I meant
to say. If I said that, I promise you that's not what I meant
to say. I of course would never deny the notion of
ethical responsibilities with respect to non-intentional conduct.
I of course think that you have a responsibility to moderate
your community. That's why I established rules. You know, those
rules that I'm establishing What is your responsibility though?
Why do you have the rules? Or why do you have that? Yeah. One
aspect and that's why I'm not like joking when I say this is
for self-protection. That I was just being honest when I say
like
I know but when So, you would acknowledge that the one of the
first rationales of why I do it is to protect myself to make
sure that no one can make the accusation that I'm not doing anything
because and then I I I I know I >> like a private payment.
We're asking for the morals. No, but but hang on a second. I
think that protecting yourself from things that where you you
don't intend it, that actually is an ethical obligation you have
to yourself. I think you want to have obligations to themselves.
Nobody thinks like this.
I do. I [__] do. My point is My point is that that
that is not an indication of bad faith. Just to be clear, just
to be clear, you do not think like this. If somebody would ask
you why I'm maybe you can buy the bonus. If somebody say why
shouldn't you somebody, would you say as part of the first thing
you say well, you don't want to get arrested, right? Okay. In
that example, no, I wouldn't. In that example, I would lead with
the harm done to others. That Okay, but I can't explain to you
why my mind in one situation comes up with the rationales for
something first or another. And I'm asking you please have >> don't
think what you did is that bad. That's why. No, no, no. So, you're
you're saying that because the first thing that comes into my
head, you're reading into that to say that I'm trying to protect
Denims from her conduct, whatever it is. Yes. Okay. And and the
evidence of that is because if I didn't, I would have brought
up the other the harm and potential risk to others. Even though
I acknowledge that before that statement is made, I acknowledge
the risk factor. That's what's so absurd about this whole thing
is the notion that This is what you do to kill a sunset. The
reason he does this is because he knows that if there's over
like 500 people in the chat, he now has a majority of people
who will have some sort of sympathy for him, right? And I think
there's around 2,500 or 3,000 people in this. It's like obviously
going to be mostly his fans who are watching at this point, right?
And he just knows that he can signal to
and the chat will think he's correct. And he thinks that it makes
him correct. It doesn't.
But he he believes it does, right?
So, he'll often say like oh well, a normal person thinks this.
This is like the same guy who tells you that like he totally
he totally hides all of his social media presence from like the
women he and then it comes out who he's and it's all social media
influencers, right? Or people who are in his community.
Like it's just he he just lies all the time. He doesn't even
care about what he's saying. He'll use any argument he can to
be right. That's all he cares about. Again, the Vaush soul read
was entirely correct. >> I was ever establishing the my
view that like somehow there are no norms in moderation that
there are no such things as obligations with respect to negligent
or reckless conduct. It's just bizarre that you think that I
would have thought that and that you didn't hear me making this
point. Maybe I didn't do it as clearly, whatever, but I'm asking
people to have some amount of grace in when I'm making these
arguments and I'm not going out there to say the only thing that's
ever bad are things that are intentional. I mean, do you do you
really think I thought that?
No, that's why I accuse you of being bad faith. But it felt like
that was the only answer you gave.
Okay. Can somebody link me the clip? I really want to hear I
wish I could remember the exact word you used. It was like when
there's a when there's like a non-trivial hurdle to moderation
you should avoid active both things. >> this is what I
recall. So, what I recall was Hutch asked a question like do
you have a duty to moderate when people
And Pisco said yes, you have a self-standing obligation to moderate
your chat. >> Basically say to call CPS, right? And I I
thought about it for a little bit. I'm like I think that you
should moderate calls for CPS. I do agree with that. But I'll
ask you, do you think you should moderate >> no, hold on.
I just want to be clear. You can say this to me but I just want
to be clear that's not what I was trying to You gave an answer
that was the most
syntactically crafty answer I've ever heard to avoid committing
yourself to any sort of moral obligation. That was essentially
just saying like as long as it's not a big deal or not too difficult,
you should moderate bad [__] so that you don't get
banned. That was that was the the substance of your answer. I
didn't If somebody finds a clip of it later but we can move on
to the next thing. Go ahead. Okay. I mean what I'm trying to
do is
these accusations are made that I'm adopting arguments that I
don't really believe, that I'm being influenced into becoming
you know, one thing or the other, that I'm specifically with
bad intent trying to do one thing. And listen, you all can have
the opinion that you want. What I want to say though is it's
totally unjustified. I have been a lib capitalist through and
through. I'm on a show called No, because you say that I'm appealing
to tankie audiences. That's what you say to your audience. where's
the responsibility for that?
statement here doesn't do anything to vindicate you, right? Of
course you're going to say that you don't do these things. It
doesn't mean anything, right? >> but but do you believe
that I'm trying to appeal to the snarkers?
You believe it. Yes. Okay. And that's based on your on your divine
revelation.
Well, it's That's literally what he said. He said I'm not going
to try to prove this. I'm just going to say it and it's based
on divine revelation. I know so much. I'm so smart. That's how
he decided that I was doxing people is how he decided Queen was
doxing people. It's just all divine revelation, okay?
And he thinks it's like a joke, but it's not a joke. That's literally
the argument he's making. That's the argument he's going with,
dog.
He just makes this argument and then he pretends that that's
like a joke. No, no, no. You haven't proven [__]
Dude, it's crazy.
He's don't Hold on. I'm going to pull this back up. >> here
doesn't do anything to vindicate you, right? Of course you're
going to say that you don't do these things. It doesn't mean
anything, right? >> But what's but but do you believe that
I'm trying to appeal to the snarkers?
You believe it. Yes. Okay. And that's based on your on your divine
revelation.
So So, like basically he's argued Pisco is like with Hutch. And
that must be because he wants to appeal to snarkers and or protect
a snarking community as in what he's referring to is the J's
Talk community.
So Okay. Like you could make that argument, I suppose.
Just with I guess and he has like no evidence. That that doesn't
make any sense by the way. Like it doesn't make any sense. It
makes no sense. My community is not big enough to appeal to over
his. My community doesn't make money. If Pisco is going to
appeal to somebody, why wouldn't he just disingenuously appeal
to the
to the Destiny community, right?
Where he already has a ton of overlap, a ton of buying from people.
If he was going to grift, why wouldn't he just grift to the community
that he could easily just co-opt? Or H3? Yeah, or H3. Bro, there's
so much money in the Hasan
in the Hasan bad stuff. And Hasan is bad sometimes. But just
like there is a demand for Hasan is bad content that the supply
can't possibly keep up with.
It's like free money for anyone.
Well, it's based on the unfathomable logic that you employ in
your conversation with >> I just explained it. Do you not
believe that my explanation? I mean, this doesn't seem like what
I what are >> here Well, I'm waiting Well, I'm curious.
Well, can you tell me cuz I didn't remember hearing an answer
at all yesterday. It was low cost of compliance. That was the
phrase you used. So, why is he Why is it bad Yeah, why do you
have a duty to moderate your chat? >> of reasonable care,
which is what negligence is is
sort of pinned to, the reasonableness relates both to the sense
of the risk and the cost of mitigation, all right? So, there
are things that you can always do to reduce risk, all right?
You could pad yourself up in a million different pillows and
Oh, you think dude I'm sorry. It's like
I I trust me. I used to be the number one in in Destiny's community.
I used to like A log Hasan's content. It's incredibly fun. I
find Hasan incredibly funny to make fun of, okay?
I do. I find him incredibly funny to make fun of and we go back
and forth and like like we do jokes. There'd be like a woman
on stream be like Cherry. I Cherry made this joke like a couple
times but how like Hasan was really gorgeous, right? And it's
like I get how people would say that. I get how
You know what I'm saying? Like we would we would try to keep
it a little balanced in some ways. Like oh, that's exactly how
he gets away with all of this. He's just like a gorgeous human
being who's like 7 ft tall and Yeah, no, it wasn't a joke. But
it's
We try to keep it a little balanced
if we're going to go and like A log him. And now it's just like
people who are like he's evil. He's the worst. He's the He's
like unbelievably evil. It's like I don't know, man. He just
seems like seems like kind of narcissistic, kind of like a diva.
And when you put those things together, he'll not admit he's
done things wrong, but I don't see the difference between him
and a lot of other big streamers. And like make sure that So,
when I So, when I said when I said cost of compliance, when I
say compliance cost, there you might not believe me, but explicitly
what I'm invoking is the notion that part of the assessment of
what constitutes reasonable risk relates to how much it costs
for a person. Like you would never say that Denims the starter
of her stream to say I condemn this, I condemn that, I condemn
Hasan, I condemn Bad Bunny. I condemn like you would never say
that she has has run through a thousand trillion throat clearers
and it's an infinite amount of things,
Well, here wait. Can you I'm just curious. Can you watch some
This is This is actually true also, Kathy.
I unfortunately I started stocking on Hasan when it was like
a noble pursuit, okay? It was like a noble pursuit. Hasan got
really mad at my stuff. He would specifically address it directly.
He knew who I was. And then a whole bunch of other people started
doing it. And then it was like, oh, everybody's doing it. And
they're also like getting really inaccurate in the way they're
doing it. They're starting to like make things up. They're starting
to way over embellish things. They're starting to say things
are true that aren't true. And I was like, oh,
I don't think I can do this anymore.
I think I don't think I can do it anymore. And by the way, I
was the guy who argued that like, hey, we should get Hasan to
think that like DGG got him kicked out of the
the what do you call it? The DNC. Cuz he didn't get kicked out,
by the way.
I was like, oh, it'd be funny if he thought DGG did it. I never
advocated to get him kicked out. But it was like it would be
funny. So like I'm totally fine with like sciopping the guy.
But I never
I never wanted to like lie about him and make him seem worse
than he was. I just wanted to laugh at his, you know, his behavior
that was funny. >> Somebody like me This is what you get
as an answer. Okay, I just see if it's Is Kafka still in here?
I am, yes.
That's weird. No, it's not weird. It's super funny. He would
blame DGG for everything. And I thought that was over embellishment,
okay? So I thought it'd be funny if he blamed DGG for that.
But it was like a it was like two second thing. And by the way,
I said that would be funny to do explicitly knowing that if I
wanted to do it, I would have to go get someone to do it in private.
I was like I was just running through a hypothetical of what
would be funny in my head. Okay, here. Pass this along.
Can you answer that question? I will. Yes, I heard you. Yes,
I heard you. What's the point of What's the point of moderation?
There's self-standing obligations to moderate to reduce risk
that, you know, a streamer I think has it's where it's there's
a low cost of compliance and where there are obvious potential
Yeah, it's like Destiny be sitting here arguing that enjoying
the downfall of your ops is the same as advocating for whatever
caused their downfall, even if it's like horrible. Like when
Coach Redpill died,
it's like Destiny finding that funny that he died while being
like a totally disingenuous grifter in Ukraine. Destiny finding
that funny must be him saying all of these people should die
or something. It's like totally insane, right? You could just
find it funny that something bad happened to your op and still
go, oh, actually I don't think that should happen, though.
Which obviously he understands cuz it's obviously how he was
with Charlie Kirk. Or maybe Well, no, he actually was less obvious.
He's like less obvious than Denims about it. Like Denims is obviously
acting with moral with more moral clarity than Destiny does in
those cases. Destiny Sorry, Denims says, well, I don't think
you should ever do this. I don't think you should tap the glass.
I don't think you should ever get
Right? Exactly. Exactly, Ryle. Yes.
No, I mean
No, I mean no. No.
benefits to a low cost compliance incident. The fact that you
have a self-standing obligation to mitigate risk. I'm going to
repeat it, make sure you hear it. So I'm going to say it
That you violated your duty to moderate does not mean you are
culpable for actions that underlie it.
So what part of that did Destiny disagree with? >> Yeah,
that's very consistent with what I just said. Okay, so you said
that He wasn't following. Oh, no.
Bro, his chat This is the issue is he got rid of so much of like
the opposition in his chat that it really is like a cult.
And when when he says something, everybody just tells him he's
correct. He doesn't get any pushback.
People just say he's correct.
Like that has to be what's going on, right? Like he he weaves
in a bunch of [__] that makes no sense.
Cuz there's just no possible way
that he heard what Pisco just said and and actually thinks that
means Pisco says you don't really have that much you're not responsible
for anything that happens in your chat. You don't really have
to do anything. You only have to moderate to us.
It's something about like if a stream if the action has a the
risk a streamer faces has a low cost of compliance and there's
an obvious benefit to the low cost of compliance, there's a self-standing
obligation to mitigate
>> Yeah, it's What risk were you talking about? So so the
risk relates to the likelihood that some crazy person is going
to do something crazy.
Pisco is saying you should say I disavow. You should moderate
the people who say call CPS, someone should call CPS right now.
That's what he That's what Pisco is saying, that you should do
that. You ought do that.
But the failure to follow through on that ought is not enough
to say, okay, you did CPS. Okay, you're responsible for what
happened. You should mitigate the risk cuz it costs you nothing.
Costs you very little compared to what you make streaming. But
the failure to do so is not like some massive failing.
Especially depending on what it is. Okay, wait. If there if you
Why would you have an obligation
to mitigate that risk, but then not be culpable for the actions
that happen if you fail to moderate You could just make it more
extreme in how unlikely it is to happen. Like if if somebody
in your chat was like, we should set off a nuclear bomb in New
in New York City right now,
and you didn't disavow that cuz you thought it was totally insane,
and then it happened,
well, you have like the moral obligation to tell them not to
set the bomb off, but do you have a reason to believe that that's
going to happen? Do you do you really believe that they're going
to set that Like you're not culpable for the bomb being set off,
right? You just make it more absurd. So so like the concept obviously
works. We're just quibbling over where the line is. I I don't
know how many analogies we need to go through to get this. mitigate
that risk.
So it it it depends what you mean by culpable. So when I use
culpable in that sense, it relates to an ethical violation, not
to the result independent of itself. If you say It is an ethical
violation, though, right? If you fail
she's ethically responsible for failing to moderate the chat.
He's not ethically responsible for the
What I'm referencing, though, is when it comes to culpability,
isn't the result in and of itself. It's what what you the act,
by which I mean the intentional volitional malicious act, that's
what you're not culpable for. When I'm talking about culpability,
it isn't a kind of naked result. It's culpable with respect to
not just an outcome, but the state of mind and the improper
Oh, there's another one right there. Yes. So you pull up that
Tekton clip and people are like, someone call the FBI. Do I actually
think someone's going to call the FBI on Tekton? Probably not.
Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
But Tekton's talking about like what a 9-year-old's feet taste
like. Kind of weird, man. But I don't think somebody's going
to actually try to swat him or call the FBI. I don't think that's
actually happening. >> For moral fault. That's what I'm
talking about with respect to culpability. Okay, I just want
to ask Okay, then I just want to ask for this, okay? When Hutch
said that you are culpable for what a person does, do you think
that Hutch literally meant Let's say that you say something and
a person goes There's always somebody who hasn't seen the clip.
Tequila Sunset, hit him with the tweet now. on first degree murder
means in actuality that a transubstantiation
occurred in your body morphed into place of another person, you
also are guilty of the crime of first degree murder, that you
did the exact same thing. Do you think that's what Hutch I think
he means I think he means moral fault, right?
But moral fault You have an obligation to prevent the risk of
Moral fault with respect to a moral obligation, correct?
Yes, but the moral obligation is tied to the potential risk.
Sure. No, no, no, no, but it but it doesn't exist independent
of the mindset. That's what I'm saying. Moral obligation exists
not just in the result, but in the actual it it it must by necessity
include the state of mind. Otherwise, it might not even be a
moral obligation, right? You don't have a moral obligation independent
of the state of mind, right? So So that's what I meant. That's
what I meant. You said it might Sure, but you said it might exist
out there somewhere. I'm glad you clarified. You said it might
exist out there somewhere, but can you honestly recall off the
top of your head I'm not going to push you for clips like you
did to Hutch, okay? Like you did for me earlier. Can you honestly
recall a time where Denims was sincerely
and act and deliberately talking to her chat and intentionally
saying like, guys, we don't engage in this type of
Yeah. I can. I literally have it. Oh, not here, but I have the
I have the timestamp. I already pulled it up on this stream to
show that it happened. Right? And Destiny's basically only operating
off of the fact So Okay.
Destiny says this. Is it not super obvious to the people who
are in the middle here somewhere? Rebuttal Ryan Beard song, yeah.
I could I could listen
every single time Destiny makes a claim, every single time Hutch
makes a claim, they're trying to defend H3, they are overstating
the truth. They are overstating what they what the actual factual
reality is. Every time. Have you ever seen Denims do this? Yeah.
Uh Well, why don't we find a clip? Yeah, we can find a clip.
The clip exists. I was posting the clip in Pisco's Discord at
this point, right? Of her rejecting
Her saying no, it's bad.
I don't understand how Destiny could possibly push back against
that because his entire thing is, well, I can joke about this
stuff, but I always break it down and say, no, no, no, I totally
disavow it, seriously.
And I don't know what what he means I don't know how he pushes
back against this at all.
Um I don't I remember the one time where she after it happened
where she said, um you know, I never called it and it's not good.
That's what I recall. I don't remember the exact words she used.
>> called it and it's not good. I don't remember the I'm
telling you right now. I remember the exact words. It's don't
tap the glass. >> I thought that she condemned it and I
thought I saw that clip. It's possible that it's more weaselly
language. I'm not saying that that's not true. That's what I
recall. Okay, wait. And like you know what? I'll grant this.
I'll grant all that, okay? If that clip didn't exist or if it
only came after a ton of public backlash or lawsuit threat or
whatever else, if it came like two months ago, okay?
Sure. Would that Wait. Wait. Would it change your mind for the
recklessness? No, cuz I've already granted that.
Oh, wait. So you granted her behavior is you agree that it was
already at the reckless thing. >> Yeah. Does Okay, then
I won't even bother to argue a higher higher standard. Why doesn't
recklessness
grant some moral culpability to the person who engaged in the
reckless behavior? Yes, I That that was our whole conversation.
You missed the part where I said, "Yes, she's culpable for the
things she actually did."
Did you not >> but for the things that result for the things
that result from those things. >> just You're just not
understanding what I mean by culpable. What I mean by culpable
isn't indexed to just the result by itself. When I say culpable,
it includes some notion of moral fault fault, which is indexed
to a state of mind. You don't have I'll just say it. You don't
have But the moral fault is also indexed to the potential harms
that result from the failure to adhere to the obligation. No,
no, no, I agree
I No, I I agree that it it it's related to the obligation. And
but the moral fault is also indexed to the potential harms that
result from the failure to adhere to the obligation.
Potential harms, but it's mitigated by the probability of those
harms happening, right? Again, like we said, the guy who steps
on the steak, like if that person dies, are we saying that he's
a murderer? Maybe he could go to jail for some sort of like recklessness
thing, but you wouldn't call him a
right? That's like basically That's the entire purpose of Pisco
saying, "She didn't do CPS."
Like when Destiny joked about the Charlie Kirk thing, if like
the day after Destiny joked Sorry, didn't joke. Uh well, he did
joke, but if the day after, like that evening, when Destiny makes
that comment about how Republicans should be scared, and then
a DG here goes out and shoots somebody,
is he a Is Destiny now a murderer? Is Destiny now responsible
for that shooting? I don't see how he could be because he absolutely
went on Piers Morgan the next morning and said, "I actually stand
on business with that comment." Right? No, no, no, I agree You
agree or do you disagree with that? I No, I I agree that it it
it's related to the relative risk and the harm. That's why I
was bringing up those concepts with Hutch, and that's why it
shows that I'm good faith because I'm I'm aware of the different
issues when it comes to issues of causality. I brought up proximate
causation in the context of uh where things break the causal
chain. So, yes, I'm I'm aware of these concepts. I'm deploying
them in the conversation. Maybe I'm not as clear as possible.
But then so then but then but then but Like if a person But this
is what This is why Okay, I'm going to explain this with a doctor
thing, and tell me if I'm not understanding or if I'm stating
it accurately, and I'll just say nobody understands what you're
saying to me this. Okay? A doctor decides to never wash his hands
or do anything, and he goes in to perform surgery on a person.
Okay, we all, I believe, I don't know the [__] rules.
My guess is doctors probably have to scrub in before they go
into a OR, operating room, whatever, right? Doctor doesn't do
this.
It's like malpractice insurance. This is like a malpractice case.
Um they would You literally wouldn't be charged with murder here
if you failed to scrub in properly. Patient ends up dying because
of a secondary infection, okay? Or because of some primary infection,
whatever, right? Oh, but also,
how likely is it that you do damage by not scrubbing in, right?
Like that is you failing in something that you actually have
a duty to do. Like and not It's a duty because you expect if
you don't wash your hands, you're going to kill a patient. You
don't expect that if you don't have a moderated chat, you're
going to get CPS called on somebody. If that would happen, we
would say that the doctor, he had a moral and professional oblig-
and legal obligation to scrub in. He failed that obligation.
>> Correct. When you fail that obligation, the moral failing
is seen as accepting the consequences of all the things potentially
that could result in the failure to adhere to that obligation.
In the specific scenario where a patient died, he has some moral
obligation there where the of the for the death of the patient.
Just like Denims would have a moral obligation there >> of
his state of mind.
So, I do I also agree, by the way, that depending on what's going
on there, like if he Let's say that guy's mom just died, and
he didn't scrub in because he was like He He like scrubbed in
partially, and then he like touched something, and he didn't
scrub in again, and he got a patient killed. But he absolutely
like has scrubbed in a million times, and he was emotionally
distraught. There's like something affecting his mental state.
He probably shouldn't have been doing surgery, but other people
should have caught it, right? There's like some level of okay,
he clearly wasn't intentionally doing this at all. It was a total
accident. Should he never practice medicine again medicine again?
Should he be held responsible for killing that patient as in
like go to jail for it? I don't think so. I don't think most
doctors like I think the worst case scenario there is you kind
of get like a malpractice claim. You might lose your license.
To the extent of the moral violation. That's what you were saying.
>> recklessness state of mind is enough to say that she
didn't adhere to her her obligations or professional obligations
to her chat that she should have over there. I'm telling you
now for the maybe the 10th time, I grant that and did in the
conversation.
Do you understand that? Okay, then just the final thing I So,
then what do you disagree? Do you think your biggest disagreement
with Hutch is on this particular topic? >> The disagreement
is people are conflating
the degree of her desire. In other words, they are overstating
the evidence. They are stating that it it was Denims' conscious
object to bring about the result of By the way, Destiny's done
that now twice in this conversation. Said she was celebrating,
totally embarrassed himself on that point. Now has said has basically
claimed has intimated that there is no clip of Dest- of Denims
strongly disavowing this. Right? And Hutch did it multiple times
as well. Hutch's initial claim is Denims of like actually openly
and explicitly called for CPS to be called. She advocated calling
CPS in that clip.
She did no such thing. >> the CPS call, and that is not
the evidence that I have seen has not shown that. It is weak
on that. And so, what I am addressing is this notion because
there's one thing you could say if Oh, the community was reckless,
they didn't moderate, and this is a risk that they should have
mitigated by just by signaling that this is not okay, by pushing
back when possible. Absolutely, people will say that that's at
fault. We have We didn't yet weigh that against the the lawsuits
and if there's anything about it. >> way, do you think
that Hutch Do you think that Hutch was doing that?
I'm I'm not I'm not sure we >> your What was your
Hutch was objectively doing that. So, Destiny's going to take
advantage of the fact that Pisco doesn't want to throw more hate
at Hutch. Pisco doesn't want to direct anything bad at Hutch.
Right? Oh, you think Hutch was like overstating things? You think
Hutch like can't accurately analyze things? I mean, if Pisco's
being honest, then the answer is yes, obviously.
Obviously, he totally failed to answer it, which is why that
conversation was so embarrassing for >> What is your main
disagreement with Hutch? You had a 7-hour conversation about
What was your main disagreement with Hutch? Yeah, no [__]
They're basically arguing that she advocated for calling CPS,
right? Both of them are having are saying this. And Ethan literally
had to come out on stream and say there's no way you could think
You'd have to be if you thought I said that. I'm not sure. We
were trying We spent most of it trying to to get him to understand
this concept that I was trying to to show. That like I'm not
sure that what he would say in response to >> what concept?
>> The concept that one's ethical obliga- that multiple
ethical obligations exist, and each one of them has an indexed
state of mind, and one's violation of one does not entail the
other. That was Anyone who watches that fairly knows that I was
struggling for hours to come to that. And to suggest that there
are different um you know, different implications from that.
And yet, you could say, for example, >> the struggle was
because it took you a long time to get to the point that culpability
wasn't a binary yes or no. There are contributory negligences,
or there are other factors at play that He never said it was
a binary net yes or no. It's a binary yes or no on whether or
not Denims is directly culpable
for the CPS call, right? That's a binary yes or no. And Pisco's
saying, "No, even if she failed to moderate, and even if someone
from her chat called, she's not responsible for somebody else's
intentful act." As in somebody formed an intent to call CPS and
[__] Ethan over, Denims cannot be responsible for
that because she did not form that intent. And there's the evidence
that she had that intent with her coverage is scant at best.
Um the foreseeability of the certain actions and responsibilities
on the other thing. And Hutch kept saying things like that. Like
sometimes Hutch would even say a phrase. I don't know if he realized
this, but he was intuiting when he was saying things like, "Well,
didn't it" He would say like, "Didn't this contribute to?" And
then he would switch immediately to like, "Well, she's not culpable
for." And it took you like 2 hours to get to that like
So, is this a significant contribution was where it went. What
do you think the percentage is, Hutch? That's what the conversation
turned into. As in Pisco understands that there is some contributory
form of this, right? You can contribute, and he still thinks
that whatever her contribution was, it was it falls below something
where you say she's culpable for the actual thing, somebody else
forming the intent to call CPS and then executing on that intent.
>> Isn't the better inference moral obligation to ever
moderate your chat under any circumstance that
maybe maybe what I'm saying is or the thing that she's being
accused of by everyone who's who's saying is that she bears responsibility
not for the the being reckless, but for essentially wanting this
to occur, wanting the CPS stuff to occur. >> but because
I think that I think there's plenty of evidence to say that you
would say this
is like a depraved heart, constructive
I think there's plenty of evidence.
okay, just present any of the evidence. Oh my god, you're asking
for evidence of my claim? Yes.
Why do you think that? Otherwise, say why you think that. How
many times have we gone in the same circle? Hey, you've reached
the same point that that Hutch and Pisco reached after 4 hours
of talking yesterday. Yes, if you're going to make a positive
claim, I think you should have some evidence for that claim.
Destiny's about to be like, "Uh who cares, man? I'm
10 thing, for sure. >> You're going to have to show some
I mean, if that's the case, then I'm sorry, but like you're going
to fall under that rubric big time, and not just for the doc
stuff. Oh, thank god. Yes. Like Destiny, if that is the standard,
you understand you fail that standard a thousand times more than
Denims, right? You understand that you fail on that standard
so probably more than any other influencer in this entire space.
You fail on this standard. This standard is totally insane for
you specifically to advocate for. Are you out of your mind? No,
not only if you believe the start narrative. Anybody could have
said this. If your standard is if you joke about something, you
can't actually disavow it, and now you're responsible for it
happening in the future if you joke about it. If that's the standard,
Destiny's literally the guy who's known for joking about all
of the bad things
That's like his thing. Oh, somebody got shot? Well, I'm going
to go laugh about that. Oh, somebody
Dude, a child got a child got killed? Oh, I'm going to make a
joke about that. Oh, this guy's daughter um went on a date? Oh,
I'm going to ask if she lost her virginity. Like he's the guy
who joke He makes all these jokes. He does this all the time.
How is he the guy who's now saying, "Well, even if you disavow,
even if you say that the thing happening is bad, you joking about
it means it doesn't mean
Like you're it actually undoes your
And I don't think that you deserve it on that stuff. Hold on.
If somebody from my community showed up and beat up Justical
because of a doxxing I posted in my chat, you would come out
and say, "Oh, he has absolutely no That's he's not responsible
for that whatsoever." So, I don't think that you would be So,
I think that you would have a fault with respect to recklessly
endangering the health and security
So, unfortunately for Pisco, he just doesn't realize that Destiny's
actually advocated directly for the thing. So, Destiny's own
argument works against him here. Like right, Destiny's advocated
for somebody to show up and kill me,
Right? And he's directly taken the action the bad action to begin
with. He's directly done the doxxing.
So, like this is pretty This is a pretty rough hypothetical we're
working with
um Justical, but I don't think that anyone could say that you
were culpable for the intentional assault of Justical unless
they could prove you wanted it. You agree with that, don't you?
How would you ever prove But do you agree
Well, uh luckily he laid it out. tons of circumstantial evidence
Wait, how would he prove Wait, DID HE JUST SAY HOW WOULD he prove
that? But do you agree Wait. Did Did he this just say how could
we prove that? It's sort of doing this for these DMs about you
saying like, "Hey, I wish this person Has this person been doxxed
yet?"
Yeah, I um for Anna that's for Justical and Queenet, I kill them
if I could. I'd chop the [__] house and do it. Um
but not for Anna, no. We'll get back to the Okay, hold on. Hold
on. But that's not the only one. Well, so we got that one, but
there's another one. Hold on. This right here. You're saying
Yeah, no, what the [__] Like why would I even want
to do that? Like what am I want to like kill her or what? Like
that's So, I do want somebody to kill Justical though or Lav
or Mr. Girl or Queenet. Those people can all die. But not not
Anna, no. Since you do want these [__]
Just to make sure we get that part in as well, okay?
So, how would we Dude, how would you ever go about proving this?
How would you go ever go about proving this? How would you How
would you do it? tons of circumstantial >> don't understand,
guys. You don't understand, guys. That one was just a joke, even
though he's doubled down on it. That one was just a joke, okay?
That one was just a joke, actually. When he calls for violence
directly, that's just a joke. When Denims goes out of a point
of video, that's her explicitly wanting Ethan's kids killed,
okay? So, evidence. Circumstantial evidence. Any kind of evidence
that you that any kind of evidence of of you guys planning for
it. Any kind of evidence of you guys That's not circum- That's
like you're talking about direct evidence. You're talking about
a confession. You're doing the 416 argument. >> Yeah, what
would be No, no, no, no, no. That's not the case. What I'm saying
is not that you only need confessions to get to intent, all right?
Uh also, he justified Hassan over a intentionally mis- intentional
misreading of a clip, by the way. Over the I believe that's the
um uh talking about Eilo's operations into Rafa or whatever,
right?
Something like that. I think that I'm pretty sure that was I
went walked through that one and I argued with some people and
it was so [__] annoying. But I know I was correct
on that that like there was nothing wrong with what Hassan said
there. He was not advocating anything against Ela Klein at all.
That's not at all the case. Um for instance, for example, if
you drew a map to his particular address,
right? You You think that that would show that would tend to
show more intent. Wait, if you show frustration If you call them
No, no, if if you did if you did say something like, "Oh, it
doesn't look like uh you know, guns are allowed in wherever he
is, right?" If if you said that if if you that's not a direct
confession, but it's the kind of conduct that shows that you
don't really care about the health or safety. Maybe if you if
you started saying things like um they should be
Okay. Well, that would never happen. That seems basically a direct
confession is almost what you're saying. But like what if you
were to say statements like, "Well, under 4 years old children
don't even form memories." Or what if you were saying statements
like, "Well, Dude, that's not That's a factual statement that
can be minimizing of the bad thing that happened, but is not
advocating for it to happen again.
>> diseases as a child that you get as an adult, that's
basically
Well, one of one I kind of view as as downplaying, right? The
first one is like, "Oh, it's not a big deal, right?" And I understand
they're different, but if like Tim Pool got mad that someone
So, let let me give you an example, right? So, there have been
people where you have justified a doxxing if the I can't tell
if Pisco knows and is doing this on purpose. Well, I Maybe. >> Because
someone put your location, right? Someone put your location live
on Twitter and you your response I I recall this. You remember
this? And your response was Oh, this is actually a really good
point from Pisco. You've basically said that doxxing you is like
trying to get you killed, right, Destiny? Right, Destiny? Like
Hey, this is Destiny's location. That's them trying to get you
killed, which you used to justify doxxing them in return, right?
So, now you're doxxing people. You've explicitly said in the
past you think doxxing people is trying to get them killed and
then call for these people's deaths. It seems pretty obvious
what you're trying to do, right? >> Basically like you're
asking for me to be killed, right? You're asking for me to be
hurt. People will get killed, right? Remember that? Well, depending
on depending on how you doxx people, yeah,
And so Well, depending on how you doxx people. Like if for example,
if you doxx me, it's really bad. If I doxx other people, it's
really good. Did you think about that, Pisco? I I think it really
does depend on So, in that instance,
I think that you could make a case, right? You could make a case
that if your intention is a particular thing or if the kinds
of evidence that we would bring to bear in those situations might
be different. >> I
don't know. I don't know. Destiny, can I ask something, please?
I think honestly, I think for as And I listen, this is I'm [__]
around a little bit, okay? I'm [__] around a just
a tiny bit.
But how is it remotely arguable that Pisco is taking the side
of me or Queenet or our communities?
How is it possible to say that when the people he's platformed
about this stuff
have exclusively been from Destiny's community almost. I I believe
almost entirely, right? Has somebody from my community been on?
I haven't been on I don't know if I would be allowed to go on
and just say like, "Hey, I just want to clear the record on some
of these things."
I don't know if that would be allowed. I think probably
like they would paint Pisco Dude, they would like
they would lose their minds if I came on because realistically,
I think what bothers them here is the fact that this Denims situation
applies almost one to one with my situation. Destiny trying to
paint my community as some as people who like doxxing [__]
where he doesn't really have evidence any evidence he has of
any wrongdoing is massively overstated,
right? And so, I think what they're really worried about is that
Pisco would support my arguments that Destiny is almost one entirely
one-sidedly
like using super underhanded super escalatory tactics that I
haven't even remotely approached or okayed or done anything to
I haven't even responded in the same way, right? So, should I
ask him via DM? I don't think I can DM him. Do you accept evidence
of uh But I'm just saying like how could you argue he's supporting
like me or or anyone around me if nobody around me is able to
get is like gets on his platform, right? I I don't get it. So,
I I do think also I'd like to argue about the the cyber stuff
with him if he if he feels like it's appropriate to go and say
that that's what what was happening. Not sure. Is D-man getting
cooked? Oh, he's like
every He's become like every caricature of himself whenever he
argues about something where he's wrong, Cozer. Like he he's
spurted out so many times in this conversation and tried to run
away from like claims he makes. It's very embarrassing. An admission
by admission?
there are things where she is in a position where she could make
a statement, where she could get in the way of potential CPS
calls, of people making these play
If CPS is called again, is Destiny culpable because he sent a
tweet saying he hopes CPS saves Ethan's children? Well, is in
her I I don't know how he gets away with stuff like this and
then virtue signals against jokes.
Very weird, to be honest with you, but For sure. She has the
ability to see it.
Why would we hold Destiny to his own standard? Why would we ever
do that? That would be crazy. >> get in the way and say,
"Guys, we don't do it because right now I've only seen a disavowal
from her after everything has happened." >> Right. What
was the disavowal?
I There was There was some video that someone shared that showed
her saying like, "God
That was me, by the way. There's some video that someone shared.
I added Kafka Esquire and I was like, "Hey, could you send this
along to these guys so they could see it?" Guys, I never condoned
the CPS thing, uh which again is like after all of this has happened.
>> That's not a disavowal, though. That's not a disavowal.
Who is this Kafka Esquire guy? Uh Destiny's fighting on the wrong
side of this. Uh this guy is someone who tells Destiny that he's
right about everything. He's very good at showing up and going
like, "Destiny, you're actually correct about everything. Destiny,
you're actually right about everything. Destiny, you would you
would never be wrong. Destiny, you're right about everything.
Destiny, you're correct. Destiny, you're correct. Destiny, you're
perfect." Well, isn't it? What would it be? What else would it
be? What would it be? >> It's a It's a It's an It's an
attempt to avoid like direct like TOS responsibility.
So, you think she should have said I did Wait, she should have
said I did condone it or what did you say? Or saying I I shouldn't
do this. It's not that they shouldn't do this. It's saying I
didn't do it, >> You should make a more positive statement
of like, "I don't want this behavior in my community. We are
not doing this in my community. Like this is a thing we're going
to have like a strong stance against." Oh, no. Oh, no. Also,
Also, to be clear, the correct statement was, "I did not condone
it, nor did I do anything to get in the way of it." If we're
because she's just speaking descriptively at a at this point.
Why don't we just go I You know, for some reason I don't really
trust these guys to describe it. Why don't we just go listen
to what she said? Wouldn't Okay, maybe there's no explicit statement
of condoning it, but there's also probably an equal amount of
evidence of you trying to stop the I mean, is that the full quote?
I mean, what did she say? At any point did she say anything like
I don't know how long this is going to take, but I'm just I'm
linking it to Kafka. You can send a piece of code. I'll just
I'm going to listen to this for
Oh, is this another Denims moment? Your house at night, going
through all your things, accusing you of things you didn't do.
No one should be subjected to such treatment. Sure, but we're
talking about not cops showing up at your house. We're talking
about CPS. Which anyways to begin with, one I don't condone.
I've never Two, I've never been donated and you will not be able
to find a clip of me saying, yes, we should do this because it
doesn't exist. I think CPS should be exclusively used for family
vloggers who are total pieces of [__] that use their
kids as content. I've literally given Ethan Klein credit on multiple
times or multiple instances and I will do it again right now
for not showing photos of his kids. I think it is actually very
cool of him to try his best to not have his kids in photo
So So, like going above and beyond, even though she hates Ethan
Klein, going above and beyond to go, I do not think CPS is appropriate
at all for Ethan Klein. It makes it super
clear. Pisco's gobsmacked because he's just been lied to repeatedly.
Actually lied to repeatedly about the things Denims said. Every
single time he asked for evidence, no wonder these people virtue
signal about how bad you are for asking for evidence when they
present the evidence and it's this embarrassing for their argument,
right? It's this cataclysmic
for every argument they make. Remember Desi was implying earlier,
oh, if you found out Denims refused to denounce this and if she
like wouldn't denounce it at all, that change your mind, right?
Yeah, that would change my mind,
I respect a lot. I think he's he's a piece of [__]
and he's going insane and he's crazy, but I respect a lot that
he doesn't bring his kids on camera. >> unambiguous condemnation,
right? Wait, wait, wait, wait. So, you would agree that's an
unambiguous condemnation? Uh, yeah, and this was condemnation.
So, that's an unambiguous condemnation and also Pisco the sycophant
is so dishonest is dishonestly framing what Denims said. Just
check your DMs. Surely surely this is all fine, right? That's
an unambiguous disavowal.
Surely if Destiny were to say that this is not a disavowal because
she jokes about it after the fact, then he explicitly wanted
Charlie Kirk and he explicitly wants more conservatives
under that metric. Under that rubric, under that standard.
So, you would agree that's an unambiguous condemnation? No.
It makes Destiny so childlike.
I don't want No, I don't want to I don't want to No. Bro, how
in the world? It's like she she joked about it. SHE WATCHED BADEMUPANDADA
do a fake CPS call and she she joked about it.
Yeah, you've never definitely never joked about a tragedy, Destiny.
I do not condone I do not condone this.
That's not condemnation. What do you think condemnation is? If
you
What do you think condemnation is? Um, saying it's unacceptable
that they don't meet the standard, that she thinks the only standard
that could ever rise to this is family vloggers who use their
kids for content and Ethan Klein is actually like exemplary on
that standard. Here's the only standard I think you could call
them under. Ethan Klein on that standard is exemplary.
That is a total disavowal of any CPS call on Ethan Klein explicitly.
You were going to push me Hold on, wait, wait, wait. Wait, wait,
just to be clear, I just want to point out cuz you're doing this
again, it's funny, okay? Is that earlier some What is Pisco doing?
Dude, Pisco is sitting here just like tragically Dude, Pisco
is fighting against his own love for Destiny so badly here. I'm
sorry, I hate to say it, but that's like Pisco's literally on
Destiny Pisco wants to be wrong. Pisco wants to be proven wrong
and he just asked the question. He begrudgingly asks, please,
I don't please like you understand that's an explicit disavowal,
right? Please just don't Please don't say no.
Please stop. I thought you were my friend. Please stop. Please.
>> somebody like giggling along and laugh Please stop saying
insanely things that apply to you way worse than they apply to
Denims. >> saying your rambling or whatever didn't count
as celebration to you, okay? It counted as downplay or whatever,
but now somebody's saying, well, I didn't condone this behavior.
I do not condone
It is expressing more So, I understand condemnation to be That's
not all he said. That's not all she said, sorry. That's not all
she said. She also said, there's only one acceptable case for
calling CPS and Ethan Klein is exemplary on that front and you
could never justify it.
What is that if not a condemnation?
be expressing moral disapproval of an action, okay? That's what
I understand a condemnation to be. Do you agree with that? Yeah,
but I don't feel like this
I don't think that's what she
Dude, just walk him through it slowly.
the fall from grace is just insane here. >> Or like, well,
I didn't tell anybody to do it. So So, you don't think that if
someone says, I do not condone assassination or murder, that
is not expressing moral disapproval of a thing.
I think it would be in that circumstance. I think the way that
she uses condone here, it sounds like she's saying, I didn't
tell anybody to do it.
I mean, she's also saying that. But no, she's really unequivocal
in the language here. One thing would be I didn't say it. She
said, I do not presently I do not condone such things. Oh my
god. >> a That is a way of saying, I don't support it,
right? Pisco is not even going to the next line, which is where
she says, there's only one way I could support a CPS
call and under that exact thing in >> TOS violations of
people saying the N-word constantly in kick chat, okay? And I
had to turn off the chat. Do you think that I condoned and was
was like okay with those messages? I didn't see them. I didn't
see them, right? I didn't see them. And if I had seen them earlier,
I would have done something, but in order to show that I endorsed
the message, you would have to show that I saw it, right? >> You
would have to Yeah. You have to show that I actually
So, I think Desi Desi has an argument here, which is, but you
weren't pulling up a video where like people were using the hard
R or something.
Right? Which is the argument with with regards to Denims, but
it's still like difficult to say whether or not she condoned
the call because she never says anything that indicates she condoned
the call. You keep you you're I can't tell if you're doing this
intentionally if you're just trying to say that they're leading
the key at crucial moment now.
I mean,
Desi you brought up only hypotheticals where he was correct via
the construction of the hypothetical, so I feel like him calling
up Pisco's hypotheticals a little disingenuous.
I think he's going to Desi's going to say what I just said. in
your chat and you miss them for a while and then you close your
chat, does that mean that you condone the N-word, right? Yeah.
Wait, no, no. No, no, no, no, sorry. Imagine that I never found
out, right? And I just it stopped because someone you know, they
just stopped, right? And And someone comes up and says, you know,
Pisco's a racist, you know? Yeah, he he left those
You let those N-words be there.
You were watching a video beforehand. That was a 10-minute video
on why it's so cool to spam the N-word. >> never be accused
of allowing any N-words in my chat. in YouTube chats. And you
weren't even looking at your chat and you didn't moderate it.
Do you think that there would be a difference of opinion? Yeah,
I think people would have a difference of opinion, But, it be
a problem moderation. It'd be like the fact that they're putting
it up there in the first place. It would be the the the kind
of the act right there. It's not No, but but but hang on a second.
The problem there is not like that she is that there's an a call
for CPS. I understand that people could justify calling CPS on
the basis of what's said there. But, I don't think that you can
do a one-to-one there. I mean the the act of reviewing it I I
think it's culpable for its own reasons. I've already said that
there's culpability there in what they did. So, so we don't need
to get there. But, like all I'm saying is Arcandriel, Arcandriel
you get 5 minutes. Don't push like that much. >> to the
intentionality, that's what's missing. And that's what like maybe
you could make the case a little bit better with circumstantial
evidence. If she knows about it and chooses to disregard it and
chooses not to a lot of >> me Okay, I'm going to do a I'm
going to do a 30,000 ft view of this issue then, okay? Cuz here's
like the huge issue. And honestly, this is the biggest Yeah,
no. We do be We So, I Doobie, I actually believe fully
that he used to have like a Basically, he didn't really care,
but he would just pick the places where he could be correct,
which was where like the moral like the morally good side lined
up with him. So, it happened to be accurate, but now he's done
something bad and he doesn't want to accept responsibility for
it. And he keeps taking actions that are in furtherance of like
preventing people from talking about the bad thing he did. And
they keep getting worse, so he's like done this thing where he's
spiraling.
And he can't make the same arguments he used to make. Like here,
he's totally disingenuous with all of the arguments he's making.
And it looks worse and worse and it's all I believe it's essentially
all spiral
after this stuff was revealed. Like almost all of it is just
purely spiraling after
the the videos were revealed that he had sent these videos without
consent. Yeah, I really I really do think it's like
Like I
I Like he used to be able to argue on the morally good side.
And he has lost
that capability.
And so, I think he looks worse because he's trying to be as correct
as he used to be. And he knows how to like disingenuously frame
things, but he didn't have to do it all the time because he just
argued the points,
But now he like keeps having to take these positions where he's
not arguing the points. He's arguing some insane
Okay. Uh SpaceGhost, thank you very much for the gifted sub.
I forgot to thank Anonymous for a gifted sub earlier, as Now
he's arguing like some insane [__] to try to But,
he used to just be able to pick the morally good side. I don't
think he ever really cared, but he just used to be able to argue
the facts. And now he's kind of argue
I don't know. He's pounding the table a lot, okay? >> that
I have with a lot of these communities. Do you Are you worried
at all that you've set up an environment where none of these
people will ever be held accountable for basically encouraging
the behavior that they know exists and that they know is actively
happening, as long as they themselves are smart enough to like
never actually come out and explicitly condone it or I explicitly
Yeah, explicitly condone This is like the dog whistle question,
right? Where you basically have to admit that if they if they
refuse to ever take responsibility or say what their beliefs
are, then you say that's worth the
Right? Like they just don't If they never If they basically say,
"I think you're trying to get something else done there." And
they go, "No, no, no. I would never advocate that. Obviously,
don't call CPS on Ethan Klein." Then you take the win on that,
right? Or they lean into the belief and then you can accuse them
of it.
Seems very similar to the dog whistling conundrum. So, he's basically
saying that Denims is like hiding her power level here. She wants
it to happen. But, I think Pisco would just say, "Why don't you
just accuse her of like watching a Bad Empanada video and with
like no care to go and like fact-check anything in it? A guy
who's like a known
Right? You wouldn't watch a Destiny video on stream, a guy who's
a known liar, and not fact-check it, right? So, the same same
situation. Like a doxing, totally deranged liar. You wouldn't
So, you wouldn't do it with a Destiny video. You shouldn't do
it with a Bad Empanada video. Same principle applies. >> Done
it. Am I worried about that? Yeah. I don't I don't think that
I'm respon- >> So, so many of these communities are like
Snark or adjacent or Kiwi Farms adjacent and they do this and
they know this and they've got like inner flow, exchange of information
back and forth. But, obviously the You see that he just made
an allegation that's essentially
Like DGG has a flow of information, right? DGG has always had
a flow of information from Kiwi Farms.
Do you know how I know that? Cuz I used to type a lot in DGG.
Like he's saying something that applies to every community that
includes online people. He's basically just justifying all doxing
of anybody who talks badly about them anywhere on the internet.
It's like totally wild to do. I don't understand how he can make
this argument with a straight face, but obviously he's been making
arguments where he's proposing a standard that he doesn't measure
up to, that he's actually worse at in terms of that that applies
to him and and looks far worse upon his actions and the things
he's done than anyone else he's proposing the standard applied
The streamers themselves will never come out and say like, "I
am doxing this person." Or "I am harassing this person." Or we
But, so like in your mind, is it literally impossible to ever
get past just recklessness, basically? >> No, no, no, no.
I I think that there's there's you can definitely imply culpability,
by which I mean moral fault. I definitely can can can agree to
that and and say that there is a moral fault there, 100%. But,
and and I will always like I'm not a literalist, okay? If there's
enough wink wink nudge nudge wink wink nudge nudge that I get
the sense that it is their intent Like if I got the sense from
the video of um of Denims reacting to either either of these
different things. But, you see what it's really about I Dude,
maybe I am Maybe I Maybe Nicholas DeOrio was right and I do have
main character syndrome, but I do think the reason they're taking
the fight on this
is because if Pisco doesn't agree that you can like culpability
this this collective guilt collective responsibility thing. If
Pisco doesn't agree to that
it's actually the case that Pisco would defend my community and
everything falls apart. Like I And I hate to make it about me,
but I do think that Destiny is like all of the propaganda for
his community is riding on that concept. And so, the idea that
somebody whose community finds particularly compelling
would argue against that, would be against that in general, I
think that's what he has to attack here. I think that's the primary
motivation.
Unironically. No, I don't want to make it about me, man. But,
really Destiny is the one who brought you into it. Before that,
it was just about H3. Yeah. So, like I Man, I hate to do that,
but it's like I think he needs a bad guy. And if Pisco is is
saying that this tactic, making a bad guy with this tactic, is
wrong then he can start convincing people that the idea of like
what Destiny's been doing with in terms of doxing, all of that
all that [__] has been wrong, too. that she actually
wanted the CPS call to
I'm sorry. I'm just saying, Windy, that he keeps bringing up
my community
Right? Like I haven't heard him say spicy chat here. I've heard
him mention Queen Man maybe once or twice. But, he keeps focusing
on like my community and my Discord. And I think that is a calculation
on his part. Unironically. Um You should reach out to Pisco and
offer to go over any evidence DGG has to offer. Not sure if Pisco
would do that, but it would be great content. Yeah, I I would
love to do that, right? And I would explicitly love to do that.
What I would love to do is say, "You doxxed You've doxxed multiple
people
like before May of 2025. I want to know what evidence you have
before May of
of this group of people that you say like what has happened in
terms of harassment, what has happened in terms of doxing, what
are you holding these people responsible? Cuz he's basically
got a window from January to around March, April, May where I
think he could make this up, right?
We already got to the Dan doxing moment. No, but we'll take a
look. We'll keep
And that that would be my question, right? Cuz I understand that
around
the past like 2 months or something, he's going to get mad at
Cybert. But, like the Cybert stuff wasn't even a thing until
August and he'd already doxxed a bunch of people. So, I want
to know what the pretense for doxing was.
Pretext, whatever. What was his reason for doxing all these people?
I'd also love to know or just ask pretty explicitly, "What was
your reasoning for lying about and trying and saying like threatening
to dox Wicked Supreme?"
What was your reasoning for doxing Esports Batman? Cuz of course
we've seen Counter-Points try to justify the doxing of Esports
Batman and it was pretty
occur. I would be treating her as though that was her conscious
object initially. And I would be saying You You say this, that's
that's just counter-propaganda right there, Split Kitty Lite.
Oh, spicy chat's five uncs and anyone who's mad about that is
crazy. That's complete counter-propaganda
that is obviously a lie, okay? [__] off with that.
I don't know. Spicy chat's just five guys. Spicy chat has like
tortured people to the point where they like want to end
It just happens to be funny, okay?
It's just not outside of the the rules. And you can just ban
them and not pay attention to them. But, yeah. Spicy chat literally
They're The unfortunate fact of the matter is they're very funny
and they're very good at like cruel humor.
It's It That's how it is.
So, I understand why people get mad about it, but I feel like
anytime I've just left spicy chat, any concern about what spicy
chat says goes away for me. I don't understand how that doesn't
happen to other people. Like you you're not in spicy chat, you
just you just stop caring about what they say, right? It's pretty
easy. I just think the the cope that it's like, "Oh, it's just
five uncs." and saying saying something No, no. They go to chats.
They They can They can [__] with people. But, it's
like all within the bound It's not like Destiny's chat doesn't
do the same thing, right? Go and like try to psyop coach. Gen
chat and Chud is usually worse than spicy. Okay, not when I wasn't
banned there, but like I'm currently banned there. So, No, I
like get along in that culture. I just I don't think it's like
wrong. I It's like a culture that I am totally okay with. I just
think people I understand why [__] with people. But,
if it [__] with you, you just can't pay attention
to it. It's like you totally opt in to think that it like to
make it let it [__] with you. Right? It's totally
opt in. All you have to do is not pay attention.
But, that's why I just think the idea that it's like five uncs
is like crazy. Cuz it's very funny and very good at [__]
with people.
So, just the uh the counter propaganda of oh, why does anybody
care? Yeah, you off off >> And you know, high degrees of
moral and condemnation.
I'm just telling you, and maybe that is I'm naive, maybe I'm
a grifter, whatever you want to say. I do not get that
Hey, but it's not five people. It's like 25 people, okay? There's
like 15 to 20 people. It's not five dudes. I get the impression
of someone who is downplaying a risk. I get the impression of
someone who culpable for other things. >> Just looking
at
example we both know well, okay? So, then how do you get to the
idea that Donald Trump wanted people to do an insurrection? Yeah.
So, circumstantial evidence is how you get to intent. So,
Trump brought them all there.
This is quite literally the entire conversation has been I think
your circumstantial evidence is weak, which is why you overstate
it every single time. I think the circumstantial evidence against
Trump is overwhelming.
That's the difference. >> Brought them all there for a
particular purpose, right? And and just to be clear, intent is
needed for incitement and for insurrection engaging in an insurrection.
So, you need to show intent. Um it was his conscious object to
steal the election from Joe Biden. So, we know that intent as
a bare minimum. No one even really disputes that intent. He um
was failing on all his other operations uh to try to steal the
election. He sent them over to the capital knowing
Kareem and describing the fact that he that DK was willing to
spend like half of his editor check on like 14 prime boosts to
keep Ryze's name part is pretty crazy, okay?
It's like just DK by himself buying like 12 boosts. >> there
was going to result in either intimidate intimidation by which
we mean threats of physical force, or and we all agree that they're
very knowing they're very conscious and aware that that he had
the Oh, you're just misunderstanding circumstantial evidence,
F-bombs, is um
I think Pisco's got like a he explained it once. There are a
lot of things that fall under circumstantial evidence that are
not Like most cases are built significantly by circumstantial
evidence. The mag uh the the the people were armed. He said he
didn't Like testimony, I believe is circumstantial evidence,
right? Like testimony itself from anybody involved is circumstantial.
>> care, right? You have the evidence from all of the different
reports.
Why wouldn't he know that sending them to the capital would cause
that intimidation? Why would I know, yeah, yeah, because there's
Oh. Testimony from third parties isn't circumstantial? Okay.
>> substantive and unjustifiable risk with respect to sending
them there, but we are intuiting his intent based on all this
huge amount of circumstantial evidence we have here. We have
his knowledge that they're armed. How do you get past this? the
anger is particularized to a group, the presence there, their
immediate presence right there, the the clear purpose a clear
objective um to stop the steal, a clear objective to prevent
the certification, one that's been explicit and stated that that's
the clear objective. Not just an observation, not just a position,
but one where it's their goal, right? The goal is to stop. And
then, in addition to all that, when it actually
Hey, I love that Destiny like
I swear this is a one of the ways Destiny used to be better,
okay? And it what he used to do was he would get arguments from
people,
and then he would like check them against other arguments he
got from people, and he had like a broad enough set of opinions
that he could sort of do this calculus in his head and figure
out like a good opinion to have. And it's like I think he only
gets one kind of opinion now, and this is the kind of thing that
rises from that opinion where they go, Pisco I don't even think
Pisco actually believes that January 6th was like an incitement
from Trump anymore.
And you just give Pisco the argument the the chance to go, oh,
this is all the reasons I think it is. By the way, Pisco never
at any point here going, oh, you want me to just lay out my entire
argument for why January 6th was like incitement by Donald Trump.
He just starts laying it out, right? He doesn't go, oh, it's
totally unreasonable for you to want me to lay out all of my
reasoning for why January 6th was actually like a a total miscarriage
of total miscarriage of justice, a totally a stain on the American
system. He just goes and says to >> when the violence actually
occurs, and when he's told he's told he's he's updated about
the fact that they've breached the capital, the fact that they're
minutes away from the lawmakers. This is all in the reports.
Um he tweets out what he does about Mike Pence condoning
what's happening with his moral support. And so, there's a ton
of circumstantial evidence.
So, Pisco's like obviously correct here. >> that Trump's
conscious object was to cause the the stopping of the or the
attempt to stop the steal. >> but there's a lot also where
there's at least some to say that he wasn't, right? >> Yeah,
yeah, so yes, yes. So, what I'm telling what what what I'm telling
you is that On balance um yeah. On balance, and the mere self-serving
statements, I'm not going to try to be fooled by those. I I I
really won't. If I really got the impression that the apology
was >> you say that we're all like depraved heart, we're
at like We are at 100% intentional. Yes. Yes. Yes.
Okay, so like obviously >> That's what you have you have
to believe that, yeah. Otherwise, it's like
So, the but then the parallelism I'm obviously drawing here are
that like Denims has a chat gathered, they obviously all super
hate Ethan and Ela. Um you've got them watching videos claiming
that Ethan's children are basically being negligently abused
and are potentially dying of these horrible diseases that Denims
goes out of her way to state could be lethal to children. They
downplay the calling of CPS just like Almega downplays, you know,
the actual riot itself. Like she's doing all of these things
that seem to have easy parallels. I'm not even
Where did she specifically go after the thing had started happening
after the CPS call happened? She goes, this has my explicit moral
support. She actually goes, no, no, no, no, no. She didn't downplay
She kind of downplayed the calling of CPS. Come on, man.
But she goes, well, I don't think kids even form memories. I
think that's downplaying. It's kind of to even suggest otherwise.
But she's downplaying the calling of CPS because she's saying
I don't like it's literally because she hates these people. These
people have like tried to ruin her life, right? Like these people
have been going after her. They've been supporting other people
going after her for months now. Yeah, she has She had them front.
She doesn't want to go, oh, these people are total
Which by the way, that's a spite-based position. Destiny should
have complete empathy for that.
When? When she says, yeah, the thing about ages, oh, I don't
even think they form memories. I think that's downplaying the
CPS call with regards to the clients. But I I understand why
that happens, and I think she does the right thing anyway. Like
right in that same stream, I believe, she does the right thing
and says, obviously I'd never advocate for this. Don't tap the
glass. Don't do this. It's bad. asking for like a first degree
100% intended. I just don't know how you're not at like at the
very least like this like basically whatever this whatever another
word would be for the depraved heart >> Like she is playing
into this as much as she possibly can without basically calling
for it. So, so let me let me let me give you an example, right?
And that By the way, through this whole thing, Pisco's been incredibly
charitable, calm. He's with He's literally said before he goes
into the clips,
if he had watched these clips beforehand, by the way, he's like
like a Jedi master, okay? Cuz he's gone into these clips and
he's like, oh, if if she says that, I'll totally like take your
side right now. And every single time, they're just lying about
what's in the clips. And now Destiny goes, but I think there's
like something like depraved heart here. What is even the
They downplay the call for hate Ethan and Ela. Um you've got
them watching videos
I really I really won't. really got the impression that the apology
was Okay, would you say like would would you say that we're all
the way up to like it's not even like depraved heart, we're at
like We are at 100% intentional. Yes. Yes. 100% intentional.
Okay, so like obviously That's what you have you have to believe
that, yeah. Otherwise, it's like So now, Destiny's going to try
to list parallels between Denims and Trump on January 6th. So,
right off the bat, you'd have to do the parallel the obvious
parallel of spending months implying Ethan Klein's a really bad
father, right?
parallelism I'm obviously drawing here are that like Denims has
a chat gathered, they obviously all
She's a chat gathered. Okay. Where's the time pressure that you
have to do this >> super hate Ethan and Ela. Um you've
got them watching videos claiming that Ethan's children are
Multiple Have multiple videos been
Is this another time where we're actually going to make it even
like where we're going to be hyperbolic? Videos. Is this multiple
videos that they've watched? >> basically being negligently
abused and are potentially dying of these Okay, why why would
they believe that? If Donald Trump, when played a clip where
Joe Biden was like, how we totally stole this election from him,
I guess,
and then Biden came out like a week later and was like, actually
no, I was totally lying. That was a joke. That was a joke. That
was a joke, right? If you had the clip of Biden saying that,
which is the equivalent to the Ethan Klein clip of him saying
that his kids basically got giardia by eating sh then horrible
diseases that Denims goes out of her way to state could be lethal
to children. They down
But Destiny himself has agreed multiple times that giardia in
a child that young is potentially something that you should call
CPS over. That that is a disease of neglect, and that is a reasoning
for calling CPS. So, everything Ethan Klein did there, Pisco
probably should have just brought the clip up again and said,
so, you would agree that everything in this clip Ethan is essentially
admitting to neglect of his children in this clip, right? I think
Destiny has to say yes.
Key differentiating factor here or key mitigating factor is the
fact that Ethan came out shortly after, and nobody was confused
about this. I believe Bad Empanada knew this 100% that Ethan
came out shortly after and went, oh, whoops, I I [__]
this up, okay? >> downplay the calling of CPS just like
Almega downplays, you know, the actual riot itself. Like she's
doing all of these Okay, so she gathered a chat.
And she watched some videos where they said Ethan was a bad dad.
Ethan himself said he was a bad dad. And then, she didn't disavow
that. Where is the Where is the hinting towards, hey, we should
go over here. Hey, you should go, you know, people should be
looking stuff up around this. People should be going to Ethan's
Like there's no imply There's no implicit thing, right? There's
no equivalent to the fight like hell, march down to the capital,
right? There's no equivalent to this in the
There's no telling them that these kids are for months telling
them that these kids are abused, these kids are in
There's none of this.
Right? And then after the fact, there isn't explicit support
for it. There is I actually categorically deny this. Categorically
categorically deny that I said it and categorically deny that
it's okay. things that seem to have easy parallels. I'm not even
asking for like a a first-degree 100% intended. I just don't
know how you're not at like at the very least like this like
basically whatever the whatever another word would be for the
depraved heart thing that like she is playing into this as much
as she possibly can without basically calling for it. So so let
me let me
No, she's not. Yeah, she could have played into this way more.
>> Let me give you an example, right? In that specific
context, Rob Noor, all right? Rob Noor absolutely was reckless,
I think, in in the the statements that he was making regarding
election theft Oh yeah, why are we presenting the stop the steal
rallies didn't exist? What were the stop the steal rallies, Destiny?
Love how you guys have to web Well, hold on. No, no, no. What
what's happening here, Cozer, is this is the argument that Pisco's
known for in Destiny's community that Destiny didn't believe
Donald Trump like intentionally incited the riot?
And Pisco is the person who convinced him that he did. And so
Pisco so Destiny's trying to take away the thing that everybody
knows Pisco for and he just failed horribly. in uh pre-2020.
He wasn't saying that the the election was explicitly stolen,
right? He was saying that he didn't he didn't say or sorry, he
did say that it was stolen. Oh, don't worry. If you stick around
long enough, Cozer, you'll get to see Destiny actually lie about
Lauren Southern to throw her under the bus to try to win an >> because
of like the Hunter Biden Twitter file stuff, okay? So he he did
say that. Um and he was supporting in in practice a lot of the
efforts made by um by Trump in the legal cases. But and he was
trying to um
So in other words, in other words, he didn't support violence.
I'm never going to say that he directly said that he supported
violence. But I do think that his kinds of statements contributed
to an air of like um feeling that things were unfair, feeling
like they were getting over and he literally did take the view
that the election was stolen. So in that context, you're not
in but immediately when the insurrection happened, he condemned
the violence immediately, okay? So that's a good point. I'll
also say I'll also say difference too is as much as I hate [__]
Rob Noor, I feel like I've heard Rob I don't know what I don't
think I heard Rob Noor I feel like I've heard Rob Noor say a
billion times I know that. Yeah, so I'm trying to give you an
easy case of someone who definitely I think you could contribute
to risk of people feeling disenfranchised, but Just trying to
get through this part. directly inciting what's happening on
January 6th, right? Take someone like Ted Cruz, right? Ted Cruz
is launching objections in the Senate, right? To place electors,
right? Ted Cruz before January 6th, um he was basically Lockstep.
He supported the Trump versus or the Pennsylvania versus Texas
case that went all the way to the bunch of Supreme Court on the
original jurisdiction. That Do you hold Ted Cruz that that he
intended the insurrection to happen? That was his intent for
the insurrection to happen, not not to steal in the
sense of the procedural due, in the sense of the insurrection.
Probably not. >> Yeah, I agree. I think it's it's hard
because he's he's culpable
Destiny getting totally raked over the coals again because he's
despite making a documentary, he's still factually inferior to
Pisco. Pisco off the cuff, okay? Destiny made this allegation.
Well, I don't think you can even justify say Trump incited. And
Destiny did this and Pisco off the cuff totally mogging him,
never once said, "Hey, I don't have evidence for this. Hey, you
want me to like You want me to be able to state my whole opinion
out of nowhere?"
No, he tried to make a documentary. He might have written a script.
Gets totally mogged on knowledge by Pisco. Absolutely has to
everything Pisco is
Sorry, he pretended to make a documentary. I I misstated. >> um
you can have a legal coup. So technically the Senate is allowed
to do their objections, right? It's pretty easy or whatever.
I don't know what Ted Cruz knew in so far as the whole Eastman
plot and the whole fake electors bill. He had knowledge of Tucker
Carlson spread lies he knew to be lies, right? He knew they were
lies. And we have that from the
insurrection, I would have to know I would have to know about
the ECA violations and the fake elector Anybody that was involved
in that obviously 100% knew. 100 billion percent, yeah. We're
we're going to hold Tucker Carlson accountable for some stuff.
We're going to hold Ted Cruz accountable for some stuff. But
I don't think it's fair to say that we're going to charge Ted
Cruz with insurrection, that we're going to say that he actually
did as his conscious object have for the specific insurrection
to happen. Now, you again, this is just a way to demonstrate
what I'm talking about here and that I'm in good faith. Sure.
I I think yeah, but but but but the but the problem I have with
this is that like
this is a once-in-a-lifetime Well, I guess now we have a civil
war, so twice or whatever. This incredibly rare event that what
like we have to talk about the foreseeability aspect here, right?
Like does Ted Cruz really think that if he's able to engage in
actions that's increasing the risk of an actual violent insurrection
happening? Like if Ted Cruz would have been There are other actions
I would have to see that like would be in that So do you think
that Hasan uh with his coverage of stuff that he is um intentional
if if there's some kind of sort of communist violence that occurs,
would you apply culpability to someone like Hasan?
Well, you see, we don't like Hasan. We're pretty spiteful about
Hasan, so yes, absolutely. New Doobie donation. Would one of
you unlovable mouth-breathers mind explaining why you're so worked
up about KF when Destiny directed people to Anna's KF page while
she was having a multi-month break mental breakdown?
That's a another great question. Another banger from Doobie.
that his rhetoric has a high degree of connection
And he said yes. With that and because I think he more or less
basically calls for it and lays out all of the justifications
and anytime violence happens it it seems like for every single
time I feel like he calls out a false flag and constantly tries
to downplay it when it's pretty obviously like a horrible day.
Yeah. Yeah, so so maybe that I'm like the whatever. Maybe you
guys think differently. I don't know if I would I wouldn't put
it on like the depraved heart level. Like this is a much So Hutch
said this thing kind of by mistake maybe Hutch is like, "Well,
there's a much broader thing when you talk about like Donald
Trump." I think that the culpability when it's more diffuse in
a population it's going to be harder to ascribe a higher percentage
to any Okay, here we go.
Lauren Southern the Christchurch
Yes. She's culpable in the sense of she airs is she reckless
with her in the sense of uh with respect to the result
At least, yeah. Yeah, what her whole thing was basically that
um white people are literally being violently replaced by immigrating
people. Didn't the
I think it's non-violently replaced. >> Christchurch literally
uh cite her in his manifesto or am I making that up? Uh He wrote
He I think he referenced the great replacement, right? That a
lot of people were attributing to Lauren Southern. I can't remember
if he specifically said Lauren Southern he just referenced the
great replacement.
>> They did, yeah. actually took real life actions violating
international law literally in the Mediterranean shooting flares
in the direction of immigrants or
Now, as somebody who's personally witnessed Lauren Southern on
Destiny's stream while they were in a relationship say, "Hey
Destiny, I'd really appreciate if you stop saying I shot flares
because you know I didn't shoot flares. I've explained this to
you multiple times." For him to show up again and say that Lauren
Southern was shooting flares in the Mediterranean, I feel like
that would hurt my feelings if I were Lauren Southern.
Why does he keep lying about this? Why does he keep saying that?
Well, he could win an argument with Pisco right now. He thinks
that if he throws Lauren Southern under the bus
If he throws Lauren Southern under the bus right now she No,
she was on the boat. She just wasn't shooting a flare gun. She
had like a torch that she was like waving back and forth. But
um
he believes that if he he throws Lauren Southern under the bus
right now
that he can get Pisco to agree to his argument, I guess. >> Yeah,
this standard is going to apply to basically all of MAGA. Wait,
what standard? The the standard uh of holding accountable, by
which we mean in in the degree of risk. Um Oh, sure. I mean I
almost am there for for almost every elected person. Yes, that's
why I half-jokingly say that like all of them should be barred
from holding future office if you're like a MAGA Republican right
now. Yes. Okay.
Um as funny enough, it seems like Counterpoints is sure been
on the whole mass migration is happening um demographic replacement
is happening. Is Counterpoints now responsible for Is he
Interesting question. >> That that's just a different in
terms of how we I think we see the the balance of evidence in
terms of what goes into intent. I I think that some people um
like want these attacks to happen. Like
I don't think someone like Alyssa Slotkin or Mark Kelly when
they say the National Guard person shoot Like we think they're
all unhinged, right? When they say Slotkin wanted the National
Guard member to be shot or members to be shot. We all think that
they're unhinged. Do you think for example >> we Wait,
wait, wait. But why are we why are we saying that? That they
wanted them to be shot. Why are they saying it? We're not saying
it. Oh, wait, wait. What do you mean when you were saying they
wanted them to be Wait, Destiny, you understand that Mark Kelly's
on your side, right? You get that, right, Destiny? Hey Destiny,
you know that, right? Cuz you definitely pay attention to politics
and stuff. the Republican state
Alyssa Slotkin and Mark Kelly, they wanted the National Guards
people to be shot. That's why they said We all We all caught
that, right? We all caught that he just didn't understand what
was being said cuz he didn't know those names. We all caught
that? I hope we all caught that. The politically involved guy.
>> don't follow illegal orders. Oh, oh, I was I was Oh,
yeah, sure. Okay. Because because and and that we don't agree
with
Do we think that for the Hortman murders? Do you think that Ted
Cruz or average Republican wanted the Hortmans to be killed?
They intended it.
Wanted to? No, but I don't know if there's another word for this
depraved heart standard that would be above recklessness or gross
recklessness. I don't know gross recklessness. But like I I would
say that all of their behavior has gotten to that level, yes.
To the point to the point of them of of a constructive intent
that you think that basically all of these
have a constructive intent to have them Hortmans be killed.
Yes, I know that we're like because everything is so normalized
and crazy in this country right now and people like Hutch Hutch
think we're all going back to normal and everything, but like
I think that in any world where
half the country doesn't believe in the results of the 2020 election,
when you've contributed that in almost any manner, I think you
you are the culpability is so much higher than where we're placing
it right now. And Republicans just got away with being treated
like children. I It shouldn't be surprising to you that people
are murdering politicians when you're telling people that their
country's being stolen by uh Jewish space >> Whether they're
surprising or not isn't the isn't the question. I do think it's
really crazy how all the people who were talking about the 2020
election being stolen led to Charlie Kirk getting merked, right?
Definitely. 100%. >> is whether they Is the question because
it surprisingly has to do with the foreseeability of it. And
if you if it is easily foreseeable that people are going to start
to get violent and murder people and do crazy [__]
as a result of your rhetoric, then yeah, I'm I'm going to start
to hold you at a very high level of But it wouldn't apply to
the fascist rhetoric, what, because it's
Yeah, the fascist rhetoric is true. Well, yeah, wait, wait, wait.
Yeah. >> It's true because hold on, because of I've said
this before, if they were
I think maybe the the J6, the murders, everything, maybe they
are justified. I think you would agree with that. We have to
agree with that. If If it was the case that people in Congress
were stealing the [__] elections and people wanted
to revolt against that, I think we would think that's justified,
Wait, all the J6 murders, what J6
>> Even through our People say that about Bush v. Gore
that it was stolen. Sure.
Sure. Would it be justified to launch an insurrection to unseat
George Bush?
I think for George Bush, I think that that gets trickier because
you're bogged down in more procedural stuff that's not such a
clear
wrong. I think it gets a little bit >> I think maybe I
would grant that at some level of clear >> the hard Supreme
Court decisions suck because the Supreme Court is the [__]
god of all things, but when there's so much evidence >> I
hear you. So, but but I I don't really buy that like truth is
a defense here on the violence stuff. Like it could be true that
they're fascists, but >> violence is I'm I'm be careful.
I'm not saying that they wouldn't be culpable for the violence.
I'm saying that it's the violence to be justified, right? >> Really?
Is it Wait, wait, wait. So, so the question is, since you think
a violence against against fascists is it justified against Charlie
Kirk?
I never said violence is justified against fascists, though.
Oh, I thought you just said that. >> States, we shouldn't
kill people. What do you mean? Well, I I thought you had Who
is he saying denied the results of the election
and there's an argument violence is justified against them?
If those aren't the people he's calling fascists, who are those
people?
Pisco is in bed Pisco is just walking Destiny through his opinions
that are clearly totally disjointed.
just said that um well, it's okay >> No, I'm not saying
it'd be justified because they're fascists. It'd be justified
because they're literally stealing all of your elections and
literally just
Wait, why do you call them fascists?
That is the next question if you're not a total
and spiraling down some unwinnable
corkscrew into oblivion right now. Wait, why do you Wait, why
do you call them fascists? Is it not because they're stealing
elections? They're not like willing to submit to liberalism?
They're totally liberal in every way. You're literally describing
the reasons you call them a fascist right now. No, no, no, I
would never say they can't do it cuz they're fascists. I would
say it's cuz they're like totally liberal. They want a government
takeover. They want total authoritarian overreach, right? I I'd
say it's all because they're trying to It's not because they're
fascists. It's just because they want all the things that make
up fascism and they're trying to enact them actively. But it's
not because they're >> No, but but but but but but but
right now people are saying that by calling them fascists, whether
it's true or not, you're just increasing the likelihood that
they're going to be killed by crazy people. And in fact, you
have I mean, I don't agree with the entailments here, but you
do have someone who who had a bullet that said catch fascist.
I don't know whether he fired that one or not, who cares. Um
so, you know, there's a plausible case there, right? That the
fascist rhetoric someone some crazy people can use it. But but
that's if the analysis is accurate and true, it's a different
form of analysis than if you're just lying. >> Why? Why
Why does truth be
So, now he's gone back to well, if they are fascists, then I
can say
So, you understand he just totally ran away from his own like
he didn't want to set stand up business on his own points
Dude, this is actually This is so disastrous.
That whole section right there was just meandering.
Because when you're lying, because when you're lying, it doesn't
seem like you're trying to make an accurate analysis. It seems
like there is an
to encour- to invoking violence. If I were to tell you if I genuinely
Okay. What did Denims lie about?
What did What did Denims lie about? I just Show me where she
lied. >> believe that in the next room, John is
Yeah, this is supposed to be about Ethan
Pisco asked for evidence
that Denims supported calling CPS on Ethan Klein. Destiny couldn't
provide any. Destiny totally failed on that front. And Destiny
argued that Pisco asking for that evidence was evidence that
Pisco was trying to get in good with my community or defend my
community or take talking points from my community. They accused
him of being like my friend.
I I don't even know how that is coherent or makes sense. It's
very confusing. >> Um okay. And you run into that next
room and I genuinely believe that and you run into that next
room and John's not Sam and you end up killing John anyway. Okay,
well, [__] that's really tragic for a variety of
reasons. But if I say John is killing Sam and I know for a fact
that he's not,
Don't you and Pisco hang out? >> Only at the secret meetings
with BadBunnyAuto, Hasan, Kweiman,
um the genetic clone or sorry, the genetic clones of Mao and
Stalin, okay?
Only at those meetings, but those meetings are really secret,
so
I don't know I don't know what to tell you, man. How can you
read that beyond me trying to get you to do something horrible
to John? Yeah, I think that lies a much different thing. Well,
I I think I think the deception, all else equal, probably plays
a role in the evidentiary case that someone has >> no.
It doesn't play a role. It makes it a fundamentally different
action. Well,
So, again,
you're lying about the action John is undertaking. Where did
Denims lie about the action Ethan was undertaking?
He reacted to BadBunnyAuto. BadBunnyAuto played a clip of Ethan
Klein and did some like obvious snarking there where he was like
making it seem as bad as
But like what did What is the lie here?
The lie is in leaving some information out, right? Which is that
Ethan came out and said that none of this hap- that none of this
was true. Ethan up he
Dude, who What do you Do you know what she No, but it makes it
a fundamentally different type of action. I mean, I know, but
like if I lie to you and say, "Hey, uh can you go pick up my
mail over to the to the right?" And like it's there's actually
I think that there's going to be a surprise party for you right
there, right? But I'm lying to you and and it turns out instead
of a surprise party where there's like a clown desperately needs
help, my god. It's a murderous clown, man. [__] up.
Right? In that situation, the lie, right, doesn't bear on my
intent there. I lied to you for sure. I lied to get you in the
other room, but it just happens to be the case that I had no
intent to do the bad thing for which we're all criticizing, which
is the clown murder of my friend. >> this ties back to
the but this ties back to the earlier thing where my question
Dude, I I've Smeatic, I've seen your bad AI images of Dan and
BadBunnyAuto. I'll pull them up on screen so you just stop leaking
them, okay? So, Dan and BadBunnyAuto
AI Photoshop and then another Dan and BadBunnyAuto AI Photoshop
that also just looks horribly, horribly disjointed, okay? There
you go. I pulled them up on screen. Don't leak them again. Thank
you. Appreciate it. >> else would you expect people to
do when
Do better work next time. That last one was really sh- you tell
them that children are dying because of parental
It seems like I I think the average person I think the average
person would just be like let them be like I'm just being honest
with you. I think the average person watch No, no. I No, I think
the average person sees would expect that their audience would
do the same thing they see when they see a bunch of [__]
up [__] in the news, right? Which is to take no action
at all. That is the expectation. When you when that is always
like Yeah. Let's test Let's test the intuitions in the other
direction. Let's say that CPS was called and then let's say that
they showed up and they actually found out the children were
being severely neglected. Do you think in that case Denims would
be taking
for bringing light to the issue and that everybody would be celebrating
all these people for publicizing the issue as much as they did
and all of them would feel some moral like credit, goodness,
responsibility, virtue for bringing such a horrible situation
to light? I think They would, but it'd be disingenuous.
It would just be them lying to say they were ahead of the curve.
It wouldn't be because they actually thought that was happening.
It would just be like lying. I think it's possible that she that
she's not beneath that. No, but I don't I I'm not saying that
No, but you don't think she'd be worth like giving a little bit
of congratulation to? Like you were calling the you were saying
he's going to murder. Yeah, so so I think that she would like
raise her eyebrow and she would certainly be like this is really
bad and maybe she might even take credit. I'm not saying that
she'd be on that. I don't know perfectly that she would do that,
but I think that there's a decent chance that she would do that.
The question is doesn't really bear on >> No. I think they
would. It doesn't bear on the conduct. It I'm not saying this
even if I grant it, it doesn't bear on whether or not the action
itself reaches
that in retrospect the call was unjustified, but the claims are
true, doesn't mean that the the conduct here is is the same level
of culpability as one who whose conscious object is to do a certain
thing, right? Like Trump probably didn't intend for some things
to happen, you know, he probably didn't intend for the bipartisan
infrastructure bill to get passed, but he bet his bottom dollar
he's going to take credit for a lot of these projects and there's
nothing inconsistent with that.
Okay, we're not to the Dan part yet. But let's just see here.
If
If, okay, Destiny's close personal friend Dan, his business associate,
believes playing video games with on stream right now.
If it came out that Hasan [__] was a Do you think
Dan would say, "Well, I told you guys. I told you guys, even
though I proved it with the with the Rothschild stuff. I proved
he was Do you think Dan wouldn't do that? Does that mean that
Does that have any bearing on Dan accusing him of being a Now,
does that make it okay for him to do that? Would that make it
okay for him to accuse him on like totally baseless
I don't know. I don't like I don't think so. But it's fine. Sure.
I just I know that like when people lie about a thing, it it
lets you read into their intent a lot more than if they just
tell you a >> That's why I said it's relevant to the evidentiary
case, but not dispositive. That's what I'm saying.
Like if you totally apologize for violating somebody's trust
in the worst way possible and then take that apology back and
say you weren't actually talking about the thing, like that tells
you a lot. Oh, who was informative? This is all Everything we're
saying is like reasonable discourse. People, you know, one mind
can go one way, one mind can go the other. What it's not is and
I was so what I want I want the acknowledgement on is, "Oh my
god, this is so crazy. What happened to him? He lost his marbles.
All of a sudden he went into Distilks uh uh penumbra and all
of a sudden he's coming out and saying all crazy [__]
that he would never ever believe. He just said penumbra.
Why don't you say shadow, dude? Who the [__] does
penumbra? The [__] That [__] me off.
And you know, you might say like who cares, but whatever. >> Let's
figure this out. This is This is you and maybe I just played
too many video games so my mind is rotted, but right now our
disagreement seems to be I'm pushing
Wait, why would video games have any bearing on this? >> for
depraved heart and you're content with recklessness. And in my
mind, there's not very much daylight between those two positions.
>> My feeling is okay, that's fine. My feeling is that
Hutch and other people seem like they're pushing for at least
depraved heart and you're at zero moral culpability whatsoever.
That's what I think most people's perception of you is that and
I That was my perception at the end of the whole convo. I basically
If I'm being honest, I think that she has moral fault, but I
I because I I view the risk, right? What you have to show, right?
In terms of this being depraved heart murder, is that her reacting
in the way her reacting in the way that she did that that significantly
increased the likelihood that the CP the CPS call happened. And
I'm just like >> don't. Why do you keep repeating this?
You do in order to have for you to like The idea of depraved
heart is that no reasonable person could expect anything else
other than the the situation of CPS getting called when they're
saying that in the chat. That's the point of depraved heart.
Depraved heart is your conduct is so reckless that basically
the obvious assumption by all reasonable people is that you wanted
it to happen. That is not the like the level of depraved heart
murder is like you pulled out a gun and fired shots in a direction
like at a house and then somebody got killed inside and you're
like, "Well, I had no idea. I wasn't trying to kill someone specific."
Like no, if you fire like a machine gun at towards a house, there's
a decent chance you kill somebody, bro. That's not the level
of conduct Denims has engaged in here. Like uh consciously disregard
a substantial
unjustifiable risk. You have to say at the time the action was
taken, it was reasonably foreseeable that you took would have
induced some like significant risk of this occurring. And I just
view it as a low-risk policy >> I think maybe that maybe
there might be low risk with regards to a CPS call, but there's
a high risk of harassment altogether. And that's what these communities
have been like doing. Wait, no. No, it's not different because
the CPS call or getting Bro. And harassment's like the worst
thing in the world, isn't it?
Dude, I'm sorry. This guy virtue signaling about causing harassment
to people is just crazy. Skulls mailed to your house or whatever
else. They're all subsets of harassment. Maybe you can't foresee
the particular type of harassment, but when all you do is sit
Wait, maybe she Maybe she couldn't
the CPS call, but but skulls and CPS
Maybe she couldn't have foreseen the CPS call, but skulls? Swords?
CPS? >> engage in insane personal attacks that are digging
into a person's family and you're trying to out these crazy things
where the only remedy is basically some law enforcement intervention
or somebody else intervening in a physical manner, yeah, I think
you're in a hugely contributory intentionally contributory environment
where you're all doing things to push people in this direction.
That That definitely doesn't and by
Where did Denims say something? So now he's broadened it to like,
"Well, I think maybe she's not culpable for CPS, but she might
be culpable for the
How? What happened to just talking [__] on the internet?
What happened to internet bullying isn't real, just close your
eyes?
What happened to the Tyler the creator tweet, guys? What happened
to that? >> sitting laughing along with it, you're contributory
environment.
They have to I I swear to God, I understand this like main character
syndrome. They have to tow this line because if Pisco stands
on business here, that's Pisco and him trying to convince his
community that he's correct on this that you can't just go and
say, "Oh, everybody who is like remotely tiable to this is guilty."
They have to defend that logical premise that if I can tie you
to this in some way, you're guilty. I hope Pisco understands
that they're essentially trying to tie him to this with no reasonable
connection.
And by continuously saying and tying him to my community they
are opening Pisco up to all the harassment that would come to
me or somebody else, including getting doxxed, right? Like obviously
so. There's no reason to say he's tied to my community in any
way, but they're doing that. And not only does that not only
is that trying to undermine his defense of the overall Sorry,
his pushing back against the overall narrative they use against
Denims and then my community, but it's also opening him up to
the same harassment that he would get for being associated with
my community. Which for Destiny is
Anything is on the table to him. >> you too, not you, but
Denims in this
Okay. I That's the disagreement. I think honest minds, reasonable
minds can disagree about that. I think it's a low-risk thing.
No, I don't think Pisco's defending himself or practicing self-preservation.
I think Pisco's too to do that. I think Pisco's just arguing
his opinion. I don't think Pisco sees me when he goes to make
these arguments at all. I don't think he does. I don't think
there's anything going on there. But I don't see him either.
That's the thing. I didn't listen to Pisco to get these arguments.
These were my arguments the second I read that [__]
case.
Before I ever saw Pisco react to any of it, before I ever saw
him say anything about it, I was like, "Oh, this is like [__]
absurd, clearly."
Remember I was arguing with WillyMac about the um like how insane
the [__] filing was? He's got like a bunch of pictures
of him in it. Um and I I think that there's this kind of explosion
of the word harassment where it means like any kind of negative
criticism. I mean, by that view, like I'm being harassed right
now, but I don't think I'm being harassed, really. Harassment
has to do with like, you know, your your privacy >> you
talking about this right now? Hold on. When Ethan talks about
harassment, is it people saying mean things about him online?
>> No, no, no. I'm not saying that. >> say contributing
to harassment, the two examples I gave were CPS call and skulls
being mailed to the house. I think the harassment is a lot greater.
No, I I agree that's hara-
Except where he said that where Destiny said that was, "Well,
I agree maybe she's not culpable for the CPS calls, but she is
culpable for harassment, which could be skulls Sorry, could be
CPS calls or
So he's basically saying she's she's I guess also possibly culpable
for skulls, but where is that? harassment I I'm not Guys, I am
only saying what I'm saying. I'm not saying what I'm not saying.
I don't know why you're explaining this other random harassment
You need to show her tendency
to uh with those statements as opposed to just her
So why we're forced tragically to engage
in the most
Semitic act of all which is some skull account revisionism, okay?
We have to do it. It has to be I'm sorry. I don't want to deny
the skull account any more than any other person online, okay?
But we just we have to reset. We have to We have to break down
the mythology of the skull account because it's it you know,
it's just been a tragedy for online discourse. So sad to say.
>> presence in the community in the general sense to contribute
to specifically the harassing incidents, not just the criticism
that is part of like our discourse, right? Which could be unfair,
which could be lies, but that we all accept as part of being
part of the like the the marketplace of ideas. >> that
if you were part of the if you were part of the clan and you
didn't directly participate in a lynching of a black person,
do you think you share some culpability for being part of the
organization? Say you pay your dues and you help in other ways.
Yeah, I I think you could be culpable with respect to your your
participation in the community, for sure. But what
Can you think of like people around Destiny who might do things
that are sort of equivalent to online lynchings? I can. I can
think of like a business partner who might do some crazy [__]
I can't think of
Yeah, yeah, so
her participation in the community, I
bears on her, you know, increasing risk in the ways that we've
talked about, for sure. At some level of abstraction.
Um and absolutely, like I I would I can grant that, you know?
Uh just like for you would grant, right? Being a part of the
Destiny community, do you think there's any risk involved in
there and there's some culpability for what Destiny DGG does?
You grant that for yourself and for your community members being
part of the Destiny community?
My community doesn't even doxx. I complain that they won't doxx
people for me. For for what actions? Okay. I'm just going to
say, okay, I looked at Destiny's proposed doxx, the failed doxx
of me. Saw the name from that doxx getting spammed in Pisco's
chat earlier.
What community do you think was doing that, by the way? Do you
think it was like Destiny's community that definitely doesn't
participate in doxxing or I Hmm. Hmm. I wonder. >> kinds
of actions which um listen. You agree your community doxxes,
right?
Not usually. It's just me, unfortunately. My community sucks
at doxxing, so I have to do it on myself. But that's usually
because I've hardcore like edited most of this [__]
out of my community. No, I had TO POST EVERYTHING MYSELF. WHAT
DO YOU MEAN? MY COMMUNITY DOESN'T EVEN DO THIS [__]
anymore. Where does my Where's my community actively doxxing
people? Oh, sorry. I thought that that
So you did. Did! Did!
Uh by the way, they post the doxx like all over the place. They
absolutely use the doxx information that Destiny collects and
then publishes to doxx people further. Yes.
Literally got upset in DGG chat that DGG or Kephos posting doxx
got banned.
Oh, wait. Did that happen? Send me links to that. What? You're
saying you to the extent that a doxx doxx is coming from you,
it's you doing it? >> it's me. YEAH.
THIS IS IT'S SO HARD to actually talk through
I'm just
Let's say there are people hypothetically close to Pisco
that he might care about a lot who have been doxxed by
people who clearly are aligned with Destiny and Destiny says,
"Nobody around me or or aligned with me will even doxx people.
I'm the one who has to do all of it." What do you think Pisco
might think when he hears something like that?
Yeah, what the My community doesn't even do this [__]
anymore. So Dan does So So his community doesn't do it. It's
like all him and then Pisco knows of people like close to him
that he would care about who have been doxxed by people close
to Destiny, by people who are aligned with Destiny. What do you
think he Do you not think that's like a mind a little bit? doesn't
do it, right? I don't know. Dan is not my Dan is on his own thing
against Ethan and or with Ethan and all that [__]
>> know whether Dan has Do you know whether Dan has doxxed
anybody, yes or no?
No. Dude. Do you know whether I know that's false because I believe
I've explicitly told Destiny in DMs that Dan doxxed somebody
on my stream. I Bro, what? What are we talking about, dog? There's
definitely clips where they've talked about it. He's just lying.
DUDE, IT'S THE TUCKER bit again. Wait. Who is Dan? Why are you
acting like I know this Dan guy? Are you insane? Are you totally
out of your mind? Are you crazy? Like, what? Again, it's happened
again. It's crazy.
No. Okay. Uh Destiny said Sunday's name, I believe. Yes. >> I
think Same same level I would say as doxxing, yeah. Uh that's
not even the worst of it, okay? No Nobody will believe me on
this, but that's fine cuz you probably heard differently from
Justical server. Um me
Well, I heard differently from people close to Dan and I've told
you explicitly in DMs that Dan doxxed somebody on my stream.
So, to say you probably know at least about that, right? What
Wait, why did Destiny think that Dan would argue about how doxxing
people is totally justified? Why did Destiny adopt Dan's exact
outlook on
Was it because he was unaware? He was just like he thought Dan
was just being
Like, Destiny used to be against doxxing and then he adopted
Dan's exact precise position on doxxing.
I watched Dan talk about doxxing people on Destiny's stream.
But, this is like the biggest And then he says, "Oh, if you if
you believe that if you believe that I would know about Dan doxxing
people, you might have learned that from Justical server." Bro,
like literally hate. You Everybody knows.
Would Dan never have mentioned the fact that Willy Mac turned
down doing a podcast with him because of Dan doxxing >> Subhuman
degenerate just tipped $5.
I am a totally obnoxious, spineless, incapable re when I'm speaking
with Pisco. Skulls, CPS, Skulls, DMs and doxxed a minor, Skulls,
CPS, Skulls.
Thank you very much for the donation. I really super appreciate
it. Bro, like
Yeah, I remember this, the Glenn the Golden Guy asked >> about
his I I think it's cringe. We
We argued about this basically every anything else episode and
it even carries over to Moon and Dan doing things and talking
about I don't give a [__] His That's That's his thing.
Do it whatever. I have basically nothing to do with it. I think
I've exchanged all of
Two text messages with or not DMs with Ethan in my entire life.
You what? What? Why is Destiny talking about a bunch of Sorry,
why is Destiny talking about a bunch of [__] that's
like irrelevant to what Pisco asked?
I I have not He He does his own I have nothing to do with any
of that. >> Well, I'm glad that he's not part of the community
because
Uh cuz I I would say he's not part of the community. That was
tricky. I said that whatever behavior he's engaged in, that's
not part of my community. You think Dan is [__] doxxing
or whatever? I mean, hold on.
The entire time with Twitch with the Twitch anti-Semitism stuff,
the whole time is very obvious people going, "Hey Destiny, you
know Dan's using your community to do this, right? You know Dan
is like explicitly weaponizing your community against Hasan,
right? You know that, right? Whatever, my [__] >> I'm
not sure. I'm asking the question. I'm asking the question. That's
all I'm saying. It's a People People
Didn't Destiny accuse him of doing this? Didn't Destiny literally
say Dan did this and then walked away? I thought he like actually
had a whole rant about it. Am I misremembering? >> Well,
talk, you know, that sometimes people say that that Dan has contributed
to this, you know? Do you think he has? I don't know. He might
have. So, I'm I don't think it's bad faith for me to ask the
question, but if you're just going to take accept like responsibility
for all the doxxing events and Wait. Wait. I thought I I thought
you're responsible for the people who are in your little blob,
Destiny. Aren't you responsible for all those people connected
to you? Isn't that Wait, why do you get to deny even though you
literally go off of this stream and have a stream with Dan where
you guys were playing video games?
How do you then tie everybody who's against Ethan together? You
know, maybe you don't think that your your community has done
They're just innocent little >> In my In my community In
my community I'm not Dan is in other communities besides mine.
I don't take it I don't He's not my child. I don't take responsibility
for every single [__] thing that he does. Would you
accept that responsibility? Would you Would you accept that like
response from like one of these lefties? I don't know [__]
about that Abanadana. I'm not even a part of the [__]
thing. I don't I don't know what [__] Hasan is doing.
I'm doing my own thing. You would never accept that. Nobody's
going to believe Destiny because this is a clear lie. Yeah, no,
it's a very clear lie. It's Dude, this guy sucks. I would take
a look at the behavior of the people. There have been times where
Dan wanted to call people out or get Oh. Oh, hold on. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Um Sorry. Let's look at it. Destiny,
is there a reason you haven't posted Queenman's doxx? By the
way, the guy who doxxed Queenman and Royal on KF is now banned
from the thread.
Why the [__] did he get banned from the thread? I
thought they didn't play favorites there.
Yeah, I'm I like Just to be clear, again
Again, I have to say it once and you guys can clip it or be upset,
but realistically The guy he's talking about, the guy that he's
mad is banned from that thread.
Nope, I'm not going to say it.
Never mind. I'm not going to say it. You can't say it either.
Don't Nobody say it. I will ban you permanently from my chat
if you say what I was about to say.
Make no mistake.
Nope, not going to say it. Get into weird personal That guy doxxed
other people. Okay? attacks or whatever. I And it's crazy that
Destiny's going to go and and at that time get mad that that
guy got banned. >> done it against you and I told Dan it's
no, I don't do that. I don't give a [__] about this
type of [__] I don't do these arguments here. I don't
I don't care about this or whatever. And I told him no. And my
community knows my stance on it. There's a very clear stance
on it. My community doesn't engage in it because they know that
stance. People get banned for it. I know, but like it does seem
like we are applying So, if Dan Wait. Wait. People get banned?
Wait, what? Never accept that. What do people get banned for?
I would take a look at the behavior of the people. There have
been times where Dan wanted to call people out or get into weird
personal attacks or whatever. I HE MIGHT EVEN HAVE done it against
you and I told Dan There's no way he just argued that people
in his community get banned for doxxing when he is literally
complained multiple times on this day that his community won't
doxx people for him. There's no shot he said that. I don't Oh
my god. I don't I don't do these arguments here. I don't I don't
care about this or whatever. And I told him no. And my community
knows my stance on it. There's a very clear stance on it. My
community doesn't engage in it because they know that stance.
People get banned for it. I know, but like it does seem People
get banned for it, but he just complained that nobody in his
community will doxx for him. He is literally saying, "You guys
don't doxx people enough for me." Why is he also saying
that he
would ban people for doxxing? I Dude, I wish I had a camera right
now so you could see my face. I'm in psychic pain, okay? I wish
you could just see the look on my face as I as I hear these things
said out loud.
seem like we are applying So, if Dan can't be held responsible
You can't be responsible for Dan. Uh talk to me about how Denims
can be responsible for BadBunny or whatever.
Because it's not Denims being held responsible just for BadBunny.
It's her entire community and all of the other communities that
she Oh, now that I remember it I believe Destiny also retweeted
a bunch of people in his community who were posting the failed
doxx of me.
I think I think I saw that happen as well. So, like the idea
that he's unaware of his community doxxing people or he bans
those people, I think that's just an open and obvious lie. interacts
with engaging with the same type of behavior and all engaging
in the same type of behavior. If Denims is watching their whole
community is like, "Ooh, not a good look for BadBunny. This isn't
cool." I got I would do this significantly differently.
Well, I I at least we can agree that >> That's Hold on.
Wait. That's a valid difference, right? I think >> different
things. I don't play videos of Dan doxxing people and say like,
"Ha, Dan doxxed this guy. Good for him. Yeah, hell yeah." I don't
do any of this [__]
Dan comes on your platform. Dan went on your platform
and talked about why he called that guy's wife. He literally
was like, "Yeah, this guy called me a Mossad agent and I called
his wife and asked if she was really okay with him saying [__]
like that, saying anti-Semitic [__] on the internet."
That is Dan going on your platform and talking about doxxing
somebody and then basically trying to intimidate his wife. Like,
it's just an open and obvious lie again.
In my community and half the people in my community when they
see Dan talk about Hasan, they all [__] type yes
honey and he gets [__]
It's not about Hasan, though. The doxxing >> Triggered.
Like, that's Destiny's I'm
That's the Glenn the Golden thing. You don't remember the Glenn
the Golden thing, Dong Devil? >> I'm accepting your representation.
Um you know, maybe he is you know, you're generally unaware of
what's going on that you don't really interact with it and I
would I would hope that you would accept that grace. >> on.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Cuz you said
>> Oh, did he Did he say [__] about me?
I don't remember that. I I don't remember him saying anything
about me over that. I think he knew how stupid that looked all
that all looked for Willy Mac. I don't think he said much there.
I think he like privately tried to get Willy Mac to run with
that. Willy Mac did. Oh, wait. What did But, there's a whole
bunch of stuff around Cherry, too. Yeah, I forget at that point.
This is like totally disingenuous, but it's fine.
It's fine. We are righteous. We will win in the end. >> what
you're saying. I'm accepting what you're saying. I'm accepting
what you're saying. Yeah. Continue so I can call you out cuz
So, I'm I'm accepting what you're saying that you don't have
knowledge of what Dan has done or not done and that therefore
you you and your community can't be held responsible cuz that's
like out of community activities. That's okay. >> saying
you don't help you extend that same charity. Go ahead. Extend
that same charity to people who fit that test. In other words
So, I ran the stream the stream community for Destiny. Dan came
on my stream and doxxed one of Hasan's
Right? And I told Destiny, "You got to tell Dan to reel it in
or I will not have him on my stream anymore."
So, I don't understand how he's arguing that it's out of community
or that he's uninvolved or that he's unaware. Doesn't make any
sense to me. >> Or it's If we can't show that it's not
Denims, it's Casey not Frogan. Got it. Okay. Because if Dan was
doing this in my community, you would have a good argument. I'm
not Do you think I'm responsible for every single thing that
Does Dan have a community outside of
What does he mean outside of my
Like he understands how stupid that sounds, right? Like that
all of Dan's
originally came from Destiny's community. He started the entire
Twitch anti-semitism thing with just Destiny's
He's built up more of his own thing like after that. But that's
like literally entirely Destiny's community he built that with.
Destiny understands that. I'm almost positive I've seen Destiny
rant about how Dan was using his community
Right? Was that Hold on. Was that during
Oh, was this during the Fourthought
Remember the Fourthought argument where where Dan tried to burn
Fourthought's relationship? Also, I had a big hand in that um
from the sidelines. My apologies, Fourthought. I feel bad about
that still. My bad. I had a big hand in that and then I just
explained to Dan exactly how he should go about it. And then
he did it and then it totally worked. But um
Sorry. That's my I feel bad about it. But I do remember this
happening where Destiny's like you can't just use my community
to go after people. It's [__] up.
Did you save Fourthought's life by getting him out of there in
time? Maybe. Dan or Mr. Mouton does not. But if it was happening
in my community, I think I would have some responsibility. If
Dan was posting this [__] in my community, I think
I would have some responsibility for it. Sometimes it can be
hard to disentangle, right? It can be hard. >> not. I think
it's super easy. How is it hard? Because because like >> What's
Dude, is Pisco is he performing? Is he like doing a Hutch cosplay
right now or
Why is he doing a Hutch cosplay? I know he knows all the arguments.
He's like actually doing a legitimate Hutch cosplay right now.
How about because Dan doesn't have a community outside of you
How about you start a podcast with him and that was the only
community you had was anything else you
Is Why is he doing the Hutch cosplay where he can't actually
say anything >> Yeah, give me any I think it's hard to
Yeah, so the spaces kind of inner intersect. People have, you
know, continue conversations from one thing that is, you know,
technically distinct, you know, one server to another. People,
you know, these are not these like >> Oh, wait. Hold on.
Maybe he's doing the flow of information thing. Maybe. >> sealed
communities and and and people, you know, have friendships across
the different lines. >> They are. They are sealed. They
are sealed. I think I If you want to If you're bored, you should
go back and reread your chat like today. They're very sealed.
And it's a very intentional thing. It's Sealed means no flow
between the communities.
And I think Destiny's trying to point out that the communities
do flow
So I don't know what he means by sealed.
He's just not paying attention. >> done that way. Um they're
they're very distinct. They're very sealed. When Hutch was doxxed
and everybody else's [__] was getting posted, people
in my chat were like, "Oh, I don't know how to talk about this
cuz I don't want to post like
Hutch was doxxed before any of the Pixie leaks, before any of
the leaks that came out, right? On in November, before the lawsuit
dropped and then finding out that he'd non-consensually recorded
multiple people, Sherry and very likely some gay dudes from Grinder.
Right? There's there's no Hutch's doxx was not in connection
to other stuff. Hutch's doxx was posted before. That Destiny
only mentioned the doxx when it was brought up a little bit later
in reference to some content Queenman had posted about Hutch,
right? And then somebody was like, "Wait, wasn't Wasn't this
posted earlier?" And then somebody was like, "Here's where it
was from earlier in the thread." So when Hutch was originally
doxxed and it could have been perceivably Destiny's fault, he
didn't let Hutch know.
Right? But then when it became like expedient for Destiny, when
he could use it to weaponize against somebody, he immediately
pounced on that and decided to say, "OH MY GOD, THEY DOXXED HUTCH."
Didn't let him know when it happened in the first place. Just
let that hang out
with no other commentary, I guess. >> the dogs and blah
blah blah and I don't want to do this. And now especially since
I've done mostly politics for the past three two years, it's
hard to even talk about [__] like kiwi farms cuz
a lot of people like me don't even know what this [__]
is. Drew attention to it in DGG chat, too? Haha, he did indeed.
at the moment. Besides the people that are like the more hardcore
follower types. >> Well, if if that's the case >> case
examples. They might be edge case examples where some people
are making weird Like I would agree I would say that like misogyny
is a weird thing that gets happens in my community especially
cuz of the male female divide. But it's a thing that I try to
pay a lot of attention to. But whatever we're talking about for
like the harassment, and I mean that in the literal sense of
the word, not by the same thing. The harassment that Casey Tron,
Frogan, Denims and Hold on.
Yo, check DMs for proof that Destiny and multiple members of
his community working together to doxx people including Dan,
by the way. Oh, cool. >> the literal sense of the word,
not by the same thing. The harassment that Casey Tron, Frogan,
Denims and the Snarkers and all these people engage in, it's
whatever the the ambiguities are they're way the [__]
over the line. Way the [__] over the line. >> Okay,
so so if that's the case and listen, maybe I don't know enough
about these communities to make that
You would at least extend that courtesy to me, right? Because
I Am I going to be held responsible for just Stilk, for Queenman,
for any of these other people? So the standard that you just
applied to yourself How come I don't get the benefit of that
aegis? Why don't I get the benefit of the doubt? >> I don't
hold you responsible then. What did I say? What did I
Oh, wait. I forgot the entire like basis of this conversation
was him blaming Pisco for trying to take my side, trying to defend
my community. Right? I thought that was I thought that was the
whole
the whole I don't know reason this entire thing got brought together.
Why did he say Why do you think he said this? Casey Tron is being
insincere in her apology and Ethan Klein knows her to be insincere.
You would say that it's okay for Ethan to lie about that. What
I'm curious about, I just really want to know cuz I don't spend
enough time in these Discords. I just want to know where um Pisco
got this argument from cuz it didn't come from him. This is either
I don't know if Joe Anna would make this kind of an argument.
He blames Pisco's girlfriend?
Aaron? Pisco's >> JustaGoal in his Dis Discord server might.
I don't know if Pisco hang
JustaGoal in his Discord server might. By the way, I I actually
thought Pisco was wrong here. So I don't I I got dragged in here
for no reason. Why am Why am I being webbed to Pisco?
What's the purpose of that? Cuz I don't have an alt there. There's
There's no Oh, Pisco maybe got an alt there, I guess. Maybe Pisco
got an alt >> world where this argument originated in Pisco's
brain though. He's he's not this stupid. They're We're going
He might have got Presumably if you're joking about it. Presumably
if you're joking about it after the fact and only after >> What about
this one? >> know there's a causal connection at all between
what occurred and the community I Okay, I Normally I'm like good
faith I'm not good faith. No, I am good faith. I'm good faith
towards everybody, but I don't say anything personally. Normally
I'm good faith. Wait, no, I am always good faith. Wait, am I
good faith? Yeah, I am good faith. Okay. All right. All right.
I'm definitely not on too high a dose. No, I'm fine. Okay, let's
get it. >> really hate the fact personally on a very personal
level that Pisco's making this gaslight contributing argument.
I don't know if he's getting rotted by the people in his chat
or if he just lost too many friends and he's like desperate for
either income or audience capture or
Dude, it's Definitely that is not projection at all, right guys?
That couldn't possibly be just open and flagrant projection.
That Pisco's lost too many friends.
Pisco's lost too many friends, guys. I'm sorry. I That's crazy.
And I actually really hate the fact personally on a very Sorry,
I just have to I have to keep listening cuz I need to see all
the things he's actually worried about since he's going to tell
>> Pisco's making this gaslight contributing argument.
I don't know if he's getting rotted by the people in his chat
or So people in his chat he's worried are changing his opinions
and >> he just lost too many friends and he's
Or he lost too many friends. >> desperate for either income
or what.
Or he's desperate for income or audience capture. So maybe the
lawsuits are running his his pockets dry, I don't know. I don't
know what it is. But this weird gaslighting thing that occurs
where a community of people can stand around and and tacitly
and implicitly support a thing, but if you can't draw this direct
causal connect
Dude, I wasn't really paying attention during this. So he is
This is why it is about me. It was all about me from the beginning.
It's the direct Oh, you can't draw a direct causal connection.
You can't say this is what they're culpable before and so you
can't hold them responsible. Destiny needs it to be true that
if he has a group that he wants to blame for something and he
wants to do like crazy [__] to them, he can just
say, "Well, they're all connected and I think every single person
they're all responsible for the worst actor that I can connect
them to." Yeah, no, this is actually
It is just about that, wanting to maintain that argument. >> connection
between A and B. And this whole weird thing is going on where
if you're not affirmatively attacking the thing, that doesn't
necessarily mean that you approve of it. Is this is like this
is A+ gaslighting weird behavior. I can't believe that he's moved
over. But he Well, he has to, I guess, for whatever tankie um
adherents to now. This is like reprehensible and disgusting behavior
that now he supports this. One of the biggest frustrating things
for me when it comes to like doxxing people and [__]
is that like I can't get my community to do it cuz I don't have
a community that generally supports that type of [__]
I have to do it myself because I haven't fostered that type of
community. Yeah. Um We went through a couple of the logs. There's
just very
When he posts doxxes, people are definitely like, "Oh, no, Destiny,
don't do that." They're definitely not like, "Let's go, Abanather.
Let's go. This is
Definitely not. >> don't generally do the relentless
the anytime anybody would have done it in the past, I would have
Why are Why are people Pepe laughing at >> them for it
because I I have the most moderation for my community of any
large content creator on the internet. I probably still do in
the political space. And so when it comes time to play these
games, I just generally don't
I'll do it. We will do it.
Have the community for There's some other people say they don't
want to, but
Uh off I'm busy. Let's get them, boys. I would never doxx. Seems
like it's kind of evenly split. And I'm just saying when Destiny
does post the actual
doxxes, it's not a whole bunch of people going like, "Oh, I can't
take this anymore, Destiny. You changed." >> Yeah. Whereas
these communities, all of them play this game. All of them do
this stuff constantly. All of them wink wink nudge nudge laugh
at all of it happening. Like I'm so sorry, but if I were to step
into like some community and be like, "Holy [__]
did you hear that Casey Tron and got yesterday by a guy? And
everybody's like Lim Fayeaux, good for her. Her I hope she got
to death. And you would be like Ooh, that's kind of weird. And
Pisco would have come and go like, well actually you can't actually
demonstrate to me any causal connection between the response
that people are having in that chat room with anybody who actually
her and I actually don't think that it matters whatsoever with
the Did the creator himself actually
So like
That should actually be an important thing. He's doing the straw
man voice, but that's actually an important thing, right? Hey,
you can't causally link anybody here to the thing you want to
punish them for. That's like how the entire justice system works.
That's how we as a society have like decided to do justice. If
you can't causally link somebody to a thing, you can't blame
them for it and punish them for it. That's like literally how
this is supposed to work, right? He's just doing a straw man
voice and saying something totally insane. It's like saying that
it was good that Casey got raped and I was like, excuse me, that's
[__] up. That's [__] weird. And at some
point you need to have like something needs to be turned Pisco
is just like, I think if you want to punish somebody or do something
bad to them, you probably need at least a reason to do it.
Good one, Pisco.
Straw man voice, now the fact voice, I guess so. All these people
that are celebrating this type of behavior or engaging in this
type of behavior or at least looking upon this kind of stuff
favorably and encouraging it to kind of be advertised in their
community. It's really weird, but
even that one celebrating it. Where did I celebrate Destiny getting
like swatted or something?
Where Like I Dude, everything he says is just a lie. Oh, BB Poison,
if you weren't here most of the night, you missed him basically
arguing that laughing about something is endorsing it and how
laughing about it undoes any disavow you've done. Now how Destiny
would make this argument, the guy who laughed at Cory Campora
Torre getting merked, the guy who laughed at Charlie Kirk getting
merked, the guy who made jokes about
I don't know how. I don't know how, man, but it it happened.
We're watching it. >> hour ago I said you're like the 2018
centrist that provides cover for the I didn't say that you're
doing it or that you're not necessarily doing it. Your community
is doing it. I'm saying that like all these other people have
infected your [__] community. Doobie's donated almost
12 months of [__] welfare checks to you in the chat
to try to [__] own me or whatever. Yeah, these people
are are >> Should I Should I ban him? Should I What do
you want me to do? I'm asking, is there any ought that you want
me have with respect to Doobie, with respect to >> a matter
of whether you should or shouldn't. It's a matter of what Do
you engage in a type of behavior that seems to attract these
types of people or have they set their eyes on you for a particular
type of reason? That's the >> by by by your standard, by
DGG standard, what ought I do with Doobie? Can we just get it
concrete on Doobie? What What should I do with him? Should I
ban him? Should I stop
What did Doobie do wrong? Uh he was like saying very mean factual
things about Destiny and he donated a lot of money to do it.
It's wrong to say mean factual things about Destiny.
That is the wrong. That's the moral wrong when it ultimately
when it just comes down to it. You're saying mean factual things
about Destiny. Hey, you're a bad person. You deserve to get doxxed.
Accepting money What What What should I do? My issues My issues
with you rise to and are capped at extreme and intense annoyance,
but that's it. I'm I'm not going to say that you have to [__]
change your thing. It's not the same as the issues that I have
with Doobie or Queenman or Disco or those communities. Those
are two level of hatred and and I think there's malice and everything
else. My issue with you is is annoyance and irritation. That's
it. So there wouldn't be a stronger prescription there. So but
like okay, so I can continue accepting Doobie money, Doobie bucks
and you're not going to like say that that's bad. You won't say
that's bad to accept Doobie bucks, right? So is Destiny going
to admit that he just totally made up any connection to these
communities or
Like basically he's going, oh well I wouldn't say you should
do something different, but you're complaining and saying Pisco's
bad faith because of these communities. He's basically asking
How do you How does he get you to stop lying about him? Hey Destiny,
what do I have to do? Is there some easy way I could get you
to stop lying about me? Would that be possible? Turns out Pisco,
the way you get Destiny to stop lying about you is you just stop
saying mean things or bad things or allowing other people to
say bad things about Destiny.
I mean the average DGG monthly salary to mock and Destiny. Well
snuggled up with my son and my dog, I'm basically the devil.
Sounds pretty evil to me. Is it bad or No, but like
If it's annoying, you wish I wouldn't accept it, right? It is
your preference that I not accept that money? It's not about
you accepting it. It's about you attracting it. If I was debating
with you and I had a whole and I had the an
I forget Peruvian or whatever the [__] your background
is, the anti whatever South American people were all showing
up and they're like, oh you need to get
wet I don't know what they call I don't even know what slurs
are for people in South America. Dude, I play Dota and I can't
think of slurs for Peruvians. What is wrong with me? Why can't
I think of any slurs for Peruvians? That's crazy. It's like I've
missed a whole part of my culture. I'm like I'm blanking on a
whole part of my They start donating all My question would be,
why the [__] are these people my But isn't isn't
isn't the answer like obvious? The answer is because I've taken
some kind of takes on two issues, exactly two issues, um where
people think that this is true. We disagree with DGG. Issue number
one, Hassan Global Entry Entertainment, and issue number Do not
Hold on. Do not suggest slurs for Peruvians, please. I wasn't
actually meaning to do that. Bro, it's such I I didn't even think
about how this is. Destiny's complaining he's lying about Pisco
saying he's like trying to weaponize other communities and Pisco
goes, oh well what's the odd here? Destiny goes, well I don't
have an odd. There's You're not doing something
How is that? For him to lie about Pisco to try to weaponize other
communities that he knows his community doesn't like to try to
his money, his ability to make money from crossover association,
right?
And then when Pisco goes, what do you think I'm doing wrong?
Destiny goes, well I don't think you're doing anything wrong.
How How much of a mindfuck is that? It's so [__]
up, actually.
But if I were But But if I were to never address that and were
to become bedfellows with all these people, I think they would
start to look at me and I think they would rightly say, well
hold on, are you Do you like support everything these communities
No, because they're giving them another path. I talk to Doobie.
I talk to these other people in in the chat when I see them,
when they when I disagree with them on the same grounds that
I No, but like No, but Unless you just agree with me, you're
actually just going to be evil. Unless you agree with me, you're
basically Constantine Kisin, okay Pisco? Agree with me or you're
Dave Rubin. Agree with me or you're Dave Rubin. Agree with me
or you're Dave Rubin. Like Pisco shouldn't even have to be justifying
this. Um again, as Doobie pointed out, as I pointed out earlier
in the stream as well, Pisco does miss his friendship with Destiny,
I think. I don't mean that in like I'm not saying this is a moral
failing of his. I think he thought he had a friend, thought he
had a like a kindred spirit who was willing to work hard on this
stuff. I think he's slowly coming to terms with the fact that
this guy was not a good person, probably not that good a friend.
I personally believe that.
That he
is having a hard time figuring out
where it all went wrong. If you think that there's something
else I ought do other cuz Do you want me to withhold my genuine
opinions on the Ethan Klein lawsuit, withhold my I don't understand
how you're Oh, this is what I said when that Kafka guy was telling
Pisco that he shouldn't be doing this. It's like Yeah, do you
want him like basically if we agree with him, does he have to
change his opinion? Does he have to like
to what Destiny wants that makes Destiny comfortable, Destiny
and his community
Sure. I don't understand you're you keep saying the thing.
Sorry, good. If I found out that Kick was owned by Israel and
I was getting paid money by them because Israel so strongly agreed
with my position on
that they were like, we need to funnel this guy a [__]
ton of money. Yeah. You don't think that I would stop and think
like How is it that I'm so aligned with Israeli interest that
they don't even have to give me marching orders and they find
it like prudent to pay me. You don't think that I would think
like that's kind of weird? I I would maybe think about it. And
I have thought about it. I'm like, am I being used? >> Pisco's
sitting here like Yeah, if I was wrong and I was defending these
arguments, I would look like you guys, totally making up what
my examples say, like what my evidence says. I would have to
totally make it up and then lie and then just try to gaslight
the whole time. I would look like you guys if I was wrong. Since
I'm sitting here being the person proven correct over and over
and over again, I'm going to go with you're the one lying. How
about that? How about you're the one lying and I'm the guy who's
actually got a touchstone like a touch of reality. I've got some
idea of what reality is. You're the people who have to come to
me. You lie completely. You're so full of [__] And
then you say that I'm bad for pointing that out. Off. Or come
with an argument next time. Come with some evidence. Don't show
up and totally embarrass
How about that? Wow, what a revelation. >> of a proxy war
with respect to Snark. And what I did in response to that was
to edit the rules of my community to specifically say that like
excessive drama baiting and that kind of stuff is not allowed.
And that was I thought a reasonable response to some of the quote
unquote turf wars that were happening in my Discord and in my
community to to make it clear that hey By the way, essentially
nobody engaging in that and then Destiny trying to engage in
it for no reason
when it originally happened. I will admit today I posted some
stuff in his Discord, okay? But Destiny was the person like overly
engaging in that stuff when it originally came about. And by
the way, super like just super disgustingly not attacking me.
Going after one of his victims, he said piece of [__]
piece of [__] I don't want to talk about this lawsuit
for reasons I've already stated, the one that that you're involved
in. And I don't want this to be a turf war where that happens.
And by the way, there there's a lot of criticisms from both sides
on that. I think I've taken a reasonable position. There are
a lot of reasons that you guys will never know about about that
position. And I it is not because of what some people think,
although I have stated I some actual public reasons why
Is it Pisco's Discord a DGG hellhole now? Uh maybe. I just I
just go and I you know, engage nicely with people, engage honestly,
give my opinion. That's what I'm going to do, okay? I do it.
But
Come on through the back door. >> That was the actions
I took so that to make sure that my community, which has a lot
of Destiny supporters in it, which I have never said is not okay,
which I I have continued to, when there are public issues that
are of like national importance, or where you do a good debate,
I have signaled that I'm willing to praise you. That is not something
consistent with one of these snarkier like are these snarker
people like uh taking opportunities to I don't understand you're
like the you're missing I just don't understand substantial how
you're missing the point. If my community were to start we're
up full of a bunch of people and they were like spamming all
these crazy slurs at you and everything and I said my response
is okay guys, you guys are like super racist against people you're
spamming all these slurs. We're going to ban racial slurs now
from my chat. Would that be adequate to address that behavior
do you think? Using the racial slurs it um sorry banning the
slurs
Sorry I want to make sure I understand it as opposed to banning
the people who were saying the slurs, right? No no I'm not even
I'm just yeah I'm saying that we ban all slurs. No more slurs
in chat. So it depends, right? If the people are you know the
problematic people are indicating like a Pisco thinks there's
a good faith reason to ask future tendency in my uh spaces both
my chat and my Discord to violate the rules, then the mere fact
that like the rule change wouldn't be enough, right? I would
have to remove the members, but
Now that we're at the end of this cuz we're almost at 10 hours
in the stream and I do want to finish this up and we will finish
it up cuz I don't want to keep going over tomorrow, okay? I don't
want to split this into two streams. So I will finish this no
matter what. But now that we're right at the end, I just say
that other content is apparently FoodShops tried to hop into
Destiny's stream to expose usly fight with Dan and Mr. Mouton
about being about getting called a Then got banned, then got
their perms
and threw like a [__] fit on their own stream and
tweeted about it. So we'll have all of that content tomorrow
to go over. Oh my god, it's like Christmas in December. Wait.
It's like Christmas.
It's the most wonderful time
of the
It's not so much of removing the members it's like why are the
members why are these particular people attracted Because first
of all I have known Doobie for years, right? So Doobie and I
even though like I I don't know him personally, right? Like
Yeah you're personalizing this so much. It's not like I me and
Ethan hate each other now, okay? Cuz I think he did weird [__]
and I countered him, so [__] it, okay? That being
said, my community's never turned into an Ethan snarker community,
okay? I just think And and my community my community If my community
were to start attracting snarkers, I wouldn't just say we're
going to ban this type of conversation. I'd be like well [__]
what kind of content am I drawing or what am I engaging in? It's
like fostering this type of community. I think that Frogan, Denims,
and Keystron maybe should have asked that question way before
it got to all of their communities basically laughing along with
CPS calls. I think you're way over the [__] line
at that point. Okay, so I
Let me cut in real quick. Let me Let me I'm sorry. Let me cut
in real quick. Guys, um I do have to I have a family that uh
wants to see me today. So I'm not leaving. Keep this good. Okay,
well, you know, you have a family. I would love if you just keep
prioritizing your beef with Aaron straight up rape over that
family, okay? Very cool.
Uh Pisco, you keep hanging out with Aaron and that's really unacceptable.
Wic is ready to come in. Pisco, if you want to invite him in
just so we can finish this out for you guys. Um just so you guys
have a three I don't think we I don't think we need a mod. Um
I think we're finishing out. Um but I appreciate that you're
being here. Um so like Yeah. And I appreciate you. Good luck
with your family. Hope your daughter
Okay, thanks. Appreciate everybody. Go resubscribe to my papers.
Bye. Um so the the final thing I'll say is
there's plenty of Destiny supporters in my community.
Uh uh you know, I I started on PrimeKai, but I really got a lot
of a follow I'll be honest, my PC is having like major like uh
memory issues or something with regards to the sound like the
Bluetooth the the Bluetooth stack the audio stack. If I if I
crash, I'm probably not coming back, okay? appearances on your
stream. That is true. And so I'm sure there's going to always
going to be crossover. And I have never said you can't talk about
Destiny, you can't praise Destiny in my community. I continue
to uh you know, um not exclude that and I don't want to make
my subreddit a Destiny hate subreddit and it's not. A lot of
my mods really support you. Some of the people who are helping
me with like my channel stuff, they are Destiny fans and they
have been and they can Oh, I noticed that because whoever posts
shorts for him, out of the past couple days where Pisco's fighting
with people, there's like only one short that came out and it
was the one where he was like fighting with Ogre Boy. Yeah, like
how bad Mogwai is, none of his like fights with DG Giers have
been in any of his shorts, but the one short that's like Ogre
Boy is here.
continue to be. So this whole notion that I'm just because I
take this opinion I'm sure if you like ask my audience, probably
60% of them disagree with my take on the at a bare minimum on
the global entry detainment issue, it's just like me and like
two other people in my Discord who stay on that topic. And so
it's just not the case that I'm fostering a community to antagonize
you, to antagonize DG G. I'm doing what I've always done, which
is say what I believe, say it loudly. Maybe there's an ego thing
where I'm like myopic or maybe I'm arrogant or whatever, but
what I'm not doing is being insincere. I you can guarantee I'm
being sincere and I'm not grifting cuz if I was trying to grift,
I would read the room and say Denims, Hasan, these lawsuits are
based, hahaha, and do what everyone else is doing and do Yeah,
make the money the way everyone else is making the money. But
I'm not doing that I don't think it's right and I think that
there's uh you know, additional insight I can provide and it's
not my view and so I'm not doing the thing that would get me
the most money. Whenever I do one of these videos, one of the
reasons I don't I don't post them anymore they get [__]
view bombed because everyone on that community hates them. So
I I I think that I'm aware of that um but I'm not stopping because
of money and I'm certainly not going on this crusade to the extent
that it is based on like uh you know, trying Hey, everybody think
everybody's like oh you're so you're just grifting cuz you like
are you refuse to like hate on Hasan. It's like dude,
the grift would be keeping the opinion I had and just making
the easiest money on planet Earth and I know I could do it. I
know I could do it because I did it already and I know I'm better
than everyone who's doing it now.
I know I know I am. I know I was. I know I could be, but it's
like it's just not worth it, man. It's not worth your soul. >> say
one other thing, right?
Ethan made a malicious lie about me,
No, this isn't true. Hasan is like a goober. Hasan's story is
funny and the best part about Hasan is no matter if you hate
him or like him, you can make fun of him and laugh at him from
a position of liking him or hating
Like his story is he is like a total he is like an isekai anime,
right? Where it's like a total virgin reborn into like a hero's
body or something, but he's got like the coordination of like
the fat kid who had to go into high school on like a
on like a scooter or some [__] Like he has no coordination,
he has no flexibility, he has nothing. He is like the Tin Man,
okay? You ever watch You ever try to watch him kick a heavy bag?
You ever watch this [__] He's the least athletic
person on planet Earth and it's hilarious because he looks like
he's one of the most athletic people on planet Earth. He's like
this giga chad and then you see him like try to throw a kick
and he literally can't twist his hips. He literally has no understanding
of how his hips move in concert with the rest of his body. I
guarantee you I want a picture of Hasan throwing a football.
Sorry, I want a video of Hasan throwing a football. I guarantee
if we could get a video of Hasan throwing a football, it would
be the funniest thing in the
Okay? Please. Please get me somebody get me a clip of Hasan throwing
a football
Ethan said that I larp Anyway, that story is could be really
funny from a snarking perspective or really funny from a haha
it's like such a cool a cool like a juxtaposition perspective,
His hips move just fine when he's making stars not.
Uh the only clip I've ever seen on that is from a girl who said
his fingers really good. So actually kind of low-key dissing
his hip game. Just saying. >> PA, that's basically suggesting
that I don't have any uh that I was never admitted to practice
in any state. That's what he suggested. Never taken that back.
So on this entire thing,
Oh so Ethan Ethan said that Pisco's not a real lawyer. Crazy.
Wait wait wait. Yes. What did Ethan say? Yes, he said so I'll
I'll bring up the quote. Do you know what I'm about to ask? Or
Chop's TV, see you. No, I don't know what you're about to Okay,
well I just want to see the thing. Bring up the quote. He said
Pisco larps as an There's a quote, direct quote. Pisco larps
as an attorney when he's about as qualified as Mike from PA.
What did he mean by that? I'm doing a little bit of mind reading
here, but my guess is is he just thinks that Mike from PA is
[__] and he thinks that you're [__] I
don't know if I don't know and maybe Ethan does, but also this
cuz I think Ethan's I don't know if Ethan knows the difference
between like an attorney and a lawyer. I have no idea if he knows
that. If he said That is an insane amount of charity. He has
lawyers up there who are
What what is Destiny's thought when Pisco tried to pull this
with Denims? Maybe Denims is just dumb. He He says You know this
one anyway. He says we're about legal stuff all the time. Toxoplasmosis,
you understand that you train like mind body connection over
your whole life, right?
for for disagreeing with this. It's like well known. It's why
you can't become an athlete after you turn like 25 in some field
you've never tried.
It just doesn't happen. Okay. Now but listen I don't I'm not
I don't have to say that to my community.
You could show me you could show me one of a million quotes or
whatever and I'd be like okay, yeah he can do that. That's probably
what he was implying I guess. But I I actually if I had to put
money on it, one to one odds, my guess is Ethan probably doesn't
know the difference between an attorney and a lawyer. That'd
be my guess.
Just real quick, I was just going to pull out this one last thing
which was
this FoodShops tweet real quick, okay?
Got my perms removed. Now hopefully nobody bothered me to join
in to challenge Dan.
Hopefully nobody bothered me to join in to challenge Dan. Why
would you come in in the middle of
uh ATM3E
and scream? It's funny, you're into that kind of
I don't even know.
39 likes, let's go.
How is Dude, it's like why are you being bad faith in a side
argument?
Okay, I'll click on it. Uh if you're offended by this, you want
to silence pro-Palestinian voices.
He's not that inflexible, is he? Yeah, that's pretty inflexible,
bro. That's pretty infle- I'm not going to lie to you, that's
pretty inflexible,
I'm sorry. That's not That's not super
for Ethan to to do these kinds of things and to cover people
and to go after people who have maliciously lied about him. I
think at a bare minimum, I want to see if you agree that it's
justified for me to scrutinize Ethan's lies.
I don't understand how Dude, no wonder all of the DGers are energy
vampires. Destiny is. Dessy's been humiliated on this point multiple
times where he couldn't point out anything wrong with Pisco's
analysis like at all other than hey, you're a little uh That's
the only valid complaint Destiny had. Hey, you're a little you're
a little too detailed sometimes.
But otherwise, all of his major
he's fallen flat on all of them. He's lost on all of them. And
then at the very end of the conversation, he goes,
Uh you just say all the most things.
He just goes he reset. He just reset to the beginning of the
conversation before he was humiliated on every single point.
You can go after whatever you want, but it's weird to do it.
You can go after what- You can do whatever you want, but you're
weirdo for doing it.
Dude, where does this guy's spine go? Where does Destiny guy's
spine go?
Make a Make a critique. Make a claim, man.
You don't have a problem with me scrutinizing Ethan's motivations,
do you? No, of course not. Okay. Sweet. I think we I think but
it feels like you commit yourself to positions that are just
so much on the opposite end. I I don't agree.
But these lawsuits are obviously heavily personally motivated.
But like the the but then you see people making the Jesus argument
and you're out here like every single civil lawsuit should only
come from the purest of intentions and it's like dog, 90% of
of civil lawsuits that aren't involved in like corporations are
going to be spite personally motivated. You you didn't quite
get there on Hutch's lawsuit stuff, but you or the when you were
talking about Hutch, but it's kind of like you were saying like
well, people are launching lawsuits for personal motivations
and not the actual underlying civil cause of action, that's probably
not a good thing.
But it's the fact that he came out and lied and said it was for
a like pure reason that obviously doesn't apply. And then Pisco
didn't even say that he wouldn't win, didn't say that he couldn't
do it. Pisco just said, you're lying about your motivation really
Ethan's lawsuit, okay? I'm not saying they're exactly the
And I'm grappling, I think honestly in front of everybody, with
what are the factors that go into whether or not I'm going to
like think that a lawsuit is okay. And there's nothing wrong
with that. Hold on, I I don't like that comparison because the
biggest issue with Trump bringing the lawsuit, I would argue
is is quasi procedural. It's the fact that he is the chief executive
and he is the president of the United States. Like Like nobody
has a problem with Macron filing a lawsuit, I don't think, against
like Candace Owens, right? Um I don't have
No, but like you can think of unhinged lawsuits between private
people that you would be like this is a bad lawsuit. I'm sure
you can think of such lawsuits, can't you? I mean like Yes, right?
You It depends on what you mean by It depends on what you mean
by bad lawsuits. Ones that you think are ethically wrong to bring?
Okay, I'm like I'm like so tired of Pisco right now.
Never ever concede to anything Pisco says. Pisco's wrong about
everything. Pisco's wrong about everything.
10 hours is a crazy stream on one piece of content. Yeah, but
like Hold on, it was like a 4 and 1/2 hour conversation.
And realistically, like to transform it, you have to actually
comment.
I wanted to watch it, but I don't want to like just sit here
quietly.
Oh, Pi- Pisco's lied about a lot of the
Without getting into merits, should she have sued you? Sure.
You think she should have sued you? If she If she genuinely believed
that the evidence that she had in the beginning was correct and
true, then yeah, I think she had a right to and I think she should
have. If she If she felt like I'm not saying should have is weird,
but like So, what Okay, Pisco's going to ask the obvious question
and I feel like Dessy's going to go, "Actually, I can't answer
it cuz I'm in a lawsuit." It's the obvious question is,
you have evidence to believe that she doesn't believe that and
then it would be what is that, right? Like she wouldn't be in
the moral wrong for doing it. So you So another another way of
saying that is she ought have sued you given that it that is
her belief if if you assume it is? It's When you say ought, you're
implying like a moral compulsion. I don't know if I would use
ought here. By which I mean it is morally good.
It's It's fine. It's It's not morally
Okay. I I have a different view. I think we can be scrutinizing
towards lawsuits, their motivations, why they're being brought,
the purpose.
Dessy just had like a bit of a Hutch moment there where he was
like he just didn't know even know what to say. He was like terrified
to give any answer cuz he thought Pis- Pisco like perked up and
Destiny immediately like felt the aura and like backed all the
way off. He was just like, "Um huh huh huh." He's just terrified,
right?
our intuitions that some lawsuits we don't agree with. And so
I I don't think I should be blamed for that. Sure, I'm curious
then because this is my issue. I don't know what you're listening
to me screaming at you over this. Like my issue is that the standard
that you're using, I feel like there might be I feel like 90%
of certain types of lawsuits are almost exclusively going to
be motivated by personal spite. So like um contract law, maybe
not. Um maybe certain torts or whatever, maybe not. But like
when you get into things like defamation or um intentional infliction
of emotional distress or whatever, any of these I feel like almost
all cuz what are we What are we saying?
It's a It's a hypothetical. That they're suing They don't give
a [__] about the property infringement at issue.
They don't care about it. In fact, they like that it was infringed.
And they're suing over that. Do you Would you support such a
lawsuit? Absent some overriding social concern, I can imagine
where impact litigation mattered or So absent those kinds of
or where, you know, it's it's kind of futile, no matter what
lawsuit's going Oh god, I didn't watch all the way to the end
or something and now I have a feeling Dessy's going to like totally
come out and admit Pisco was right right at the So absent those
things, I think I think I think I think if I like there might
be a world
maybe where if I could maybe perfectly ascertain it, I would
say no, that would be unethical. But I think this would get really
I think it would be on the border of like should you deny people
who are not vaccinated access to medical treatment related to
the disease that they didn't get vaccinated against. And I think
it's an easy yes for people to say, but as soon as you start
to push a little bit, it's like well, what about if you're fat
and you have an obesity or like heart related disease? What if
you smoke cigarettes and you got lung cancer? What if your parents
smokes? Right? Then it's like okay, actually there's no way to
draw a line here. Right? So what
That's probably what the case is here, but you can just call
it out and say like this guy's clearly full of [__]
and then expect other people to be honest and do the same. >> that
like the vast majority of certain types of civil litigation is
it's it's motivated by spite. Otherwise they would just settle
it out of court, right? I basically think that usually motivated
by harm.
>> I'm I just want to say that you are correct that in
litigation
almost always there is some human story of emotion, spite, anger,
betrayal. These These stories are often times lost by the legal
formalism. And I should never have No one should interpret me
as to say that I think that legal, you know, lawsuits are all
formalistic. All I'm saying is there are certain purposes that
I think are proper, certain that I think are improper. So the
mere presence of malice or a spite to me isn't going to be sufficient
to say I don't care about a lawsuit. I just want to be clear
about that. So the presence of spite, I've never represented
that that's sufficient for me to say a lawsuit's not justified.
I have a view about when lawsuits are justified, and it's not
that. But I'm just saying like we all are trying to honestly
grapple with when that is the case and when it's not the case,
and that's what I'm trying to do. I you might disagree with me.
It's honest disagreement.
I don't Okay. I don't like when you keep saying it's honest disagreement.
I agree with you. You do this thing where there are a particularized
How much was running this dude? There's a particularized example
where it feels like you're so far beyond the pale. And then you
back it up to like, well, aren't there times where Like, for
instance, we could say that like aren't there times where like
consent is hazy when two people have had maybe a little bit too
much to drink, but they like have had some before, they had some,
and you're like, okay, sure. But the particular case you're talking
about is like a guy who roofied some girl and ran a train on
her with his entire family. It's like, I don't know why we're
bringing up that like reasonable minds can just like we're so
far beyond the pale of this point. I feel like with regards to
the Ethan lawsuits, we have like very clear and obvious copyright
infringement. It was so obvious that he literally set it up in
advance of this happening. The copyright infringement was being
used to further the other harms that were being done to Ethan.
I think that it feels like I could be wrong, but it feels like
sometimes civil litigation is used to recoup or attack somebody
for other harms. Like, for instance, if people don't get a criminal
conviction, there might be civil litigation that follows somebody's
trying to be made whole again. So I like I feel like in terms
of like a vehicle for Ethan's spite, this copyright related lawsuit
is kind of a perfect vehicle. Yeah, I'm I'm I'm probably I'm
probably the guy should I'm sorry. I like actually got to Don't
Pete. Uh thank you so much for the gifted sub there, SpaceGhost.
I appreciate it. Bye. Okay. I'm sorry. We We've gone over We're
almost 10 and a half hours now. I'm going to raid Chud. I got
to go. I just I can't do it anymore. If you guys want to watch
the very, very end, here's like the the time la here, and
we watched basically the whole thing. Oh, Fallout's out. Yeah.
New season of Fallout is out. Sick. Let's go. Chud's live. Chud
is live. I'll raid you guys over there right now, okay? You can
go watch Chud. Have a good night, everybody. Go say hi. He's
watching our favorite guy right now.
Sending him over Sending you over there
Give it a second. We'll see you guys. All right. We'll see you
guys tomorrow, okay? Good night.